HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. TODAY WE
WILL BE DISCUSSING ANTI POVERTY
PROGRAMS RACIAL EQUITY HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES AND FOSTER CARE AND
FINALLY SERVICES AND CARE FOR
AGING AND VULNERABLE ADULTS
COMMUNITIES. I HAVE BEEN ASKED
TO READ SOME DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY WHILE ALLOWING FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION.
FOR THE PANELISTS ALL OF THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. A GENTLE REMINDER
TO ALL PANELISTS THAT THEY HAVE
FIVE MINUTES TO COMPLETE THEIR
TESTIMONY PLEASE TRY NOT TO
EXCEED THAT TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF HOW MANY
SPEAKERS WE ARE HEARING FROM
TODAY. THERE WILL BE NO VOTES
OR ACTIONS IN THE COMMITTEE
TODAY BUT FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WANT TO GIVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THE HEARING. BOTH
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND ALSO SHOULD BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET BUT THE
NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CALL THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
916-319-2090 NINE. AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. THE
AGENDA FOR THIS HEARING IS IN
TWO PARTS PART ONE CONSISTENT
PRESENTATION ITEMS THAT THERE
ARE FIVE OF THOSE SO WE WILL BE
HEARING FROM FIVE DISTINCT
PANELS TODAY. PART TWO WILL
CONSIST OF THE NON PRESENTATION
ISSUES FOR WHICH THERE ARE NO
PANELS. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
TAKEN ON ALL ISSUES IN BOTH
PARTS ONE AND PARTS TO. I WANT
TO QUICKLY NOTE THAT THE ADMIN
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION THAT THE
PART TO AGENDA INCLUDES
REQUESTS QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PROPOSALS. WE ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE SHARE THE REQUESTED
INFORMATION IN WRITING BEFORE
OR BY APRIL FIFTEENTH TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF IN THE
APPROPRIATE STAFF AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. I
DO ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE FOR THEIR WORK
THAT HELPS TO SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS WE REVIEW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. IT IS
INVALUABLE AND WE KNOW THAT THE
UNIQUE TIME FRAMES OF THIS YEAR
HAS PUSHED EVERYONE TO PRODUCE
MORE AND MORE QUICKLY I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE TO START
TODAY BY SAYING THANK YOU. NOW
IF I CAN I WANT TO GIVE A FEW
OPENING REMARKS TO HELP US TO
FRAME TODAY'S DISCUSSION.
BECAUSE THIS PANDEMIC AND THE
DEVASTATION MUST BE A CATALYST
FOR CALIFORNIA POLICY MAKERS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT RACISM HAS
CAUSED LASTING AND NEGATIVE
EFFECTS ON COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. WE NEED TO MARSHAL ALL
THE ATTENTION AND RESOURCES OF
OUR GOVERNMENT AS A WHOLE
TOWARDS ADDRESSING RACISM. FOR
WHAT WE WILL HEAR TODAY IS THAT
OUR CASELOADS FOR MANY OF OUR
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS ARE
DOWN. AND IT LEADS US TASK WHY
AND DO WE NEED OUT OF REACH HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT OUR
ORIENTED AND MORE HUMAN
CENTERED. BECAUSE WHAT WE WILL
ALSO HERE TODAY IS THAT NEARLY
FOUR OUT OF FIVE FAMILIES FROM
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. ARE STRUGGLING TO MAKE
ENDS MEET RIGHT NOW. THE NEED
IS THERE AND I ASKED US IN
GOVERNMENTS TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES AND TO COMMIT TO
PASSING ANTI RACIST POLICIES.
TO EVALUATE OUR PROGRAMS AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WORK FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT I
HAVE THE HONOR OF REPRESENTING.
WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN TODAY'S
HEARING AND BEGIN WITH PANEL
ONE. FOR OUR PANELISTS. AS WE
BEGIN IF YOU CAN JUST PRESENT
IN THE ORDER THAT YOUR NAMES
APPEAR ON THE AGENDA AND PLEASE
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO THE
INFORMATION THAT HAS BEEN
REQUESTED WITHIN THE AGENDA WE
WILL HOLD ALL THE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER THE
PANELISTS HAVE CONCLUDED. WE
HAVE TWELVE TOTAL PRESENTERS ON
THIS PANEL STARTING WITH SERRA
BOND. VICE PRESIDENT OF
RESEARCH AND SENIOR FELLOW AT
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE BEGIN
MISBACH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHAIR DR ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
TERRIBLE AND I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF RESEARCH AT THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE TO MAKE
FOUR POINTS TODAY BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE AS A RESEARCHER
STUDYING LONG TERM TRENDS IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND
POVERTY IN THE SOCIAL SAFETY
NET. FIRST THE DEFINING FEATURE
OF THIS RECESSION IS A
BIFURCATION AND DISPARITIES IN
OPPORTUNITY. THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE CURRENTLY STANDS AT 9% BUT
IT IS SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER FOR
LATINO AND BLACK WORKERS FOR
THOSE WITHOUT A COLLEGE
EDUCATION. AND AMONG LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES. THESE
DISPARITIES PREDATE COVERT
NINETEEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
EVEN WITH THE STRONGEST
IMPROVEMENTS FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES WE'VE SEEN ABOUT FORTY
YEARS ONE FIFTH OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES FOR RELYING ON FORTY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS OR LESS
PER YEAR. WORSE STILL BLACK AND
LATINO FAMILIES WERE ESPECIALLY
LIKELY TO BE AND THAT'S LOWER
INCOME GROUP. WHERE WE ARE
TODAY IS THE RESULT OF A FOUR
DECADE TREND TOWARDS GREATER
INCOME INEQUALITY AND STAGNANT
PROPERTY. SECOND EVERY
RECESSION IN THE PAST FOUR
DECADES HAS EXACERBATED
ECONOMIC DISPARITIES THE ONE
EXCEPTION IS THE DOT COM BUST.
MIDDLE AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES
TOOK TEN TO TWELVE YEARS TO
RECOVER FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION AND A BIT LONGER AND
SOME PARTS OF THE STATE SO MANY
FAMILIES BARELY CAUGHT THEIR
BREATH BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC
HIT. WE DO EXPECT THAT THIS
RECOVERY MAY BE FASTER
HOPEFULLY WILL BE FASTER BUT
ALL RECESSION HAVE A LAG. AND
SO AND THAT LIKE IT'S FELT MORE
SEVERELY FOR LOWER INCOME
FAMILIES. SO WE REALLY MUST
BEAR IN MIND THAT EVEN WHEN THE
ECONOMY WIDE METRIC START TO
LOOK BETTER LIKE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES. THE
RECESSION WILL STILL LIKELY BE
FELT VERY STRONGLY FOR MANY
CALIFORNIA. THIRD WE NOW KNOW A
LOT ABOUT WHAT WORKS TO SUPPORT
FAMILIES AND EAT. AND TYPICAL
TIMES WE KNOW FROM THE PP I
SEIZE DOWN FOR CALIFORNIA
POVERTY MEASURE THAT MAJOR
STATE AND FEDERAL SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS KEEP NEARLY THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS OUT OF
POVERTY EVERY YEAR. INCLUDING
ONE MILLION CHILDREN. CALFRESH
IN TAX CREDITS ARE THE BIGGEST
POVERTY REDUCERS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN FOLLOWED
BY CAL WORKS. THESE PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY SUPPORT MANY MANY MORE
CALIFORNIANS IF WE LOOK BEYOND
THE POVERTY SNAPSHOT AND THINK
ABOUT WELL BEING OVER TIME. AND
RECENT RESEARCH WE FOUND THAT
50% OF CHILDREN BENEFIT FROM
CALFRESH CAL WORKS OR BOTH. AT
SOME POINT DURING THEIR FIRST
FIVE YEARS OF LIFE. WE ALSO
FOUND THAT IN THE LAST
RECESSION. THE ONLY WITH
CHILDREN FELL DEEPER IN NEED SO
THEY WERE MORE LIKELY TO RELY
ON BOTH CALFRESH AND CAL WORK
WHEN IN REGULAR TIMES THEY MAY
HAVE JUST BEEN- SUPPORTED BY
CALFRESH SO CALIFORNIA'S ROBUST
POWERS PROGRAM RELATIVE TO
OTHER STATES REALLY PROVIDED
VITAL SUPPORT IN THE LAST
RECESSION. ONE FACTOR THAT
MIGHT MAKE THE NEED DIFFERENT
THIS TIME IS THE SCALE OF THE
FEDERAL STIMULUS THERE IS SOME
CONSENSUS I BELIEVE AMONG
RESEARCH THAT THE INITIAL
STIMULUS IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
CARES ACT- MAY HAVE PREVENTED
POVERTY FROM IMMEDIATELY
INCREASING. THE DIRECT STIMULUS
PAYMENTS WERE THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL TO THAT AND
FOLLOWED BY UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE EXPANSIONS. HOWEVER
WITH IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES
LAPSES IN SUPPORT AND GAPS IN
ACCESS TO THOSE PROGRAMS AND
OTHERS I WOULD EXPECT THAT
WE'LL SEE AN INCREASE IN
POVERTY WHEN WE LOOK BACK ON
TWENTY TWENTY OVERALL.
ESPECIALLY WITHIN CERTAIN
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS AND
COMMUNITIES MOST IN NEED.
FOURTH AND FINALLY POLICY
DECISIONS THIS YEAR WILL HAVE
MAJOR IMPLICATIONS FOR NEAR
TERM WELL BEING AND I HOPE ALSO
FOR LONG TERM WELL BEING. THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT SIGNED
BY PRESIDENT BY THEN EXTENDS
MANY PROVISIONS THEIR RESEARCH
BELIEVES WERE EFFECTIVE DURING
THE PAST YEAR AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. IT ALSO EXPANDS
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN ON AND ON A GREAT NEW
SCALE THROUGH FULLY REFUNDABLE
TAX CREDITS. NATIONWIDE
ESTIMATES SUGGEST THAT THIS
PACKAGE TOGETHER COULD CUT
CHILD POVERTY AND HALF. AN ARE
ROUGH ESTIMATES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA POVERTY MEASURE
SUGGESTS A SLIGHTLY SMALLER BUT
SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT ON IN THE
STATE FOR THOSE CHILD TAX
CREDITS ALONE. AND IF THEY'RE
EXTENDED BEYOND THIS YEAR IT
COULD REALLY BE A GAME CHANGER
FOR CHILD POVERTY. THERE IS
STRONG CONSENSUS IN THE
RESEARCH LITERATURE ABOUT LARGE
SCALE PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
CASH AND CASH LIKE BENEFITS CAN
EFFECTIVELY REVERSE DETRIMENTAL
HEALTH EDUCATION AND ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF MATERIAL NEED THAT
MANY CALIFORNIANS FACE. TWO
OBSERVATIONS MAY HELP I THINK
PUT THIS CHILD TAX CREDIT IN
PERSPECTIVE CONSIDERING THAT
YOU'RE HEARING IS TALKING ABOUT
OTHER PROGRAMS RELATED TO THAT
TODAY AND I'LL AND ON THIS
POINT. FIRST AS CURRENTLY
DESIGNED THESE TRACK CREDITS
ARE UNLIKELY TO DISCOURAGE
FAMILIES FROM WORKING A
COMMONLY. RAISED CONCERNS OR IN
MY VIEW NOT IN IN AGGREGATE OUT
WITH BENEFITS. SECOND TACK
CHILD TAX CREDITS ALONE WOULD
NOT BE SUFFICIENT TO KEEP CHILD
POVERTY AT BAY OR TO CUT IT IN
HALF AS ASTON THAT SUGGESTS. IT
MUST WORK TOGETHER WITH
CALFRESH CAL WORKS IN OTHER
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT ALL
TOGETHER AS A PACKAGE AT THE
SCALE THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
TALKING ABOUT AND EFFECTIVELY
AND EQUITABLY REACH
CALIFORNIANS IN NEED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THIS WITH
YOU TODAY. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM S. C. HUTCH FULL.
POLICY ANALYST AT THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER. HELLO AND GOOD
AFTERNOON TO EVERYONE MY NAME
IS SB HUTCH FULL I AND I AM A
POLICY ANALYST AT THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK TODAY.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
WHILE CALIFORNIA IS A WEALTHY
ST HOME TO MANY HIGH INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GREATLY
EXPANDS OUR WEALTH IN THE LAST
SEVERAL DECADES. BECAUSE OF
POLICY BARRIERS AND GENDER AND
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY MANY
CALIFORNIANS OF COLOR WOMEN AND
IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN BLOCKED
FROM ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES.
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THESE
CALIFORNIANS FACE ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP EARNING LOW WAGES THAT
SIMPLY DID NOT MEET THEIR BASIC
NEEDS. SECOND COBIT NINETEEN
TOOK THIS BAD SITUATION AND IT
MADE IT EVEN WORSE WIDENING
RACIAL AND GENDER INEQUITIES.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
THE JOBS STILL GONE ARE IN
INDUSTRIES SUCH AS THE
PEOPLE OF COLOR WOMEN AND
IMMIGRANTS WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY EMPLOYED.
LEADING THEM TO SEEK NOTABLY
HIGHER UNEMPLOYMENT LEVELS.
BECAUSE THESE INDUSTRIES WERE
MOSTLY LOW PAYING. THIS
RECESSION ALSO MEANS THAT MOST
PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL OUT OF
WORK WEREN'T EARNING MUCH
BEFORE THIS CRISIS AND ARE
UNLIKELY TO HAVE SAVINGS TO
FALL BACK ON IF THEY DON'T GET
ENOUGH PUBLIC SUPPORT BEFORE
THEY CAN FIND WORK AGAIN. THIS
WILL LIKELY BE A LONG TERM
CONCERN BEYOND THE PANDEMIC. AS
IT WILL LIKELY TAKE TIME TO
RECOVER ALL OF THE JOBS LOST.
LOST JOBS AND EARNINGS HAVE
STRETCHED CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLD
BUDGETS. INOUR STATE ALMOST
TWO MILLION HOUSEHOLDS WITH
CHILDREN ABOUT FIFTEEN POINT 9%
REPORTED SOMETIMES OR OFTEN NOT
HAVING ENOUGH FOOD TO EAT
DURING A FOUR WEEK PERIOD I IN
LATE JUNE AND JULY. THIS
INCLUDES MORE THAN ONE IN FIVE
WITH YOU NEXT HOUSEHOLDS AND
BLACK HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN.
ALSO REPORTING SOMETIMES OR
OFTEN JUST NOT HAVING ENOUGH
FOOD TO EAT. THIRD WHILE THE
FEDERAL RELIEF PACKAGE WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY HELP REDUCE POVERTY
ESTARá BONE HAS ALREADY
HIGHLIGHTED WE STILL REQUIRE A
SAFETY NET THAT IS ACCESSIBLE
ROBUST AND THAT PROVIDE ON
GOING SUPPORT BEYOND THE
PANDEMIC. EXTENDED UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS IN THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN WILL EXPIRE IN EARLY
SEPTEMBER AND IT'S VERY
UNLIKELY THAT EVERYONE WHO'S
LOST JOBS WE'LL FIND WILL HAVE
FOUND EMPLOYMENT BY THEN. SO
SIMPLIFYING ACCESS TO THE
SAFETY NET NOW. BECAUSE FEDERAL
RELIEF COULD RUN OUT AT A TIME
WHEN MANY PEOPLE STILL NEED
HELP. THE STATE SHOULD ALSO
PROVIDE DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE EXCLUDED
FROM FEDERAL SUPPORT DUE TO
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS. SUCH
AS THROUGH EXPANDING THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND PROVIDING DIRECT
CASH AID SUCH AS BROUGH ARE
PERHAPS ANOTHER GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS. FINALLY AFTER THE
PANDEMIC WE SHOULD LOOK BEYOND
JUST RECOVERY TO CONSIDERING
HOW OUR SAFETY NET CAN BE
RESTRUCTURED TO MEET THE REAL
MEAT. AND CAL WORKS FOR EXAMPLE
WITH THE CURRENT MAXIMUM EIGHT
PAYMENT A TYPICAL FAMILY OF
THREE WITH NO OTHER INCOME BUT
ALSO RECEIVE THE FULL CALFRESH
ALLOWANCE WOULD STILL LIVE
BELOW THE FEDERAL DEFINITION OF
PROPERTY. THIS IS CONSPICUOUSLY
CONCERNING BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THE FEDERAL DEFINITION DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR IT WILL REFLECT
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER HOUSING
COSTS WHICH HELPED DRIVE
POVERTY IN OUR STATE. A ROBUST
SAFETY NET WILL HELP CREATE A
CALIFORNIA WHERE EVERYONE CAN
THRIVE. IN CLOSING TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIANS AND THE LEVY A
HARDSHIP STATE POLICYMAKERS
SHOULD SHORE UP OUR SAFETY NET
TARGET INEQUITIES AND FILL IN
THE GAPS IN THE FEDERAL
RESPONSE. SO THE CALIFORNIANS
AND THEIR FAMILIES CAN MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM- KIM JOHNSON
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
DIRECTOR JOHNSON. THANK YOU
CHAIR IN MEMBERS CAN JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH YOU THIS
AFTERNOON I'LL START WITH- THE
CALFRESH CASELOAD IN WHEN THEY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
MADE OUT WITH THE SPEAKERS
PRIOR IN TERMS OF THE
IMPORTANCE. OF THIS CRITICAL
FOOD SUPPORT FOR INDIVIDUALS
AND HOUSEHOLDS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE CALFRESH
CASELOAD REACHED AN ALL TIME
HIGH THE MONTH OF JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY REACHING TWO
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE A MILLION HOUSEHOLDS OR
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION
INDIVIDUALS. AGAIN THAT IS THE
HIGHEST IN PROGRAM HISTORY
TOWARDS THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY WE DID SEE SOME DECLINE
IN IN CASELOAD- BUT WE WILL LET
YOU KNOW THAT OVER THE COURSE
OF THE FIRST TWO MONTHS OF THIS
YEAR WE ARE SEEING SOME MINOR
BUT PROMISING CASELOAD
INCREASES. IN TERMS OF REACH IN
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY. SOME OF
THE REASONS RELATED TO A
CASELOAD NOT BEING EXACTLY WHAT
WE WANT IT TO BE WERE SOME
INVESTMENTS IN FEDERAL
RESOURCES THAT EXPANDED AND
EXTENDED UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS. AND THOSE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON CALFRESH
ELIGIBILITY. UNTIL RECENTLY ALL
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WERE
CONSIDERED INCOME FOR THE
PURPOSES OF DETERMINING
CALFRESH ELIGIBILITY. WHILE YOU
AYE BENEFITS HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
TO THE STATE'S PANDEMIC
RESPONSE THE FEDERAL POLICY
DECISION TO INCLUDE ALL OF
THOSE BENEFITS. I CERTAINLY
HAVE AN IMPACT. MORE RECENTLY
THERE HAS BEEN AN EXCLUSION OF
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION OR P. YOU SEE
WHICH IS CURRENTLY THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER WEEK. AND
ALSO AN EXPANSION OF HOUSE OF
COLLEGE STUDENT ELIGIBILITY FOR
CATHOLICS WE EXPECT THESE TWO
CHANGES TO HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON THE CALFRESH
CASELOAD. I'M IN AND THAT
CHANGES WE'VE SEEN SO FAR ARE
AN INDICATOR OF THAT. FEDERAL
POLICY CHANGES ARE SET TO
CONTINUE TO THE LENGTH OF THE
FEDERAL PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
INCLUDING THE ALLOTMENTS THE
ADDITIONAL LOT MEANS WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PROVIDE TO YOU CALFRESH
RECIPIENTS. THE RECENT
CONGRESSIONAL ACTIONS- ALSO
EXTEND THE 15% BENEFIT THROUGH
THE END OF THE FEDERAL FISCAL
YEAR SO GREAT AT EFFORTS IN ON
THOSE SPACES. I WE ARE
CONTINUING OUR EFFORTS IN TERMS
OF TARGETED OUTREACH FOR NEWLY
ELIGIBLE POPULATIONS WE'VE HAD
SOME NEW PARTNERSHIPS THAT HAVE
BEEN DEALT DEVELOPED WITH THE
LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AND THEIR DEPARTMENTS.
AROUND OUT REACHING TO THOSE.
EFFORT AS WE LOOK TO EXPAND
OUTREACH FOR ADDITIONAL
POPULATIONS. IN A RELATIONSHIP
TO QUESTIONS RELATED TO FOOD
BANKS I WANT TO AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE TREMENDOUS
EFFORTS OF FOOD BANKS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. IN THE END THAT
AGAIN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
PROVIDING A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL
INCLUDING A RESOURCES AND
BENEFITS FOR DIAPERS. SINCE THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN. INTO OF JAZZ
BLUES LOW CALIFORNIA FOOD BEING
UP WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL. HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCEPT THE FIVE AND MIL DOLLARS
WORTH OF STATE FUNDED FOOD
BOXES IN EACH MONTH OF THE
PANDEMIC AS AN EXAMPLE LAST
MONTH. OUR INTERMEDIARY
CALHOUN'S LOGISTICS DELIVERED
OFF NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND BOXESOF FOOD WORTH
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS THE STATE FOOD BOXES
HAVE BEEN ESSENTIAL PART OF THE
RESPONSE. ACROSS THE STATE. I
ALSO WANT TO THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE THROUGH THOSE THESE BOXES
IN THE STATE DISTRIBUTION TO
REACH. THAT OR OTHERWISE NOT
CONNECTED OR POTENTIALLY HAVE A
LOCAL FOOD BANK THAT'S TOO FAR
AWAY SO WE HAVE INCLUDED TRIBES
IN THE DISTRIBUTION. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE COSTS OF ALL
OF THE FOOD BANKS HAVE
SKYROCKETED IT'S CERTAINLY BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE VOLUNTEERS. ARE
THAT THEY RELY ON IN THE
WAREHOUSES AT TO MANAGE THE
DISTRIBUTIONS AND COMMUNITIES
SO WE APPRECIATE. THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ADD BONDS
HERE AS THE PRIVATELY BANKS AND
ALSO SUPPORT OUT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF
THE NATIONAL GUARD HE'S BEEN
PARTNERING AS WELL. IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE EXPECT TO SEE MOVING
FORWARD WE KNOW THAT FROM
PREVIOUS ECONOMIC CYCLES THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY AND WELL
BEING OF PEOPLE WHO ARE FOOD
INSECURE REMAINS IMPACTING.
LONG AFTER THE REST OF THE
ECONOMY STARTS TO STABILIZE TO
BE SEEN THAT NEED. REMAIN I
WANTED YEARS RESET IN DISASTERS
THE PAST AGAIN LOOKING FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE. HEADING
INTO BUDGET YEAR AT TO SUPPORT
THIS TREMENDOUS PART OF OUR
OVERALL FOOD DELIVERY SUPPORT
SYSTEM FOR THOSE IN NEED. IN
TERMS OF THE LAST QUESTION
RELATED TO THE EFFECTS OF HOW
WORKS- IN WHAT WORKS THE WHAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING SEEING. OUR
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OUR FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT EMPOWERMENT DIVISION
JENNIFER HERNANDEZ WILL FOLLOW
ME THIS A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THE CASE LOAD CHANGES OF
COURSE- THE- ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT THE STATE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO MAXIMIZE AND LEVERAGE
TO SUPPORT FAMILIES EVEN JUST
THIS WEEK. WE ARE AT WITH THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION AND
CONGRESSIONAL ACTIONS AS SEEING
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE SOME
SUPPORT- IN RECOVERY AT JUST
EVEN THIS WEEK GIVING THOSE
RESOURCES IN THE HANDS OF MANY
SO. SOME OF THAT RELIEF HAS A
B. AND THEN HAVE AN IMPACT ON
ELIGIBILITY. FOR PROGRAMS LIKE
HOW IT WORKS BUT WE AGAIN
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE AGAIN
SPEAKERS BEFORE ME AB THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF HOW
WORKS AS ONE IF THE ARRAY. OF
STATE TO GET PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO SUPPORTING FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING POVERTY THIS
DEFENSE AND THIS LAST YEAR HAS
BEEN EXTRAORDINARY AND LIKE NO
OTHER SO AGAIN. WE WILL LOOK
AHEAD TO- IN TERMS OF NEEDING
CASELOAD AND HOW IT CAN WORK
CONNECTING. ADD TO IT TO
RESPONSE. TO THE FULL ARRAY
MAKES SUCH A- TO BE ABLE TO
THAT SET. UP THROUGH EACH. WITH
WORKS WITH HEALTH. MAY CALYX
ADDRESS. AND WITHOUT ALL. THERE
THANK YOU. THANK DIRECTOR NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FROM JENNA HER
NAME. OF WITH THE FAMILY
ENGAGED AND- DIVISION- IS THE
DEPUTY TO OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU- CHAIR
CHAIR. SO THE AFTERNOON I LIKE
TO TALK ALL THREE POINTS- THE
FOR QUESTION THAT I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS IS THIS ISSUE THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN TERMS OF DECLINE
IN THE- BURKE TOLD CASE- ALONG
WITH. TO REASON- FOR WHY WE'RE
SEEING OTHER NUMBER OF PEOPLE
EXETER OUR PROGRAM AND WE
NORMALLY EXPERIENCE- IN TERMS
THE K. DECLINE DO US OF HONE IN
ON A FEW KEY EXAM- FOR INSTANCE
NEW OP. EYES DRY JOHN MEN- THE
XP OF THE- OF ON. BENEFITS
ESSENTIALLY MADE MANY FAMILIES
AN ELIGIBLE FOR OUR PROGRAM
RIGHT AND SO THAT WAS A KEY
FACTOR POTENTIALLY IN MY NEW
APPLICANTS WERE UNABLE TO
ACCESS OUR PROGRAM IN ADDITION
TO THE PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION. THE OTHER PIECE
IS THAT- IN SORT OF HEARING AND
CHECKING IN WITH OUR OTHER
STATE PARTNERS WE HAVE HEARD
AND LEARNED THAT- OTHERS. HAVE
EXPERIENCED SIMILAR SITUATIONS-
NOT ONLY ON THE TENNESSEE SIDE
BUT ALSO ON THE TRIBAL TENNIS
SIDE- WHERE THEY'VE SEEN
SIMILAR DECLINES- IN COLORADO
AND MASSACHUSETTS THE RECENTLY
SHARED WITH US- THAT THEY SAW A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE'VE SEEN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- BUT ON THE FLIP
SIDE WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM
STATES SUCH AS NEVADA. THAT
HAVE GONE. THE OTHER DIRECTION
RIGHT- WHERE IN ABOUT IT THEY
HAVE EXCLUDED ALL- UNEMPLOYMENT
INCOME- FROM FROM ELIGIBILITY-
I WILL FLAG. THE AND INCOME IS
A FEDERAL INCOME. FOR TNF AND-
BUT THAT IS AT THE DISCRETION
OF STATES IN TERMS OF THE
TREATMENT- ANOTHER FACTOR THAT
WE HAVE LOOKED AT IS IN TERMS
OF THE ISSUE OF DISCONTINUING
SAYS- AS YOU MAY RECALL IN IN
THE AT THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE DID WAIVE- THE
PROCESSING OF WORKS DETERMINE-
DURING THE SPRING RIGHT AND
WHAT THAT CENTRAL DID A KICK
THE CAMP FOR- SERVERS. IN AN-
IN DISK. SAYS IN THE FALL OF
LAST YEAR AND SO- WHAT WE THE
DAY THOUGH IS THAT. THAT THREE
MY PEAK OF DE. IS THAT WE SAW
IN THE FALL. OUR DECEMBER DAY
SHOW THAT DISK. IS HAD ACTUALLY
DROPPED BY TO WHAT WE WERE.
SEEN ON WITH OUR CASE- SO.
THAT'S A TRYING TO SEE- IT
COULD BE SHOWING- THAT THERE IS
A NATURAL DECLINE IN PLACE LOAD
THAT WOULD HAVE OCCURRED-
PRETEND SOONER. WHAT THAT THREE
MONTHS OF DISCONTINUING IS- AND
POSITING THAT THIS R. SEVEN-
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY THE
IMPORTANT PIECES THAT FAMILIES
WERE POTENTIALLY ABLE TO STAY
ON LONGER- AND THAT THE POLICY-
PUSHING OUT THAT DISCONTINUANCE
OF THE FALL WAS- RESULTED IN
AND NOT BENEFIT. AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. TO
HIGHLIGHT- ANOTHER PIECE THAT I
SAY THAT- DO CAN TO- WE OUR
TOWN WELFARE. WITH SOME. TO
REALLY LOOK AT LOOK AT THE DAY.
IN GREEDY. TO I DON'T ANY OTHER
P. CALL- ANY PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES THAT WE MAY TAKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE ARE CONTINUING T
RECEIVE THEIR BENEFITS- WE
HAVE- AS YOU MAY RECALL IT IN
ANOTHER CONVERSATION. OUTLINED
A SERIES OF WEAVERS EVERY
IMPLEMENTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE CLIENTS WERE ABLE TO KEEP
THEIR BENEFITS AND THAT. THEY
WERE ABLE TO DO THIS WITHOUT
HAVING TO BE PHYSICALLY PRESENT
IN THE OFFICES- AND SO THAT WAS
CERTAINLY AYE AYE KEY FACTOR-
ANOTHER FLAG THAT I WOULD POINT
OUT THERE DIRECTOR JOHNSON
ALLUDED TO. IS THAT MOST
RECENTLY- WE HAVE AGAIN-
DISCONTINUE COUNTY INTO THE
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYED
COMPENSATION- FOR NEW
APPLICANTS AND THAT. IT'S TOO
EARLY TO TELL THE IMPACT- BUT
KNOWING THE IMPACT UNEMPLOYMENT
INCOME HAS HAD ON FOLKS- IT WE
SHOULD EXPECT TO SEE SOME
POSITIVE OUTCOMES FROM THAT. ON
THE OTHER PIECE THAT I WOULD
SAY IS WE HAVE STARTED TO WORK
ON IMPLEMENTATION. OF THAT THE
GOLDEN STATE GRANT AND SO OF
THOSE ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS WILL
AGAIN HELP FAMILIES- DURING
THESE THESE CHALLENGING TIMES.
MOVING ON TO OTHER PART THAT
WERE IN AGENDA- ANOTHER P. OF
ADVICE TO ADDRESS SORT OF HOW
WE INTO TO AND OUR RATES OF- OF
L. AND OUT REACH FAMILIES AND
TO PER. CASE ACCESS. AND SO ONE
OF THE KEY THINGS WERE LOOKING
AT JOIN AND HOPPING JOINED IS
OUR EACH AND REALLY BECAUSE-
GIVEN THE NEW CASELOAD ON GIVEN
THE CHALLENGING TIMES UNDER
THAT ARE BOTH. I CAN- MAKING
SURE THAT THEY ARE AWARE OF THE
RESOURCES IS CRITICAL BUT ALSO
BEING ABLE TO REDUCE THE STIGMA
RIGHT AND SO FRAME MEAN- OUR
BENEFITS ARE PROGRAMS IN SUCH A
WAY THAT REALLY EMPHASIZE ON
THAT. EDUCATIONAL AND JOB
TRAINING SKILL DEVELOPMENT-
SUPPORT IS GOING TO BE REALLY
QUICK CRITICAL THE OTHER PIECE
IS- WE OFFER MANY SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES SUCH AS CHILDCARE
RIGHT. AND SO ENSURING THAT
FOLKS UNDERSTAND THAT- ENTRY
MENTOR PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR
CAN ALSO- HELP LAND- THOSE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IS GOING TO
BE REALLY CRITICAL TO ENSURING.
THAT WE DO AWAY WITH THAT
STIGMA- IN TERMS OF DECREASING
EXITS AGAIN ENSURING THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR OUR ADVOCATES
AND OTHER COUNTY PARTNERS. TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE CLEARLY
IDENTIFYING WHAT THOSE KEY
REASONS ARE AND ENSURING THAT
WE CAN BE PROACTIVE ABOUT
REACHING OUT TO OUR CLIENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN RIGHT THAT THEY'VE NEVER
DROPPED OFF. AND IF THEY DO-
PERHAPS- DIG INTO THOSE FACTORS
AND I'M NOT AND I WOULD SAY
THAT WE'RE ALSO EXPLORING WAYS
TO PERHAPS DO EXIT SURVEYS TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
REASONS ARE. BEHIND FOLKS
DROPPING OFF. AND THEN AND
LASTLY I'D LIKE TO TOPPLE THE
ISSUE OF- IT WAS POSE IN THE
AGENDA AROUND- ENROLLMENT AND
WHAT. WHAT WHAT DO. WHAT WE
USED TO TRY TO PREDICT- OUR
CASELOAD. AND SO- IN IN OUR P.
CASE LOAD US TO WE DO USE A-
TIME SERIES. METHODS IN
PREDICTING CASELOAD- HOWEVER
WHAT FOUND IS THAT- EARLY IN
THE- WEEKS. ANY IN OUR CASE LOW.
OTHER METHODS ON TO HELP US
WITHOUT FORECASTING- INCLUDING-
OTHER VARIABLES SUCH AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES.
FORECAST ON UNEMPLOYMENT RATES-
CIVILIAN LABOR FORCE AND
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX AND SO-
AGAIN TODAY THE BASE CASE LOAD
WILL INCLUDE AN ESTIMATED
IMPACT FROM THIS NEW. POLICY
SHIFT THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH THE
EXCLUSION OF PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION- AND
SO AGAIN THAT WAS ONLY IN
EFFECT AS OF FEBRUARY SO TOO
SOON TO TELL- BUT THAT SHOULD
HAVE AN IMPACT AND- IN WITHOUT
I WILL END WITH APPRECIATION
FOR THE TIME TO. TO UPDATE YOU
ON SOME OF OUR OUR WORK AND HOW
IT WORKS- IN APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET TO WORK WITH
THAT WITH YOUR STAFF IN OUR
COUNTY AND- STAKEHOLDER-
PARTNERS IN IDENTIFYING THESE.
CHALLENGES THAT OUR COMMUNITY
IS FACING AND HELPING A TOPPLED
WITH SOLUTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
DAVID KILGOUR DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU MY NAME IS DEREK OVER
MCGREGOR THEIR PARTNER
CHILDBIRTH SERVICES IN JUMPING
INTO THE QUESTIONS ASKED IN THE
GENDER THE FIRST HOUSTON AROUND
THE BUDGET FOR THE CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM HE'S JUST A
SICK EXPECTS THE USE OF THESE
FUNDS TO INCREASE STAFFING
LEVELS ARE REDUCED BY THE
EFFECTS OF THE RESULTS OF
COMMON REDUCTIONS. RAINEY'S
COUNTY SPONSORED FUNDING
METHODOLOGY THIS INCREASE IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT IRECTION LC
STAYS WE USE THESE POSITIONS
THE STATE MY SERVICES. IN FOCUS
ON THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF THE
FAMILIES THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED
BY THE PANDEMIC FAMILIES THAT
NEED THEIR ORDERS REVIEW TO
MODIFIED OR TEMPORARY CAN
PROCESS ORDERS HAVE BEEN
CONTINUED FOR REVALUATION IN
FINALS FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES
THE PARENTS ARE EVER CHANGING.
AS CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
RECOVERS. ON THE- EFFECTS OF
THE IN COUNTY COMPARED THE
CURRENT. YEAR TWENTY FOUR ONE.
TWENTY LEVELS USING THE LC
STATE FUNDING METHODOLOGY LC
STATEMENT EVEN A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED AND- SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. TO COME INTO
LINE WITH THE FUNDING FORMULA.
FIFTY SIX MILLION OF THAT IS
STATE JOURNAL FINE AND THEN
THERE'S A TWO TO ONE MATCH. OF
A HUNDRED TWELVE MILLION FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO MAKE
UP THAT HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION. AND THERE IS A NOTE
HERE THAT THE SYSTEM IS NOT
BASED ON THE NEED TO PROPOSALS
CURRENTLY BEING CONSIDERED SO-
EDITION OF MONEY AND. TRANSFER
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD. SIX IN IN.
FOR THAT PARITY. NOW AND I
WOULD. NOTE HERE. THE THIS PAST.
CHANNEL CAPTURES WE AND JUST. A
FEW YEARS BACK. AND STEPPING
CONSTANCE ARE BEEN NON PROBABLY
EVER IN. A BIT. IN NEED TO
REVISE WHAT THAT NUMBERS LOOK
LIKE MOVING FOR. A PIECE OF OUR
PROPOSAL HERE SON AND- THE-
COLLECTIVE STAY AND CALGARY
CHILD KILEY ARE SET BY STEP.
INCLUDED DEFINITELY BY LEDGER
ON IN RECOMMEND CHANGES TO
CHILD SUPPORT. AND WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT THIS THIS STUDY
WILL HELP INFORM WILL. AGENCY
AND LEGISLATORS ON WHAT THOSE
ACTIONS MIGHT NEED TO BE. ONCE
HE NOW SAYS ORTION OF THE
RESEARCH PROJECT IS COMPLETED
IMPLEMENTATION OF CHANGES IS
POSSIBLE ONLY WITH THE
LIMITATIONS. WITHIN THE
LIMITATIONS SET RECORDS
STATUTES SO THEREFORE AIN'T
STAGERS INVOLVEMENT WILL BE
HELPFUL IN ADVANCING
IMPLEMENTATION UNNECESSARY
CHANGES. TO THE PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES. I'M ESTHER. CONCERN
OF THIS PARTICULAR. THIS INCHES
THAT DRAFT WHAT A REVIEW
REPORTS RECOMMENDATIONS EARLY
AND FALL TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDED
INCLUDING AIRPORT WILL INFORM
THE STATEMENT OF WORK DELIVER
WILL START RESEARCH PROJECT.
DELIVERABLES WILL ALSO INCLUDE
PROJECT MANAGEMENT COMPONENT
FOR WHICH THE VENDOR AWARDED
THE CONTRACT WILL BE EXPECTED
TO PROVIDE A DETAILED PROJECT
PLAN. IN IN THE FUNDING FOR THE
RESEARCH PROJECT RECEIVED
AFFECTED JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IT'S INTERESTING THE
CONTRACT WILL BE AWARDED NO
LATER THAN EARLY. SPRING TWENTY
TWENTY CHEN. ROLES DO PROHIBIT
THOUGH- CONTRACT SOLICITATION
DOCUMENTS REMAIN CONFIDENTIAL
UNTIL YOUR PROCESS IS COMPLETED
DECSS CAN PROVIDE A
SOLICITATION PACKAGE TO A
LEGISLATURE ONCE IT'S RELEASED.
IN THE INTERIM PEACE ASSESSMENT
RIGHT UNLESS THERE IS A STATE
THAT MAY BE INCLUDED IN THE
SOLICITATION I WOULD SAY HERE
THAT THIS STUDY IS GREATER THAN
THAT JUST A CONVERSATION ABOUT
COMPLEMENT THE WORST PROGRAM.
AND THERE WAS A STEADY TWO
THOUSAND THREE ON
COLLECTIBILITY OF THE ENTIRETY
OF THE RACE BALOCHS THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO LOOK FOR
TO- MOVING FORWARD IS-
COLLECTIBILITY OF ALL THE
ARREARS EIGHTEEN BILLION THAT'S
SITTING OUT THERE. IN IN HOW
THAT BREAKS DOWN COPAS.
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE A PIECE
OF THAT. DOES IT QUITE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NOW WE WILL HEAR
FROM HWANG CHIEF STEP DIRECTOR
FOR THE ALL OFFICE FOR SO. IN A.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
BRIAN WONG CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SPEAK TODAY- I
WOULD LOOK FIRST LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTION IN REGARDS
TO THE ROLE OF AUTOMATION
SYSTEMS. OUR ACCESS BEFORE IN
IN THE PANDEMIC. AUTOMATION
SYSTEMS ARE MAINTAINED OVERALL
CONSISTENT PERFORMANCE BOTH
BEFORE AND IN THE PANDEMIC.
KELSO SYSTEM MADE CHANGES TO
COMPLY WITH EXECUTIVE ORDERS
PROVIDE MERCY RELIEF AND
BENEFITS TO BENEFICIARIES
IMPACTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES. THANK OPEN NINETY.
THIS INCLUDES PROACTIVELY
PREVENTING NEGATIVE ACTIONS AND
PROTECTING MEDICARE CASES FROM
PART OF DISCONTINUATION FOR
CALIFORNIANS UNDER THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. ADDITIONALLY
THE MODERNIZED ONLINE CAL WORKS
APPRAISAL TOOL WAS IMPLEMENTED
TO STREAMLINE THE WELFARE TO
WORK APPRAISAL PROCESS FOR ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. THE
INCREASE BETWEEN THE NEW VOCAB
AND SALAS IS A REAL TIME. WHICH
ENABLES IMMEDIATE EXCHANGE OF
CASE INFORMATION MINIMIZES
DUPLICATIVE ENTRY AND
STREAMLINES THE WORKFLOW ACROSS
CAL WORKS AND WELFARE TO WORK
CASE WORKS. BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
OF THE CALIFORNIA EBT SYSTEM
PROVIDED OVER TWO MILLION
RECIPIENTS WITH ELECTRONIC
ACCESS TO FOOD AND CASH
ASSISTANCE BENEFITS USING
MAGNETIC STRIPE CARDS THAT WE
SELL TERMINALS AND AUTOMATED
TELLER MACHINES. THE PANDEMIC
RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF UNCERTAINTY AND ANXIETY FOR
CALIFORNIA FOOD AND CASH
RECIPIENTS. ONCE THE REACHING
PROJECT IMPLEMENTED TO PROGRAMS
ONLINE PURCHASING AND PANDEMIC
EDT CAN YOU CHECK. PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC RECIPIENTS ONLY OPTION
WAS TO VISIT A GROCER OR
RETAILER. IT TWENTY TWENTY ALSO
I ALONG WITH OUR SPONSOR
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
IMPLEMENTED ONLINE PURCHASING
WITHIN A MONTH DUE TO THE IN
PERSON NEEDS OF THE PANDEMIC.
AND THE MANDATORY SHELTER IN
PLACE REQUIREMENTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS. ALL MY PURCHASING
ENABLE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
TO PURCHASE GROCERIES ONLINE
USING THEIR EBT CARD AT AMAZON
AND WALMART. AND FAMILIES WERE
ALSO ABLE TO USE CASH BENEFITS
TO MAKE PURCHASES ONLINE AT
WALMART. AS OF MARCH SEVENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE HAVE
BEEN OVER SIX POINT ONE MILLION
TRANSACTIONS. AND NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS SPENT ON MY PURCHASE.
IT MAY. AGAIN IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. IMPLEMENTED PBT. PBG
ENABLE OVER THREE MILLION
CHILDREN WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
RECEIVE FREE OR REDUCED PRICE
MEALS AT SCHOOL TO RECEIVE
EXTRA BENEFITSWILL SCHOOLS
WERE CLOSED. IN SEPTEMBER WE
IMPLEMENTED TEACHING EXTENSION
CORD ADDITIONAL BENEFITS FOR
ELIGIBLE SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
AS OF MARCH ELEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THURMOND NEARLY ONE
POINT FOUR ILLION DOLLARS OF
BENEFITS ISSUE. REPEATING THE
TEAM AND INITIAL SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION FOUR PBT
EXTENSION. IN REGARDS TO THE
QUESTION- MCCARTY SAID SHORT
MEDIUM AND LONG TERM.
OPPORTUNITIES THAT FACILITATE
ACCESS. BOTH SIDES WELLS OUR
PARTY DEPARTMENTS WIND WITHIN
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY ARE CONSTANTLY REVIEWING
AND EVALUATING IMPROVEMENTS
THAT COULD HELP FACILITATE
ACCESS FOR ELIGIBLE POPULATIONS
THAT ARE UNDERSERVED. ONE
EXAMPLE IS THE CHAO SAUCIER FOR
UNIFIED BENEFITS CAL PORTAL
THAT WILL REPLACE THE LEGACY
FOR ALL APPLICATIONS. THE
BENEFITS CAL BOTTLED BEVERAGES
FOLKS ON USER CENTERED DESIGN
AND MAKING THE NEW PUBLIC
FACING CORPS GET PATIENT
CUSTOMER FOCUSED ON THE LIBEL.
THIS IS ACHIEVED BY ACTUALLY
ENGAGING DIVERSE STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING ADVOCATESTHE SISTERS
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AS WELL AS THEIR FOCUS GROUP
INTERVIEWS SURVEYS AND MULTIPLE
ROUNDS OF USABILITY TESTING. TO
ENSURE THE NEW PORTAL IS USER
FRIENDLY AND INCLUSIVE FOR
EVERYONE. THE NEW PORTABLE
GREATLY ASSIST UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS BY SIMPLE BIND
ONLINE APPLICATION. FOR
TARGETED QUESTIONS RELEVANT TO
THE CABINET. OPTIMIZING SEARCH
ENGINE CAPABILITY TO MAKE IT
EASY TO FIND A WEBSITE AND
MAKING THE POOR SOLUTION A
RESPONSIVE WEB DESIGN. THE NEW
PORTAL'S CREDIT GO LIVE IN LATE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ENHANCED AS NEED
THE MARK. A CLOSING. WITH INPUT
FROM ADVOCATES CAL SAWS OR
SORRY TEOSINTE H. U. S. OF
CONTINUED WORK TOGETHER TO LIFT
IT UPWARDS AND RIVER CITY.
EQUITY AND INCLUSION. THIS
SERVER INCOMES THAT SHORT
MEDIUM AND LONG TERM GOALS
WHICH IS CREATING AN
INTENTIONAL PROCESS. WERE
DENIED TO ADDRESSING. EQUITABLE
LIFE HAS ACCESS INTEGRATING DTI
INTO DECISION MAKING IN
CONTRACTING PROCESSES. AND
INTENTIONAL DATA GATHERING
ANALYSIS OF PROGRAM OUTCOMES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK DIRECTLY. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM BRIAN
BOSTON WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. GOOD MORNING
RYAN ANDERSON WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
BUILD OFF OF WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN SAID INTERESTING QUESTION.
UNDER WOULD LIKE TO. IT'S NOT
THE BIG PICTURE GENERALLY WHEN
WE SEE AN INCREASE IN
UNEMPLOYMENT AS WE DID LAST
SPRING WE SEE A NOTABLE AND
CONTINUED INCREASE IN CASE LOAD
FOR OUR SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
INCLUDING HEALTH QUESTION
CALPERS. THIS LAST YEAR HAS
BEEN IN THE- TO. BECAUSE OF HOW
IT WORKS IT'S BEEN MOVED SINCE
OUR SERVICE A FAMILY OF TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND LOW INCOME
CHILDREN THAT IS BOTH THE
LOWEST CASELOAD NUMBER AND THE
HISTORY OF THE PROGRAM AND
REPRESENTS THE FASTEST DECLINE
IN CASE THOUGH THAT WE HAVE
SEEN THROUGHOUT THE LIFE OF THE
PROGRAM IT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND FEWER CHILDREN THAN WE
SERVED. A YEAR PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC FOR EXAMPLE NOW THE
QUESTION IS OF COURSE WHY ARE
WE SAYING KISSEL AND DECREASES
WHY IS THIS TIME DIFFERENT THAN
PREVIOUS RECESSIONS AND
GENERALLY WE THINK THAT THERE
ARE PROBABLY A LOT OF FACTORS
THAT GO INTO THAT. PRESS
FACTORS INTO THREE THE POCKETS.
ONE OF OUR THAT THE ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS THEMSELVES ARE
DIFFERENT OR MAYBE DIFFERENT.
IN THIS CURRENT RECESSION FOR
EXAMPLE WE KNOW THAT- IN THE
DATA. THAT WAY ELSE IN THIS
RECESSION OF DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED WORKERS WITHOUT
CHILDREN OR DIGITAL AND ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR CAL WORKS
ASSISTANCE. ANOTHER BUCKET OF
REASONS IS THE ECONOMIC RELIEF
THAT HAS BEEN ALL. FOR IT BY
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS
THIS IS ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED-
ADDITIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE IS HELP THEIR DIRECT
STIMULUS CHECKS ALSO EFFORTS
SUCH AS- THE INFECTION
MORATORIUM ALL OF THESE EFFORTS
MAY HAVE REDUCED DEMAND. FOR
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS. ABOUT
FINAL REASON IS PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES AND CONCERNS
THEMSELVES I'M GONNA SPEND A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME ON THIS NOT
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THIS IS.
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT FACTOR BUT
BECAUSE TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS
IS A FACTOR SUGGEST SOME
POTENTIAL. POLICY OPTIONS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE. SO ONE THING
KNOW ABOUT PROGRAM SUCH AS CAL
WORKS IS THAT THEY TEND TO-
POSE A LARGE PAPERWORK BURDEN
ON APPLICANTS AND- EXISTING
RECIPIENTS- APPLICATIONS CAN BE
DIFFICULT. ONCE ENROLLED A
FAMILY HAS TO SAY
RECERTIFICATION PAPERWORK AT
LEAST EVERY SIX MONTHS. AND WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
FRICTION OF BOTH OF THOSE
POINTS- SINCE THE PANDEMIC
WE'VE SEEN THAT THE NUMBER OF
DENIALS ON APPLICATIONS OF
INCREASED WITH THE MOST COMMON.
REASON FOR DENIALS AND IT COULD
WORK ERRORS. WE HAVE SEEN AT
LEAST A TEMPORARY INCREASE IN
CASES EXITING WITH THE MOST
COMMON REASON BEING CONNECTED
TO. RESEARCH PAVE IT BEING
EITHER INCOMPLETELY OR
INCORRECTLY FILLED OUT. WE ARE
ALSO SEE RYAN WE'RE HAVING SOME
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES- WITH
YOUR FEET I MAY ASK YOU TO TURN
YOUR VIDEO OFF IF THAT'S OKAY
JUST SO THAT WE CAN- GET THE
INTEGRITY OF YOUR COMMENTS. OF
COURSE LET ME TRY THIS AUDIO
ONLY SEE IF THAT WORKS BETTER-
SO- SO- AS AS BEEN MENTIONED BY
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS WHILE WE DID
SEE A TEMPORARY INCREASE AND
I'D CASES ACCIDENT- IN THE MOST
RECENT DATA IN DECEMBER WE DID
SEE THAT EXIT RATE COME DOWN
SOMEWHAT BUT ANOTHER THING THAT
WE SAW IN DECEMBER WAS THAT THE
NUMBER OF. GENES FOR
RESTORATION THESE ARE CASES OF
FAMILIES WHO WERE DISCONTINUED
IN THE PREVIOUS TWELVE MONTHS
WERE ASKING TO BE REINSTATED
HAS ALSO INCREASED AND THAT'S
NOT AT HISTORIC HIGH THE
SUGGESTS THAT MANY OF THOSE
CASES THAT WERE DISCONTINUED IN
THE MONTHS WHEN THE CASE PHONE
WAS CASELOAD EXIT RATE WAS
HISTORICALLY HIGH WE'RE STILL
FOLKS THAT. REQUIRED WILL. A
DESIRE ASSISTANCE IN SOME WAYS.
WELL ALL OF THIS TO US SUGGEST
THAT THERE MAYBE- SOME FRICTION
IN TERMS OF COMPLETING
PAPERWORK AND ESPECIALLY IN
THIS CONDITION WHERE-
APPLICANTS AND RECIPIENTS. ARE
EITHER UNABLE OR UNWILLING TO
COME TO A PHYSICAL COUNTY
OFFICE WHERE THEY MIGHT BE ABLE
TO RECEIVE STAFF ASSISTANCE IN
COMPLETING THESE PAPERWORK-
AGAIN WE EMPHASIZE THIS NOT
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT IS THE MAJOR
OR EVEN A MAJOR CONCERN BUT
BECAUSE AND SUGGEST SOME POLICY
OPTIONS. AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY IN THE SPRING WE
TEMPORARILY SUSPENDED RE
DETERMINATIONS FOR THE COW
WORKS PROGRAM AND THIS RESULTED
IN A TEMPORARY INCREASE IN CASE
LOAD CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE
WOULD EXPECT GIVEN THE STATE OF
THE ECONOMY AT THAT TIME. WELL
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE BEEN MADE
AWARE OF SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND REINSTATING
THAT SUSPENSION WHAT WE THINK
THE LEGISLATURE MAY HAVE SOME
OPTIONS TO. AGAIN SUSPEND RE
DETERMINATIONS THROUGH THE LIFE
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
THE QUESTIONS. ASK ABOUT THE
AFFECT OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS THIS HAS
BEEN ADDRESSED TO SOME EXTENT
BY. PREVIOUS SPEAKERS- WE WILL
NOT THAT- EVEN IN EIGHT
TRADITIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFIT WILL
TYPICALLY RENTER FAMILIES
INCOME AND ELIGIBLE FOR CAL
WORK SO THIS IS BEFORE ANY ADD
ONS THAT WERE INCLUDED. IN
RECENT FEDERAL MEASURES. ALSO
MANY CAL WORKS FAMILIESHAVE. A
TENUOUS CONNECTIONS TO LABOR
MARKET MANY OF THEM HAVE BEEN
UNEMPLOYED FOR A VERY LONG TIME
AND THOSE. ARE PROBABLY
UNLIKELY TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BUT
THERE'S SOME REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT THIS WAS A FACTOR. YES LEE
AND SOME APPLICANTS BEING
DENIED AND- THE LEGISLATURE
RECENTLY AND IT'S EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE AND COVERT EXEMPTED
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. THE
ADDITIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FROM COUNTING AGAINST
INCOME ELIGIBILITY SO WE THINK
THAT WILL ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS
THERE. FINALLY THE QUESTIONS
ASK ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S CASH-
I'LL SAY THAT SOME OF. MY
PREVIOUS COMMENTS APPLY TO THE
CONFERENCE CASELOAD WE HAVE
SEEN A DECLINE SINCE AS THE
DIRECTOR NOTED WE DID SEE. I.
P. N. CALFRESH CASELOAD- EARLY
LAST SUMMER. WE'VE SINCE SEEN A
DECLINE. THE CASE HOWEVER ABOVE
ITS PRE PANDEMIC LEVEL AND- AS
HAS BEEN NOTED THERE'S BEEN
SOME CHANGES ON THE FEDERAL
SIDE WHICH WE REASONABLY EXPECT
WILL RESULT IN. A CASELOAD
INCREASES DOWN THE LINE. AND
THE OTHER THING ABOUT HOW FRESH
IS THAT MOST OF THE RELEVANT
POLICY SET AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
SO LEGISLATORS DISCRETION THERE
IS A LOT MORE DETAILED THAN IT
IS FOR OUR X. I BELIEVE THAT
ADDRESSES THE QUESTIONS OVER
PERFORMANCE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
JACKIE BOTTLE SO YOU'LL-
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
HI JACKIE BUT ON ZERO FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE-
STARTING OFF WITH THE FIRST
QUESTION IN YOUR AGENDA-
BETWEENFEDERAL FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN AND FEDERAL
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TRANSPORT CASELOAD HAS DECLINED
STATEWIDE BY 4% FROM ONE POINT
ONE THREE MILLION TO ONE POINT
ZERO NINE MILLION AND THIS IS
LIKELY DUE TO DECLINING
CASELOAD IN CAL WORKS WHICH
SERVES AS THE PRIMARY CASELOAD
PIPELINE INTO THE CHILD SUPPORT
PROGRAM. DESPITE THE DECLINING
CASELOAD COLLECTIONS OF
ACTUALLY SPIKED FROM TWO POINT
FIVE BILLION TO TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION OVER THE SAME TIME
PERIOD WHICH REFLECTS A 12%
INCREASE. IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE SPIKE IS
LARGELY ATTRIBUTED TO
INTERCEPTIONS OF KERR'S ACT
FEDERAL STIMULUS PAYMENTS AND
THE INTERCEPTION UP BASE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. DIES WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THIS COLLECTION
SPIKE IS LIKELY NOT INDICATIVE
OF BASELINE PROGRAM TRENDS.
MOVING ON TO THE SECOND
QUESTION REGARDING OUR
ASSESSMENT OF THE PROPOSED
STUDIES. ON THE COMPROMISE OF A
RICH PROGRAM AND THE K. FACTOR
WHICH IS THE SHARE OF INCOME
FAMILY SPENT ON CHILDREN- WE
FOUND THAT THERE ALREADY ARE
EXISTING STUDIES BUT THE STATE
COULD PULL FROM. TO INFORM
POSSIBLE PROGRAM CHANGES FOR
EXAMPLE A NUMBER OF STUDIES
HAVE BEEN CONDUCTED OVER THE
PAST TEN YEARS SOME AT THE
REQUEST OF THE STATE AN EFFORT
TO UPDATE THE K. FACTOR. THE
MOST- RECENT STATE REPORT ON
THE CHILD SUPPORT GUIDELINE
NOTED THAT THE REASON WHY THE
STUDIES MAY NOT HAVE RESULTED
IN SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IS
BECAUSE IT IS DIFFICULT TO
COMPARE THE STRENGTHS AND
WEAKNESSES OF EACH STUDY IT MAY
BE DIFFICULT TO SELECT ONE
STUDY OVER THE OTHER. BUT ALSO-
THERE THERE ARE PROCEEDS
CHALLENGES OF KEEPING POLITICS
OUT OF THE ULTIMATE DECISION
WITH THAT SAID WE SUGGEST THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REQUEST
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON.
THESE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON THE
STRUCTURES OF THE STUDIES TO
ENSURE THAT ONE THEY'RE NOT
DUPLICATIVE OF PAST RESEARCH
AND TO THEY ACTUALLY WILL HELP
OVERCOME THE BARRIERS. THAT
HAVE PREVENTED CHANGES THUS FAR.
WHAT THAT SAID- WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER WAYS TO MAXIMIZE THE
INFORMATION- THAT CAN COME FROM
THE STUDIES. FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REACH REQUEST
THAT THE COLLECTABILITY STE-
STUDY ASSESSED AND EQUITABLE
EFFECTIVE DATE ON CERTAIN
SUBGROUPS LIKE RACIAL
MINORITIES. AND BE PERSON
CENTERED AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
ADDITIONALLY THE LEGISLATURE
MAY REQUEST THAT THE STUDY
ASSESS THE BENEFITS AND TRADE
OFFS- I'M SPECIFIC POLICY
INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS NOT
COLLECTING INTEREST ON
GOVERNMENT OWED ARREARS- OR
ENDING ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS ON
CASES DEEMED UNCOLLECTIBLE.
WHICH WERE INCLUDED IN PAST
LEGISLATIVE BILLS. THAT WERE
ULTIMATELY VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR. I'M IN THE
LEGISLATURE JUST MAY WANT TO
KEEP IN MIND- HOW ANY ADDITIONS
OR CHANGES TO THESE STUDIES
JUST MAY IMPACT THE TIMING OF
THE STUDIES AS WELL- BUT IF THE
RESEARCH PROPOSAL I'M- AS THE
DEPARTMENT MENTIONED CANNOT BE
PROVIDED UNTIL THE END OF THE
SOLICITATION PROCESS. THEN THE
LEGISLATURE COULD LOOK AT HOW
CURRENT PROGRAM UPDATES- THAT
ARE BEING PROVIDED- AS A RESULT
OF SRL PASSED LAST YEAR COULD
SERVE AS A VEHICLE FOR CHECK
INS- WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
BOTH GO OVER THE RESEARCH
DESIGN AND SOLICIT LEGISLATIVE
AND PART FOR THOSE STUDIES.
MOVING ON TO THE THIRD
QUESTION- I WOULD FLAG THAT AS
WRITTEN WHEN IT COMES TO THE
FINAL FINAL RULE THE STATE WAS
ACTUALLY ABLE TO GET AN
EXTENSION FOR COMPLYING WITH
THE FINAL FINAL RULE
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO CHILD
SUPPORT GUIDELINES AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF SUPPORT
OBLIGATIONS- AND THAT EXTENSION
IS. TO SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR SO THIS MEANS THAT THE
STATE MAY HAVE ADDITIONAL TIME
TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO COMPLY
WITH MAJOR REMAINING COMPONENTS
OF THE FEDERAL FINAL ROLES SUCH
AS- CONSIDERING BASIC
SUBSISTENCE NEEDS OF THE PAYING
PARENT WHEN ESTABLISHING. CHILD
SUPPORT OBLIGATIONS OR COMING
UP WITH AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE
CURRENT PRESUMED INCOME
PRACTICE AND POSSIBLY EXPANDING
CASE CLOSURE CRITERIA. AGAIN
THE LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
HOW TO LEVERAGE THE CURRENTLY
SCHEDULED SRL MEETINGS I'M TO
AT FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO
KEEP THE LEGISLATURE UP TO DATE
ON PROGRESS MADE SO FAR BUT
THEN ALSO OPPORTUNITIES IN
WHICH THE LEGISLATURE CAN
COMPLETE CAN PROVIDE IMPACT.
AND WE WOULD ALSO FLAG THAT
WHEN THE STATE IS IN THE
POSITION TO ADOPT CHANGES
RELATED TO THE FINAL FINAL RULE
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER THE BENEFITS AND
TRADEOFFS. OF MAKING
SIGNIFICANT PROGRAM CHANGES I'M
THROUGH REGULATIONS VERSUS
STATUTE. AS FOR THE LAST
QUESTION BESIDES WHAT WE HAVE
ALREADY FLAGGED- RELATED TO THE
STUDIES AND THE FINAL FINAL
ROLE WE WOULD ALSO I'M NO FOR
THE LEGISLATURE THAT DURING
COVERT NINETEEN THROUGH AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THE STATE
SUSPENDED THE REQUIREMENT THAT
FEDERAL TAX REFUND INTERCEPT BE
APPLIED TO GOVERNMENT OWED
ARREARS. FIRST BEFORE FAMILY-
BUT BEFORE BEING APPLIED TO-
CHILD SUPPORT- TO FAMILIES. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER THE
BENEFITS AND TRADE OFFS OF
ALLOWING FEDERAL TAX REFUND
INTERCEPT TO GO TO FAMILIES
FIRST ON A PERMANENT BASIS I'M
DURING THIS BUDGET CYCLE- AND
WITH THAT AND THAT AND MY
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
KATHY SANDERLING MCDONALD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU MEDICARE
MEMBERS KATHY CENTER WHEN IT ON
ALL OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. THAT THE
FIRST QUESTION ON THE AGENDA IS
RELATED TO- KELLY'S PERSPECTIVE
ON THE PRECIPITOUS DECLINE AND
CAL WORKS AND WHAT COULD BE
DONE TO TRY TO ARREST THAT
INCREASE ALSO THE TAKE UP RATE
IN THE PROGRAM. AS YOU HEARD-
CAL WORKS CASES HAVE BEEN ON
THE DECLINE SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN
ALIGNED WITH ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
HOWEVER WE'VE SEEN AND EVEN
MORE RAPID DECLINE IN THE PAST
NINE MONTHS. THEY CAN'T FUNDING
INCREASES GENERALLY COINCIDED
WITH THE REDETERMINATION
PROCESS THESE THAT WERE
INITIALLY POSTPONED FOR SIX
MONTHS DUE TO THE PANDEMIC.
REDETERMINATION TYPICALLY
HAPPEN AT THE SAME TIME EVERY
YEAR SO AS WE TALK WITH
COUNTIES ABOUT THIS ISSUE. THE
FACT THAT THESE READERS
TERMINATIONS WERE DELAYED BY
SIX MONTHS. RATHER THAN AN
ENTIRE YEAR LIKELY CAUSE
CONFUSION FOR MANY FAMILIES WHO
WERE NOT EXPECTING THE PAPER
WORK AND REQUIREMENTS TO OCCUR
WHEN THEY GET. AS A RESULT MANY
PEOPLE DID NOT COMPLETE THE
REDETERMINATION. AND AS YOU
HEARD THE BIGGEST REASON FOR
DENIALS IS ALSO DUE TO
PAPERWORK WHICH SPEAKS OF THE
BURDEN FOR OUR CLIENTS OF THESE.
PROCESS REQUIREMENTS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. NOT TO MENTION
GOING THESE PROCESSES AND
ALREADY OVERWHELMING TIME.
IMPORTANTLY YOU WHEN SOMEONE
DROPPED OFF A COUPLE WORKS
PROGRAM THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO
BE ABLE TO GET BACK ON EVEN IF
THEY COME BACK WITH QUICKLY
WITH THE NECESSARY PAPERWORK.
THEY BASICALLY HAVE TO REAPPLY
ALL OVER AGAIN. UNLIKE WITH
MEDI CAL WHERE SOMEONE CAN COME
BACK AND BE- AND HAVE THEIR
DISCONTINUANCE OR SEND IT UP TO
NINETY DAYS AFTER THE FACT THAT
THEY BRING THE INFORMATION BACK
BUT THEY- FAILED TO PROVIDE.
OUR WE DO NOT HAVE A GRACE
PERIOD AND THE CALYX PROGRAM.
AND THE APPLICANT RULES ARE
MORE STRICT THAN THE RECIPIENT
ROLES. IN PARTICULAR ARE A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WE INCREASE
THE- EARNED INCOME DISREGARD
FOR RECIPIENTS. MEANING THEY
CAN KEEP MORE INCOME AND REMAIN
ON THE PROGRAM. HOWEVER THE
APPLICANT EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD ROLE WAS MAINTAINED
AT A VERY LOW LEVEL THAT HAS
NOT BEEN INCREASED SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. WHEN THE
CALLER KERR GRAHAM WAS AN ACT
THAT. WE HAVE LONG SEEN A TURN
OF THE CASELOADS COST MEDIC CAL
POLY WORKS IN CALFRESH.
DELIVERIES PAPERWORK
REQUIREMENTS WE ARECURRENTLY
WORKING WITH THE STATE AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN A
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED PROCESS.
TO EXAMINE THE PERIODIC
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND CAL
FRESHMAN CAL WORKS. TO SEE HOW
THEY CAN BE SIMPLIFIED TO MAKE
IT LESS ONEROUS FOR CLIENTS.
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT COULD
BE DONE TO HELP ADDRESS THE
SITUATION. WE RECOMMEND
POLICIES THAT INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR FAMILIES ON
OUR PROGRAM. INCREASES THE
MAXIMUM AID PAYMENTS ARE
COWARDS FAMILIES ADDITIONAL
ROUNDS OF STIMULUS PAYMENTS IT
OR ONE TIME BENEFITS PROVIDED
THE A PRE LOADED CARDS CAN ALL
BE WAYS OF ACCOMPLISHING THIS.
YOU CAN ALSO POTENTIALLY DO
THIS VIA CAL FRESH WITH
INCREASED NUTRITION BENEFITS
HOUSEHOLDS PROVIDED OVER SOME
NUMBER OF MONTHS. WE HAVEN'T
ACTUALLY DONE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT BEFORE SO THERE COULD BE
POTENTIALLY ON SOME TECHNICAL
ISSUES TO WORK OUT BUT WE FEEL
IT'S WORTH DISCUSSING GIVEN HOW
MUCH THE PANDEMIC IS INCREASED
HUNGER FOR MILLIONS. AND
DEMANDED CALIFORNIA'S. ALTHOUGH
CONTINUING TO BOLSTER THE
COWARDS PROGRAM GRANT INCREASES
IS CRUCIAL TO ENSURE FAMILIES
ARE LIVING ABOVE FIFTY PERCENT.
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
GIVEN THE CASE LAW DECLINES
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO EXAMINE
UPFRONT ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROGRAMS.
THREE NAVAL AS MANY FAMILIES AS
POSSIBLE TO RECEIVE THE SERVICE
OF THE BENEFITS OF THE PROGRAM.
THIS IS WHERE AN INCREASE TO
THE APPLICANT YEAH ID TO BRING
IT IN LINE WITH THE RECENTLY
INCREASED RECIPIENT EARNED
INCOME DISREGARD WOULD BE VERY
USEFUL. IN THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WISH TO CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING
PROPOSALS AT CEDAR BDA IS
PUTTING FORTH THIS YEAR. ENSURE
THAT ONE TIME AND PERIODIC
FEDERAL AND STATE ENDEMIC AND
EMERGENCY PAYMENTS ARE
DISREGARDED FOR PURPOSES OF
HOWARD'S ELIGIBILITY. ALLOW
ELECTRONIC VERIFICATION OF
IDENTITY AND CAL WORKS. THERE
ARE NO PHYSICAL ID VERIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS AND MEDICAL OR
CALFRESH BECAUSE WE HAVE MANY-
REQUIREMENTS AND OTHER
PROCEDURES IN PLACE. TO CATCH
THE TUITIONS OR SOMEONE MAY BE
TRYING TO DIVIDE US THOUGH ID
FRAUD IS VERY RARE IN HESE
PROGRAMS. HOWEVER AND HOW IT
WORKS WE STILL REQUIRE PEOPLE
TO COME IN PERSON TO THE
OFFICE. THAT IS CURRENTLY
SUSPENDED DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
BUT WE THINK THERE SHOULD BE
CONTINUED. PASSED THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND ALLOW FOR
VISUAL ID VERIFICATION.
PLATFORMS SUCH AS THE ONE WE'RE
ON RIGHT NOW. WE ALSO RECOMMEND
CREATING A ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE.
FOR COUNTIES TO BE USED ACROSS
PROGRAMS TO FURTHER TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF TECHNOLOGY AND
REQUIRED FOR YOUR PEOPLE TO
COME INTO OUR OFFICE. AND OF
COURSE WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IN THE ADULT
THAT PASSED THE L. A. O. AND
THE ADMINISTRATION PROVIDING
COST OUT POSSIBLE ACTIONS. TO
FURTHER FOR HIS PARTICIPATION
IN AS WELL AS SUPPORT FOR THOSE
ENROLLED IN OUR SAFETY NET
PROGRAM. ON THE EXTENT OF THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT CALFRESH ACCESS
IN THE COLLEGE STUDENT ACCESS.
AS YOU HEARD- WE'D HAVE SEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED DEMAND
BOTH IN TERMS OF DATA AND FUND.
DURING HOW FRESH. IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE INITIALLY SAW VERY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE- IN
APPLICATIONS BEGIN AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE CALL THE
PANDEMIC. THAT CONTINUE THROUGH
MAY. THE REST OF THE YEAR THE
APPLICANTS WERE APPLICATIONS
ARE MORE IN LINE WITH THE
TWENTY NINETEEN APPLICANTS
UNTIL WE FOUND ANOTHER SPIKE IN
DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR. SO FAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OUR
APPLICATIONS ARE TRENDING ABOVE
THE PAST THREE YEARS. AND WE
THINK IT'S VERY LIKELY DUE IN
LARGE PART TO THE STUDENT
APPLICATION. THANK IT HAS ALSO
AND THOUGH YET AS AS WAS
PROJECTED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
WE THINK THAT- THAT IS GOING TO
BE HELPFUL THAT PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
THAT ARE- INCREASE THOSE BOMBS
IT APPEARED THAT MAKE ARE
EXCLUDED WHEN DETERMINING
ELIGIBILITY IN THIS PROGRAM AS
WELL AS THE STUDENT ELIGIBILITY
WILL. WE'RE REALLY EXCITED AND
SUPPORTIVE OF THE EXPANSION ON
CALFRESH STUDENT ELIGIBILITY
PARTICULARLY AS THE CHANGES ARE
EXPECTED TO EXPAND ELIGIBILITY
TO AT LEAST THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS WITH ZERO- I.
AM SORRY- I. AM TO A HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A
WORK STUDY SO WE COULD BE
LOOKING AT HALF A MILLION
STUDENTS JOINING OUR PROGRAM
DURING THIS YEAR. WHILE WORKING
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO
OUTRIGHT ELIMINATE THE STUDENT
RULES WHICH ARE CONFUSING. AND
DO NOT MAKE IT EASY FOR
STUDENTS TO GET CALFRESH
BENEFITS WE KNOW THAT HEALTH
CRISIS UNDER UTILIZED AMONG
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN LARGE PART
DUE TO THE RULES AND
REQUIREMENTS. SINCE THE HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS BEGAN
OUT REACHING TO THE STUDENTS
AND FEBRUARY TO INFORM THEM OF
THE TEMPORARY CHANGES WE HAVE
SEEN A SPIKE IN OFFICE
APPLICATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE
CALPERS APPLICATIONS FROM THE
SAWS DATA ARE STATEWIDE
AUTOMATED WATER SYSTEMS SO THAT
APPLICATIONS LAST MONTH IN THIS
MONTH OF TRIED AND A KIND OF
ABOVE THOSE FROM THE PAST THREE
YEARS. WE BELIEVE THAT
APPLICATIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
COMMAND. AS I REACH CONTINUES
TO STUDENTS. FIVE I JUST WANT
NOTE FROM THE FOR THE X. COULD.
TO BE SIX. RONNIE'S WILL NEED
BE SOME IN. WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION PROVIDED
COUNTIES WITH TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT YEAR. TO
ADDRESS THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH ITS EXPANSION. AS-
OUTREACH TO STUDENTS OF THESE
TEMPORARY CHANGES. IN TEN YEARS
WE MAY CONTINUE TO FACE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF NEW
APPLICATIONS AND WE WILL BE
WORKING WITH THAT-
ADMINISTRATION. TO SEE WHAT CAN
BE DONE TO PUT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING INTO THEM A REVISION
AND WILL COME BACK AND TALK
WITH YOU FURTHER ABOUT THOSE
ESTIMATES AT THAT TIME. THANK
YOU THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM MIKE
HERALD WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. THANK YOU
DR RANDALL. A MEMBERS AND OF
THE COMMITTEE- THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
CURLED THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND YES I AM WEARING MY
FIRST SUIT AND TIE IN ABOUT ONE
YEAR- WHAT WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S FOCUS TODAY ON
HOW THE STATE CAN MAKE OUR
PROGRAMS MORE RESPONSIVE-
DURING BAD ECONOMIC TIMES I
THINK ALL OF US HAVE BEEN
REALLY CONCERNED WITH- THE
DECLINES IN THE CASELOADS THAT
WE'VE BEEN SEEN. I WOULD NOTE
CALIFORNIA IS KNOWN FOR HAVING
ONE OF THE STRONGEST HANNAH
PROGRAMS IN THE COUNTRY WE
PROVIDE YOU KNOW RELATIVELY
HIGH BENEFIT AMOUNTS NOT ENOUGH
BUT WE ALSO HAVE RELATIVELY
HIGH LEVEL OF THOSE WILL
FAMILIES PARTICIPATING AND WE
PROVIDE A PRETTY WIDE VARIETY
OF WELFARE TO WORK ACTIVITIES
IN OPTIONS AND WE PROVIDE
SUPPORT OF SERVICES LIKE
CHILDCARE TRANSPORTATION
DIAPERS AND OTHER ANCILLARY
BENEFITS THAT FAMILIES NEED IN
ORDER TO BE EFFECTIVE- BUT
HAVING SAID THAT. OURS IS ALSO
A LEGACY OF THE PAST THIS
PROGRAM OF ALL FROM THE
PREVIOUS AID TO FAMILIES WITH
DEPENDENT CHILDREN PROGRAM M.
AND CAL WORKS WAS ADOPTED IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN IT
UTILIZING MANY OF THE OLD FTC
ELIGIBILITY RULES LIKE THE IN
IN THE SACK INCOME TEST THE
HUNDRED OUR RULE AND. THE
DEPRIVATION REQUIREMENTS. FOR
OF MANY WE- TO USE QUARTERLY
REPORT IN OF NUMBERS. RESULTED
IN HIGH LEVELS OF CHURN FOR THE
PROGRAM AND WE WERE MAINTAIN
HARSH OVER PAYMENT RULES. BUT
ON TOP OF ALL THAT. WE DID
MANAGE CANNOT MANDATED
REQUIREMENTS LIKE WORK
REQUIREMENTS SANCTIONS AND TIME
LIMITS ON EIGHT FOR ADULTS.
MOST PROBLEMATIC WAS THE PUBLIC
MESSAGING ABOUT CASH
ASSISTANCE. IN WHICH THE
PRESIDENT DECLARED THE END OF
WELFARE AS WE KNOW IT. SO WE
WERE SENDING OUT A LOT OF
MESSAGES ABOUT THIS PROGRAM TO
THE PUBLIC IN ABOUT ITS-
WORTHINESS AND ALL OF THIS I
THINK HAD UNPACKED ON CASELOADS
EVEN BEFORE THE BEGINNING OF
POWER SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. WE HAD SEEN LARGE DROPS
IN THE CASELOAD AND EXCEPT FOR
ONE BRIEF SPIKE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE AND TEN. THE STORY OF
POWER HAS ALWAYS BEEN ONE OF
DECLINING CASELOADS. SOME SEE
THIS IS A SIGN OF SUCCESS BUT
ANOTHER WAY TO LOOK AT IT IS
THAT WE HAVE BUILT A PROGRAM
THAT'S MORE FOCUSED ON DENYING
ELIGIBILITY AND ONE INTENDED TO
HELP PEOPLE LEAVE POVERTY. ONE
ONLY NEEDS TO RECOGNIZE THAT
DESPITE AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF POOR FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT WE HAVE THE LOWEST
CASELOAD EVER. THAT'S NOT AN
ACCIDENT BUT PERHAPS AN
INTENTIONAL OUTCOME WE
ATTRIBUTE MUCH OF THIS TO THE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS WE ERECTED
TO GETTING ON AND STAYING ON
ASSISTANCE. BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT HANNAH THE PROGRAM ITSELF
THE FEDERAL PROGRAM. IS PARTLY
TO BLAME IT'S BORN OUT OF A OUT
OF WHITE SUPREMACY AND INCLUDES
A HARSH COMPLAINTS NATURE TO
THE PROGRAM THAT WE THINK IS
REALLY DRIVEN MANY FAMILIES
AWAY. I DON'T SEE IT AS
SOMETHING AFFECTED FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO GET OUT OF POVERTY
QUICKLY. SO YOU DON'T HAVE
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES LATER ON
THE AGENDA TO SPEAK ON THIS BUT
I DID WANT OUTLINED A FEW
THINGS THAT WE WOULD RECOMMEND.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE LOOK AT
AND CONSIDER- GIVEN THESE.
RATHER ALARMING DROPS IN THE
CASELOAD. ONE IS REALLY SURE-
WE AGREE WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS WE THINK WE
SHOULD. MAKE THE INCOME. EXCUSE
ME THE APPLICANT INCOME TEST TO
BE THE SAME AS THE CURRENT-
PARTICIPANT INCOME TEST. ON WE
ACTUALLY THINK THERE'S AN
ARGUMENT THAT IT OUGHT TO GO
EVEN HIGHER THAN THAT. WE ALSO
THINK WE NEED TO EXAMINE SOME
OF THESE ARCHAIC RULES LIKE THE
ON THE ONE HUNDRED DOLLAR
ENROLLMENT APPROBATION RULE-
THERE REALLY ONLY DESIGNED TO
REDUCE CASELOADS. AND NOT
REALLY THEY DON'T REALLY
PROVIDE. A POLICY BENEFIT. WE
ALSO WOULD. AGREE THIRTY WELL
FOR DIRECTORS THAT WE NEED TO
REALLY MODERNIZE THE PROGRAM.
AND REDUCE THE DOCUMENTATION
THE VERIFICATIONS IN THE OFFICE
VISITS NEEDED TO BECOME
ELIGIBLE. AS WE SEEM DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHEN THE GOVERNOR
SUSPENDED MANY OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS THE INTEGRITY OF
THE PROGRAM DID NOT SUFFER. IN
FACT DOING SO- WE THINK
ACTUALLY IS THE WAVE OF THE
FUTURE. IT ALSO HAS THE EFFECT
OF FREEING UP COUNTY STAFF TIME
TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS MORE ON
HELPING FAMILIES SUCCEED. AND
FOCUS LESS ON COMPLIANCE WITH
THE PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS. ONE
WE ALSO REALLY WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
RAISING THE INCOME EXACT
THRESHOLD. AND LOSE OUR
ATTACHMENT TO THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE. NOW THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY
BEEN MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION
IN RECENT YEARS BY INCREASING
GRANTS IN THE EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD. BUT EVEN WITH THOSE
CHANGES A FAMILY EXIT HOURS
WHEN THEIR INCOME IS JUST TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS ABOVE THE
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE FEDERAL
POVERTY. LEVEL AND THEY NOT
ONLY YOU LOSE THEIR POWER AT
THAT POINT BUT EVENTUALLY
THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE
POTENTIALLY CHILD CARE AND ALSO
SOME OF SIR. THEY COULD GO WITH.
SO WE REALLY THINK THAT WE
SHOULD WE SHOULD EXTEND THE
EXIT POINT FOR POWER AND
PERHAPS LOOK TO DEVELOP A
BETTER MEASURE THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY MEASURE. WHEN A FAMILY
IS ABLE TO GO OFF PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE- WE HAVE THINGS LIKE
THE CALIFORNIA POVERTY MEASURE
OR PERHAPS WE NEED TO EVEN
THINK ABOUT DEVELOPING A METRIC
LIKE ELDER ECONOMIC SECURITY
INDEX. WHICH REALLY I THINK.
DOES A FAR BETTER JOB IN
ESTIMATING THE TRUE COST OF
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA FOR
FAMILIES AND SINCE WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE YOUNG CHILDREN IN THESE
HOUSEHOLDS. WHOSE DEVELOPMENT
REALLY DEPENDS ON US BEING ABLE
TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TOXIC
STRESS THAT THEY LIVE WITH. WE
THINK TRYING TO RAISE THESE
LEVELS UP WOULD BE A REALLY
CRUCIAL STEP TOWARD COMING AND
IT WILL ALSO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO COME INTO THE PROGRAM AND
STAY ON IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE FOR THE CHANCE TO SPEAK
UP WITH PAM. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM ANDREW SHANE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
OKAY ARE YOU SEE MY SCREEN
FORGIVE ME FOR THAT UNTIL
EITHER. WE CAN. OKAY I'LL BE
I'M USING WILL BE BRIEF I
APPRECIATE THE TIME THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME ON AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS IN THE INTENT I'M
INTERCHANGE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF. FOOD
BANKS- THIS WAS ALREADY TOUCHED
ON BY AS THE AND SO I WON'T
BELABOR THE POINT BUT- JUST
JUST THAT WE ALL. NOT FORGET
WHERE WE ARE WE'RE STILL OFF
THE CHARTS FROM WHERE WE'VE
BEEN. AND I'LL BE PRESENTING
SOME DATA THAT SPECIFICALLY-
CORRELATE THE IMPACT OF JOBS
LOST ON HUNGER FOR EVERY
PERCENTAGE POINT IN
UNEMPLOYMENT THERE'S ABOUT.
THREE QUARTERS OR RELATION-
CHU. TO FOOD AND SECURITY AND
THEN JUST A REMINDER OF HOW
LONG IT COULD BE INTEL- WE
REACH. THE END OF THE GREAT
RECESSION BUT EVEN THEN AND
THERE WAS SIGNIFICANT HUNGER-
BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT JUST WANT
TO PROTECT. IMAGES ARE WE'VE
ALL SAYING I'M IN MY HONEST MY
HEART GOES OUT TO SOMEONE OF
YOU THE MEMBERS THE STAFF- WHAT
HAVE. EVEN THE MIDST OF THE-
PUT ON MASS AND GOING TO THE
DISTRIBUTIONS- BUT EVENTUALLY
THE LINES WILL GO INSIDE- BUT
WE CANNOT ALLOW HER TO BE
HIDDEN. AND STIGMATIZEDAS IT
HAS BEEN- FOR. YOUR FOR FAR TOO
LONG AMONG JUST A QUOTE FROM
BLAKE YOUNG WHO SERVES THE
COUNTY AND I KNOW MANY OF YOU
AGAIN SERVE AND- AND CONTRIBUTE
TO- REALLY THINKING ABOUT THE
LONG TERM IMPLICATIONS. FOR
FOOD SECURITY IN CALIFORNIA. SO
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT NOW. OUR
DATA FROM I'M DYING SHINES IN
BOX NATIONAL EXPERTS. BROKE
DOWN AND STATE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION INCLUDING
DEMOGRAPHICS. OF FOOD
INSECURITY DURING COVERT. DID
IN TWENTY NINETEEN PARTICLE
THAT. WOULDN'T SCREEN
CALIFORNIA WAS NINE POINT NINE
PERCENT- AROUND- YOU WANTED
TEN. APPETITE NAY INDESCRIBABLY
DID 223% EVEN REACHING TWENTY
FIVE AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE
BOTTOM LINE AT THE END OF THE
YEAR. THAT'S THANKFULLY BACKED
OFF JUST A BIT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE'RE STILL AT RECORD
LEVELS. AND CLEARLY YOU CAN SEE
THE DEEP DISPARITIES. AS AS THE
ANSWER OF SPOKE TO WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS ON. THE RACIAL
INJUSTICES BEHIND STUDENT
SECURITY AND APPLYING POVERTY
AND I APPRECIATE THE CHURCH
COMMENTS ABOUT. THAT NEW
OPENING REMARKS. SIMILARLY WITH
RATES FOR CHIU. I'M A SHOCKING
THAT ACTUALLY WAS EVEN RATE
CHILDREN- FIFTEEN FOR TWO PER
IN THE LINE THERE AND AGAIN
THOSE DEEP DEEP DESPAIR FOR
LOWER. CAN OF COLOR. SO WHAT
HAPPENED TO DEFEAT BANKS I KNOW
MANY OF YOU SAW WITH YOUR OWN
EYES BUT- THANKS TO WORK BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
CAL WE ASK HELP ON TEARS WE
ACTUALLY HAVE MORE DATA THAN
EVER BEFORE WHICH YOU KNOW WAS
SO HELPFUL TO STATE
POLICYMAKERS. SO IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE IT- THE BEST ESTIMATE
WAS THAT- FOOD BANKS WERE
SERVING. APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION PER WEEK BECAUSE OF IT-
IS WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE IS
THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE SEARCH PER WEEK AND SO
IT'S A HOUSEHOLD WENT TWICE TO
GET COUNTED TWICE IN THIS IS
THAT THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. OR THE DUPLICATED COUNT
INCLUDING SPEAK- SO WE WENT
FROM ONE MILLION PRIOR TO
BECAUSE OF IT INST ALMOST
INSTANTLY TO THREE MILLION AND
THE NEARLY FIVE MILLION- BUT WE
SAW IT AT THE END OF YEARS
ACTUALLY STABILIZED AT ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED PERCENT. I'M IN
FACT THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF AN
UNDER REPRESENTATION HERE
BECAUSE AS WE BANKS GOT INTO
THE BUSY HOLIDAY SEASON THERE
WERE SOME REPORTING SO WE
ACTUALLY DON'T EVEN THE NUMBER
WOULD BE A LITTLE BIT HIGHER
NOVEMBER. IMAGINE THE SAME
THING FOR DECEMBER- ACT DURING
THAT TIME IT'S NOT REALLY
SPEAKS TO AS AS TRUCKING
JOHNSON SPOKE TO EARLIER JUST A
MOMENT OF NEED FOR FOOD ON
WHICH- AS YOU CAN SEE THE FOOD
SUPPORTS. THANKFULLY ROSE
SUBSTANTIALLY. THROUGH THE
SUMMER. I THE TO GO AND SEE
COMING EARLY. AND THAT. THE
MAJOR BY. IN THE- WEST PLAN ARE
STILL LOOKING AT A FIVE. FOOD
OF NASH MORE THAN A BILLION.
DOWN FROM THREE TWENTY TWENTY-
AND SO THAT DOES WE CONTINUE TO
ASK FROM CONGRESS OBVIOUSLY BUT
THAT IS THE CASE- FOR- BUT
WE'RE SEEING. THE SAME DEMAND
AT THE TO OUR PERCENT LEVEL BUT
WE'RE SEEING A POTENTIAL DROP
OFF AND FEDERAL FOOD- PUTS THE
FOCUS ON AS WAS SAID EARLIER OF
THE STATE'S ABILITY TO CLOSE
GAPS IN THE FOOD SAFETY NET.
OTHER PROGRAMS. I JUST HOPE
THAT- YOU KNOW ALL STAKEHOLDERS
FROM THE DEPARTMENTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE GOVERNOR. I
FEEL REALLY GOOD ABOUT THIS
THIS PROGRAM IS AND I REALLY
THINK DIRECTOR JOHNSON FOR HER
COMMENTS. WE'RE SEEING SOME
PICTURES ACTUALLY OF THE FOOD-
AND TRULY WAS GOVERNMENT AT ITS
AT ITS FINEST- WITHIN A FEW
WEEKS REALLY IN MARCH- BY THE
END OF THE MONTH THERE WAS
ALREADY THESE. THESE BOXES
FLOWING ACROSS THE STATE. THERE
PROVIDING SHELF STABLE FOODS
THAT ARE IN SHORT SUPPLY
BECAUSE OF INCREASED DEMAND A
GROCERS MEANS THERE'S LESS.
DONATIONS OF THESE FOODS. I
MEAN ONE THING THAT I DIDN'T
APPRECIATE WHEN THIS PROGRAM.
BEGAN IS THAT IT ACTUALLY
SUPPORTS ABOUT SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA JOBS. MANY
OF WHICH ARE UNION TEAMSTERS
BUILDING THE BOXES SHIPPING
THEM TO FOOD BANKS. AND
SUPPORTING THE HARD HIT FOOD.
SERVICES SECTOR I'M AS
RESTAURANTS AND OTHERS YOU KNOW
STILL ARE ONLY BEGINNING TO RE
OPEN. AND SO I JUST HOPE THAT
ALL STAKEHOLDERS FEEL GOOD
ABOUT THE FACT THAT IT'S
BUILDING THAT CIRCULAR FOOD
ECONOMY IN ADDITION. TO
FIGHTING HUNGER IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. I'M INTERESTED OF
QUICK. OF THE THERE. TO AT BY
BANKS- WE'RE SEEING ON THE LEFT
DOCTOR ARE BELOW- FROM THE
FEEDBACK SERVING DISTRICT- NEW
PARTNERSHIP SERVING- AS WELL AS
HIS UP NORTH. IN FOOD FOR
PEOPLE IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY-
FEEDING THAT. THE WHO THE
TRIBE- BUT YOU HAD THESE
PROGRAMS- AS STRUCTURE DOESN'T
MENTIONED FOOD BANKS DSS ARE
DOING MORE THAN EVER BEFORE. TO
CLOSE GAPS IN SAFETY NET BUT
OFTEN DOES COME WITH THE
HIGHEST COSTS. WE HAVE THE MOST
REMOTE LOCATIONS THE LATEST
HOURS AND THE HIGHEST NEED FOR
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE FOODS-
BETTER. DIFFICULT CONSUMERS AT
SCALE. THE SAME TIME. I THINK
EVERYONE'S FAMILIAR JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE ALL
GROUNDED THAT EVEN DRINK
COCONUT INCREDIBLE BURDEN ON
LOW INCOME FAMILIES EMERGENCY
FOOD PROVIDERS CALFRESH IN THE
PROGRAMS. THAT THE REST OF THE
DISASTERS NEVER STOPPED WE HAVE
THE WORST WILDFIRE SEASON IN
HISTORY STATE HISTORY AND WE
HAVE THE RETURN OF BLACKOUTS
AND SOME PS PS EVENTS- FOR THE
FIRST TIME THOSE BLACKOUTS IN.
TWENTY ODD YEARS- AND I SPENT
MUCH OF THE CREEK FIRE BECAUSE
THAT GROUP ARE ACTUALLY
DISRUPTED. THE SERVICE TO THE
RANCHERIA IN FRESNO COUNTY- AND
SO WHEN WE HAVE THESE MULTIPLE
COMPOUNDING DISASTER. RELIEF
BUT STRESS ON- THAT THE SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS TRYING. TO SERVE
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. SO HOPE
THAT. ANIMUS WILL CONSIDER
PROPOSALS THAT WE BROUGHT
FORWARD AND WE'RE SEEING- WE'RE
SEEING AT A CHART THERE ON THE
RIGHT THAT REALLY HITS HOME FOR
WHY WE NEED TO HAVE
INTERVENTION RIGHT NOW. I'M
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET CONDITION
ME INSTEAD MORE AND CAN SHOULD
BE DONE. JUSTICE FAMILIES OF
HUNGRY CHILDREN CAN'T SAVE FOR
A RAINY DAY THE STATE NEEDS TO
USE ITS TEMPERATURE QUESTION TO
MEET IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND TRYING
TO PREVENT THIS MATHIS SPIKE.
AND THE LONG DECLINE AND SO WE
HAVE BROUGHT FOR PROPOSALS AND
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL- FOR US IN
THE GROUP WICKS. I'M SUPPORTING
THE REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
COVERED FOOD SUPPORTS A
STRUCTURED JOHNSON MENTIONED
THERE IS A NEW STATE
INTERMEDIARY CALPERS LOGISTICS.
BUT BILLS CAPACITY AN EXPANSIVE
POTENTIAL OF THIS PROGRAM- AS
WELL AS WORKING WITH THE SUMMER
REVIEW IF THE DO A- ANA AND I'M
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THE FOOD
BANKS DON'T LOSE FOODS DURING-
POWER SHUT OFFS. OR P. S. P. S.
OFFENSIVE FIRES WE HAD SOME
VERY CLOSE CALLS LOW JUST
HAPPENED IN TEXAS WE DON'T WANT
TO SEE THAT HAPPEN HERE- AND
BEAT THE SIGNIFICANT CAPACITY
NEEDS. ARE CONTINUING TO SERVE
SO MANY I'M CAN YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE- FORESEEABLE
FUTURE. SO THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU NOW WE WILL FROM.
CRAPPIE LEAD CHAPTER. FOR VOICE
CAL. HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CRAPPIE AND I AM THE
LEAD CHAPTER ORGANIZER WITH HER
VOICE IS CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
STATEWIDE LED ORGANIZATION WITH
THIRTEEN CHAPTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING A
DIVERSE GROUP OF FAMILIES.
THANK YOU I NEED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME OF
THE CREATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT
PARENTS HAVE TO SUPPORT THEM
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND BEYOND.
THIS IS WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
FAMILIES AS TO WHY THEY'RE NOT
ACCESSING HEALTH WORKS PROGRAM.
THE BIGGEST REASON- I'LL IS
THAT SOCIETY HAS DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF MAKING
FAMILIES WHO NEED GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE FEEL TERRIBLE ABOUT
IT. THIS STIGMA IS SO DEEP THAT
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE JUDGED BY
SINCE VIçT BRANDS FAMILY FOR
NEEDING HELP. FOR IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES. THEY FEAR THAT
ACCESSING SUPPORT SERVICES
THROUGH CAL WORKS WILL IMPACT
THEIR IMMIGRATION CASE TO THE
PUBLIC CHARGE. EVEN THOUGH THAT
ROLE HAS BEEN THROWN OUT BY THE
COURTS LAST WEEK IT WILL TAKE A
LOT OF TRYING TO REBUILD.
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES TRUST THAT
APPLYING FOR SERVICES WILL NOT
IMPACT THEIR PATHWAY TO
RESIDENCY OR CITIZENSHIP.
FAMILIES ARE HERE. BECAUSE THEY
ARE FOOD INSECURE A LACK STABLE
HOUSING CHILDCARE AND LESS THAN
ADEQUATE CIRCUMSTANCES MAKING
CPS INTERVENTIONS ALL TOO REAL.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS PROVIDING
STABILITY FOR SO MANY FAMILIES
WHO WOULD OTHERWISE BE ON CAL
WORKS. IT IS REQUIRED FOR COUCH
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE WORKING
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC TO APPLY
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT IF ELIGIBLE
THUS MAKING THEM ELIGIBLE FOR
CAL WORKS GRANTS BUT THEY CAN
STILL ACCESS SUPPORTED SERVICES.
ONCE THESE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT
STOPS FAMILIES AGAIN WILL LOOK
TO THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM FOR
HELP AND SUPPORT. TO UNDO THE
STIGMA AND TO MAKE THE CALL
WORKS PROGRAM ACTUALLY WORKS
WITH FAMILIES HERE ARE SOME
SUGGESTIONS FROM HOWARD'S
CLIENTS THEMSELVES. FIRST LIFT
SANCTIONS FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE
UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
WELFARE TO WORK PROGRAMS DUE TO
LIMITED JOB OPPORTUNITIES AND
LIMITED SCHOOL OPTIONS. WAVE
HOW WORKS OVER PAYMENT
COLLECTIONS FROM FAMILIES
QUALIFY FOR UNEMPLOYMENT. SO
MANY FAMILIES OVERPAYMENTS DUE
BECAUSE IT TOOK SO LONG FOR
THEM TO ACCESS THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. MAKE
PERMANENT ONLINE APPLICATION
AND DOCUMENT COLLECTIONS THAT
CAN STREAMLINE AND INCREASE NEW
APPLICATIONS SPEEDING UP
APPLICATIONS AND PROCESSING I'M
IN A TIMELY MANNER. REQUIRE
COUNTIES TO BETTER UTILIZE THE
CAL WORKS DIVERSION PROGRAM. AT
THIS COULD PROVIDE ONE TIME
CASH BENEFITS TO COVER RENT YOU
ELOISE CHILD CARE AND OTHER
COSTS THAT WOULD PREVENT
FAMILIES FROM HAVING TO GO BACK
ON HOW WORKS PROGRAM. FREEZE
ALL TIME FOX. ALL TIME CLOCK.
AND TELL THE PARTICIPANTS
RECEIVED AT. I'M SORRY SKEWS ME
AT AND TELL ALL. JUST STOP I'M
PROVIDE- CODES FOR CAL WORKS
FAMILIES SO THAT THEY CAN
RECEIVE VACCINES THIS WE'VE
SEEN THIS WORK IN THE CHILD
CARE INDUSTRY AND IT'S A REALLY
GREAT WAY TO ENGAGE SONOMA
FAMILY. REQUIRE COUNTIES TO
BETTER UTILIZE THE COW WORKS
DIVERSION PROGRAM THIS COULD
PROVIDE ONE TIME CASH PAYMENTS
TO COVER RENT UTILITIES
CHILDCARE AND OTHER COSTS.
PROVIDE I'M SORRY SCRUB THE
CHILD CARE WAITING LIST TO
IDENTIFY CAL WORKS A LEGIBLE
FAMILIES. AND PROVIDE THE
FUNDING THAT áP IN OUR IN OUR
AGENCIES WOULD NEED TO DO THAT.
I PROVIDE FUNDING TO STRENGTHEN
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN TV AGENCIES
AND CHILD CARE AGENCIES TO
SCREEN SURVIVORS FOR CHILD CARE
ASSISTANCE. MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES ARE ELIGIBLE FOR POWER
ADDED FOR CHILD CARE AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
KNOW THAT THEY'RE THAT THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE. WE NEED TO BE MORE
DELIBERATE IN ASKING IF A
FAMILY IS A DV SURVIVOR AND
CHANGE THE WAIVER PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS TO A SHALL INSTEAD
OF A MAY. EXPAND HOME VISITING
TO PROVIDE ONE TIME ONE ON ONE
NAVIGATION SERVICES FOR
FAMILIES FIVE BABIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC. I HAVE NEVER HAD
ACCESS TO EARLY MORNING. FIRE
PASSED CAL WORKS PARTICIPANTS
TO SUPPORT AND HELP NEW CLIENTS
NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM. AND
REQUIRE ALL COUNTIES TO COMPLY
IT ALL WORKS TO RIGHT NOW.
HOWARD'S TWO POINT OH IS IN
EVIDENCE AS AUTHENTIC PARENTING
DETACHMENT STRATEGY IN A REAL
WAY OUT OF POVERTY FOR FAMILIES.
THE PANDEMIC AND THE CRISIS CAN
BECOME AN OPPORTUNITY. NOT TO
RETURN TO NORMAL BUT TO REBUILD
AND RE CREATE A SYSTEM THAT
ACTUALLY WORKS FOR FAMILY. BUT
IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE NEED TO
GET FAMILIES WERE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THESE ISSUES A SEAT
AT THE TABLE IN CREATING
SYSTEMS THAT WORK FOR THAT.
ANYBODY WHO'S READY TO DO THAT
WERE READY TO WORK WITH YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU JENNIFER
AND WHAT AN APPROPRIATE WAY FOR
US TO AND THAT FIRST PANELS
LIKE TO THANK ALLTHE PANEL FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY I WILL NOW
BRING IT UP TO THE DíAS TO SEE
IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS.
I WILL BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
PRESENTERS ANOTHER ESPECIALLY.
TO THOSE ARE BRINGING UP THE
COORDINATION WITH THE TRIBAL
GROUPS AND TRIBAL TOWN OF- ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE IS
FOR THE FOOD DISTRIBUTION- THE
SPEAKER- MENTIONED THAT THEY
WERE WORKED WITH THE HOOPA
TRIBE. BUT I'M LOOK BECAUSE WE
HAD A HEARING OF THEIR SELECT
COMMITTEE WE FOUNDED THE FOOD
DISTRIBUTION. DURING A COVERT
NINETEEN AND SOME OF THE OTHER
AREAS WAS A LITTLE CHALLENGING
FOR TRIBAL COMMUNITIES. SO IS
THERE ANY- INPUT THAT. YOU
COULD ADVISE US ON OF HOW THAT
WORKED THERE WITH THE HOOPA.
TRIBE THAT THEN WE COULD
ACTUALLY START TO MOVE FORWARD
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
BUILDING THOSE RELATIONSHIPS.
HI THIS IS SANDRA FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS THE
DEPARTMENT MAY ALSO WANT TO
ADDRESS THIS MORNING I CAN SEE.
THAT THE FOOD BANK FOOD FOR
PEOPLE HAS HAD A LONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE WHO BUT
TRIED THAT ACTUALLY LOST ITS
GROCERY STORE AND THE FOOD BANK
WAS ONE OF ITS ONLY SOURCES OF
SUPPORTS- BUT AS I SAID. AS I
SPOKE TO IT IS IMPERFECT I'M IT
IS COSTLY THERE ARE CONCERNS
ABOUT SUSTAINABILITY SO I THINK
I WILL ON THE POINT ABOUT
NEEDING TO REALLY DO AN
ASSESSMENT AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE FROM. CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE FOODS CHU THE HOURS
THE LOCATIONS- AND THE
SUSTAINABILITY BUT I THINK IT.
IN THIS KIM JONG. DEPART OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ALL JUST ADD TO
ADD VERY EARLY ON THE PANDEMIC
AS WE WERE WITH MANY GROUPS WE
DID HAVE A SPECIFIC. A CALL
WITH TRIBES ARE OFFICE OF
TRIBAL AFFAIRS DIRECTOR HEATHER
HOSLER CONVENES ACT. SO THAT WE
COULD ADDRESS AND IDENTIFY ANY
AND THAT NEEDS FOR THAT WERE
HAPPENING ACROSS THE STATE THAT
IS WHERE. WE SAW EIGHT EIGHT
SOME GAPS IN IN FOOD AND WERE
ABLE TO THEN FOLLOW UP TO BE
MORE TARGETED IN THEIR SPECIFIC
OUTREACH TO ADDRESS THOSE SO.
WE CONTINUED THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THROUGHOUT OUR
TRAVEL ADVISORY. COMMITTEE AND
OUR CONSULTATION- BUT BUT
CERTAINLY THAT INITIAL THAT
REACH OUT TO ADDRESS UNMET
NEEDS- WAS THAT A GOOD SOURCE
OF INFORMATION TO CONTINUE TO
IDENTIFY WHERE WE CAN FOCUS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT THAT OUR
OFFICE CAN DO TO SOLIDIFY SOME
OF THOSE RELATIONSHIPS WITHIN
INDIAN COUNTRY. TO ENSURE THAT
WHEN THE NEXT CRISIS HITS
BECAUSE WE KNOW ONE WILL.
WHETHER IT'S FIRE OR OR RAIN OR
WATER. OR EVEN ANOTHER-
PANDEMIC HOPEFULLY NOT. BUT
THAT THE GROUNDWORK AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS THERE SO THAT
THE FOOD BANKS CAN. I'M START
TO DELIVER- IN A SEAMLESS FLOW
TO THE- INDEED COMMUNITIES HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. OUR
OFFICE IS OPEN TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO ENSURE THOSE
RELATIONSHIP. BUILDING
TECHNIQUES CONTINUE. TO HAPPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU. I AM GOING TO START MY
QUESTIONS TODAY WITH THE L. A.
L. BEFORE I. TURN BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT ASK QUESTIONS
REGARDING CAL WORKS AND
CALFRESH. AND FOR RYAN ANDERSON
I WAS TRYING TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING IF I COULD ABOUT
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN AND
HOW IT COULD SPECIFICALLY HELP
CALIFORNIA'S ANTI POVERTY
PROGRAMS. IT HAPPENED SO
RECENTLY THAT I REALLY WAS
HOPING TO GET YOUR EXPERTISE
AND OPINION ON IT. SPECIFICALLY.
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY FUNDS AND
WHAT OPTIONS DOESTHE
LEGISLATURE HAVING USE OF THOSE
FUNDS. YES RYAN ANDERSON WITH
LA- AGAIN- WE'RE IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF REVIEWING THOSE
PROPOSALS- IN IN PARTICULAR WE-
ARE LOOKINGTO GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
USE OF THOSE ARE. ENDEMIC
EMERGENCY FUNDS THEY THEY DO
APPEAR THAT THEY COULD PROVIDE
SOME SUPPLEMENTAL ASSISTANCE TO
I COMMERCE ELIGIBLE FAMILIES
BUT WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT. AT
THIS TIME ON WHAT THE-
BOUNDARIES OF THAT ASSISTANCE
OR THE OTHER- ASSISTANCE THAT I
WOULD CALL OUT AS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT TO THIS COMMUNITY
WOULD BE THE EXPANSION OF THE
CHILD TAX CREDIT- WHICH WILL
IMPACT CAL WORKS ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES ON. IT IN SOME CASES
TREMENDOUSLY- ESPECIALLY IF AS
THAT IS POSSIBLE IT IS RENDERED
INTO A MONTHLY PAYMENT OR
MONTHLY INSTALLMENT AS OPPOSED
TO AN ANNUAL LUMP SUM SO THOSE
ARE THINGS WE'RE MONITORING AND
WE'LL WE'LL GET BACK. TO YOU AS
SOON AS WE CAN AS WE LEARN MORE.
THANK YOU AND- NOW GOING TO ON
CAL WERE IF I CAN AND- WOULD
LIKE TO PULL IN- DIRECTOR.
JOHNSON OR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
HERNANDEZ INTO THE CONVERSATION
BUT I'M REALLY FOCUSED A BIT ON
CASELOADS AND- WANT TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING FROM YOU-
REGARDING DENIALS IT SEEMS
THAT- MILES HAVE BEEN
INCREASING. IN THE PANDEMIC IN
THE GENDERED STATED IT WAS AT
60% AND WAS AT 48% BEFORE THIS.
TO REALLY DIG IN AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT ELSE WE COULD BE DOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE KEEPING
PEOPLE ON TO THE PROGRAM AND
THEN NOT DENYING THEM. ACCESS
TO THE PROGRAM EXCUSE ME. THANK
YOU CHAIR CAN JOHNSON
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
NOW ALSO ACTORS ARE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR TO JOIN ME IN THE
CONVERSATION HERE. IN TERMS OF
THE NILE SPECIFICALLY AGAIN I
THINK PART OF IT- IS WE WANT
THAT WE SPOKE TO A LITTLE BIT
AROUND THE- INCOME THE
DIVISIONAL INCOME AND THAT
BEING COUNTED- AND THEREFORE
MAKING- INDIVIDUALS- INELIGIBLE
FOR SERVICES I WOULD SAY- IN
TERMS OF- THOSE THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING AND- WANTING TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR ON ONE EFFORT
THAT WE ARE UNDERTAKING. THAT
NOT ONLY FOR CAL WORKS BUT ALSO
FOR A CALFRESH IS OUR
VERIFICATION HAVE WORK. AND
THAT IS SUPPORTING AT THE AT
BILLETE KIND OF BEHIND THE
SCENES IN THE BACKGROUND USING
THE TECHNOLOGY. TO ENSURE THAT
NO MATTER IF IT SAY ELIGIBILITY
WORKER AT LOOKING FOR CAL WORKS
ARE CAFES PURPOSES THAT THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO.
OBTAIN THAT THE INCOME UPDATES
OTHER OTHER VERIFICATIONS ARE
IN THE SYSTEM THE SYSTEM KINGS
OUT OF THAT BUT THE BURDEN IS
LESSENED ON BOTH THE INDIVIDUAL
RECIPIENTS AS WELL AS THE
PROGRAM THE COUNTY THEMSELVES
TO HAVE TO. GO MOST PLACES
THAT'S ONE EFFORTS TO MAINTAIN
I'M SERVICES BUT IN TERMS OF
THE NILES AGAIN IT'S SOME OF
THAT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT THAT
THEN MADE. MAKE THEM TO BE
JEWEL'S INELIGIBLE BUT I DEFER
TO MY COLLEAGUE HERE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. AT HERNANDEZ THAT
SHE'D LIKE TO ADD MORE. THE
ONLY OTHER ADDITION I WOULD
MAKE IS WHAT JENNIFER CRAPPIE
ALLUDED TO EARLIER- AROUND THIS
THE MESSAGING
COMMUNICATION- WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS TO
ENSURE THAT. IF FOR SOME REASON
FOLKS WERE DENIED THAT THEY
KNOW THAT THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY APPLY AT A LATER
DATE RIGHT THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF CONFUSION WITH A LOT OF THE
OTHER. PANDEMIC RELATED
ASSISTANCE- THAT MAY HAVE
DEEMED FOLKS INELIGIBLE AND SO
BEING ABLE TO ADD TO
PROACTIVELY ENGAGE THEM THROUGH
THAT COMMUNICATION IS GONNA BE
REALLY CRITICAL MOVING FORWARD.
SO ALONG THOSE LINES- WE SPEND
A LOT OF OUR TIME IN THIS
COMMITTEE ALSO LOOKING AT
MEDIKAL I'M- WONDERING WHETHER
OR NOT WE CAN SUSPEND RE
DETERMINATIONS THROUGH THE
DURATION OF THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AS- WE HAVE DONE WITH
THE MEDICAL. YES I BEGIN WE ARE
LOOKING TO PROVIDE AS MUCH
PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY AS WE
CANNOT CROSS ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS HERE SO. OUT FOR THE%
PURPOSES OF WHAT WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED TO DATE WE ARE.
PROPOSING TO CONTINUE THAT
AFTER THAT TO THE EMERGENCY.
NEXT QUESTION IF I COULD IS
FOLLOWING UP ON WHAT C. W. D.
A. HAD COMMENTED ON REGARDING
THE GRACE PERIOD- I WAS HOPING
YOU COULD COMMENT ON THAT TEND
TO THE COMPARISONS WITH MEDICAL.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND AN INDUSTRY
WANT TO ADDRESS THAT QUESTION.
I APOLOGIZE COULD YOU REPEAT
THE QUESTION I WAS HAVING
TROUBLE HEARING C. W. D. A. HAD
COMMENTED THAT THERE WAS A
GRACE PERIOD FOR A RE
DETERMINATIONS THAT HAD NOT
SUBMITTED THE APPROPRIATE
PAPERWORK AND THAT. ON MEDICARE
ALL WE WERE ABLE TO RETURN BACK
TO BEING BACK ON MEDIC CAL
WHILE ON CAL WORKS WE HAD TO
REAPPLY AND WAS WONDERING WHY
THERE WAS NOT A GRACE PERIOD
WITH AND CAL WORKS. SO THIS IS
A CHALLENGING ONE- SO- THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ARE
FEDERALLY MANDATED AND THEY ARE
CLOSELY ALIGNED BETWEEN CAL
WORKS AND CALFRESH AND SO IT'S
REALLY PROBLEMATIC TO BE ABLE
TO APPLY FLEXIBILITIES TO ONE
PROGRAM AND NOT THE OTHER AND
SO WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT- THE REDETERMINATION-
PERIOD HERE FOR KICKING THE CAN
FORWARD IF YOU WILL- WE DID IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY
FOR BOTH PROGRAMS. I'M SO
SEPARATING THAT OUT IS
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE- GIVEN HOW
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO IMPLEMENT-OUR AUTOMATION SYSTEM- TO
CLOSELY ALIGN INTERCONVERT
THOSE THOSE POLICY ALIGNMENT
AND AGAIN A LOT OF THAT IS
FEDERALLY DRIVEN- I. THOUGHT
YOUR COMMENT EARLIER ABOUT HOW
THE REGION TERMINATIONS ALLOWED
US TO KICK THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD BUT THAT THE BENEFIT IS
FAMILIES CAN STAY ON LONGER.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
FAMILY STAY ON LONGER IF WE
CANNOT END THUS THE REASONING
WHY I WAS ASKING ABOUT RE
DETERMINATIONS. THROUGHOUT THE
REMAINDER OF THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY I. FEEL LIKE I'VE
MADE MY POINT THE ONES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO- NOW MOVE ON TO A
QUESTION IF I CAN REGARDING THE
ONE POINT 5% THAT SOME COUNTIES
ARE RECEIVING- WITHIN CAL WORKS
AND- WHETHER OR NOT THAT.
EQUITABLE IS THAT. AN
APPROPRIATE WAY FOR US TO BE
DISTRIBUTING THESE RESOURCES.
AGAIN DEFERRED TO. DEPUTY
DIRECTOR HAND ANDERSON ON THAT
QUESTION THANK YOU. I'M NOT
SURE THAT I AND I CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION
APOLOGIES- I'M- ON PAGE
NINETEEN OF THE AGENDA IS A-
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
ONE POINT 5% INCREASE TO CAL
ARTS GRANTS FOR CERTAIN
COUNTIES THAT ALL APPEAR TO BE
ON THE COAST. AND I'M WONDERING
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS AN
EQUITABLE WAY AND CONSISTENT
WAY THAT WE HAVE- APPLIED-
INCREASES TILL CAL WORKS GRANTS
OR OTHER PROGRAMS. OKAY NOW I
AM TRACKING APOLOGIES FOR THAT
THANK YOU- SO PART OF WHAT THIS
DOES IS LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
LOWER COST COUNTIES AND THE
COASTAL COUNTIES. AND SO REALLY
IT IS LOOKING AT THOSE AREAS
THAT HAVE A- UNFORTUNATELY-
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGHER-
HIGHER COST OF LIVING RIGHT AND
SO- IF I'M UNDERSTANDING
LOOKING AT THE CHART THAT IT'S
ON PAGE NINETEEN I BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS WHAT IT'S REFERENCING.
I AM HAPPY TO HELP US FOLLOW UP
IN A CONVERSATION I THINK WHAT
I'M REALLY TRYING TO DIG INTO
HIS THIS IS NOT- CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WE DO WITH ANOTHER
PROGRAMS. AND SO I'M REALLY
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHY IT'S
STILL PRESENT WITHIN- TODAY'S
PROGRAM AND WHAT REASONS- WE
HAVE BECAUSE I. DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE- WORKING TO PROVIDE
THOSE RESOURCES TOWARDS OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
REPRESENTING. PORTION OF THE
MAP THAT IS NOT SEEING THOSE
INCREASES. MANY OF US ARE
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE NOT
RECEIVING OUR FAIR SHARE. AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO TAKEN TO WITHOUT
QUESTION. WITH THAT I WILL
TRANSITION TO CALFRESH IF I CAN.
AND WOULD LIKE TO ASK IF I
COULD. NOT CURRENTLY. EXCUSE
ME- THE DEPARTMENT EARLIER HAD
SAID THAT YOU WERE WORKING ON
EQUITABLE PARTICIPATION BY
WORKING ON LANGUAGE ACCESS AND
WAS HOPING THAT YOU COULD
EXPAND UPON THAT FURTHER. GLAD
TO CHAIR- CAN JOHNSON
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
APPLE OF THINGS THAT WE'VE
DONE- OVER TIME TO REALLY AGAIN
BOTH AB MAP- AT DEMOGRAPHIC
LANGUAGE NEEDS- IN THE AND MAP
THAT AGAINST ELIGIBLE
POPULATIONS AND CREWS CURRENTLY
RECEIVING. CALFRESH SERVICES WE
DID THIS AS PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD FOR ALL
WORKGROUP ADD THAT WE WORKED ON
WITHIN THE NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS- PREVIOUSLY I
REALLY TRYING TO AGAIN
IDENTIFIES SOME TARGETED
STRATEGIES AND WHERE WE ARE
SEEING KIND OF THAT THE
GREATEST GAPS AT IN TERMS OF
LANGUAGE ACCESS WE ALSO HAD- A-
A FELLOW FROM AT UC BERKELEY-
DO SOME ADDITIONAL WORK TO
IDENTIFY HOW WE COULD IMPROVE.
UPON A LANGUAGE ACCESS IN ALL
ALL ALL KINDS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS OPTIONS
EVERYTHING FROM HOW INFORMATION
IS AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE OF
COURSE I WRITTEN DOCUMENTS
ETCETERA AND THAT CERTAINLY AYE
WE CONTINUE TO OFFER ALL
OPTIONS IN THE MULTIPLE
MODALITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
CONNECT WITH THE PROGRAM SO.
AGAIN I THINK OUR OUR EFFORT
INTO ALSO DISCREPANCIES EARLIER
COMMENT RELATED TO OUR
POPULATIONS IN THE PUBLIC
CHARGE IMPACT WHAT THAT STANDS
FOR COMMUNITIES WE AGREE AND
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE SOME TIME. OR AT CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES TO RE ENGAGE AND WE
DID SEE SOME CHANGE OVER TIME
IN TERMS OF A BOTH A NEW
ENROLLMENTS AND ALSO I IN TERMS
OF THOSE STAYING ON PROGRAM SO
WE WANT TO BE FOCUSED IN OUR
OUTREACH STRATEGIES- ESPECIALLY
AS IT RELATES TO CALFRESH AGAIN
USING SOME OF THAT INFORMATION
THAT WE'VE- OBTAINED TO DATE
AND THE FEEDBACK WE'RE
RECEIVING FROM FROM THOSE THAT
ARE IN OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR AND I WILL
JUST COMMENT MY OFFICE HAS- IN
JOINT PARTNERING. AND WORKING
WITH YOU ON. CASH OUT FOR SSI
WITH CALFRESH AND LOOK FOR TO
OR WITH YOU AS WE EXTEND THESE
BENEFITS- WITHIN HIGHER
EDUCATION- BUT DID WANT TO ASK
IF I COULD THAT IT DOES SEEM
THERE'S A FAIR AMOUNT OF TURN
THAT IS. GOING ON THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB RECENTLY
REPORTED. AN ESTIMATE THAT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALFRESH
HOUSEHOLDS EXIT BECAUSE OF.
ADMINISTRATIVE REASONS OUR
PAPERWORK REASONS. AND THAT
MORE THAN HALF OF THOSE ARE
STILL ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM.
MY QUESTION IS THE DEPARTMENT
DOING OUTREACH TO THE HOMELESS-
APPLICANTS INTO SEEING IF WE
CAN INCLUDE THEM IN OUR PROGRAM.
I APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION VERY
MUCH CHAIR AND SHARE THE
CONCERN AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH A
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAP AROUND
THIS ANALYSIS AND- SO YES AS
REPORT ADDS. THAT CURRENTLY
IDENTIFIES UNDER FEDERAL
REGULATIONS WE HAVE MOST OF OUR
CALFRESH AT CASELOAD
INDIVIDUALS PARTICIPATING
CERTIFIED FOR TWELVE MONTHS IN
THE REQUIRED TO. REPORT A
PERIOD AT THE SIX MONTH MARK
**** BE CERTIFICATIONS THAT THE
TWELVE MONTH MARK INCLUDING AN
INTERVIEW AND SO. WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN RESPONSE- IN
RELATIONSHIP TO COLD IT IN
AGAIN- ONE OF LIFT UP THE MANY
WAYS THAT WE'VE BEEN CREATING
ADDITIONAL MODALITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO ENGAGE AS WELL AS
FLEXIBILITY SPENT WE DID. OFTEN
TO A WAIVER TO PROVIDE SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO WAIVE THAT
INTERVIEW REQUIREMENT AT
ADDITIONAL CERTIFICATION AND
RECERTIFICATION FIRST FOR
HOUSEHOLD TO SUBMIT A COMPLETE
APPLICATION. THAT WEAVER AT
WILL WILL TAKE US THROUGH THIS
IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR- WE HAVE
NOT YET HEARD BETTER ANXIOUSLY
ENGAGED WITH USDA TO CONTINUE
THAT WAY BURKE POST PANDEMIC SO
WE'RE GLAD TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT
FRONT. INDIVIDUALLY AND APART
FROM A COPAYS WE M. AS REQUIRED
BY LAST YEAR'S BUDGET BILL AT
THE SCHOOL TO THE WORKGROUP
WHICH STAKEHOLDERS TO ASSESS
THE STATE'S IMPLEMENTATION OF
SIMPLIFIED REPORTING. AND
IDENTIFYING AREAS FOR
IMPROVEMENT THAT ARE WITHIN THE
AT THE FEDERAL REGULATIONS WE
ARE GOING TO FACILITATE THE
DEVELOPMENT- AND POTENTIAL
IMPLEMENTATION OF A PRE
POPULATED OUT A BIT
CERTIFICATION FORM. TO HELP
PROVIDE CLIENTS ALL OF THE
INFORMATION THAT IS CURRENTLY
ON FILE WITH THE COUNTY AND ASK
THEM TO REAFFIRM WHICH WE THINK
COULD ALSO. MAKE MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THE CONTRIBUTION
I IN THAT SPACE. I'M WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT- TO IMPROVE
COMPLETION RATES AND IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CODE FOR
AMERICA WE'VE EXPANDED BEGETS
CALFRESH APPLICATION ASSISTANCE
TOOL. AT TO INCLUDE THAT MADE
APPLICATION REPORTING THAT'S IT
NOW. AVAILABLE IN TWENTY NINE
COUNTIES AND IN SOME AT TEXTRON.
FOR THE PURCHASE IN SOME LIVE
CHAT THAT HELPS Q. AND A- I
ALSO NOTE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO. REALLY FOCUS AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP THAT
YOU MENTIONED ON SUPPORTING OUR
SOCIETY POPULATION GETTING
ACCESS. SO AB TO ENSURE THERE'S
A BENEFIT RETENTION IN OUR
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE. WITH
DISABILITIES- WE ARE-
IMPLEMENTING THE ELDER
SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION IN
ELIMINATING THAT RE
CERTIFICATION ENERGY
REQUIREMENTS IMPROVING ALSO A
THIRTY SIX MONTH WINDOW SILVA
HAVE A LONGER- APPLICATION
PERIOD AGAIN NOT ANTICIPATING
CHANGES TO OCCUR FOR THAT
SPECIFIC POPULATION SO. I THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY UNDERWAY AND HAVE
ACTUALLY OPERATIONALIZED AB
ABSOLUTELY WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE. OF THE RETENTION
ESPECIALLY OF COURSE FOR THOSE
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO CONTINUE ON
THE PROGRAM. Q- FINAL QUESTION
CALIFORNIA SHOULDN'T WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE PANDEMIC
AND PLEINEMENT COMPENSATION.
MADE MANY HOUSEHOLDS AN
ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH
ORIGINALLY BUT NOW THAT THE
POCD IS EXCLUDED FROM CALFRESH
ELIGIBILITY WHAT STRATEGIES ARE
BEING USED TO RECONNECT THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS WITH THE PROGRAM.
SURE AS I'VE MENTIONED IN MY
EARLIER REMARKS WE HAVE CREATED
A NEW PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY ET DE I AND SOME OTHER
STATE PARTNERS TO TEST OUT A
TARGETED OUTREACH CAMPAIGN SO
AGAIN AS WE'VE BEEN AT- AS I
THINK WAS REFERENCED EARLIER
APPROACHING VARIOUS CLIFFS AND
TERMS OF AT AT AND IMPLEMENT
POTENTIALLY ENDING WHICH AGAIN
GRATEFUL THAT WE'RE CONTINUING.
WE ACTUALLY WERE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THEM TO GENERATE THROUGH
THEIR SYSTEMS THE CONNECTION TO
CALFRESH- AND SO WE WANT TO
CONTINUE THAT KIND OF
COLLABORATION TO BE FOCUSED
AGAIN ON AND FORMING PEOPLE
THAT THIS MAY BE A RESOURCE
THAT THEY COULD BOTH BE
ELIGIBLE FOR AN ACCESS-
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE PARTNERING
WITH CODE FOR AMERICA ACT WITH
THE UPDATED GET CAUGHT GET
FRESH APPLICATION ASSISTANCE
TOOL AGAIN TO LOOK AT SOME
MESSAGING- AND SEE IF WE CAN'T.
GET MAKE STILL TAKE THOSE
CONNECTIONS WITH THOSE-
RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT SO
THAT'S JUST AT THE START OF
THOSE EFFORTS AGAIN LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH MANY
PARTNERS ACROSS THE SUN
ADDITIONAL WAYS WE CAN GET THIS
INFORMATION OUT. TO THOSE WHO
NEED IT MOST THANK YOU DIRECTOR
BEFORE WE CLOSE OUT THIS PANEL
I WILL NOW ASK QUESTIONS OF
DIRECTOR KILGORE WITH. THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES- MY FIRST QUESTION FOR
YOU THAT THERE ARE CURRENTLY
HAS MORE THAN SEVEN BILLION IN
UNCOLLECTED CHILD SUPPORT DEBT.
MUCH OF IT WHICH IS OWED BY
PERSONS EARNING LESS THAN
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
AN ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT MUCH OF
THIS DEBT IS UNCOLLECTIBLE. HAS
THE TIME COME FOR THE STATES TO
FORGIVE THIS OLD CHILD SUPPORT
THAT DIRECTOR. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION AND IT WORKED FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES NASA THE COLLECTIVE
ONLY SAY THAT WAS DONE IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE IDENTIFIED HE-
TOOK A LOOK AT THE AVERAGE
BALANCE AN ESTIMATED THAT THAT
WOULD BE AT AROUND THIRTY FIVE
TO THIRTY NINE BILLION DOLLARS.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME RIGHT NOW
IT'S SITTING AT EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THERE MANY
OF WHICH WERE ADOPTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE PRINTER PRACTICE
HAS MITIGATED SOME OF THE BUILD
UP OF BILLS ARREARS BUT
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S- MORE TO GO
THAT ROUTE. AT THAT TIME IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE THERE WAS A TEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN THAT AND
CLICK WILL GET OVER THE
GOVERNMENT. AND THAT'S DROPPED
ON THE SEVEN. NUMBER MY
GENERATION. CASE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO KIND OF MANY. THE OF THAT
PARTICULAR. BUT OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE STILL MORE DIRECTION
CHINKO. WITH REGARD TO THAT
PARTICULAR AREA. INTO
DEPARTMENTS PROPOSAL FOR THE
CAKE BACK IN THE COLLECTABILITY
IS TO GET THE ECONOMIC AND
SOCIOLOGICAL INSIGHT. INTO WHAT
FACTORS INSURANCE EARNED BEST
FORECAST THE COLLECTABILITY
AMONG THE DEAD. AND WITH THAT
INFORMATION THE DEPARTMENT
COULD MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
HOW BEST TO PROPOSED CHANGES.
IN THE MANAGEMENT OF THE
RAIDERS AND- IN THE FUTURE. AT
THIS POINT IN TIME THAT WE HAVE
NO MECHANISM TO IDENTIFY WHAT'S
UNCOLLECTIBLE IN TO REMOVE IT
FROM THE BOOKS. THAT'S WHERE
WE'LL GET SOME. THANK YOU UP ON
QUESTIONS. AT USE OF. LICENSES
TO PUNISH PEOPLE FOR THINGS
THAT ARE NOT RELATED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY HAS COME INTO QUESTION.
IN RECENT YEARS. AND THERE ARE
SERIOUS CONCERNS THAT
SUSPENDING LICENCES TO RECOVER
DEBT IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
BECAUSE PEOPLE LOSE JOBS AND
INCOME. WHEN THEY CAN'T DRIVE.
YET OUR CHILD SUPPORT. PROGRAMS
CONTINUE TO USE LICENSE
SUSPENSION AS A WAY TO COLLECT
THAT. HOW MANY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY OF LICENSE
SUSPENSION DUE TO UNPAID CHILD
SUPPORT AND WHAT IS THE TREND
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS. SO
THE DEBT IS A LITTLE SKETCHY
MISTER WE KNOW HOW MANY
SUSPENSION REQUEST WE SENT OVER
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES- WHAT THEY ACTUALLY
SUSPEND WHETHER THEY SUSPENDED
BECAUSE OF CHILD SUPPORT
BECAUSE OF OTHER MATTERS. IS
REALLY UNKNOWN TO US- THAT'S
AROUND UP AROUND A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND ANNUALLY WE ALSO
RELEASE ABOUT THE SAME AMOUNT
AND AS FAR COLLECTIONS TOOLS
THAT. THE DRIVER'S LICENSE
SUSPENSION IS MORE ABOUT
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE CHILD CARE
PROGRAM THAN IT IS ABOUT
COLLECTIONS WE DO HAVE A STATE
WE GET A COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT
INDICATED. FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS COLLECTED PRIOR TO THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE SUSPENSION AND
A HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION
COLLECTED AFTERWARDS. THERE'S A
POPULATION OF BOOKS THAT ARE ON
PAINT. THAT ARE IN THE GIG.
ECONOMY THAT ARE IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY AND THIS IS
THE ONLY MECHANISM WE HAVE TO
ENGAGE WITH THEM. BUT I WOULD
AGREE THAT THE DRIVER'S LICENSE
SUSPENSION IS A BIT OF A BLUNT
TOOL. AND TO THAT EXTENT I
THINK THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES TO
LOOK AT THIS AND FINE TUNE AND
WE'D BE INTERESTED IN.
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR SOME. PAPER TO COME UP.
THANK YOU. BEFORE WE MOVE
FORWARD I'D LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
THAT. SUBCOMMITTEE REQUESTS
THAT ARE MADE IN THE AGENDA AT
THE END OF ISSUE ONE. STARTING
AT THE BOTTOMS OF PAGE THIRTY
THREE. AND THESE ARE. FIRST I'D
LIKE TO ASK THE L. A. O. TO
PROVIDE A LIST OF OPTIONS WITH
GENERAL FUND COSTS. AND
INDICATING WHETHER OR NOT THIS
IS A ONE TIME OR ONGOING COSTS.
FOR SIMPLIFYING ACCESS TO THE
CAL WORK PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY.
AND TO ALLOW FOR MAXIMUM
UTILIZATION OF THE PROGRAM FOR
FAMILIES IN NEED. IT IS
REQUESTED THAT THIS COME BACK
TO THE SUB COMMITTEE BY MID
APRIL. TWO WE ASK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE A
LIST OF OPTIONS WITH GENERAL
FUND COSTS AND INDICATING.
WHETHER OR NOT THESE ARE ONE
TIME OR ONGOING COSTS. FOR
SIMPLIFYING ACCESS TO THE
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM. AND A
PROFILE OF WHAT COSTS WOULD
MEAN TO MAXIMIZE. EMERGENCY
FOOD ASSISTANCE STATEWIDE IT IS
REQUESTED THAT THIS ALSO COME
BACK IN MID APRIL. THREE WE ASK
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION. THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN INCLUDED AS PART OF A
REPORT THAT WAS REQUIRED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET. ON THE
STATUTORY CHANGES NEEDED TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE. THE CALOR.
WHICH WAS NOT RECEIVED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY CALENDAR YEAR.
FOUR WE REQUEST A MORE IN DEPTH
INFORMATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES ON
ITS RESEARCH PROPOSALS AND A
SCHEDULE WITH THE CONVERSATIONS
TO OCCUR SOON WITH INTEREST
INTERESTED LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
ON IF AND HOW THESE ISSUES CAN
BE RESOLVED AS A PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET. APART
FROM THESE REQUEST PLEASE KNOW
THAT OUR STAFF MAY. ALSO
REQUEST FURTHER INFORMATION
AFTER THIS HEARING AND AS WE
DEVELOP OUR PROPOSALS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION. BUT CAN I FIRST ASK
IF THERE'S ANY FEEDBACK OR
REACTION AT THIS TIME FROM THE
L. A. O. OR THE ADMINISTRATION
REGARDING THESE REQUEST.
ADJUSTED PRE INSTALLMENT
FINANCE. SO LIKE I SAID JUST
GET SOME CLARIFICATION ON-
REQUEST NUMBER TWO AND THE WAY
THAT I'M UNDERSTANDING IN THIS
IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
LOOKING FOR A POTENTIAL OR
ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS BEYOND
WHAT'S INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET RELATED TO THE
CONFERENCE PROGRAM AND I THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO COMMENT
THAT AT THIS TIME WE DON'T HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS-
BEYOND WHAT'S BEEN INCLUDED- TO
THE EXTENT I THINK THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL IS IT FIVE THIS ENDS
UP BEING A PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. I'D BE HELPFUL THE
LAST NO AND TOTAL THROUGHOUT
THE- MAYBE GET SOMETHING BACK
FROM YOUR OR YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF ON THE AGENDA IN TOTAL ON
WHAT PRIORITIES THAT YOU'D LIKE
US. TO MAYBE LOOK AND SEE IF WE
CAN PROVIDE TECHNICAL SO ON
THEIR THIS QUITE A FEW I
REQUEST OF A PROPOSALS. HERE
ARE PRIORITIES AND- YEAH KIND
OF THE TIME FRAME THAT WERE
GOING ON WITH COMING UP WITH A
MEMBER VINCE THE WORKING. THE
DEPARTMENTS OF FINANCE AND
DEPARTMENTS ARE WORKING ON. HI
I THINK WORKERS. A LITTLE TOO
HIGH ON ON BEING ABLE TO
ADDRESS EVERY SINGLE PRIORITY.
SO I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
IT MAY BE ON THINGS THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED AS A PRIORITY FOR
THAT THE LEGISLATURE. IF YOU
CAN LET US KNOW AND THEN MAYBE
IF THERE'S THINGS BEYOND THAT
IT MIGHT BE MORE APPROPRIATE
TO. OUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
COLLEAGUES TO MAYBE LOOK AT
SOME OF THESE ISSUES FOR YOU-
BOB HAPPY TO CONTINUE THAT
DISCUSSION. I AM HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP OFFLINE I WOULD JUST
HIGHLIGHT THAT WITHIN THE
AGENDA WE SEE THE NEED FOR
THIS- DISCUSSION AND- REALLY
WOULD. LIKE TO PROVIDE SOME
URGENCY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING IT PRIOR TO THE MAY
REVISION. AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO THANK VERY MUCH PANEL
ONE. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON THE
PANEL TO ON CURRENT CRITICAL
STEPS TOWARDS RACIAL EQUITY. WE
WILL HAVE EIGHT PANELISTS FOR
ISSUE TO AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ADRIANA- ALMOST YAMAMOTO.
POLICY ANALYST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER. AGAIN WE WILL HOLD ALL
MEMBERS QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER
THE PRESENTERS HAVEN'T
CONCLUDED. MYSTERON MOST
YAMAMOTO PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS A DROUGHT AROUND THE
STATE A MODEL POLICY ANALYST AT
THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND
POLICY CENTER. AND I AM HONORED
TO BE HERE TODAY TO KICK OFF
THIS INCREDIBLE PANEL ON
ADVANCING RACIAL EQUITY. IN A
RECENT REPORT CONFRONTING
RACISM OVERCOMING COBIT
NINETEEN AND ADVANCING HEALTH
EQUITY WE PRESENTED AGE
ADJUSTED COVERT NINETEEN CASE
AND DEATH RATES BY RACE
ETHNICITY. AND FOUND THAT
NATIVE HAWAIIAN AND OTHER
PACIFIC ISLANDER CALIFORNIANS
AS WELL AS A LOT NEXT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE HIGHEST
RATES OF COVERT NINETEEN
INFECTION AND DEATH. WE
ACTUALLY JUST RECENTLY UPDATED
THE CHARTS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
TODAY'S AGENDA AND THIS REMAINS
UNCHANGED. THESE DISPARITIES
ARE ALARMING ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THAT SOME RACIAL
ETHNIC GROUPS SUCH AS LIVE NEXT
CALIFORNIANS ARE GENERALLY
YOUNGER. THAN OTHER DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUPS. AS YOU ALL KNOW AGE IS
RELEVANT BECAUSE THE RISK FOR
SEVERE ILLNESS AND EVEN DEATH
FROM COVERT NINETEEN INCREASES
AS A PERSON. GETS OLDER OF
COURSETHE OTHER MAJOR RISK
FACTOR IS HAVING AN UNDERLYING
HEALTH CONDITIONS SUCH AS HEART
CONDITION. ASTHMA OR A WEAKENED
IMMUNE SYSTEM AND WE KNOW THAT
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
NATION RACIAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES PERSIST IN CHRONIC
HEALTH CONDITIONS. AND EVEN
MORTALITY. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
TAKE A STEP BACK AND ASK WHY DO
WE SEE RACIAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THERE'S A LOT OF RESEARCH THAT
POINTS TO THE PURPOSE FULL
INTEGRATION OF RACIST POLICIES
AND PRACTICES FROM HOUSING TO
THE ENVIRONMENT EMPLOYMENT TO
HEALTH CARE THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
TO EDUCATION. ALL OF THOSE
CONDITIONS IMPACT HEALTH. AND
SO THE RACIAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN COVERT NINETEEN
CASES AND THAT'S CONFIRM WHAT
MANY HAVE FIRMLY ESTABLISHED.
THAT RACISM IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE. LONG STANDING ISSUES OF
RACISM EMBEDDED IN EVERY
INSTITUTION HAVE PLACED PEOPLE
OF COLOR AT A HIGHER RISK OF
HARM. FROM COVERT NINETEEN. OUR
REPORT INCLUDE SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES WHERE FROM THE MOMENT
THE POLICY WAS CONCEIVED THE
INTENT WAS TO BLOCK BLACK LATIN
NEXT AMERICAN INDIAN AND OTHER
FAMILIES OF COLOR. FROM HIGH
QUALITY HOUSING HEALTHCARE
EMPLOYMENT EDUCATION AND THE
ABILITY TO BUILD GENERATIONAL
WEALTH. FOR EXAMPLE GOVERNMENT
SUPPORTED HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION AND DISPLACEMENT
ON THE BASIS OF RACE IS DEEPLY
INGRAINED IN THE UNITED STATES
THAN IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
INCLUDES THE OFFICIAL
GOVERNMENT POLICY OF REDLINING
PREDOMINATELY PREDOMINATELY
BLACK AND LATIN NEXT
NEIGHBORHOODS WHICH LED TO THE
DENIAL OF MORTGAGES FOR HOMES
IN THESE AREAS PREVENTING BOTH
INDIVIDUAL ACCESS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND NEIGHBORHOOD
CAPITAL INVESTMENT FOR BLACK
AND LATIN NEXT FAMILIES.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS THE RACIST
FEDERAL POLICY THAT BLOCK
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS FROM
ACCESSING COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
COVERAGE THROUGH MEDICAID I'LL
ORDER FOR PURCHASING FEDERALLY
SUBSIDIZED COVERAGE THROUGH
HEALTH INSURANCE MARKETPLACES
SUCH AS COVERED CALIFORNIA.%
THIS EXCLUSION HAS ALWAYS BEEN
HARMFUL BUT IT IS ESPECIALLY
PROBLEMATIC DURING A PANDEMIC
WHAT WE SEE IS THAT LET NEXT
CALIFORNIANS REMAIN MORE LIKELY
TO BE UNINSURED AND
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS MAKE
UP THE LARGEST SHARE OF PEOPLE
WHO LACK HEALTH COVERAGE IN THE
STATE. THESE ARE JUST A FEW
EXAMPLES AGAIN THERE'S A LOT OF
RESEARCH THAT DOCUMENTS HOW
RACISM PERSISTS IN VARIOUS
INSTITUTIONS AND HOW THAT
IMPACTS HEALTH AS WELL AS THE
EFFECTIVE EVERYDAY RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION OR INTERPERSONAL
RACISM ON HEALTH. ALL IN ALL
RACIAL USING RACIAL HEALTH
INEQUITIES ARE THE RESULT OF
POLICYMAKERS AND OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WITH POWER
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTING
POLICIES AND PRACTICES THAT
HAVE CREATED ADVANTAGES FOR
WHITE PEOPLE AND HAVE A PRESS
TO PEOPLE OF COLOR. BOLD POLICY
ACTION IS NEEDED TO CORRECT
THESE AFFECTS DECLARING RACISM
AS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA IS AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP IN THAT DIRECTION
BECAUSE IN ORDER FOR POLICY
MAKERS AND OTHER LEADERS TO
SOLVE A PROBLEM WE NEED TO
DEFINE IT AND CALIFORNIA HAS
YET TO DO THAT ALSO
DECLARATIONS ARE OFTEN THE
FIRST STEP IN PROMPTING POLICY
ACTION. AND THE ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES. ON A FINAL NOTE WE
CAN'T GO BACK TO THE SAME
CALIFORNIA OR NORMAL BECAUSE
THAT WAY OF LIFE WAS NOT
WORKING FOR SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS OF COLOR. STATE
LEADERS HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE A CALIFORNIA WITH ANTI
RACIST POLICIES THAT VALUE THE
LIFE OF EVERY CALIFORNIAN AND
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE HAS THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO BE
HEALTHY AND THRIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM MARCO ME JACK DEPUTY
SECRETARY PROGRAM AND FISCAL
AFFAIRS CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY MARCO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR POSTING THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION AND
BITING ME CERTAINLY TO BE PART
OF THAT OUT BEFORE I BEGAN I DO
WANT TO EXPAND- AT LEAST FROM
OUR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY FAMILY INCLUDING OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES. OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILIES OF THOSE WHO WERE
MURDERED YESTERDAY TO LANA. AND
I ALSO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
JUST EIGHTY THAT ASIAN
AMERICANS ARE ASIAN AMERICAN
FAMILY FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS IN
CALIFORNIA. HE CAN'T PREVAIL I
AM THAT WE SEE WHEN WE MUST
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
SAFE. AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
YOU'RE IN A REALLY IMPORTANT
PART OF THE FABRIC OF OUR
STATE. I ALSO WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT
THAT AT THE END OF THIS WEEK WE
WILL BE. APPROACHING THE ONE
YEAR MARK OF WHEN THE GOVERNOR
ISSUED THE STATE HOME ORDER
RELATED TO COVER NINETEEN. AND
A LOT HAS CHANGED OVER THE
COURSE OF LAST YEAR AND WE'VE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE PIECES. I THINK THIS IS
BEEN A DIFFICULT YEAR FOR MANY
OF US AND SO I THINK THAT.
HOPEFULLY THERE IS MUCH MORE
OPEN AHEAD OF US AND I'M. WE
ARE THRILLED AND EXCITED ABOUT.
EFFORTS UNDER WAY TO FURTHER
MEDIC. THE SPREAD OF THE- MUST
HELLO KITTY TO SURE THE WE'RE
ACT. TO THE COMPANY. PAXTON
WELL. MISTER CHAIRMAN OKAY
NINETY. AND THE KIND MAKE
REALLY HAVE A- MONSTER HEALTH
AND- SEEN AMONG OF. DEMOCRATS
ALSO HIGHLIGHTS THIS IS REYES.
AND THAT WAS CREATED SOCIAL.
ECONOMIC AND HEALTH INEQUITIES
CONTRIBUTING TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGHER
INFECTION AND MORTALITY RATES
FOR BOTH CHRONIC AND INFECTIOUS
DISEASES. AND COOPER NINETEEN
INCIDENTS HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY BLACK AND
LATINO AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
POPULATION. HIGH PREVALENCE OF
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS
SUCH AS DIABETES OBESITY AND
HYPERTENSION I'M NOT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR INCREASES
THE LIKELIHOOD OF MORE SEVERE
OUTCOMES AS WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PAST YEAR. AND AS
WE LOOK TO OUR RECOVERY WE MUST
RECOMMIT OURSELVES TO ENSURING
THAT WE'RE BUILDING HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. DON'T FURTHER
PERPETUATE THESE RACIAL
INEQUITIES A LOOK TO ADDRESS
THAT. WE ALSO MUST ACT ON THE
STRUCTURAL ASPECTS OF OUR
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES TO ENSURE
WE ADDRESS THAT ADDRESS
INDIVIDUAL AND IMPLICIT BIAS
SEES SMOKE ALSO ADDRESSING THE
RACIAL INEQUITIES. THEY MIGHT
PERPETUATE. AND I WILL LOOK
FURTHER WE MUST LOW FOR A APPS
IN OR TO ADDRESS SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. IN
ORDER PREVENT AB OKAY IN THE
FOR PLACE DEMOCRATIC AND IN
FACT DISEASE. AMONG ALL OUR
BLACK AND BROWN FAMILY
NEIGHBORS HOW DO WE DO THIS. I
THINK WE SET GROUNDWORK WITH
REGARDS OF OUR WORK RELATED TO
THE PANDEMIC FROM INSURING THAT
TESTING WAS MORE EQUITABLE
RELATED TO IT. TIP CODE NUMBER
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY COOKING
NINETEEN SIMILARLY. WITH
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION. I'M A
HARD PART ALSO ENGAGE IN OTHER
WHICH IS MASTER FOR EACH AND
MAKE SURE THEY- AGING IS.
EQUITIES PART OF IT AGING COME.
OUR MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY
LEARNING CARE OUR HERO HEALTH
TASK FORCE THE WORK DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES IS DOWN AROUND
CAL WORKS AND THE OUTCOMES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE- BECAUSE OF
THAT WE HAVE BEFORE YOUNG BACK
OUTSIDE RELATED TO CALLIE. AND
REALLY LOOK AT WAYS IN WHICH WE-
IT WE RE. THE MEDICAID SYSTEM.
COLLECTIVELY I THINK WE ARE A
LOT MORE WORK AHEAD OF US AND
WE AGREED THAT RACISM HAS HAD A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON HEALTH
OUTCOMES IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
COMMIT OURSELVES AS A
GOVERNMENT INSTITUTION TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. REDRESSED
MANY OF THESE INEQUITIES AND
DISPARITIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM TIM JOHNSON DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. DIRECTOR JOHN.
THANK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS CAN
JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES NINETY ONE I JUST
APPRECIATE AT THAT THE PANEL
THE AGENDA AT THIS A COMPONENT.
OF THE CONVERSATION AND- WELL
ALSO ASKED AND APOLOGIES FROM
OUR DIRECTOR OF OFFICE THAT.
OFFICE OF EQUITY AB MYSELF A
RELEASE WHO'S ACTUALLY WORKING
ON IT DRESSINGS AMERICAN
EQUITIES. AS WE SPEAK AND
UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T BE HERE SO
I WILL ALSO COVER AT THE
QUESTIONS ADD NEXT IN IN THE
AGENDA ON HER SEGMENT. I'M SO
START WITH HOW WORKS THE
QUESTIONS ARE RELATED TO YOU-
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE CALYXT
AT POPULATION. THE COW WORKS
POPULATION IS PREDOMINANTLY
FEMALE JUST SHY OF NINETY
PERCENT. THE AVERAGE AGE OF THE
HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD AND CAL WORKS
IS APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
YEARS OLD. AND THE AVERAGE
ASSISTANT UNIT SIZE IS TWO AND
A HALF OF COURSE WE ARE PEOPLE
SET USUALLY ENDS UP BEING AN
ADULT WITH TWO CHILDREN. AND I
AM NOT UNLIKE AS THAT THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER OUTLINED.
BLACK HISPANIC AND LATINO
POPULATIONS ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN CAL WORKS
PROGRAMS AS COMPARED TO THE
OVERALL STATEWIDE POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA. THE LET LET NEXTER
LATINO POPULATION IS SIXTY ONE
AND A HALF PERCENT. OF THE
BLACK OR AFRICAN AMERICAN
POPULATION 15% OUT WHITE 18%
ASIAN 3% THANKS ANDERSON AFTER
AT 2% SO. AGAIN I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT WHITE AND ASIAN
POPULATIONS ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED AS A PERCENTAGE OF
THE STATE'S POPULATION AND HOW
IT WORKS. I'M WHAT I WOULD DO
AGAIN TURNING TO A DIRECTOR
REASONS QUESTION IN THE AGENDA
THAT I'LL COVER HERE WHAT I
WOULD SAY THAT IN TERMS OF HOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- IS THINKING ABOUT WHO
WE ARE STARVING. OF WHO WE ARE
NOT WHOSE REACH TWO IS NOT WHAT
ARE THE OUTCOMES FOR THOSE THAT
ARE SERVED IN BEING ABLE TO DO
THINGS LIKE THIS AGGREGATE BY
RACE AS AN EXAMPLE. AND THESE
ARE KEY COMPONENTS OF THE
WORKING ESTABLISHMENT OF OUR
OFFICE OF EQUITY. DISPARITIES
EXIST NOW THESE THAT EXTRA THAT
I JUST OUTLINED TOWER OR NOT
UNIQUE AND- THE COW THEY ARE.
SIMILAR IF YOU LOOK THE PRO IN
OUR WELFARE SPACE. AND OTHERS.
I'M WHAT WHAT I WULD SAY IN
TERMS OF HOW WE'RE LOOKING TO
ADDRESS THAT WE HAVE HAD THE-
PRIVILEGE OF BEING ONE OF
TWELVE STATE DEPARTMENTS.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WHO HAS
PARTICIPATED IN THE GOVERNMENT
ALLIANCE FOR RACIAL EQUITY
EFFORT WHICH REALLY IS GIVING A
DEPARTMENT TOOLS RESOURCES.
FOUNDATIONAL UNDERSTANDING
CREATING AMBASSADORS ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT WHO CAN THEN RETURN
AND WORK THROUGH AND IDENTIFY
AND PROVIDE THOSE SAME TOOLS. I
TO OUR STAFF SO WE HAVE THIS IS
OUR THIRD YEAR IN THAT EFFORTS-
IN AGAIN HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS
SUPPORT TO US ALONG THE WAY.
ONE OF ONE OF THE WAYS OF BOTH
THE OFFICE OF EQUITY AND ALSO
BE ESTABLISHED AS A CHIEF DATA
STRATEGIST- IN OUR RESEARCH AN
AUTOMATION DIVISION IS REALLY
THINKING ABOUT THE WAYS IN
WHICH WE ARE SHARING
INFORMATION SO. AGAIN TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER THE QUESTION
AROUND WHO IS BEING SEARCHED
AGAIN WHO'S NOT TO THE EARLIER
MENTIONED IT TO THE ERLIER
EFFORT I MENTIONED OF BEING
ABLE TO MAP. OUT AND UNDERSTAND
WHO WAS ELIGIBLE NOT HAVING
ACCESS THESE ARE CRITICAL
COMPONENTS AT FOR US TO BE.
INTENTIONAL IN OUR STRATEGIES
I'M I ALSO SAY THAT- AND AS WAS
MENTIONED IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL
IS EFFORTS LIKE THE COWARDS
OUTCOMES AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REVIEW WORK HOW OR- AND THAT IS
ESSENTIAL AND CRITICAL RIGHT
WHERE WE ARE. AT DETERMINING
WHAT THE OUTCOMES ARE THAT WE
EXPECT FOR OUR PARTICIPANTS
BASED ON WHAT PARTICIPANTS ALSO
ARE LOOKING TO ACHIEVE AND
HAVING THEM ENGAGED IN THE IN
THE POLICY SETTING AND PROGRAM
DESIGN PROCESS SEES- AND BUT
REALLY MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE.
WORKING TOWARDS THE OUTCOMES
THAT WE WANT TO SEE AND NOT.
EXCLUSIVELY LOOKING AT FEDERAL
METRICS IN THAT PARTICULAR
EXAMPLE SO THAT'S AGAIN WORK
THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN TOGETHER IN
A CRUCIAL AND VERY APPRECIATIVE
AND AT THE END OF THE
ENGAGEMENT IN THE EFFORT TO GET.
TO THOSE OUTCOMES. BUT ALL
NOTED THAT- IF AS RELATES TO
HOW WE'RE IN A AGAIN TO THE-
SPEAKER IN TERMS WHAT STAYING
ON OUTCOMES. AND WHO WORKS THE
CALYX POPULATION SERVES. A
CAREER PATHWAYS ARE CRITICAL- I
AM TOO AGAIN GET TO PLACES
WHERE WE ARE SUPPORTING. I
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES- IN
GIVING TO AT CREATE AND MEET
WAGES THAT WILL SUSTAIN THEM-
IN THE COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ONE A HIGHLIGHT I'D
MENTIONED IN THE GOVERNOR'S AT
BUDGET PROPOSAL IS OUR- A
COMPONENT AROUND REMOTE
LEARNING AND BEING ABLE TO. USE
DIFFERENT. APPLICATIONS AND
APPROACHES LIKE SELL AD. THAT
IS PROVIDING A OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT THERE ON THE CELL PHONE
TO GET CONNECTED TO YOU. AT A
DIFFERENT SUPPORTS LOCATIONAL
TRAINING OPTIONS SENATE COURSES
CITIZENSHIP- AND SO AGAIN WE
WANT TO USE OPPORTUNITIES AND
AGAIN LESSONS LEARNED AROUND
HOW REMOTE ACCESS WORKS EVEN TO
GET ON TO A CAREER PATHWAY IN
THE FORCES ANOTHER PLACE. WHERE
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT AND THAT
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY. WITH
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS- AND
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
I'M THE FINAL THAT YOU HAD TO
ENDURE AT DIRECTOR REASON
SECTION HERE- IS AROUND THE
OFFICE OF EQUITY IN START
SMOKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT WE ARE
LOOKING OUR VISION HERE LONG
TERM AND- WE WANT TO SEE THAT
WE- HAD NO MATTER. WHO YOU ARE
IN IN IN OUR CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
APPROACH THAT EVERYONE CAN
REACH THEIR HIGHEST LEVEL OF
HEALTH AND POTENTIAL FOR
SUCCESSFUL LIFE REGARDLESS OF
THEIR BACKGROUND AND IDENTITY
AND AT YOUR AT YOUR GENDER
OUTLINES SOME OF THE PRIORITIES
OF OUR OFFICE AROUND. STARTING
WITH US AS WELL WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE A CULTURE OF DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION. AGAIN A HUGE
PRIORITY AROUND MAKING IN
EQUITIES VISIBLE AGAIN THROUGH
THE DASHBOARD EXAMPLES THAT I
USED PRIOR. AND ALSO HOW WE CAN
MAKE SURE IT'S SIMPLIFIED AND
UNDERSTANDABLE ATTITUDE TO ANY
USER. I'M ALSO AGAIN USING AND
DEVELOPING SOME OF THESE TOOLS
SO AS WE ARE DEVELOPING POLICY
ARE WE NOT ONLY LOOKING AT AT
HOW WE'RE DOING THAT THROUGH
RACIAL EQUITY LOANS AND AGAIN.
AT USING THAT AS DRIVERS BUT
ALSO HOW ARE WE CREATING THE
POLICY HOW ARE WE ENGAGING
AGAIN WITH OUR PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS STAKEHOLDERS AND
COMMUNITIES TO. CREATE AND
DEVELOP THE POLICIES IN WHICH
WE ARE IMPLEMENTING I SPOKE IN
A LITTLE BIT TO OUR LANGUAGE
ACCESS OUT EFFORTS AND ACCESS
FOR COMMUNITIES WITH
DISABILITIES I'VE I'VE- LOOK UP
MOST RECENTLY. AND SOME OF THE
WORK WE'VE BEEN DOING ON OUR
STAKEHOLDER SESSIONS WITH THE
CHILD CARE TO TRANSITION OF
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. REALLY
OFFERING UP MULTIPLE LANGUAGE
INTERPRETATION SIMULTANEOUS
OFFERING AGAIN ALL THE CLOSED
CAPTIONING IN OTHER- TOOLS TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT THAT THE
INFORMATION WE'RE PROVIDING
ACCESSIBLE THAT'S A COMMITMENT
THAT WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON. AND AGAIN OUR OFFICE
OF THE EQUITY WAS ESTABLISHED
WITHIN AT THE AT THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS WE START WITH WHAT WE
HAD. GRATEFUL FOR WHAT WE HAD
EVERYTHING FROM OUR IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION BRANCH IN WORK
WHICH IS ESSENTIAL. I'M OUR
OFFICE. OF TRIBAL AFFAIRS OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS EIGHT- IN THE RACE
EQUITY BUT I'M- THAT ARE PART
OF WITH THE- ALLY FOR RACE
EQUITY SO GIVE. I HAVE SOME FOR
TO UPON THAT WERE. MAKE SURE WE
HAVE A ROBUST TEAM THAT CAN
WORK TO EMBED THESE PRINCIPLES
ACROSS THE ORGANIZATION NO
MATTER WHAT PROGRAM. AND I
GIVEN ORGANIZATIONAL DIVISION
IS WORKING ON THAT THIS IS HOW
WE APPROACH AND DO BUSINESS
SAYS THAT AS AS A MATTER AB-
WORKING WITH ALL SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
JOHNSON NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
KIM MCCOY WADE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
THAT AFTERNOON SHARON THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CONVENING THIS
FORUM ON RACIAL EQUITY AT THIS
TIME. AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
BEIJING WE'RE VERY A PRIVILEGE
TO CONVENE THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING ON BEHALF OF THE GOVERNOR
AND THE SECRETARY AND WHEN WE
BEGAN RIGHT AWAY OR STAKEHOLDER
SAID IN DECEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN. EQUITY NEEDS TO BE AT
THE HEART OF THIS AND NEEDS TO
BE OUR FOCUS. AND SO WE HAD
JUST CONVENE AN EQUITY
WORKGROUP WHEN INDEED THE
PANDEMIC HIT AND THE STAY AT
HOME ORDERS CAME. AND
UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT AWAY BEGAN
TO SEE THE HEALTH INEQUITIES IN
ECONOMIC INEQUITIES THAT FACE
SO MANY OF OUR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS. AND OUR FAMILIES.
SO EQUITY WAS BAKED IN THIS
YEAR- BROWN ARE STAKEHOLDER
SAYS FROM THE BEGINNING TO THE
MASTER PLAN AND WE HOPE YOU CAN
SEE IT. IN THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND THE INITIATIVES THAT WERE
ANNOUNCED IN JANUARY YOU ARE
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT POLICY AND
BUDGET- ITEMS THAT AREN'T ARE
INTENDED TO WHICH ADDRESS. AND
REMEDY ON A RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW. SOME OF THE
POLICY THAT YOU SEE GOAL. WHICH
IS. ABOUT INCLUSION AND EQUITY
AND NOT ISOLATION. ALL CALLS
FOR AN EQUITY AN AGING ADVISORY
TASK FORCE TO. CONTINUE AND IN
FACT WE HAD OUR FIRST MEETING
YESTERDAY SO IT IS THE FIRST OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION COMMITTEES A
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING UNDERWAY
INAPPROPRIATELY FOCUSED ON
EQUITY- AND WE FOCUSED ON
VACCINES. AND DIGITAL DIVIDE TO
TOP OF MIND ISSUES WHERE THERE
ARE- CONTINUE TO BE EQUITY
ISSUES IN CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT TO SERVE ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WE ALSO CONTINUE
OUR EQUITY AN AGING WEB IN OUR
SERIES WHICH IS AIMED AT
HELPING OUR PROVIDERS. GROW IN
THEIR DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
AND EQUITY OUR LAST OF THIS
MONTH WE HEARD FROM LEADERS IN
SERVING ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
ELDERS. AND NEXT MONTH WE
CONTINUE ALL WITH LATINO.
ELDERS AND SO WE ARE REALLY
COMMITTED TO INCREASING OUR
COMPETENCY AND MOVING FORWARD
OUR DATA COLLECTION AND- MOVING
MONEY TO ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS.
AND THE THIRD THING I WOULD
JUST SAY IS A LECTURER JOHNSON
AT CDSS DEPARTMENT OF AGING HAS
JOINED THERE AS WELL THE
GOVERNMENT ALLIANCE FOR RACIAL
EQUITY AND HAS A TEAM THAT IS
COMING TOGETHER D. E. I. PLAN
FOR CDA. LOOKING AT OUR
TRAINING HIGH OR- ULTIMATELY
OUR SERVICE NETWORK IN OUR
SERVICE DELIVERY SO THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE BUDGET I TO OTHER
POLICY ITEMS RATHER. AND I
WOULD JUST PREVIEWED VERY
EARLY- WE'RE LOOKING NOW WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND ARE TWENTY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. ABOUT
CONVENING THE ELDER JUSTICE
COORDINATING COUNCIL. AND OUR
INITIAL CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN
VERY. INTENTIONAL ABOUT DOING
THAT WITH A TRAUMA INFORMED IN
A RACIAL JUSTICE BORDERLANDS SO
MORE TO COME ON THAT NEXT TIME
WE TALK I'M SURE. ON THE BUDGET
JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF
THE ITEMS IN. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET- THAT FAR INTO
THE DRESSING AGING AND WERE YOU
CAN SEE- EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION AS WELL.
FIRST IS THE NO WRONG DOOR WE
NEED TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
OLDER ADULTS AND FAMILIES. TO
GET INFORMATION AND ASSISTANCE
AND SERVICES AND SO BUILDING
OUT A NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEM
THAT'S CULTURALLY COMPETENT AND
HAS LINGUISTIC- ACCESS BOTH ON
MULTIPLE SPOKEN LANGUAGES AS
WELL AS A CELL WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT AND YOU SEE THAT IN
THE BUDGET. PROPOSED WE ALSO
SEE THE GERIATRIC CARE WORK
FORCE WE NEED MANY MANY MORE
GERIATRICIANS AND PEOPLE
KNOWLEDGEABLE GERIATRIC
MEDICINE ACROSS THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. AND A DIVERSIFIED
PIPELINE TO THAT SO YOU SEE
THAT A PROPOSAL AS WELL. BETTER
SISTER DEPARTMENT AT OSTAD. AND
THEN THERE'S A BOLD ALZHEIMER'S
PACKAGES WELL. THAT'S
SPECIFICALLY SINGLES OUT. THE
DISPARATE IMPACT OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE ITSELF ON
FAMILIES OF COLOR AND WOMEN OF
COLOR- BUT ALSO THE CAREGIVING
BURDEN THAT FALLS TO BLACK
WOMEN IN WHICH YOU KNOW WOMEN.
IN PARTICULAR. AND SO YOU SEE
INVESTMENTS PROPOSED FOR
RESEARCH OR CARE GIVING
TRAINING FOR PUBLIC. AWARENESS-
AND MORE. THOSE ARE JUST A FEW
THE BUDGET ITEM THAT ARE BOTH
TARGET AGING IN THE- ALITY.
REYES AND RACE. YOU ALSO ASK
ABOUT HOW DID HOW TO DECIDE ON.
WELL- OVER THE PAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS WE'VE BEEN INFORMED BY
BOTH THE ENTIRE CABINET WORK
GROUP ONE VERY PLEASED THAT BY
THE END OF THE PROCESS ALL
SECRETARIES WERE ENGAGED-
INCLUDING FOOD AND AG AND
CORRECTIONS ALL WHICH WAS
TERRIFIC WE ALSO HAD A ROBUST A
COLDER PROCESS WITH. OVER A
HUNDRED STAKEHOLDERS ON
MULTIPLE COMMITTEES AND WE HAD
A SERIES OF LEGISLATIVE
ROUNDTABLES A VERY GRATEFUL TO
THE MEMBERS WERE ABLE TO HELP
OUR HOST THOSE WORKING PERSON
AND REMOTELY. SO THAT LEFT US
WITH A LOT OF PRIORITIES AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE INFORMED BY
BY BOTH THE EQUITY GROUP TO
BEGIN MEETING YESTERDAY. AND WE
ARE ABOUT TO SET THE TABLE FOR
A NEW UP MASTER PLAN OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE IF YOU WELL I HOPE TO
GET THAT LAUNCH THIS SPRING AS
WE CONTINUE TO EMERGE. FROM THE
HEALTH EMERGENCY INTEND. I LOOK
TO HOW WE'RE GOING TO BILLS FOR
WORK. REALLY PUT THE QUESTION
ON DAY AND MET TO WORK VERY. TO
BUILD MEASURABLE PROGRESS INTO
THE MASTER PLAN AND I WOULD SAY
YOU'LL SEE RACIAL EQUITY
MEASURES IN TWO MAIN WAYS. AT
THE HIGH LEVEL THERE ARE FIVE
GOALS THAT ARE LAID OUT. FOR A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AGES. TO
APPROACH EXPLICITLY ADDRESS
RACIAL INEQUITY ONE AROUND LIFE
EXPECTANCY. ARE PART OF IT
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AGES WILL BE
INCREASING LIFE EXPECTANCY AND
AN END TO THE RACIAL AND GENDER
GAP- WHICH AGAIN TRAGICALLY HAS
BEEN EXACERBATED BY COULD
PARTICULARLY. IN BLACK LATINO
AND SOME SOUTH ASIAN
COMMUNITIES AS WELL- AND SO
GETTING BACK ON TRACK AND
CLOSING THE GAP ON LIFE
EXPECTANCY IS ONE OF THE MAJOR
GOALS. THE OTHER IS ELDER
ECONOMIC SITUATION SYMMETRIC
PIONEERED BY PROFESSOR STEVE
WALLACE AT UCLA. WE CONTINUE TO
SEE A LEGACY OF DISCRIMINATION
SHOW UP IN. OLDER AGE. ARE THAT
YOU DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
WHETHER IT'S AN HOME EQUITY OR
IN SAVINGS OR PENSION. TO
AFFORD A HEALTHY AND THRIVING.
ON AGING AND SO. HOW WE BOTH
MAKE SURE THAT ALL ELDERS HAVE
ENOUGH ECONOMIC SUFFICIENCY AND
WE CLOSE THAT GAP. BETWEEN
RACES AND GENDERS SO THAT ALL
CAN THRIVE IN THEIR LATER
YEARS. ARE TO THE HIGH LEVEL
GOALS AND THEN JUST BRIEFLY
BEHIND THAT THE MASTER PLAN
ITSELF. THERE'S AN ENTIRE DATA
DASHBOARD FOR AGING WHICH WE
WERE PLEASED TO DEMO FOR LET'S
STAFF IN RECENT WEEKS. THAT HAS
A DOZENS OF INDICATORS BEHIND
THE FIVE BAGELS IN THE TWENTY
THREE STRATEGIES AND AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. THE SCHOOL TO BE
BROKEN OUT. BY COUNTY BY RACE
BY AGE BAIL 607-080-9000 ARE
ALL VERY DIFFERENT. BY GENDER
AND THEN INCREASINGLY WE NEED
TO DO BETTER ON L. G. B. T. Q.
DATA. AND DISABILITY DATA SO
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT THERE
BUT I RECOGNIZING THAT KNOWING
HOW CALIFORNIA. AT THE STATE
LEVEL IS ONE THING BUT KNOWING
HOW ALL PARTS OF CALIFORNIA ARE
MOVING FORWARD. IS CRITICAL TO
MOVING FORWARD TOGETHER. THANK
YOU DIRECTOR NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM ANGELES SHORTS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS ANGELES SHORT
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. OF THE FIRST POINT THAT
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO ADDRESS
TODAY IS TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF INITIATIVES FROM THE NEW
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
REGARDING RACIAL JUSTICE AND
EQUITY. SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN
TOOK OFFICE HE HAS SIGNED MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS MEMORANDUMS AND OTHER
ACTIONS. THAT HAVE EITHERA
PRIMARY GOAL OF THE FINANCING
EQUITY OR INCLUDE. SOME
SIGNIFICANT EQUITY PROVISIONS
THE TOPICS OF THESE DIRECTIVES
RANGE FROM IMPLEMENTING OVERALL
FEDERAL APPROACHES TO EQUITY IN
A CENTRALIZED MANNER. TO
COMBATING DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST PARTICULAR RACIAL
GROUPS. TO INSURING AND- AND
ADVANCING EQUITY ACROSS HOUSING
COLEMAN NINETEEN RELIEF AND
RECOVERY EDUCATION HEALTH CARE
ENVIRONMENT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
OTHER POLICIES AND PROGRAMS.
CERTAINLY WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO
DISCUSS ALL OF THOSE IN DEPTH
TODAY BUT I DID WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE EXECUTIVE ORDER
IN PARTICULAR. WHICH PRESIDENT
BIDEN SIGNED ON JANUARY
TWENTIETH ON ADVANCING RACIAL
EQUITY AND SUPPORTING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES- AND I
HIGHLY ORDER BECAUSE IT REALLY
AIMS TO PUT IN PLACE A
COMPREHENSIVE FEDERAL FAIR
FRAMEWORK. ACROSS ALL AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS FOR IDENTIFYING
AND DEVELOPING STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS BARRIERS THAT PREVENT A
FULL AND EQUAL PARTICIPATION
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED OR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES- AND
NOTABLY THE ORDER DEFINES THOSE
COMMUNITIES TO INCLUDE PEOPLE
OF COLOR. AS WELL AS RELIGIOUS
MINORITIES LGBTQ INDIVIDUALS
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
APPLE'S LIVE IN RURAL AREAS.
AND A PERSON'S OTHERWISE
ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY
PERSISTENT POVERTY OR
INEQUALITY. THE WORST THANK YOU
TO. FOR DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES ALL WITHIN ONE YEAR OR
LESS INCLUDING IDENTIFYING BEST
PRACTICES FOR ASSESSING
BARRIERS REPORTING ON BARRIERS
AND THEN DEVELOPING PLANS TO
ADDRESS THOSE BARRIERS- ALL
WITH- CENTRALIZED FOR NATION.
THE EXACT ORDER FURTHER
MANDATES THAT ALL DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES CONSULTS WITH
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED UNDERSERVED OR
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST I FEDERAL
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS AND THEN
FINALLY THE ORDER NOTES THAT
MANY FEDERAL FEDERAL. ARE NOT
DISAGGREGATED BY RACE ETHNICITY
GENDER DISABILITY INCOME OR
OTHER KEY DEMOGRAPHIC
VARIABLES- AND TO ADDRESS THAT
ESTABLISHES AN EQUITABLE DATA
WORKING GROUP TO RECOMMEND
IMPROVEMENTS FOR FEDERAL DATA
COLLECTION. SO BEYOND THAT
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN GENERAL THE
OTHER TWO DOZEN PLUS EXECUTIVE
ACTIONS SIMILARLY INCLUDE
CERTAIN ELEMENTS OF- CONVENING
EXPERTS AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
STUDY AN ISSUE IDENTIFY
SPECIFIC POLICIES THAT MAY
PRESENT BARRIERS. ALSO
INVOLVING- SOME SORT OF DATA
ANALYSIS FOR SYSTEMS LEVEL
REVIEW OF POLICIES AND
REGULATIONS AND THEN FINALLY-
NEARLY ALL OF THE ACTIONS ALSO
INSTRUCTED DEPARTMENTS OR
AGENCIES WERE SPECIFIED WORK
GROUPS THAT ARE NEWLY CREATED
TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS- TO THE
PRESIDENT TO IMPROVE ACCESS-
WILL REDUCE BARRIERS TO
EQUITABLE PARTICIPATION AND
OUTCOMES. UP MOVING ON THE NEXT
QUESTION WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO
ADDRESS THIS IF THERE ARE ANY
STATE PROGRAMS THAT ARE NATURAL
CANDIDATES FOR FOCUSED ON THE
WORK- TOWARD ADDRESSING EQUITY
WITHIN HUMAN SERVICES- SO WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE RACIAL
DISPROPORTION AUDI'S AND
DISPARITIES ACROSS MANY
DIFFERENT HUMAN SERVICE
PROGRAMS AREAS- AND WE KNOW
THAT THESE DISPARITIES MAY
MANIFEST. AS AN EQUAL ACCESS TO
FULL PARTICIPATION OR TO
BENEFITS. OR THEY MAY MANIFEST
AS OVER REPRESENTATION OF
CERTAIN POPULATIONS FOR EXAMPLE
WE KNOW THAT AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND LATINO FAMILIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY INVOLVED
WITH THE CHILD WELFARE AND
FOSTER CARE SYSTEMS- AS AN
OFFICE. WE ARE THE ONLY- ARE
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO EXPLORE
EQUITY IN TERMS OF RACE BUT
ALSO IN TERMS OF INCOME
GEOGRAPHY AND OTHER
CHARACTERISTICS. MORE
COMPREHENSIVELY REALLY ACROSS
ALL WORK INCLUDING HUMAN
SERVICES AND ACCORDINGLY IT
WILL BE SEEKING- OVER ALL TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT SYSTEMIC
PROGRAMMATIC OR HISTORIC
BARRIERS OR OTHER
DISCRIMINATORY FACTORS ARE
DRIVING THESE DISPARITIES AND
DISPROPORTIONAL USE THAT WE
SEE. ACROSS HUMAN SERVICES AND
WE CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS WORK.
AND THEN FINALLY A THIRD OF THE
THIRD POINT WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO
ADDRESS IS TO PROVIDE OUR
ASSESSMENTS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EQUITY
FOCUSED- BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS. WITHIN HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES-
AND HE'S PROPOSALS ARE
DESCRIBED IN YOUR AGENDA ON
PAGES FORTY FIVE THREE FORTY
SEVEN SO I WON'T- DESCRIBE THEM
IN DETAIL. WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL'S THEMSELVES BUT WE DO
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
TO ENSURE THAT SPECIFIC EQUITY
FOCUSED PROJECTS WITHIN
INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENTS OR
AGENCIES. ARE REALLY
COMPLEMENTARY- AND EMPLOYING
LESSONS LEARNED FROM ONE
ANOTHER RATHER THAN BEING
DUPLICATIVE OF ONE ANOTHER. SO
TO THAT END- AND ALSO GIVEN THE
LEGISLATURE'S OVERALL INCREASED
INTEREST IN EXAMINING AND
ADDRESSING BARRIERS TO
EQUITABLE ACCESS PARTICIPATION
REALLY ACROSS MANY DIFFERENT
STATE PROGRAMS. THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WISH TO CONSIDER THE
TRADEOFFS OF DEVELOPING A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE AND CENTRALIZED
STATE LEVEL EFFORT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK AND STRATEGY- AS
OPPOSED TO FUNDING INITIATIVES
WITHIN INDIVIDUAL AGENCIES OR
DEPARTMENTS WITHOUT FIRST
HAVING A STRATEGY IN PLACE. AND
OF THE LEGISLATURE DOES WANT TO
DEVELOP SUCH A STATE LEVEL
STRATEGY WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE FIRST TO REALLY
SPEND SOME TIME CONSIDERING THE
SPECIFIC PROBLEM IT SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THROUGH EQUITY
INITIATIVES AND TO LAY OUT
SPECIFIC GOALS AND THEN- TO
THOSE GOALS. OF DIRECT ALL
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
STATE GOVERNMENTS TO ACT
ACCORDINGLY TO THE STRATEGY-
AND I'LL STOP THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM KATHY SANDERLING
MCDONALD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS CATHARINE MCDONNELL
TOGETHER FROM CEDAR BDA.
ACHIEVING RACIAL JUSTICE
DIVERSITY AND EQUITY IN OUR
PROGRAMS AND SINCE IT NEVER
AGAIN PAUL HERSEY WTA STAFF AND
OUR MEMBER AGENCIES. MANY OF
OUR COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES. OUR OWN STAFF HAVE
COME TOGETHER TO LEARN ABOUT
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS AS WELL AS
STRATEGIES FOR OVERCOMING OUR
OWN BIAS SEES AND HOW TO
INTERVENE IN MOMENTS AND WE
OBSERVE BIAS BEING DISPLAYED
FOR OTHERS. AT RECENTLY THE
MEDIA CONFERENCES WE HOSTED
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED SPEAKERS
ON RACIAL TRAUMA AND EQUITY AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA OFFICIALS WORKING TO
IMPROVE THEIR OWN ORGANIZATION.
WE HAVE A STAFF AS WELL AS AN
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTING HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES OTHER
INDIVIDUALS THEY SERVE. DON'T
BE OF THIS WORK IS BEING DONE
NOW THAT WE'VE HAD SOME
TRAINING AND CONFERENCE
SESSIONS IT'S NOT SOMETHING
WHERE YOU CHECK A BOX. AND SAY
YOU FIXED IT. RATHER THAN HAVE
IT REQUIRES US TO OWN AND
ACTIVELY WORK TO OVERCOME THE
RACES CLASS AND MORALISTIC. OF
THE PROGRAM'S ARE MEMBERS
ADMINISTER. AS WELL AS THE
UNDERLYING. ECONOMIC INJUSTICE
STRUCTURES THAT INFLUENCE THESE
PROGRAMS. IT MEANS CALLING OUT
SYSTEMIC RACISM AND BIAS
AGAINST PEOPLE OF COLOR
IMMIGRANTS PEOPLE WHO IDENTIFY
AS LGBTQ. PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES PEOPLE WHO GROW UP
IN OUR LIVE IN POVERTY. PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
MORE. AND IT DEFINITELY MEANS
CALLING OUT AND CONFRONTING OUR
OWN BY IS TO. ALL OF THE FED
THERE ARE CONCRETE THINGS WE
HAVE TO STAY TO DO TO BEGIN
ADDRESSING. RACISM A LACK. WE
MUST COLLECTIVELY EXAMINE OUR
PROGRAM AND POLICIES TO AN
EQUITY LENS AND ELIMINATE
POLICIES THAT ARE BORN OUT OF
STRUCTURALLY. WE MUST RECOGNIZE
THAT THE EMPHASIS SO MANY OF
OUR PROGRAMS PLACE ON
COMPLIANCE ABOVE ALL ELSE IS
ITSELF A RACIST. THERE ARE
BARRIERS TO EXPECTING HER
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH WHETHER SOMEONE IS
ACTUALLY ELIGIBLE. THE
PAPERWORK RELATED BARRIERS
DISCUSSED DURING PANEL ONE STEM
FROM RACES AND CLASSES IDEAS
ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE IN LINE.
CONTROLLING AND PUNISHING. THEM
AND SOMETIMES FREEZING THEM OUT
ENTIRELY. UNFORTUNATELY
SERVICES SYSTEMS AND PROGRAMS
HAS ALWAYS FOR THE FOR SOME
FOLKS. WE HAVE FOR CHANGES AND
YEARS IN AT CORRECTING THAT'S-
ALLEGATION FAMILIES DIFFERENTLY
TO FIND OUT WHERE THEY ARE. AND
WHAT HELP THEY WANT AND NEED
RATHER THAN TELLING THEM WHAT.
WE THINK THEY NEED FROM US.
HERE'S A FEW EXAMPLES OF SOME
SUCCESSES WE'VE HAD AND SOME
AREAS FOR CRITICALLY ADDITIONAL
WORK IN THIS AREA. TOGETHER WE
ELIMINATED THE HORRIBLY RACIST
CLASSIST AND MISOGYNISTIC
MAXIMUM FAMILY GRANT ROLE AND
CAL WORKS. AS WELL AS
ELIMINATING AFTER TAX AND
SETTING UP FOR HER GRANT LEVELS
THAT SHOULD ENSURE NO CHILD WAS
BELOW 50% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL IN THE PROGRAM.
SHE HERE ALSO DEVELOPING HOW
WORKS TWO POINT OH APPROACH IN
WHICH OUR STAFF ENGAGE OUR
RECIPE OF GOAL SETTING. RATHER
THAN FOCUS ON COME. WITH
WORKERS. I IN FUNDING THIS OF
GOAL WAY TOWARD THE HEALTH
PROGRAM WORKS FOR AND WITH
FAMILIES. WE SHOULD CONTINUE
CAL AID PARENTS WHEN THEY'RE TO
ARE PLAY IN THE FALL CARE AND
THEY WORKING TO REUNIFY.
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT PARENTS ON
THE RISK AND EVEN HOW. WHICH
MEANS A MUCH FLORIDA OF
BRINGING. IT'S ACTUALLY A
PRETTY QUALIFY UP RIGHT NOW
HUNDREDS OF CHILDREN FAMILIES
WILL BE MORE LIKELY TO REUNIFY.
AND MORE QUICKLY AS A RESULT OF
THIS CHANGE THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING. WE ALSO SUPPORT
CHANGES TO THE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK SYSTEM FOR
POTENTIAL FOSTER CARE GIVERS
AND ITEMS THAT. PROVIDERSALL
IN PARTICULAR IN CHILD WELFARE
THE UNDERLYING RACISM AND
EQUITY OF OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
RESULT IN MANY PEOPLE OF COLOR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND PEOPLE IN
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY IN
PARTICULAR HAVING. CRIMINAL
RECORDS FOR QUESTIONABLE AND
INEQUITABLE CHARGES FROM THEIR
PAST. THIS OFTEN MAKES COUNTIES
UNABLE TO APPROVE RELATIVES TO
CARE FOR FOSTER CHILDREN. DUE
TO A LONG LIST OF STATUTORILY
ON EXAMPLE CRIMES. THAT HAS NOT
BEEN REVIEWED USING A CRITICAL
EQUITY LANDS. WE DURING THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM ORGANIZATIONS
GROUPS SUPPORTING CURRENT AND
FORMER PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN.
AND OTHER CHILD WELFARE
ADVOCATES TO CALL FOR A RE
EXAMINATION OF THESE POLICIES.
AND HOW THEY CAN RESULT IN
CHILDREN MISSING OUT ON
OTHERWISE SAFE AND LOVING PLACE.
OR WITH FAMILY MEMBERS. WE ALSO
HAVE A THING. CHILD WELFARE FOR
EARLIER PREVENTION SERVICES. TO
BE UNDERTAKEN IN COLLABORATION
WITH COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY REPRESENTED
IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM I
WILL SPEAK TO THIS IN GREATER
DETAIL ON A LATER PANEL. AT THE
STATE LEVEL WE ARE GLAD THAT
CDS THAT'S CREATED THE OFFICE
OF EQUITY THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT.
THROUGH THIS OFFICE AND THROUGH
THE LEADERSHIP OF DIRECTOR
JOHNSON WE THINK THAT CDS
ASKING PLAYE LEADERSHIP ROLE
IN REVIEWING STATE AND FEDERAL
POLICIES. AND THE UNDERLYING
MOTIVATIONS FOR THOSE POLICIES
WORKING WITH THE WTA ARE
MEMBERS ADVOCATES IN
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE RECEIVING SERVICES
THERE ARE PROGRAMS. WE URGE
THAT DIVERSE GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE NOT JUST THE PEOPLE AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE MOST
OFTEN HEARD FROM. AND OF COURSE
WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO REPLACE ALL
THEIR TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
EXAMINE AND CONSIDER FURTHER
ACTIONS SUCH AS THOSE LISTED IN
THE ENGINE. IN CLOSING OUR
MEMBERS ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS AND
THIS IS A LONG HAUL COMMITMENT.
WE ARE SORRY SOMETIMES GOING TO
HEAR AND LEARN THINGS THAT MAKE
US REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE. BUT
THAT'S THE NATURE OF THE WORK
BEFORE US DIGGING INTO THESE
DISCUSSIONS. AND MAKING THAT
LONG HAUL COMMITMENT TO
LEARNING. SELF EXAMINATION AND
DOING BETTER WAY BETTER WILL
LEAD TO THE GREATEST CHANCE FOR
CHANGE. AND FINALLY I ALSO WANT
TO URGE THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
FOR THESE BOTH TOGETHER. WILL
BE CAREFUL NOT TO FORCE THOSE
WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED THESE
DISCRIMINATIONS. AND THE TRAUMA
THAT COMES WITH THAT. BE THE
ONES TO CARRY THE BURDEN OF
CHANGE ON THEIR OWN TAX. THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO
SHARE THESE THOUGHTS. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FOR MY
CARROLL WITH WEST CENTER MON
POVERTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY SPEAKING
OUT ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC. YOU KNOW THIS IS AN
ISSUE THE WESTERN CENTER HAS-
FOCUSED ON FOR MANY YEARS NOW-
AND WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT
WORK BUT YOU KNOW I WANT TO
START TODAY BY JUST. FOCUSING
ON THE- SORT OF HISTORICAL-
ROOTS OF HOW WE GOT HERE- YOU
KNOW. YOU ONE CAN ACTUALLY
TRACE THE ROOTS OF THIS BACK TO
ELIZABETHAN ENGLAND. WHEN THEY
ADOPTED WHAT WAS THE SO CALLED
SETTLED LAWS WHICH WERE ENACTED
TO DENY PERSONS PARRIS RELIEF
THE OLD OLD VERSION OF WELFARE
PAYMENTS. IF THEY DID NOT COME
FROM THE AREA SURROUNDING THE
PARISH. SO THIS WAS DONE IN
EXACTLY THE TIME WHEN- AFRICAN
IMMIGRANTS- AFTER AN IMMIGRANT
POPULATION WAS GROWING IN
ENGLAND AND WAS- WAS VIEWED AS
A WAY TO TRY TO DENY THEM
SYSTEMS THAT ONLY A NATIVE
BORN. ENGLISH PEOPLE COULD GET.
ON INDEED MANY OF THE FEATURES
OF OUR MODERN WELFARE
STATE TO THIS TIME. INCLUDING
CHILD SUPPORT WORK WORK WORK
REQUIREMENTS SANCTIONS. AN ACID
TEST. ON HOWEVER HAD MADE OWN
CAR BE TO A RACIST WALL FOR
PAUL. I WOULDN'T REALLY
RECOMMEND PEOPLE READ- A PIECE
CALLED THE RACES RUDE OF WORK
REQUIRED BY LEESON OFF WHO'S
WITH US FOR THE STUDY OF POLICY-
HER ANALYSIS TRACES BACK THE
USE OF WORK REQUIREMENTS TO THE
JIM CROW ERA WHEN FORMER SLAVES
WERE FREQUENTLY ARRESTED THAT
THEY COULD NOT PROVE THEY HAD A
JOB AND THEN FORCED TO WORK FOR
FREE TO PAY OFF THE FINES
IMPOSED BY COURTS FURTHER
SUPPOSE IN VACANCY. IT WAS
DURING THIS TIME THAT WHITE
POLITICIANS BEGAN TO PROMOTE
THE MYTH THAT BLACK PEOPLE WERE
LAZY AND WOULD NOT WORK EVEN
THOUGH FOR MANY BLACKS THERE
FOR MANY BLACKS. THEIR ENTIRE
EXPERIENCE IN AMERICA HAD BEEN
ONE OF CONSTANT WORK ON BEHALF
OF WHITES. ON NOT TOO LONG
AFTER SOME STATES BEGAN TO
CREATE WERE CALLED MOTHER'S
PENSION PROGRAMS THESE ARE
PREDECESSORS THAT OUR MODERN
WELFARE PROGRAMS AND IN IN THE
UNITED STATES BLACK MOTHERS
WERE ROUTINELY DENIED
ASSISTANCE AND TO COMPEL THEM
TO HAVE TO WORK USUALLY IN THE
FEELS WHEN OF FRANKLIN
ROOSEVELT AND THE AND CONGRESS
CREATED THE FIRST NATIONAL
FAMILY EIGHT PROGRAM AID TO
DEPENDENT CHILDREN. ALSO THE
STATES NINE TO AID TO WHEN
LEAVE THEM NO ALTERNATE BUT
WORK FOR ME I'LL WAIT. SO WHAT
WE SEE IN THIS BILL LOS
RESEARCH IS A CONSISTENT.
PATTERN OF USING THE LAW TO
FORCED BLACK PEOPLE TO WORK ON
AGAINST OFTEN AGAINST THEIR OWN
BEST INTERESTS. SO WE NEED TO
BE YOU LAWS THAT CURRENTLY IN
FORCE WORKING GROUP WORK
ARMAND'S WITH DEEP SUSPICION-
IN MY GREAT AUNT FORTY YEARS
LIKE. OF ANTI POVERTY WORK I'VE
STILL YET TO NEED. THE SO
CALLED WELFARE. HERE THESE P.
DON'T. PEOPLE TO THEIR LIVES
THEY WANT TO GET THEY WANT TO
HAVE MORE INCOME THEY WANT TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN TO
THE BEST YOU GREET IT WE CAN.
NONETHELESS WE CONTINUE TO SEE
PROPOSALS IMPOSING WORK
REQUIREMENTS ON RECEIPT OF
PUBLIC BENEFITS WITH THE MOST
RECENT ATTEMPTS TO DENY HEALTH
CARE TO THOSE WHO DO NOT MEET
WORK REQUIREMENTS- THANKFULLY
THE BY DEMONSTRATIONS ROLLING
BACK THOSE PROPOSALS. ON AND WE
SHOULD NOT LOSE SIGHT OF OUR
OWN HISTORY OF RACIST POLICIES
LIKE THE SENATE ONLY JUST MEANT
SETTLING JUST MENTION. LIKE THE
MAXIMUM FAMILY GRANT. OR ARE
LONG- ENFORCEMENT OF. THE DRUG
OKAY- AN EXCLUSION FOR BOTH
FRESH AND HOW WORKS APPLIQUE.
THANKFULLY ALL OF THESE HITTING
PAUL HAVE BEEN REPEAT IN RECENT
YEARS BY LUNCH. BUT THEY STOOD
FOR DE. ARMIN VAN PARTICULARLY.
AFRICAN AND LATINO FAMILIES. ON
SO WE HAVE SOME SUGGESTIONS
ABOUT THINGS THAT WE COULD DO-
THAT WOULD ADDRESS SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE SEE WITH OUR
HOURS PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR-
ONE IS. WE REALLY WOULD ARGUE
THAT SUPPORT THE NOTION TO
ABANDON THE PRESCRIPTIVE NATURE
OF TAMPA. YOU'VE HEARD THIS
MENTIONED SEVERAL TIMES BY
DIFFERENT SPEAKERS TODAY YOUR I
THINK HEARING WHAT IS A GROWING
CONSENSUS ABOUT THE NEED TO DO
THIS BUT- WE'RE ACTUALLY
ARGUING THAT YOU KNOW WE SHOULD
ELIMINATE THE ARBITRARY FIVE
YEAR TIME LIMIT. BECAUSE THESE
TIME LIMITS FAILED TO RECOGNIZE
THE UPS AND DOWNS OF THE
ECONOMY THAT ENDED THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE NO CONTROL
OVER SO IT'S GREAT IF YOU WANT
TO WELL NOT GREAT BUT IT A FIVE
YEAR TIME LIMIT JUST DOESN'T
WORK. IN AN ECONOMY BURKE JUST
IN THE PAST DECADE WE HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE TO DEEPER SESSIONS
AND SEEM THOUSAND MILLIONS OF
JOBS GO AWAY SOME OF THESE JOBS
WILL NEVER COME BACK. AND
THERE'S NO REASON TO THINK THAT
THIS ISN'T GOING TO HAPPEN
AGAIN SO I THINK THE STATE
NEEDS TO THINK ABOUT WHAT IT
CAN DO TO ELIMINATE TIME LIMITS
ON EIGHT ALTOGETHER BY
EXTENDING OUT STATE PAYMENTS TO
FAMILIES WHO EXCEED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S ON CURRENT LAW
PROHIBITING PAYMENTS BEYOND
SIXTY MONTHS TWO ADULTS. ON YOU
KNOW SANCTIONS WERE BARBARIC
TOOL IN ELIZABETHAN ENGLAND
SOME OF THE PRACTICES I CAN'T
EVEN. REPEAT FOR THIS AUDIENCE
THEY WERE SO. S. ON AND WHILE
OUR PRACTICE DON'T. INCLUDE
THOSE SAME THINGS TODAY I'M
DIEM. ARE OFF DAMAGE ON.
COMPELLING PEOPLE DO WHAT WE
THINK THEY SHOULD DO WILL NEVER
BE AN EFFECTIVE STRATEGY- WE
MUST RECOGNIZE THAT SANCTIONS.
PRINCIPALLY RESULT IN ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA. AND THAT THAT
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD TRAUMA IS
BEING MANDATED BY US BY OUR OWN
LAWS AND SO THIS IS SOMETHING
WE REALLY NEED TO MOVE AWAY
FROM- YES THE FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES US TO HAVE A SANCTION
POLICY BUT IT DOESN'T TELL US
HOW THAT HAS TO BE ENFORCED. IT
MIGHT BE WELL PAST TIME WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE GOVERNOR
TAKE A REAL HARD LOOK AT
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING IF NOT
ELIMINATING THE USE OF
SANCTIONS. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. NO OE SIZE FITS ALL
WORK REQUIREMENTS NEED TO BE
REPLACED BY HUMAN CENTERED AND
FAMILY FRIENDLY FRIENDLY PLANTS
THAT CENTER THE NEEDS OF THE
FAMILY AND NOT THE NEEDS OF THE
STATE OR SOMEBODY WHO THINKS.
THEY KNOW BETTER FOR FAMILIES
WHAT THEIR THEIR NEEDS ARE- WE
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGING MORE
EDUCATION AND SKILL DEVELOPMENT
BY FIVE FAMILIES. THE DATA
POINTS TO THIS CONCLUSIVELY AS
THE SINGLE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
FOR FOLKS TO GET OUT OF
POVERTY. AGAIN WE SHOULDN'T
MANDATE THAT WE SHOULD MAKE IT
EASY FOR PEOPLE TO GO IN THAT
DIRECTION IF THEY NEED TO- WE
WOULD STRONGLY. RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE TAKE A GOOD
LOOK AT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE CDSS WORKGROUP THAT
HAVE BEEN MENTIONED BY DIRECTOR
JOHNSON BY MISS CENTRELINK AND
OTHERS HERE TODAY I THINK THE
pTOO. WE THINK THERE ARE A LOT
OF REALLY GOOD IDEAS THERE WAS
A GOOD DEAL OF CONSENSUS AMONG
THE GOALS IN OUT THAT WERE
OUTLINED IN THE REPORTS. AND WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO TRY TO ADOPT MANY OF THOSE
DURING THIS I'M- COMING BUDGET-
LASTLY ARE I SHOULD ALSO SAY
WELL WE THE THAT'S OUT POWER
AND WILL BE GETTING THAT THE WE
FORWARD IN IN FEW YEARS WE
REALLY THINK THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO GO FURTHER AND FUND AN
EXHAUSTIVE STUDY OF CAL WORKS
AND ITS IMPACT THE IMPACT IT'S
HAD ON POOR WOMEN AND CHILDREN
OF COLOR. WE BELIEVE A THOROUGH
REVIEW WILL DEMONSTRATE THAT
MOSTLY THAT HANNAH PROGRAM.
WILL BY DESIGN RESULT IN
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVE
IMPACTS FOR WOMEN OF COLOR. ON
WE THINK WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS
DATA THAT WE CAN'T KEEP
STICKING OUR HEAD IN THE
GROUND. AND ACTING LIKE WE
DON'T KNOW THAT MORE FAMILIES
WHO ARE. AFRICAN AMERICAN OR
LATINO OR BEING SANCTIONED THE
WHITE FAMILIES- WE THINK OF AN
EXAMINATION OF KEY PROGRAM
TENANTS IS NEEDED TO EXPOSE THE
FUNDAMENTALLY NEGATIVE OUTCOMES
THIS PROGRAM. HAS HAD AND
CONTINUES TO PRODUCE. I'M AND
THEN FINALLY. UNTIL AND IT CAN
BE CHANGED AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
COUNTY SHOULD BE IMMUNIZED FROM
ANY TOWN A FAMILIES IF THE
STATE FAILS FAILS TO MEET WORK
PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENTS. ARM
WITHOUT THAT BUT WE'LL SEE IS
THAT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WILL CONTINUE TO
FEEL FISCALLY VULNERABLE AND
WILL PUT PRESSURE ON THEIR
LOCAL PROGRAMS TO GET PEOPLE
INTO WORK PRESERVATION MEETING
THE WORK THE FEDERAL WORK
REQUIREMENTS. SO WE THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE
TO STEP UP AND TAKE ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE BURDEN
OF MANAGING ANY CAMERA FAMILIES
AND TAKING THEM OFF THE BACK OF
COUNTIES BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THE ACTION IS REALLY HAPPENING
IT'S HAPPENING BETWEEN CLIENTS
AND COUNTIES THAT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. AND WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT NOTHING'S REALLY GOING TO
CHANGE IN THE CURRENT CHANNEL
PROGRAM SO LONG AS THE COUNTY'S
FEEL THE BURDEN OF. THOSE
POTENTIAL PENALTIES COMING ON
THEM SO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND.
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS GREAT
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU NEXT WE
HEAR FROM ORVILLE THOMAS COVER.
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
INSIGHT ON SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE PREVENTING
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT
POPULATION FROM ACHIEVING THEIR
CALIFORNIA DREAMS. I LIKE TO
USE THE START OF MY TESTIMONY
PERIOD FOR A MOMENT OF SILENCE
FOR ALL THOSE MURDERED IN LAST
NIGHT'S SHOOTINGS IN ATLANTA
AND AMPLIFY THE NEED TO STOP
ANTI A P. I HATE. AND ACTIONS
AND ADDRESS ANTI IMMIGRANT
SENTIMENTS. THANK YOU.
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT
POPULATION HAS EXPERIENCED COVE
IT VERY DIFFERENTLY THAN OTHER
CALIFORNIANS AND WE WILL
EXPERIENCE THE RECOVERY IN VERY
UNIQUE WAYS. IMMIGRANTS
INCLUSIVE OF A LARGE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION. MAKE
UP A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. THESE
WORKERS AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
HAD BEEN EXPERIENCING INCREASED
HARDSHIPS PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
BECAUSE OF RACIST FEDERAL
POLICIES BROUGHT FORWARD BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION. ISSUES
LIKE PUBLIC CHARGE INCREASED
ICE RAIDS AND ADMINISTRATIVE
FREEZES ON VISAS AND OTHER
IMMIGRATION STATUS APPLICATIONS
RESULTED IN A MASSIVE CHILLING
AFFECT HOVERING OVER IMMIGRANT
USE. OF PUBLIC BENEFITS.
MORALISTS FEARED THE DIRECTOR
OF HEALTH CARE PROGRAM. AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY LABOR CENTER HAS SAID
THAT THE CHILLING EFFECT
RESULTED IN A DISTANT ROMAN
RATE. FOR HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AS HIGH AS THIRTY FIVE PERCENT.
AND THESE WERE FOR PROGRAMS
THAT ARE LEGALLY AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIANS THROUGH STATE
FUNDING. SO IN ADDITION TO
HEALTHCARE SERVICES WE HAVE
SEEN A REDUCTION IN BENEFIT
USAGE FOR FREE FOOD PROGRAMS.
HOUSING PROGRAMS AND LEGAL
SERVICES. OPEN ADDED ANOTHER
LEVEL OF HARM TO IMMIGRANTS BY
INSERTING A GOBAL HEALTH
PANDEMIC TO A POPULATION THAT
WAS ALREADY SUFFERING FROM
ADMINISTRATIVE AND CULTURAL
BERRIER CALIFIA COMES.
IMMIGRANTS ARE ALSO SUFFERING
FROM MORE UNDIAGNOSED
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS AND
COMORBIDITIES THE INCREASE IN
DEBTS DUE TO KOBE IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGHER FOR
OCCUPATIONS LARGELY FILLED BY
IMMIGRANTS. COOKS SAW 60%
INCREASE IN MORTALITY DURING
THE PANDEMIC COMPARED TO PRE
PANDEMIC MISCELLANEOUS AB
WORKERS SAW 55% INCREASE
CONSTRUCTION LABOR SELL 49%
INCREASE AND DOMESTIC WORKERS
SUCH AS MAIDS AND HOUSEKEEPERS
SAW A 33% INCREASE IN DEATH.
DURING THE PANDEMIC COMPARED TO
PRE PANDEMIC. TURNING TO THE
NORM OF JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ISN'T GOOD ENOUGH. WE KNOW MORE
NOW ABOUT WHAT GAPS WERE AND
ARE PRESENT IN THE SOCIAL
SAFETY NET AND WE NEED TO DO
MORE IN TERMS OF BENEFITS
PROVIDED TO GIVE EVERY
CALIFORNIANS. REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FULFILL THEIR
PROMISE. THE CURRENT CAMPAIGNS
TOWARD EQUITY I WILL SPEAK
ABOUT INVOLVED ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN HEALTH AND
PUBLIC BENEFITS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE AND LEGAL SERVICES AND
OUTREACH. CIBC IS COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS HAS ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE. IN THAT EFFORT
WE ARE PUSHING FOR AN EXPANSION
OF STATE FUNDED MEDICAL TO ALL
THOSE THAT QUALIFY FOR IT.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE TWO BILLS TO
EXPAND HEALTH CARE COVERAGE SB
FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR THE
RUSSELL WOULD EXPAND MEDICARE
COVERAGE TO ALL SENIORS SIXTY
FIVE PLUS WHO QUALIFY
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AB FOUR BY YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA WOULD
BUILD OFF OF THAT AND EXPAND
MEDICARE COVERAGE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHO QUALIFIED.
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
THIS WOULD BUILD OFF OF
PREVIOUS SUCCESSFUL CAMPAIGNS
TO EXPAND MEDICARE COVERAGE TO
KIDS AND YOUNG ADULTS OBIT
NINETEEN AS ALSO INCREASED OUR
STATE'S FOOD INSECURITY
PROBLEMS WITH DATA SUGGESTING
FOOD INSECURITY IN THE STATE.
INCREASING BY ALMOST 50% THIS
YEAR. CIBC IS ALSO PARTNERING
WITH NURSE CALIFORNIA TO PUSH
FOR MODERNIZATION OF OUR STATE
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM C. PAP
TO ELIMINATE THE BARRIERS OF
USAGE BASED ON IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THE NEW RIVER DATO IS
AUTHORING SB FOUR SIXTY FOUR TO
FUND THE EXPANSION OF FOOD
BENEFITS FOR IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
IN ADDITION TO THAT BILL C. I.
PCS SUPPORTING EFFORTS TO
INCREASE THE CALFRESH OUTREACH
EFFORTS BY TWENTY FIVE MILLION
THIS YEAR. THIS INVESTMENT WILL
RESULT IN DIRECT FEDERAL
MATCHING A STATE CONTRIBUTIONS.
TO ENSURE THAT IMMIGRANT
WORKERS ARE SUPPORTED COMING
OUT OF THE PANDEMIC AND ARE
PROTECTED FROM FUTURE HEALTH
EMERGENCIES CIPC IS SPONSORING
A B. SIX TWENTY EIGHT BY
EDUARDO GARCIA WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
THE STATE'S PREVIOUS BREAKING
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVE. ROCO ALSO
COSPONSORING SB THREE TWENTY
ONE FROM SENATOR ALSO TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA PROTECTIONS ARE
EXPANDED AND PROVIDED TO
DOMESTIC WORKERS. LASTLY CIPC
AND PARTNERS ARE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE AN
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN
EDUCATION OUTREACH AND LEGAL
SERVICES TO IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WHO DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ONE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM. TO COMBAT THE HARM
DONE BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ASSISTANT FOR
BILLING THE PROMISE OF THE
BIDEN HERE SAID MINISTRATIONS
IMMIGRATION EFFORTS AND COUNTER
THE EFFECTS OF KOPET. WE'RE
ASKING THE STATE FOR A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME FUNDING
BOOST TO THE ONE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM TO BE SPREAD OUT OVER
TWO YEARS. THIS FUNDING WOULD
GO TOWARDS INCREASING EDUCATION
OUTREACH PROGRAMS BY STATEWIDE
PARTNERS INCREASE LANGUAGE
CAPACITY GRANTS- POSTDOC
APPLICATION COMPS COMPLETIONS
AND ALLOW THE STATE TO HAVE A
FUNDING SOURCE TO MATCH ANY
PROPOSED FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
CHANGES THANK CALIFORNIANS CAN
IMMEDIATELY BENEFIT. THE WORK
TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF EQUITY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANTS IS
GOING TO NEED INVESTMENTS IN
FUNDING AND INVESTMENTS IN
TIME. BUT CALIFORNIA'S PROMISE
OF A BETTER FUTURE SHOULD NOT
BE LIMITED BY IMMIGRATION
STATUS ESPECIALLY WHEN OUR
STATE IS FUELED BY THE WORK OF
ITS IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES. WE
COULD NOT BE A CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL IF WE ONLY PROVIDE FOR SELF.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU AND AMEN. THE STUFF
THAT WAS WELL SET- I'D LIKE TO
TURN MY QUESTIONS THE
DEPARTMENT IF I COULD BUT
BEFORE I BEGAN I WANTED TO
EXTEND AN APPRECIATION FOR
NICOLE VASQUEZ FOR A GREAT
RIGHT UP ON THE SECTION IT'S
HARD TO CAPTURE WHAT WE WERE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE AND I
THINK SHE'S DONE AN EXCELLENT
JOB OF IT AND WANTED TO MAKE
SURE TO HIGHLIGHT HER. I'M IN
IT'S- BEING SPECIFIC I ALSO
LEARNED SOMETHING ABOUT AGE
ADJUSTMENT AND THE IMPORTANCE
FOR US TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION.
AS WERE EVALUATING DISPARITIES
WHAT WE WILL SEE THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC IS AFTER WE ADJUST FOR
AGE. THAT THOSE DISPARITIES
WILL WIDEN FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE
CONVERSATION FOR US TO INCLUDE.
BUT I'D LIKE TO TURN TO
DIRECTOR JOHNSON IF I COULD WE
HAD ASKED A QUESTION OF WESTERN
CENTER OF MY CARROLLTON. BUT
I'M INTERESTED TO HEAR- THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THINKING HERE TOO BUT WHAT
STEPS CAN WE TAKE WITH CAL
WORKS TO MAKE IT MORE HUMAN
CENTERED AND LESS COMPLIANCE
ORIENTED. THANK YOU CHAIR KEN
JOHNSON A PERMANENT SOCIAL
SERVICES IN AND APPRECIATE ALFA
CONVERSATION ON THIS PANEL. I
WOULD JUST I WOULD I WOULD BE
LIFT UP A FEW THINGS AND- EACH
KNOW THERE SIR. QUITE A PERSON
IN TERMS OF THE COW PRO. AT
THAT IS CURRENTLY AT ON THE
BOOKS WE SAY STATUTE IN TERMS
OF HOW WE'RE MOVING FORWARD I
THINK. OTHER WORK GROUPS THAT
HAVE BEEN REFERENCED BECAU OR
STAKEHOLDER- AT. PROCESS THAT I
MENTIONED ALSO WAS REALLY
HELPFUL I THINK TO HAVE- THAT
THE VARIOUS PERSPECTIVES IN THE
SAME ROOM HAVING THE
CONVERSATION SO JUST GIVE A
CONCRETE EXAMPLE IT WAS I THINK
IN A AND A LOGIC MODEL EXERCISE
WHERE WE HAD ORIGINALLY. HABIT
HAVEN'T OUTCOME RELATED TO
ADHERENTS AT TO THE
INDIVIDUALS- YOU KNOW AS- IT
ARE HEARING TO RULES THE PRO AS
ASSAM WE WANTED TO IS. VERSES
AT THE ACTUAL. BEEN IF A BIG
SEEING ADDITIONAL WAGES
ADDITION RESOURCE SEEING ADS.
TO AT THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
OUTCOME O THE CHILDREN EVEN
RIGHT IN SO AGAIN I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT THE WORK THAT THAT
SPACE HAS LENT IN TERMS OF
AGAIN HOW WE'RE MEASURING
PROGRESS WHAT ARE WE LOOKING
FOR WHAT ARE WE EXPECTING- THE
WORK- THAT HAS BEEN REFERENCED
EARLIER RELATED TO THE COUNTY
AT WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION'S WORK ON TWO POINT
OH. WHICH IS REALLY ABOUT
ENGAGEMENT SO AGAIN. AS THE AS
IT CONCRETE EXAMPLE AFTER- IN
INDIVIDUAL DEVELOPS THEIR
WELFARE TO WORK PLAN DO THEY
KNOW WHAT'S IN IT IS IT DRIVEN
BY THE INDIVIDUAL I THINK ALL
OF THESE- PROCESS SEASON
EXPERIENCES THAT WE'VE HAD IN
TO GET HERE- AS WAS. PREVIOUSLY
STATED BY THE SCRAPPY THAT THE
STATE MAP RIGHT WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO SUPPORT. INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES EXPERIENCING
POVERTY AGAIN THE TREMENDOUS
ADDITIONAL STRESSORS THAT HAVE
BEEN CREATED OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST YEAR WITH THE PANDEMIC
WITH SCHOOLS BEING CLOSED
EXCEPT. IT'S JUST CRITICAL THAT
WE ARE. UTILIZING STRENGTH
BASED APPROACHES SO I WOULD SAY
PART OF OUR RESPONSE IN IN SOME
OF THE WAYS THAT WE CAN DO THAT
AND AGAIN A PLACE WHERE IT'S
NEWARK. THAT WE ARE CAPTURING
LESSONS LEARNED IS THAT ARE CAL
WORKS HOME VISITING PROGRAM
VOLUNTARY- FOR THE INDIVIDUAL-
TO PARTICIPATE AND BUT REALLY
SAYING. HAVING A TRUSTED
PARTNER TO IDENTIFY- WHAT A
FAMILY NEEDS IN A GIVEN MOMENT
HELPING CONNECTS THEM TO THOSE
RESOURCES AND HAVING A WAY. TO
CONTINUE THAT RELATIONSHIP OVER
TIME AND ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS
WITH THE ARRAY THAT WE HAVE
BUILT I THINK THAT'S GONNA BE.
A WHILE IT ALSO HAS HAD
ADJUSTMENTS TO GOING REMOTE I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
HELPFUL IN S. AT THINKING
THROUGH AGAIN. HOW WE'RE
ADJUSTING TO WHAT FAMILIES
NEEDS I THINK SOME OF THE COMP.
AND RECKON. THAT HAVE SHARE
TODAY. AROUND ARE ALL AREAS
AGAIN THAT WE ARE GLAD TO
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS- IT IS IT
IS WHAT WHEN I SPEAK TO THE
TOOLS BY WHICH THE DEPARTMENT
IS GOING TO- USE RIGHT EACH
EACH OF OUR DIVISIONS IS IN THE
PROCESS OF ESTABLISHING THEIR
OWN EQUITY PLAN AND SO. AGAIN
WE HAVE A COMMITMENT- ALONG.
IMMEDIATELY AND MOVING FORWARD
SET TO REALLY WORK ON
IDENTIFYING WHERE WE DO NOT SEE
THE NEED FOR POLICY CHANGES
MAKING THOSE. ADJUSTMENTS AND
PROPOSALS THROUGH THE PROCESS
SO I WOULD JUST AGAIN STATES
EVOLVING- WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
SECURE PROPERTY SUSPEND SOME
WAYS AT THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
THE PROGRAM ADULT MOST
SUCCESSFUL. AT FOR THEIR
BENEFIT. THANK YOU FOR THAT AND-
BEING AND WITH THE WORKS HOME
VISIT PROGRAM I'M A BIG FAN AND
PROPONENT AS WELL AND BELIEVE
IT'S AN EXCELLENT WAY FOR US TO
ESTABLISH A- THOSE TRUSTED
RELATIONSHIPS THAT ARE SO
NECESSARY. I WANTED TO DIG IN
TO ONE OF MY CAROL'S.
RECOMMENDATIONS THOUGH
REGARDING DATA FOR CAL WORKS
FOR US TO EVALUATE AND FIGURE
OUT IF THERE WERE PROGRAMMATIC
DECISIONS WHICH WERE. HURTING
OR LIMITING COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND TO GET A RESPONSE
FROM YOU IF I COULD DIRECTOR
JOHNSON. SURE AGAIN I THINK
THAT'S WE WOULD BE GLAD TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT ON THAT.
REQUEST TO SEE WHAT MIGHT BE
POSSIBLE WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
PLACES AGAIN WITH THE WORK OF
THE LEGISLATURE- INDEED
MINISTRATION OVER TIME WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF REPORTS.
RELATED TO VARIOUS POLICIES
WHETHER THEY BE- AT TIME CLOCK
SIX ADDRESS THOUGH GLAD TO TAKE
A LOOK AT BOTH WHAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AND WHAT MIGHT
BE. NEEDED IN ADDITION TO SEE
WHAT WE COULD POSSIBLY DO TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT REQUEST THANK
YOU- MY NEXT QUESTION IS FOR-
MARKHAM ME JACK WITH THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES I. WANTED TO
SEE IF THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
BE AMENABLE TO CODIFYING THE
GOALS. OF THE AGENCY AND ITS
DEPARTMENTS IN AN EFFORTS TO
FORMALIZE AND TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE. THIS
DEVELOPING MISSION OF EQUITY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION I
THINK YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT
NOW IS A BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
THAT REALLY LOOKS AT. WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN BUILD THE
FOUNDATION I THINK WE WANT TO
WORK WITH YOU ALL TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO BEST PROCEED WITH
REGARDS TO ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT PIECES. AS PART OF
THAT I THINK IS REALLY BUILDING
OUT A FRAMEWORK FOR WHAT OUR
WORK REALLY LOOKS LIKE AND I
THINK PART OF IT IS JUST MAKING
SURE. THAT OUT BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY JUST CODIFY THE IDEA
OF DOING A FRAMEWORK THAT WERE
BERMAN MORE AND MORE FOCUSED ON
QATAR. ACTUAL ACTIONS OR
CHANGES BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO DRIVE REALLY
OUR ABILITY TO DELIVER ON TRUE
OUTCOMES. AND PROGRAMMATIC
CHANGES INDIVIDUAL SMALL ALL
THAT TO SAY I THINK WERE WORSE
IN OPEN TO CONTINUE KERR. WITH
YOUR STAFF AND LEGISLATURE WITH
REGARDS WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
OPERATE THAT YOU KNOW WE WORK
WE WOULD PREFER NOT TO QATAR.
JUST SIMPLY HASN'T A FREE. WELL
WE- TO CODIFY TO SAY HERE IS
WHAT. THAT WE HELP OUT AND
REALLY LOOKING WAYS AND WE CAN
THAT COLLECT ACCOUNT OF. FOR
TIME MATTER OUTCOMES THROUGH.
TO FRAME. I AM HAPPY TO HAVE OF
UP CALL. A KNOW THAT THERE ARE
FINISHED BE LED MIKE. TO THE
SPACE AS WELL AND- I LIKE TO
JUST FOR US TO TOGETHER SO THAT
WE CAN. PARTNER DOES THAT TWO
TWENTY BUDGET AND COME TRADE
BILL FORM. THIS CRITICAL KERR
MOVING FORWARD. BUT WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO THANK MUCH PANEL TO
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PANEL THREE ON HOMELESSNESS AND
FAMILY SERVED IN THE ANTI
POVERTY PROGRAMS. WE HAVE SEVEN
PANELISTS ISSUE THREE WE WILL
BEGIN WITH SARA KIMBERLIN
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER. AGAIN WE WILL HOLD ALL
MEMBERS QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER
THE CENTERS HAVE CONCLUDED.
THIS KIMBERLIN CAN YOU PLEASE
BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MILLEN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK TODAY. MY
NAME IS ERICA MARYLAND AND I'M
A SENIOR POLICY ANALYST WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND
POLICY CENTER I'M HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE URGENT HOUSING
NEEDS FACING CALIFORNIANS
DURING BECAUSE OF IT AND AFTER
WE EMERGE FROM THE PANDEMIC.
PARTICULARLY FOR CALIFORNIANS
WITH LOW INCOMES. SB THREE
THINGS WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
HOUSING NEEDS RIGHT NOW. WHAT
HOUSING NEEDS LOOK LIKE BEFORE
CO THEN WHY THAT MATTERS AND
WHY WE MIGHT INTO WHAT WE MIGHT
ANTICIPATE AFTER THE PANDEMIC
IS UNDER CONTROL. FIRST OF
SPEAK TO HOUSING NEEDS DURING
COVE IT. THE LATEST AVAILABLE
DATA FROM THE CENSUS BUREAU
THESE ARE CURRENT AS OF MARCH
FIRST CLEARLY SHOW THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE STRUGGLING TO
KEEP UP WITH HOUSING COSTS
RIGHT NOW. THAT'S ESPECIALLY
TRUE FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH LOW
INCOMES AMONG RENTERS WITH
INCOMES UNDER FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE IN FIVE RECORDED
BEING BEHIND ON RENT PAYMENTS
AMONG RENTERS AND HOUSEHOLDS
WITH CHILDREN ONE IN FOUR
RECORDED BEING BEHIND ON RENT.
AND STRUGGLES KEEPING UP WITH
RENT WERE MOST COMMON AMONG
CALIFORNIA. RENTERS WHO ARE
BLACK OR LATIN ACTS. NONE OF
THIS IS A- BECAUSE LOSSES
DURING THE PANDEMIC HAVE HIT
LOW WAGE WORKERS THE HARDEST.
AND HIT HIT BLACK AND NOT NEXT
WORKERS ESPECIALLY HARD AS THE
BUDGET CENTER HAS DOCUMENTED. A
NUMBER OF ACTIONS BY POLICY
MAKERS AT THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVELS HAVE BEEN IMPORTANT IN
HELPING CALIFORNIANS MAINTAIN
STABLE HOUSING DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THE STATE'S ADDICTION
MORATORIUM HAS BEEN CRITICAL
BUT IT CURRENTLY EXPIRES AT THE
END OF JUNE WHEN IT IS VERY
UNLIKELY THAT THE JOB MARKET
WILL HAVE FULLY RECOVERED. ALSO
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME FEDERAL
FUNDS AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS WHO-
BACKGROUND OR WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP WITH
RENTS. AND THERE BEEN A RANGE
OF ESTIMATES FROM CREDIBLE
SOURCES OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
RENT THAT RIGHT NOW BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WE KNOW
THAT A SUBSTANTIAL SHARE
CALIFORNIA RENTERS ARE
STRUGGLING NOW. AND WE CAN BE
SURE THAT MANY WILL STILL BE
STRUGGLING AT THE END OF JUNE
WHEN THE STATE EVICTION
MORATORIUM ENDS- AND IN THE
FALL WHEN ENHANCE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS ARE SUCH AND- ONE.
LAST COMMENT ABOUT NEED DURING.
WHEN THINKING ABOUT URGENT
NEEDS DURING THE PANDEMIC. THE
BUDGET CENTER HAS HIGHLIGHTED
THE IMPORTANCE OF PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AND
THERE'S A MIX THAT I FAMILIES.
THESE INDIVIDUALS CONTRIBUTE
JUST AS MUCH TO CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES AND ECONOMY. IN
FACT MANY ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
DURING KOPET. BUT THEY HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM MUCH OF THE
FEDERAL COVET ASSISTANCE AND
ARE BLOCKED FROM MANY OF THE ON
GOING SO THE SOURCES OF SUPPORT
WHEN IN CRISIS. SO THEY FACE
THE SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER GAP
WHEN STRUGGLING TO MAKE MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS. SO THAT'S
THE HOUSING SITUATION RIGHT NOW
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO ALSO
LOOK BACKWARD TO THE TIME
BEFORE KOBE WHICH IS THE SECOND
POINT I WILL BRIEFLY ADDRESS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
CALIFORNIA FACED A HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS BEFORE COVE IT BACK WHEN
THE ECONOMY WAS FULLY OPEN AND
BOOMING MORE THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S RENTERS AND ABOUT
EIGHT IN TEN HOUSEHOLDS WITH
INCOMES UNDER 2100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE. WE'RE
ALREADY PAYING AND AFFORDABLE
AMOUNT TOWARD HOUSING. AND THE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE MOST
LIKELY TO HAVE ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COSTS FOR THOSE WHO ARE
BLACK LAB MIX THE CIVIC
ISLANDER AND AMERICAN INDIAN.
AS WELL AS CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED. IN TERMS OF
HOMELESSNESS WE ALSO KNOW THE
BLACK CALIFORNIANS IN
PARTICULAR WERE CARRYING A
STARTLINGLY INEQUITABLE BURDEN
OF HOMELESSNESS BEFORE COBIT.
THESE RACIAL INEQUITIES REFLECT
THE FACT THE BLACK LAB MIX AND
MANY OTHER CALIFORNIANS OF
COLOR I'M MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
LOW INCOMES AS A RESULT OF
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS TO
EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. AND I'VE ALSO
BEEN BLOCKED FROM HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES IN PART DUE TO A
LEGACY OF EXPLICITLY RACIST
HOUSING POLICIES. SO THERE TO
TAKE TAKE AWAY FROM WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT HOUSING NEEDS BEFORE
BECAUSE OF IT. FIRST OF THE
MANY CALIFORNIANS FACE URGENT
HOUSING NEEDS EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE TO LOSE THEIR JOBS. AND
SECONDLY EVEN BEFORE KOBE THERE
WERE RACIAL INEQUITIES IN WHO
FACE THE GREATEST HOUSING
CHALLENGES. FINALLY SPEAK ABOUT
THE HOUSING NEEDS WE MIGHT
EXPECT TO SEE AFTER WE EMERGE
FROM THE PENTOMIC. AT THE
BUDGET CENTER WE WORRY ABOUT
THE FACT THAT COULD BE JOB
LOSSES HAVE BEEN CONCENTRATED
AMONG LOW WAGE WORKERS. SO THE
JOB RECOVERY MAY TAKE THE
LONGEST TIME FOR THESE WORKERS
AND SOME OF THE JOBS THESE TO
HAVE MAYBE PERMANENTLY GONE.
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS THERE
IS SHORT TERM SUPPORT TO HELP
PEOPLE COPE WITH UNEMPLOYMENT
AND POVERTY RAT. BUT WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO
THE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE STILL
OUT OF WORK. AND STILL
STRUGGLING TO COVER HOUSING
COSTS WHEN THIS EMERGENCY
SUPPORT ENDS. THESE ARE LIKELY
TO BE THE CALIFORNIANS WHO
RESTRICT RECALLING THE MOST OF
HOUSING NEEDS BEFORE BECAUSE OF
IT INCLUDING RENTERS. THOSE
WITH THE LOWEST INCOMES AND
MANY CALIFORNIANS OF COLOR. AS
WELL AS THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN HIT
HARDEST BY JOB LOSSES DURING
THE PANDEMIC INCLUDING BLACK
AND LET NEXT WORKERS. AND THOSE
HAVE BEEN BLOCKED FROM SUPPORT
DURING HOPE IT INCLUDING
UNDOCUMENTED AND MIXED STATUS
FAMILIES. SO I'LL CONCLUDE WHY
THIS MATTERS. THAT HOUSING IS
REALLY CRITICAL BECAUSE IT
REPRESENTS SUCH A FUNDAMENTAL
SOCIAL DETERMINANT OF HEALTH.
AND A GATEWAY TO EDUCATIONAL
AND EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
SO THAT EXPERIENCING HOUSING
INSTABILITY OR WORSE FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS AND SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES. IT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE HOUSING
NEEDS ARE MET RIGHT NOW DURING
THE PATHETIC BUT IT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT TO THINK BEYOND THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISES WERE HERE
BEFORE COPAYS. AND WILL NOT
DISAPPEAR FOR THE PANDEMIC
BEDS. FOR THAT REASON IT IS
IMPORTANT TO THINK LONG TERM AS
WELL AND TO PRIORITIZE ONGOING
SUPPORT FROM THE STATE TO
ADDRESS HOUSING NEEDS AND
HOMELESSNESS ESPECIALLY FOR THE
CALIFORNIANS MOST AFFECTED BY
THESE CRISES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM KIM
JOHNSON DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAN JOHNSON THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND WANT TO APPRECIATE AND ECHO
ABS. COMMENTS IN THE IN THE
RELATIONSHIP OF HOUSING AT TO
THE RACIAL EQUITY CONVERSATION
THAT WE'VE HAD AND SOME
ABSOLUTE- SYSTEMIC ROOTS AND
STRUCTURAL RACISM AND HOW
HOUSING HAS BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE. TO TWO DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS OVER TIME SO-
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY AGAIN IN TERMS OF
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- ACT
HUGE PRIORITY OF OUR GOVERNORS
IN A PLACE THAT WE'VE BEEN.
INVESTING OUTSIDE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR PROPOSAL IN JUST A
MOMENT BACK IN TERMS OF THE COW
WORKS PROGRAM AGAIN- THE
LEGISLATURE. ADMINISTRATION
HAVE. INVESTED IN A COUPLE OF-
AT AND HOMELESSNESS. PROGRAMS
AND SO IN TERMS OF THE QUESTION
AROUND NEED I WILL SAY THAT IN
BOTH CASES NOT PROVIDE THE DATA
HERE THEY ARE. WE ARE SEEING
MORE ASK MORE REQUESTS THAN WE
HAVE RESOURCES TO FIND SO THE
COW WORKS THE HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED TO ASSIST FAMILIES
IN THE CALYX PROGRAM. MEET MEET
THE COST OF SECURING OR
MAINTAINING A PERMANENT HOUSING
OR PROVIDE. A TEMPORARY
EMERGENCY SHELTER- AB HOUSING
IS THE HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM INCLUDES BOTH TEMPORARY
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE AS WELL AS-
A PERMANENT AT THAT CAN ALSO
SUPPORT SECURITY DEPOSITS. AND
TWO MONTHS OF RENTAL ARREARS TO
PREVENT EVICTION AND
HOMELESSNESS. I IN THE MOST
RECENT FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY COUNTIES RECEIVED SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHT REQUESTS FOR HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE WHICH IS AN
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM. AND
580-002-0019 WORK REQUESTS WERE
APPROVED STATEWIDE SO AGAIN YOU
CAN SEE THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
NEEDS. IN A THE COW HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM IS THIS TO
FIVE. HOUSING STABILITY FOR
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM ASSISTS
FAMILIES IN SECURING AND
MAINTAINING PERMANENT HOUSING
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE WITHOUT
PRECONDITIONS. ASPECT
CONSISTENT WITH OUR HOUSING
FIRST MODELS. AT BEGIN LOOKING
AT THE NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR
FIFTEEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTEEN FAMILIES REQUESTED
ASSISTANCE FOR THE HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM AND NINE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN WERE APPROVED I WE HAVE A
FIVE THOUSAND OR SIX THOUSAND
FIVE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO TRANSITIONING INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING. I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT IN THIS CURRENT YEAR
AND WITH THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE
SEEN A NOTABLE DECREASE IN BOTH
APPLICATIONS AND APPROVALS. FOR
THESE PROGRAMS BASED ON OUR
COUNTY STIRRED A DAY THAT THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT COSTS FOR THIS
DECREASE IS IN FACT. AT THE
EVICTION MORATORIUM WHICH IS
ALLOWED FAMILIES TO MAINTAIN
HOUSING DURING THE PANDEMIC SO
SUCCESS IN THE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTS AT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO PROVIDE IN THIS
PARTICULAR TIME. I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
ESTABLISHED AND PUBLISHED
GUIDES TO SUPPORT BOTH COUNTIES
AND TRIBES TO ADDRESS HOUSING
INSTABILITY THROUGH THESE
EXISTING PROGRAMS. INCLUDING
ONE TIME PAYMENTS AGAIN TO
ADDRESS SPECIFIC APPREHENSION
OF ADDICTION AND HOMELESSNESS.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT GIVEN
THE DATA WE ARE SEEING BROADLY
ACROSS THE STATE RELATIVE TO
HOUSING INSECURITY AND LACK OF
CONFIDENCE IN FAMILY'S ABILITY
TO PAY RENT THE DEPARTMENT WILL
CONTINUE TO TRACK THIS NEED
VERY CLOSELY WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS AS SUCH AS THOSE IN
THE BUSINESS CONSUMER. SERVICES
IN HOUSING AGENCY TO ENSURE
FAMILIES SERVED BY UNSOCIAL
SERVICES ARE CONNECTED TO ALL
OF THAT COULD BE NINETEEN
RENTAL LEASE PROGRAMS WHICH
PROVIDE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN RENTAL ASSISTANCE
AND HAS RECENTLY ROLLED ROLLED
OUT. I JUST THIS WEEK SO AGAIN
WE ARE WORKING TO MAKE THOSE
BRIDGES AND CONNECTIONS FOR
ADVERTISEMENTS AND CAL WORKS.
AT THIS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER A
QUESTION RELATED TO THE TABLET
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY FUNDS THAT
WAS AUTHORIZED ON MARCH
ELEVENTH WHEN THE PRESIDENT
SIGNED THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN. ARE BASED ON OUR INITIAL
READING THE INFORMATION WE ARE
EXPECTING TO RECEIVE ACT
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN RELIEF AND
THAT CAN BE USED. TO SUPPORT
HOUSEHOLDS WOULD NOT BE CURRENT
SHORT TERM BENEFITS THAT DEAL
WITH A SPECIFIC CRISIS I DON'T
MEET A RECURRING OR ONGOING
NEED AND DON'T EXPECT EXTEND
BEYOND FOUR MONTHS SO AGAIN
WILL BE LOOKING TO. HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION ON THE
USE OF THOSE FUNDS. AND FINALLY
AS I MENTIONED WITH THE
CONTINUED COMMITMENTS AND
NUMBER ABS- EFFORTS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT WE THEIR GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL DOES
INCLUDE A TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME.
INVESTMENT OVER THREE YEARS FOR
THE CREATION OF THE COMMUNITY
CARE EXPANSION PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD SUPPORT TO BE ACQUISITION
OR REHABILITATION OF OUR ADULT
IN SENIOR CARE I PROGRAMS ARE
ASSISTED LIVING AS THEY'RE
COMMONLY KNOWN. THIS PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE AG
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL WHICH
WOULD EXPAND TREATMENT AND
RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS FOR THOSE
WITH APRIL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
SO IT'S PART OF A LARGER
PACKAGE AGAIN AND THINKING
ABOUT. THE LONG TERM CARE
CONTINUE YOU THE MANY WAYS THAT
WE ARE STUCK PRETTY IN THIS
CASE- ARE ARE A- IN AN- WITH
THE ABILITY AGAIN PROVIDE
RESOURCES FOR ACQUISITION AND
RENOVATION. AND AGAIN THESE ARE
SETTINGS THAT ARE SUPPORTING-
INDIVIDUALS THAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE REQUIRE INSTITUTIONAL
CARE- IN ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS.
WE HAVE- CERTAINLY HAVE A VERY
ARE BURIED- A SUPPLY OF THIS
FACILITY TYPE ACROSS THE STATE
BUT REALLY WOULD YOU HAVE A
SHORTAGE IN THOSE AT PROGRAMS
THAT ACCEPT. THE SS I SS P. A
PAYMENT IN THE AND FOR
RECIPIENTS THAT HAVE THAT FUN
SOURCE SO WE HAVE SEEN A
DECLINE IN THAT IN THOSE
NUMBERS. MORE SPECIFICALLY FROM
THE FOURTH QUARTER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN TO THE THIRD QUARTER
F TWENTY TWENTY THERE'S BEEN A
DECREASE OF APPROXIMATELY 6%
AND THE NUMBER OF EXERCISES AT
RECIPIENTS RESIDING IN ADULT
KERR SENIOR FACILITIES. SO THE
GOAL OF THE PROGRAM IS TO
ACCEPT. THE CAPITAL INVESTMENT
IN RENEWABLE- AND CHIU SAID IN
A AS A COME. OF SOME WE- HAVE
BEEN ASKED A LOT. AROUND ALSO
THE OPERATIONAL SUPPORTS AGAIN
I THINK WE ARE THINKING ABOUT
THIS PARTICULAR. COMPONENT OF
THAT PROPOSAL IN INCOME A
COLLABORATION INTEGRATED WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES COMPOUND WHICH DOES
OFFER SOME ADDITIONAL. AT
SERVICE DOLLARS IN RESOURCES-
SO I GLAD TO ANSWER ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY PROPOSING BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ADD TO PROVIDE- THAT
THE MECHANISMS TO GET THESE
RESOURCES OUT INTO COMMUNITIES
BUT CERTAINLY AS WE ALWAYS DO
WILL ENGAGE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
DEVELOPMENT. OF APPLICATIONS
AND MORE SPECIFICS AROUND
ALLOCATIONS EXCITER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM CORN BUCHANAN THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU SO MUCH HI
I'M YOU CANNOT ANSWER IS YES.
ACTOR HOUSE IN HOMELESS S. S.
B. S. SOME DETAILS THE ARE
OPERATE IN THE WEEK EVEN THEY
SUPPORT IN THE AND FAMILIES
DURING THE ACT AND HOW WE CAN
MEET THE ON NEED TO ADDRESS
HOUSING. IN HOMELESS AS WE WERE
FROM AND I'M BACK. WHY DON'T
AND ARE. A RATE THE RECORD
SHARED OUR WORK WITH THE BILL
CONCERN SERVICE. HOUSING THE
END OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
DEVELOPMENT OF. WORKER A AND-
BUT NIGHT RIGHT RELIEF PROGRAM.
WHICH WILL PROVIDE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN FUNDING FOR
RENT WERE. ON THEIR RENT. THE
TOTAL FUNDING TO K. WHICH
INCLUDES ALLOCATIONS THAT ARE
ALSO GOING DIRECTLY TO CITIES
AND COUNTIES IS TWO POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS. IT RECENTLY
SIGNED AMERICAN RESCUE PACKAGE
WILL PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FUNDING. WITH AN ESTIMATED TWO
POINT TWO BILLION IN NEW
FUNDING TO CALIFORNIA TO HELP
PAY RENTAL AND UTILITY ARREARS
AS- RECENTLY CRITICAL- NEW
RESOURCE. AND SO WE ARE WORKING
VERY HARD TO ENSURE THAT DFS
RECIPIENTS ARE ACCESSING THE
VERY IMPORTANT HOUSING RESOURCE.
LOCAL AND HOW. THE ONLY ONE TO
TALK WITH OUR PROGRAM THE FOR
HOW YEAH HOW ARE IS THAT
PROGRAM- SERVICE AND THE CALLER
PROGRAMS THAT ARE HOMELESS OR
EXPERIENCE OUT HOW CRISIS.
RIGHT THE HOUSING SAID PROGRAM
IS SLIGHTLY MORE TARGETED.
CALIFORNIA IS A HOW FIRST STATE
MEANS THAT FARM USED TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS PRIORITY YEAH WITH.
YOU MAY NEED FOR SERVICES HAS
EXCEEDED COUNTIES ABILITY TO
FOR IN PART DUE TO THE PROGRAM
RAMP UP. KOREAN NIGHT I MAY ASK
YOU TO TURN THE VEIL OFF FOR
HAVING QUITE A BIT OF-
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES IF
THAT'S OKAY. YEAH. JORDAN
PLEASE CONTINUE START. THE
COURT. BUT. I'M JUST DESCRIBING
IS A MORE TARGETED- IN THAT IT
SERVES PEOPLE WHO ARE LITERALLY
HOMELESS OR OR IN RECEIPT OF A
JUDGMENT FOR ACTON. AND THEN I
WAS DESCRIBING SORT OF THAT THE
TRENDS OVER TIME WITH OUR
PROGRAM- IN TERMS OF THE
SERVICES AT BASICALLY THE
DEMAND EXCEEDING OUR OUR
COUNTIES ABILITY TO SERVE WHICH
WAS IN PART DUE TO PROGRAM RAMP
UP OVER TIME AS WELL AS FUNDING
DEMANDS FOR THE NUMBER OF
FAMILIES AND BEAT S. PROGRAM
I'M SO IN EVERY YEAR OF
OPERATION THE FUNDING AMOUNT
THAT WAS REQUESTED BY COUNTIES
HAS EXCEEDED AMOUNT THAT WAS
AVAILABLE TO A WAR. BUT YOU'RE
OVER YOUR COUNTIES TO CONTINUE
TO INCREASE AND BETTER MEET THE
GOALS OF HOUSING MORE FAMILIES
FOR A TOTAL OF OVER FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND FAMILIES SERVICE SINCE
THE PROGRAM LAUNCHED IN. TWENTY
FOURTEEN THROUGH DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY. WE NOT AND
HOMELESSNESS FOR ALL FAMILIES
AND CAL. YES DESPITE THE- MADE
THE FAR IN THE NINETY MILLION
AN ONGOING FUNDS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE FOR THE HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM. A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF FAMILIES AND HOW IT
WORKS MORE COMPLEX ARE STILL
UNABLE BURKE. THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FISCAL YEAR YES I JUST
RECEIVED REQUESTS FROM FIFTY
FOUR COUNTIES REQUESTING OVER
ONE POINT SIX MILLION.
ESTIMATING. TO FOR FIVE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN FAMILIES. THE
PANDEMIC HAS INCREASED THE
COMPLEXITY OF MEETING THE NEEDS
OF CALVERT FAMILIES OFTEN
REQUIRING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
WE'RE SEEING THAT FAMILIES NEED
ASSISTANCE FOR LONGER PERIODS
OF TIME AND WITH MORE INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT AND AN
INCREASED NEED FOR SPECIALIZED
HOUSING NAVIGATORS. IN OUR
INCREASINGLY COMPLEX AND RENTAL
MARKET. WHEN I MOVE ON TO THE
GREEN FAMILY'S HOME PROGRAM
WHICH IS DESIGNED TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF FAMILIES AND THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK OF. NOT
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES
REUNIFYING AND TO PREVENT
FOSTER CARE. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
YES THAT'S RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS AND FUNDING
REQUESTS FROM TWENTY SIX
APPLICANTS THAT WERE REQUESTING
ALMOST THIRTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS. ALL OF TOTAL WILL BE
TWENTY FIVE BILLION STATE FUNDS
WAS AWARDED TO TWENTY TWO
COMMUNITIES FR THE THREE YEAR
PILOT GRANT I CALL. HE'S
COUNTIES AND TRIBES WHO WERE
FUNDED ACCOUNT 475% OF THE
TOTAL STATEWIDE CHILD WELFARE
CASELOADS. IN TOTAL ESTIMATING
OVER SIX THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
FAMILIES WHO ARE LIKELY
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES. WITH THE
CURRENT FUNDING LEVELS THE GOAL
OF THE PROGRAM IS TO SIR TWO
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO FAMILIES OVER A THREE YEAR.
NEXT I'LL TAKE US MOVES RIGHT
ALONG TO THE HOUSING DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAMMER EACH
CHAPTER. WHICH ASSISTS HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABLING
CONDITIONS TO APPLY FOR
DISABILITY BENEFIT PROGRAMS
NAMELY SSI WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
HOUSING SUPPORT. FORTY FOUR
GRANTEES INCLUDING TO TRIBAL
ENTITIES PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM AND PROVIDE OUTREACH
CASE MANAGEMENT DISABILITY
BENEFITS ADVOCACY AND HOUSING
ASSISTANCE. H. DOBSON SECTION
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ONE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN PERMANENTLY
HOUSE OVER FORTY THOUSAND
DISABILITY PPLICATIONS HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED AND OVER ONE
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED. YES THIS IS ABOUT
IMPORTANT NUMBER HERE THIS
REFLECTS A 78% DISABILITY
BENEFIT APPLICATION APPROVAL
RATE FOR DISPOSED APPLICATIONS
WHILE THE STATE AVERAGE IS 39%
WITH ME GREAT SUCCESS IN TERMS
OF THAT. THE APPLICATIONS THAT
ARE SUBMITTED. GRANTEES
IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR HIGHER
KEYS WE'RE OF MY STAFFING
LEVELS THAN THEY HAD ORIGINALLY
ANTICIPATED. THIS MEANS GRANT
YOU HAVE ADDED STAFF TO
ACCOMMODATE. CLIENT RATIOS
WHILE ALSO TRYING TO LEVERAGE
RELATIONSHIPS AND BUILDING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FOR. I'M AND OTHER
NECESSARY FOR. ADDITIONALLY I'D
LIKE TO ADD THAT THE ROCK THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN TWO
YEARS I HAVE SPECIFICALLY
PARTNERED ON PROJECT ROOM HE
EFFORT. THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROJECT.
RANKINGS WERE ABLE TO MORE
EASILY OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT
AND INCREASED NUMBER OF
POTENTIAL AND CURRENT EACH OUR
CLIENTS. WERE TEMPLE THAT
TEMPORARILY HOUSED THROUGH
PROJECT ROOM HE ARE CODED
RESPONSE FOR PEOPLE COMPLEX
HEALTH CONDITIONS THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE VERY CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH
OUR WITH OUR EACH CHAPTER.
RIGHT ALREADY POPULAR EACH. SO
LASTLY I'M I'LL SHARE ABOUT IT
A FEW KEY LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THE WHOLE STATE PROGRAM. WHICH
PROVIDES HOUSING INTERVENTIONS
FOR THOSE SERVED BY ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES.
TRANSACTION IN THE LOCK AND THE
LIGHTS AT TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
HOME STATE. OVER TWO THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED OLDER INDEPENDENT
ADULTS WORK THE THING RIGHT
THANK. THE PILOTS OKAY IS
PRIMARILY ON HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION BUT SOME COUNTIES
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY EXPANDED
THEIR MODEL DISTRICT PPS
CLIENTS WE'RE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WELL.
OFTEN HOMES THEY SERVES AS- A
TYPE OF BRIDGE FOR A PERSON
THAT NEEDS LONGER TERM SUPPORT
BY PROVIDING THAT SAFE
TEMPORARY HOUSING OPTION. I
CANNOT STAND OTHER STABILIZING
THESE PARTS OF. TWENTY PROGRAM.
FLAG THERE TO CIRCUMVENT. WOULD
BE A GROUP OF MORE PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE A LONG TERM CASE
MANAGEMENT AFTER CLIENT ACCEPTS
SOME STATE AND- NOT
SURPRISINGLY MORE AFFORDABLE
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OPTIONS
INCLUDING LICENSE ADULT AND
SENIOR CARE FACILITIES. FOR
CLIENTS THAT CAN NO LONGER LIVE.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE ABOUT OUR
WORK TO MEET THE HOUSING NEEDS
OF THE EFFORTS THAT. TO ENSURE
OUR ABILITY. YEAH THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM ANGELES
SHORT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THANK YOU-
ANGELA SHORT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE OF WE'VE BEEN
ASKED TO FIRST PROVIDE-
ASSESSMENTS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND THE DSS PROPOSED
INVESTMENT FOR RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY OR
RCMP'S AND ADULT RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES OR ARTISTS-
THIS IS THE PROPOSAL THAT A
TRACTOR JOHNSON ALSO SPOKE TO
YOU. EARLIER ON THIS PANEL
OTHER PROPOSALS ALSO DESCRIBED
ON PAGE FIFTY EIGHT OF YOUR
AGENDA SO AGAIN THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
FUNDING TO BE ADMINISTERED BY
DSS TO SUPPORT THE ACQUISITION
AND REHABILITATION. OF THE
LICENSED ARSON RCMP IS- GRANTS
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR THIS PURPOSE
AGAIN THIS PROGRAM I WOULD BE
PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
BROADER HOMELESSNESS STRATEGY.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
RELATED TO DATA LIMITATIONS
THAT COMPLICATES. OUR FULL
ASSESSMENT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
NAMELY DSS TRACKS THE TOTAL
NUMBER CAPACITY AND LOCATIONS
OF ADULT AND SENIOR CARE
FACILITIES THAT CLOSE AS WELL
AS THOSE THAT ARE NEWLY
LICENSED. HOWEVER TO THE BEST
PARTNER STANDING- THERE'S NOT
AGGREGATED DATA AVAILABLE ABOUT
ONE Y. FACILITIES CLOSE FOR
EXAMPLE DUE TO FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES. TO IF THERE ARE
CERTAIN TRAITS THAT ARE COMMON
TO FACILITY IS THAT CLOSE SUCH
AS AVERAGE MONTHLY RATES- AND
THREE WHAT HAPPENS TO RESIDENTS
WHEN FACILITIES CLOSE FOR
EXAMPLE WHETHER THEY BECOME
HOMELESS OR IF THEY'RE ABLE TO.
MOVE INTO A DIFFERENT FACILITY
AND WITHOUT THESE DATA POINTS
ASSESSING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT THESE
FACILITIES IT'S DIFFICULT- IN
PARTICULAR GIVEN THE STATE
LIMITATIONS. WE REALLY CAN'T
SAY FOR CERTAIN WHAT IS DRIVING
ADULT AND SENIOR CARE FACILITY
FACILITIES TO CLOSE AND
ACCORDINGLY WE DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THE PROPOSED ONE TIME
FUNDS WOULD BE AN EFFECTIVE
TOOL TO ADDRESS THEM. M. IF WE
KNEW WHETHER FACILITIES WERE
CLOSING DUE TO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ISSUES THAT WOULD
HELP US UNDERSTAND IF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ONE TIME
FUNDING APPROACH- COULD HELP
EFFECTIVELY MEDICAID CLOSURES.
WHEREAS ALTERNATIVELY IF DATA
SHOWED US THE CLOSURES ARE
ACTUALLY DRIVEN BY-
INSUFFICIENT BOARDING CARE
RATES. THEN WE COULD ASSESS
WHETHER A MORE EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTION TO PREVENT
CLOSURES. MIGHT ACTUALLY BE TO
INCREASE THESE RATES ON AN
ONGOING BASIS I'M SO AGAIN WITH
THE WITH THE DATA LIMITATIONS
IS JUST DIFFICULT TO ASSESS
WHAT THE MOST EFFECTIVE-
INTERVENTION COULD BE. I'M ONE
OF THE RECOMMENDATION WE WOULD
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT- IS RELATED
TO TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR
THIS PROPOSAL- AS YOU HEARD
FROM DIRECTOR JOHNSON THE
ADMINISTRATION INTENDS TO
INTRODUCE A TO ESTABLISH THIS
PROGRAM THROUGH BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE- HOWEVER WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW TO ENSURE.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
REALLY HAVE SUFFICIENT
OVERSIGHT OF THE PROGRAM
WITHOUT SPECIFIC IMPLEMENTING
LEGISLATION- IN OTHER WORDS
TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION AND WE
AGREE WITH THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON PAGE SIXTY
ONE OF YOUR AGENDA- THEREFORE
TO ASK THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROVIDE DRAFT. TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH- OF THIS
PROGRAM AND THAT ITS
IMPLEMENTATION- AND IN OUR
SYSTEM AND THAT LANGUAGE SHOULD
LAY OUT THE PARAMETERS OF THE
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE HOW WILL
FUNDS BE TARGETED HOW WE ENSURE
THAT FUNDS ARE USED FOR THEIR
INTENDED PURPOSE. AND WHAT
REPORTING WILL BE REQUIRED
FROM- RECIPIENTS IN TERMS OF
EXPECTED RESULTS AND OTHER
OUTCOMES TO ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRACK. THE
PROGRESS AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
THIS INVESTMENT. MOVING ON
WE'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED WHAT AND
KHIMETRICS- UP WOULD BE TO
CONSIDER TO INCLUDE IN A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
EXAMINE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THIS PROGRAM- I WILL NOTE THAT
WE ARE WORKING WITH DSS
CURRENTLY TO DETERMINE WHAT
WHAT ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD- AS
WELL AS STATUTORY OR REGULAR AT
REGULATORY GUIDANCE MIGHT BE
NEEDED IN ORDER TO COLLECT
ADDITIONAL DATA TO ALLOW US TO
MORE FULLY UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
DRIVING DON'T SENIOR CARE
FACILITY CLOSURES- AND ASSESS
BARRIERS- IN PARTICULAR FOR
CERTAIN LOW INCOME POPULATIONS
LIKE SS I SS P. RECIPIENTS. BUT
THAT'S SAID- AND DEPENDING ON
WHAT DATA COLLECTION ULTIMATELY
IS POSSIBLE WE THINK SOME KEY
METRICS TO HELP GAUGE THE
EFFECTIVENESS COULD INCLUDE A
ONE HOW MANY ARSON ARE SEE IF
HE'S WOULD HAVE CLOSED BUT ARE
STATE
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS RESIDE
AT THOSE FACILITIES. AND
FINALLY FOR FACILITIES THAT
RECEIVE FUNDING- ARE THOSE
FACILITIES CONTINUING TO
EXPERIENCE FINANCIAL IDSHIPS
OR CONTINUING TO CONSIDER
CLOSING SIX MONTHS TO ONE YEAR
AFTER RECEIVING A GRANT IN
OTHER WORDS WAS THAT ONE TIME
FUNDING EFFECTIVE. ALSO JUST
CONCLUDE AS MENTIONED WE WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH DSS TO
ASSESS WHAT DATA POINTS COULD
BE AVAILABLE. AND SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH PURSUING TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FOR THIS PROGRAM
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
OUR ASSESSMENT OF THAT DRAFT
LANGUAGE ONCE IT'S AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM KATHY
SANDERLING MCDONALD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. RIGHT
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS KATHY SUMMERLIN
WITH ALL OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. THE
HOUSING CRISIS AFFECTS EVERY
PROGRAM I MEMBERS RUN AND IT
AFFECTS EVERY COUNTY IN THE
STATE. WE CAN'T REUNIFY
CHILDREN OF PARENTS WHO LACKS
ALTER OUR CAL WORK PARTICIPANTS
CAN'T HOLD DOWN A JOB IF
THEY'RE SLEEPING IN A CAR. ALL
THEIR INDEPENDENT ADULTS WHO
NEED OUR HELP FOR ABUSE AND
NEGLECT ISSUES INCLUDING THE
GROWING PROBLEM OF FINANCIAL
ABUSE ARE MORE LIKELY TO FALL
INTO L. HEALTH AND EVEN DIE
PREMATURELY IF THEY LOSE THEIR
HOUSE. OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS COUNTIES IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION. HAS SET UP A
NUMBER OF HOUSING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS TIED DIRECTLY TO THE
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS WE
OPERATE. COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS
AND STAFF KNOW OUR CLIENTS
FASTER UNDERSTAND WHEN THE
SERVICES ARE NEEDED. WE HAVE
SOME PROPOSAL TO BOOST AND
STRENGTHEN THESE PROGRAMS TO
RESPOND TO HOUSING INSTABILITY
AS WELL AS HOMELESSNESS WHICH
ALL ADDRESS AS I RESPOND TO THE
QUESTIONS. IN THE ENGINE. FIRST
WITH REGARD TO THE EXPERIENCE
COUNTIES THAT HAD IN
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM AND
MEETING NEEDS DURING HELLBENT.
NOTHING IN SECURITY ANALYSTS
WERE ALREADY AT CRISIS LEVELS
FOR OUR CLIENTS AND NOT
SURPRISINGLY WE SEEM AN EVEN
GREATER NEED FOR HOUSING
SUPPORT AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND THE HEALTH RISKS
OF HOMELESSNESS ALREADY GREAT
BECAME EVEN MORE LIFE OR DEATH
WITH POTENTIAL EXPOSURE TO
COVER NINETEEN. ALSO WITH THE
PANDEMIC CAN BOTH UNCERTAINTY
AND CONSTANT CHANGE. COUNTING
THE NUMEROUS TIMES TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF VARIOUS ONE TIME
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES. THESE
ARE VERY VERY WELCOME THEY ALSO
CAN MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO PLAN
OUR BEST FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BLEND TOGETHER SERVICES. ACROSS
THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS WE OPERATE.
WHILE WE APPLAUD THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM BE UNINTENDED THE
FACT IS THAT IT'S ACTUALLY BEEN
MORE DIFFICULT TO HELP OUR
CLIENTS FIND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS. THIS REALLY SPEAKS TO
THE UNDERLYING LACK OF HOUSING
STOCK ESPECIALLY AFFORDABLE
RENTAL STOCK THAT WE HAVE
ACROSS OUR STATE. I'M MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DESPERATE
IMPACTS OF ONGOING HOUSING
DIFFICULTIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC. I'M EXAMPLES INCLUDE
THOSE LIVING AND NONTRADITIONAL
ARRANGEMENTS ABOUT A FORMAL
LEASE LIKE IN A FAMILY MEMBERS
CONVERTED GARAGE OR SHARING A
HOME. THEY DON'T HAVE THE
PROTECTIONS THAT SOMEONE WITH A
FORMALLY SOMEWHERE WHERE DO.
THOSE CAN STILL BE AFFECTED FOR
NON PANDEMIC RELATED CAUSES ARE
ALSO OFTEN THOSE THAT WE SERVE.
ONE EXAMPLE A WOMAN HAS ESCAPED
A VIOLENT BOYFRIEND OR HUSBAND
I MAKE A CHANGE TO COME AROUND
HER APARTMENT AND THREATENED
HER HOUSING HER TO CALL THE
POLICE. SHE MAY NOT HAVE ANY
RENTAL PAYMENT PROBLEMS DUE TO
CO BID AND AS A RESULT THE LAN
OR CONFLICT OR EVEN NOW FOR
BEING A DISTURBANCE OR NUISANCE
TO THE NEIGHBORS. THIS TYPE OF
THE VICTIM IS ALREADY A PROBLEM
WITH OUTLOOK ADDED LAYER OF A
PANDEMIC ON TOP CREATING THE
POTENTIAL FOR ANY LOSS OF
HOUSING BECAUSE OF FURTHER
DOWNWARD. SPIRAL FOR SOMEONE
WHO EXPERIENCES THAT. IT'S
REALLY IN. TO UNDERSTAND THE
CRISIS THAT ADDICTION CREATES
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
FAMILIES OF COLOR. ACCORDING TO
THE EVICTION LAB AT PRINCETON
UNIVERSITY. LOW INCOME WOMEN
ESPECIALLY FOR WOMEN OF COLOR.
ABOUT HIGH RISK OF THE- READERS
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS AND FAMILIES
WITH CHILDREN ARE AT
PARTICULARLY HIGH RISK. THE
VESSEL HAVE ALSO NOTES OF
EVIDENCE STRONGLY INDICATES
THAT THE VICTIM IS NOT JUST A
CONDITION OF POVERTY AND IS A
CAUSE OF POVERTY. A BIGGER
FAMILIES OFTEN WAS CONFESSIONS
THEIR CONNECTIONS TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR CHILDREN
HAVE TO START OVER IN A NEW
SCHOOL. LANDLORDS SCREEN OUT
PEOPLE ACQUIRE AND EXPENSE OF
THESE FAMILIES HAVE AN EVEN
GREATER DIFFICULTY GETTING BACK
IN THE QUALITY HOUSING. I ONLY
KNOW THAT EVICTION CAUSES JOB
LOSS AND NOT SURPRISINGLY AND
IT'S BEEN SHOWN TO NEGATIVELY
AFFECT PEOPLE'S MENTAL. HEALTH
SOMETIMES FOR YEARS AFTERWARD.
SO HOW THAT COMPARE. FOR
CHALLENGES THE FAMILIES FACING
HOUSING RESTS ON THE RIGHT AS
THE RED MORATORIUM'S LEFT. AND
IT IS THE CONTINUING EFFORTS TO
INCREASE HOUSING STOCK AND MAKE
IT MORE AFFORDABLE WE ALSO NEED
TO HELP PEOPLE STAY IN THEIR
HOMES AND AVOID EVICTION. WE
SHOULD BE PLANNING AHEAD TO
COVER A RARE CHANCE AT LEAST TO
THE MINIMUM 25% IN THE STATE OF
EXTEND FAR. ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
BE AFFECTED AS FAR MORE COSTLY
THAN HELPING THEM STAY HOUSE.
CEDAR BDA HAS ALSO PUT FORTH A
REQUEST FOR A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING. TO
BE SPENT OVER TWO YEARS. THE
BEST SERVICES AND HOUSING
PROGRAMS ARE MEMBERS OPERATE
FOR OUR CLIENTS. CALIFORNIA
BASED ON SELECTIVELY TO FILL
GAPS IN FUNDING AND HOUSING
ASSISTANCE ALTERNATIVES. OUR
CLIENTS. AND IT'S CRITICAL TO
CREATE A MULTI YEAR PLAN FOR
PROJECT HUNKY. AS YOU KNOW THE
FUNDS PROVIDED IN THE IMMEDIATE
EARLY ACTION PACKAGES ARE
CONSIDERED ONE TIME. WITH NO
GUARANTEE OF CONTINUED FUNDING
FOR COUNTIES TO KEEP OPERATING
RESULTS. FINALLY HOW CAN OUR
PROGRAMS BECOME MORE EFFECTIVE
TO PREVENT ADDICTION AND THE
OBSTACLES TO DOING THAT. FIRST
CONTINUING FUNDING FOR HOUSING
PROGRAMS AND ESPECIALLY MAKING
A HOMESTAY COMPONENT OF ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PERMANENT
AND PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THERE BUT I'LL TALK
ABOUT MORE IN THE LAST CHANNEL
TODAY WILL HELP BOTH IN THE
SHORT AND LONGER TERM. AS I
NOTED ABOVE THE PREVENTION OF
EVICTION IS CRITICAL BUT IT'S
NOT SUPPORTED BY ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS THEY OPERATE. IN THE
POWER SPACE HOUSING SERVICES
PROGRAMMER HSP THIS IS A KEY
BARRIER UNDER THE DEPARTMENT'S
INTERPRETATION OF CARLOCK
COUNTIES ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
SERVE FAMILIES WHO ARE AT RISK
OF ADDICTION UNTIL THEY'RE
SERVED WITH AN ACTUAL EVICTION
NOTICE. THAT'S PRETTY FAR ALONG
IN THE PROCESS AND AT THAT
POINT IT'S MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
AND OFTEN SIMPLY TOO LATE TO
INTERVENE SUCCESSFULLY. PUTS US
IN A POSITION OF HAVING TO HELP
THAT FAMILY FIND A NEW PLACE TO
LIVE WHICH AS WE TALKED ABOUT
TAKES MORE TIME IF WE CAN EVEN
FIND A PLACE THAT THEY CAN
AFFORD ANOTHER REQUIREMENT
UNDER THE STATUTE. AND THIS
WORK IS FAR MORE COSTLY THAN
JUST HELPING. THEM STAY IN
THEIR EXISTING HOME IN THE
FIRST PLACE. ALL NEED TO PAY
RECKONED ALLOWING LONGER
SOMETHING. AS WELL AS MORE.
WHEN IT COMES PURCHASING%
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS. TO
GIVE IT ALL SOME FAMILIES TIME
THEY NEED TO BUILD UP THEIR
RESOURCES IN INCOME. TO AVOID
BEING CONSTANTLY ON THE BREAK
BREAK AND THE NEXT. WE'RE
ASKING FOR THESE TWO CRITICAL
FLEXIBILITY IS TO BE ADDED TO
THE STATUTES ARE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. THESE CHANGES ARE KEY
TO STABILIZING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE FAMILIES YOUTH AND
OLDER AND DISABLED ADULTS.
THANK YOU AND I'MHAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS DURING THE
QUESTION TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FROM SOME MOUNT.
DIRECTOR OF HOUSING AND HEALTH
JOHN BURTON USED. ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
BEFORE I BEGIN MY REMARKS I'D
LIKE TO JUST SAY THAT WE AGREE
WITH AND SUPPORT THE SUB
COMMITTEE REQUEST FOR ISSUE FOR
THAT WILL BE DISCUSSED WITHIN
THE NEXT PANEL I'M IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S RIGHT ABSOLUTELY
TO THE FAMILY FOR CONVENTION
BACK. RIGHT NOW TO ROUTE TO
TURN TO MY REMARK. CURTAIN FROM
ACROSS YOUTH HAVE BEEN DEEP
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC. AS
YOUNG WORKERS WE'VE BEEN HIT
HARDEST BY JOB LOSS. BUT UNLIKE
THE 52% OF EIGHTEEN THE TWENTY
NINE YEAR OLD LIVING WITH THEIR
PARENTS NATIONALLY. BOB DO YOU
DO NOT HAVE THE EMOTIONAL
ECONOMIC THE COURT DOCKET OF AN
EXTENDED FAMILY. IN A TWENTY
TWENTY SURVEYS FEWER THAN HALF
OF BOX YOU PURPORTED THEY HAD
FRIENDS HEATH WORKER OR FAMILY
MEMBER TO RELY ON DURING THE
PANDEMIC. BLACK OF ASSISTANT
HAS HAD DEVASTATING IMPACTS
COMPOUNDED OVER TIME. IN A
STATEWIDE SURVEY OF CURRENT
FORM A BOX YOU CAN CALIFORNIA
ONE IN FIVE REPORTED
EXPERIENCING AT THE THOUGHT OF
HOMELESSNESS IN THE START OF
THE PANDEMIC. BOB DO YOU LIVING
IN HIGH COST COUNTIES ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC DUE TO
THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING PROGRAM
FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
CLASS KNOWN IT'S HUGELY POPULAR.
THIS PROGRAM WITH THE STYLISH
BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
AT THE URGING OF CALIFORNIANS
CONNECTION. AND PROVIDE STATE
REPORTED HELPING TO OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED YOU ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT
TOGETHER WITH OVER THREE
HUNDRED OF THEIR CHILDREN. HE
THREE PUTTED HIGHLY EFFECTIVE.
BUT IT'S INCREASINGLY IT'S
INCREASINGLY UNAVAILABLE IN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES WITH THE
HIGHEST RENTAL CAR. OVER THREE
FOURTHS OF CALIFORNIA'S ELEVEN
HIGHEST HAWK COUNTIES HAD A
DECREASE IN HOUSING CAPACITY.
I'M SORRY- AN INCREASE IN
HOUSING AND A DECREASE IN
HOUSING CAPACITY IN THE LAST
DECADE AS COMPARED 239% OF THE
LOWER COST COUNTY. INTRODUCTION
AND HOUSING CAPACITY COMES AT A
TERRIBLE TIME. INSTEAD OF BEING
FAKE WE HOUSE DURING THE
PANDEMIC FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
ARE WAITING. THE MOST RECENTLY
AVAILABLE DATA SHOWS THE TOTAL
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH ON A PEACH TREE
PARK WAIT LET'S STATEWIDE. THE
AVERAGE WEIGHT WITH AN ELEVEN
HIGHER CROP COUNTY IT'S FOUR
TIMES GREATER THAN THE AVERAGE
AND LOWER COST COUNTY. WHILE
THE CHALLENGES ARE DAUNTING
CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE POLLUTION.
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU
IT'S LEADING A COALITION OF ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
ORGANIZATIONS FROM ALL CORNERS
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING YOU TO
REQUEST EIGHTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE STATE
BUDGET TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
AMONG CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
BEYOND. THIS PROPOSAL INVEST IN
WHAT WE KNOW WORK TO KEEP YOU
BASICALLY HAVE. FIRST THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS AMONG YOUTH
CURRENTLY IN FOSTER CARE I
TRAINING CHILD WELFARE WORKERS
ON HOUSING RESOURCES AND GIVING
THEM A NEW TOOL IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST ALMOST NOT. HOW THE
NAVIGATION. CURRENTLY SOCIAL
WORKERS RECEIVE NO TRAINING ON
AVAILABLE HOUSING RESOURCES OR
HOW TO HELP YOU ACCESS THEM.
FOR YOU TO HAVE MORE COMPLEX
HOUSING NEEDS BETTER COULD TELL
YOUR PARENTS OR YOU COULD
DISABILITIES THERE ARE NO
DEDICATED RESOURCES TO HELP
THEM NAVIGATE THE TIGHT THE
TIME CONSUMING HOUSING SEARCH
PROCESS AND SECURE HOUSING. THE
CURRENT BUDGET PROPOSAL WOULD
CHANGE THAT BY TRAINING SOCIAL
WORKERS ON HOW THE HOUSING
FUNDAMENTAL. AND INVESTING FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND
THE STATE'S HOUSING NAVIGATORS
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE HOW
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. IN COLLABORATION
WITH LOCAL CHILD WELFARE AGENCY.
THIS EVIDENCE BASED STRATEGIES
WORK BEST APPROXIMATELY ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE YOUTH ANNUALLY. SECOND THE
PROPOSAL WOULD PROTECT FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH BY INCREASING THE
AVAILABILITY OF HOUSING AND
PREVENTING THE LACK OF HOUSING
CAPACITY AND HIGH COST PARK
WITH THE STATE OF THE GRANT
EARLIER. IT WOULD DO THIS BY
MAKING THE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM A PERMANENT ONGOING
PROGRAM. IS PROGRAM PRIORITIZES
NEUTROPENIC FOSTER CARE
JUVENILE PROBATION
UNFORTUNATELY IT WILL END ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST JUST ONE
BOX YOU NEED IT MOST. THE
CURRENT BUDGET PROPOSAL WOULD
REMOVE FIFTY EXTENSION AND IF
THIS ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE USED ANNUALLY.
ADDITIONALLY IT WOULD BE A
VALUABLE RESOURCE TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING COSTS FACED BY AN
ESTIMATED THOUSAND YOU
VOLUNTARILY REMAINED IN FOSTER
CARE PACKAGE TWENTY ONE
FOLLOWING ACTION TAKEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE MARKET BUDGET. AS
NOTED EARLIER HOUSING WAITING
LISTS ARE GROWING FOR FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND HIGH COST
COUNTIES OF THE STATE. AND THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL WOULD REDUCE
THE WAITING LED BY SABOTAGING A
HOUSING SUPPLEMENTS FOR THE T.
S. B. COCHRAN GRAHAM IN
COUNTIES WITH THE HIGHEST.
RENTAL CAR. OKAY BASED ON A
POWER A DOCK BY THE- IN TWENTY
TWENTY. AND IT WILL ENSURE THAT
ARE MOST AFFECTED HOUSING
PROGRAM FOR FORMER PROPERTIES
IS AVAILABLE WHEN AND WHERE YOU
NEED IT MOST. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM MIKE HERALD WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- PLEASE BE BACK WITH YOU
ONCE AGAIN- FIRST I JUST WANT
TO START BY SAYING THAT- I WANT
TO ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT AND TO SEND A
LINK FROM THE- COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS. OF JUST GAVE- I
THOUGHT MANY OF HER POINTS WERE
VERY WELL TAKEN AND I THINK
THERE. ARE SEVERAL THINGS THAT
WE COULD BE DOING AND- WHAT YOU
MIGHT DESCRIBE AS TECHNICAL
FIXES TO EXISTING PROGRAM.
THAT COULD ALLOW THEM TO WORK
BETTER AND SO I WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
REALLY GIVE SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION TO THOSE
PROPOSALS. ON MY NAME TESTIMONY
THOUGH ON THIS PANEL IS THAT. I
THINK THIS PAST YEAR HAS BEEN
THE MOST CHALLENGING THAT OUR
CLIENTS HAVE EVER EXPERIENCED-
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
PARTICULARLY BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES. HAVE SUFFERED BOTH
THE BULK OF THE JOB LOSSES AND
HAD THE HIGHEST INCIDENCE KOBE
CASES AND DEATHS. ON MANY LOW
INCOME WORKERS LOST THEIR JOBS.
AND MANY OF THESE JOBS MAY
NEVER COME BACK. AND OTHERS
LOST THEIR JOBS BECAUSE THEY
LOST THEIR CHILD CARE- SO IT'S
BEEN A REALLY DEVASTATING TIME
OTHER WORKERS HAVE HAD TO KEEP
WORKING AS A CENTRAL WORKERS.
EVEN AT THE RISK OF EXPOSING
THEMSELVES OR THEIR FAMILIESTO
COPE. SO I JUST WANT TO REMIND
THE COMMITTEE JUST ABOUT THE
EXTRAORDINARILY. STRESSFUL TIME
THAT. ON LOAN FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN THE- TWELVE MONTHS AND
PROBABLY WILL CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE GOING FORWARD- AS WE
KNOW MILLIONS OF FAMILIES LOST
INCOME FROM WORK AND FELL
BEHIND IN THEIR RENT AND FELL
BEHIND ANOTHER BILLS ALSO. ON
THE TRUTH AND YOU KNOW WHAT I
HEAR FROM CLIENTS IS THAT THEY
HAVE EXHAUSTED THEIR SAVINGS
THEY BORROWED FROM THEIR FAMILY
IF THEY COULD. MAYBE EVEN SOLD
THEIR BELONGINGS THANK YOU SIR
THERE'S BEEN A MAXED OUT THEIR
CREDIT CARDS. ALL WANTED HIM TO
MAKE ENDS MEET AND PAY SOME OF
THE RENT SO THE CAMPER ROF
OVER THEIR HEADS FOR THEIR
FAMILIES DURING THIS TIME.
CUMULATIVELY THE IMPACT OF CODE
HAS BEEN FINANCIAL DEVASTATION.
AND WE HAVE SEEN A PERIOD OF
WEALTH STRIPPING FROM POOR
CALIFORNIANS UNLIKE ANYTHING IN
RECENT MEMORY- AND I DON'T NEED
TO REMIND MOST OF YOU THAT. FOR
FAMILIES DIDN'T HAVE MUCH WILL
TO STRIP TO BEGIN WITH THEY
WERE ALREADY ASSET FOR. BUT THE
LITTLE THAT THEY HAVE IN MANY
CASES. IS NOW GONE. AND ALL OF
THIS LARGELY THROUGH NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN- AND WHILE INCOMES
DROP FOR MANY HOUSEHOLDS COST
OFTEN WERE NOT. THERE WERE
SHORTAGES OF ITEMS THAT CAUSE
PRICES TO SPIKE THEY- THE STATE
HOME ORDER MEANT THAT FAMILIES
HAD TO RELY ON DELIVERY
SERVICES TO GET CENTRAL ITEMS
ON SUCH AS FOOD CLOTHES AND
OTHER NECESSITIES- THIS MONTH
THE MONEY THAT FAMILIES HAVE.
IT'S NOT STRETCH AS FAR AS IT
USED TO AND MANY FAMILIES WERE
SO MANY CHILDREN ARE SUBJECT TO
SIGNIFICANT MATERIAL
DEPRIVATION AND TOXIC STRESS
DURING THIS TIME. SO. WE I
REALLY WOULD I THINK THIS IS
REALLY AN IMPORTANT POINT HERE
COM WE REALLY NEED TO USE THIS
MOMENT NOT JUST NOT TO JUST
HELP FAMILIES OUT OF THEIR
CURRENT TROUBLES AND GOD KNOWS
WE NEED TO DO THAT BUT WE NEED
TO. IMPORTANT PROPOSALS WHERE
WE COME OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC
WITH EVEN LESS POVERTY AND BAM
WE WENT INTO IT WITH. WE NEED
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OUR
TEMPORARY FEDERAL MONEY AND ARE
FORTUNATE ROBUST STATE
RESOURCES- AND REALLY TRY TO
GET MONEY INTO FAMILIES POCKETS
SO THEY CAN ADDRESS THEIR OWN
NEEDS. LITERALLY THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO
IS TO GET MONEY TO FAMILIES SO
THEY SO THEY CAN REBUILD THEIR
LIVES REBUILD THEIR CREDIT AND
ALLOW THEM TO ESTABLISH A LEAST
SOME SAVINGS SO THEY CAN
WITHSTAND THE CHALLENGES THAT
WHITE DELIVERS- SO HERE'S A FEW
THINGS SPECIFICALLY WE WOULD
RECOMMEND. ON THE LEGISLATURE
I'M SHOULD INCREASE COWART'S
UNNECESSARY GRANTS ON THE STATE
COMMITTED TO ENDING CHILDHOOD
DEEP POVERTY THREE YEARS AGO
BUT WE NEVER FINISHED THE JOB
WE SHOULD DO THAT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE HAVE ONE MORE
STEP TO GO TO GET EVERY CHILD
IN THE STATE ABOVE 50% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL IS
EXPLAINED EARLIER THAT'S NOT A
STANDARD THAT WE'RE
PARTICULARLY WHILE LOVE BUT IT
WOULD BE A REALLY IMPORTANT
STEP FOR. ON AS A SIGN WE NEED
TO RESTORE THE GRANT CUTS FROM
THE LAST RECESSION. JUST LET ME
SAY THAT AGAIN FROM THE LAST
RECESSION NOT THE CURRENT
RECESSION FOR MOBILE LAB MANY
YEARS AGO TWELVE YEARS AGO AND
HAVE STILL NOT BEEN RESTORED.
AND WHILE IT'S GREAT THAT WE
GOT SNAP BENEFITS TO RECIPIENTS
THEY CAN'T SPEND NOW ON PAYING
FOR THEIR HOUSING COSTS OR
OTHER UTILITIES. SO WE NEED TO
GET THOSE GRANTS BACK UP TO
WHERE THEY WERE AND BEYOND SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO PAY
THEIR BILLS. ON THERE TO CLEAN
OF ANY DIRECTOR JOB SITE I WAS
HAPPY TO HEAR HER REFERENCE THE
ISSUES ABOUT THE DECLINE IN THE
S. S. I. CASELOAD. BECAUSE WE
REALLY THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE ARE WE NEED TO
DO A BETTER JOB OF GETTING
PEOPLE INTO THE S. S. I.
CASELOAD. WE CAN DRAW DOWN
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON AND MOST
OF THIS IS BEING FRANKLY DRIVEN
BY A VERY HIGH FEDERAL DENIAL
RATE. THAT WE STILL SAW START
TO HAPPEN IN THE PREVIOUS
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION. THE
BEST THING WE CAN DO HERE
INSTANCE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED LEGAL ADVOCACY AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE APPLICATION
PROCESS AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE LEGAL ADVOCACY AVAILABLE
FOR RECIPIENTS ARE FOR
APPLICANTS EXCUSE ME. ALL
THROUGH THE PROCESS RIGHT
THROUGH AN APPEAL. WE CAN PUT
TOGETHER A PACKAGE OF ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THIS FIRST PURPOSE
THAT WOULD BE A VERY EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY AND- INCREASING SSI.
ON CASE LOADS. ON WE APPLAUD
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR PASSING THE
GOLDEN STATE STATEMENTS IN THE
GOLDEN STATE GRANT- IT WAS
REALLY SIGNIFICANT THAT WE
EXTENDED THESE PAYMENTS TO- TO
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS ON. A
PUBLIC BENEFIT PROGRAMS BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY IS AS MUCH AS WE
SUPPORT THE APC. YOUR FAMILIES
DON'T WORK DON'T HAVE INCOME
FROM WORK AND DON'T BENEFIT IF
WE ONLY PROVIDE BENEFITS TO THE
I. T. C. SO WE THINK THAT WAS A
REALLY GREAT STEP WE WOULD ALSO
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE- IF
WE DO ANOTHER GOLDEN STATE
STEMNESS WHICH MEANS. WHAT YOU
KNOW STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT-
THAT BE EXTENDED TO PERSONS ON
GENERAL SYSTEMS WHO ARE NOT.
INCLUDED IN THIS LOOP MOST
PREVIOUS FAME. IN THAT WE IN IN.
WHO DO HAVE TEN. NUMBER
PAYMENTS TO FOLKS DO ABOUT SEND
ARE FILE FEDERAL STATE BUT TO
THOSE WHO DON'T- BUT WE REALLY
THINK PROVIDE. THESE PAYMENTS
THESE GOLD SIX SEVEN PAYMENT
PERIODICALLY- WOULD REALLY GO A
LONG WAY TO HELPING THESE
FAMILIES RECOVER. AND WILL HELP
BOLSTER THE STATE'S ECONOMY SO
WE ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER APPROVING SEVERAL
ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS OF SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS OR MORE IN THE
COMING BUDGET YEAR- AND AS WE
KNOW EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
MANY FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING TO
PAY THE RENT. AND WE WILL
STRUGGLE AGAIN AFTER THE
ECONOMY IMPROVED YOU'VE HEARD
THE SAME FROM SEVERAL OF THE
OTHER SPEAKERS AND IT'S A FACT-
AND GIVEN THE RECENT FEDERAL
PANDEMIC ASSISTANCE OF THE
ROBUST STATE REVENUES AGAIN. WE
SHOULD FUND R A STATE FUNDED
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS ON
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE SHOULD BE THE
FIRST PRIORITY FOR THIS RENTAL
SYSTEMS. WE CAN EASILY IDENTIFY
THE HOUSEHOLDS WITH HIGH
HOUSING COSTS FOR EXISTING
PUBLIC BENEFIT PROGRAMS. AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH ENOUGH CASH
AID EACH MONTH TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE RENTS ARE AFFORDABLE
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
CONTINUALLY- PROVIDE EMERGENCY
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PAYMENTS
THAT ARE FAR MORE EXPENSIVE FOR
US TO DO. AND THEN FINALLY I'LL
CLOSE WITH THIS. SB NINETY ONE
IT WAS A MILESTONE BILL- WE
APPLAUD THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR FOR PASSING IT AND-
IT'S BEING IMPLEMENTED NOW
WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO SEE THE
OUTCOMES- AND IT'S GONNA SINCE
MANY FAMILIES AVOID EVICTION.
BUT WE NEED TO DO MORE TO HELP
RENTERS. IN PARTICULAR WE NEED
TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT TENANTS
DON'T FACE INFECTIONS IF THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY 25% OF THE
RENT. BY JUNE FIRST. NOW BAR
CAL WORKS PROGRAM HAS TO ON
PROVISIONS TO IT THAT CAN BE
EXTREMELY USEFUL HERE. ONE IS
CAO WORKS THE VERSION WHICH IS
A VALUABLE SOURCE TO HELP
WRITERS WHO ARE NOT ON CAL
WORKS BUT WHO NEED- ONE TIME
ASSISTANCE. TO BE ABLE TO PAY
THE RENT THAT THEY- BUT THE
PROGRAM CURRENTLY HAS SOME
LIMITATIONS TO PARTICULARLY A
CAP ON THE AMOUNT THAT CAN BE
PROVIDED. AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT RAISED. WE ALSO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO FAMILIES OF
HOW IT WORKS. ON YOUR- KNOWN TO
NON RECURRING NEEDS AN
EFFECTIVE RECENT PANDEMIC
FUNDING FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WOULD WOULD BE
USEFUL FOR THAT PURPOSE SO YOU
KNOW WE ALSO THINK IT WOULD BE
VERY USEFUL TO USE THOSE FUNDS
TO MAKE ONE TIME PAYMENTS TO
FAMILIES. BUT IN ANY CASE WE
NEED TO DO MORE TO MAKE
FAMILIES AWARE THAT THIS IS AN
OPTION. AND THAT WE- INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE APPLYING
FOR THESE FUNDS NOW SO THAT
WHEN JUNE COMES JUNE FIRST
ROLLS AROUND WE DON'T HAVE
FAMILIES GETTING EVICTED
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHERE
TO GO TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT
25% THAT THEY NEED TO PAY FOR
THE RENT. SO WITH THAT WILL
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THAT CONCLUDES
THIS PANEL I WILL NOW BRING IT
UP TO THE DICE TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY MEMBERS QUESTIONS AND-
I WILL BEGIN. I FIRST WANT TO-
I BEGIN WHERE THE L. A- STATED
THAT REQUEST FOR MORE DATA. I
WAS HOPING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
COULD COMMENT- REGARDING- HOW
WE CAN DEVELOP THIS DATA FOR
OUR ANTI POVERTY PROGRAMS TO
ASSIST. WITH PLANNING AND
RESPONSIVENESS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR KIM JOHNSON
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
SO WE AGREE THAT- WE BET WITH
THE START DATE IS NEEDED WE ARE
AT. GLAD TO BE PARTNERING WITH
THE BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES
HOUSING ON THE H. D. I. SISTER
H. D. I. S. SYSTEM. THAT WILL
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND GOING FORWARD-
RIGHT NOW IF WE WANT TO THE
DECISIONAL AREN'T SHOCKING
SYSTEMS RELATED TO DATA FOR.
THESE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THOSE
WOULD IT REQUIRE SOME
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES ACT CURRENTLY BEING
PROPOSED BACK. AGAIN WE WILL
HAVE SOME INFORMATION- THAT'S
ADDITIONAL. I DO WE CAN WE HAVE
TODAY IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
DIRECTORY OF THOSE WHO ARE
PATHWAY TO PERMANENT HOUSING.
IF I CAN THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
TIMES WE HEARD WHETER IT WAS
WITH EACH TAB FOR HSP OR WITH
HOME SAFE ABOUT THE NEED FOR US
TO HAVE LONGER TERM SUPPORT.
AND WAS HOPING TO GET THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE. IT I
WILL JUST START BY SAYING THAT-
IN ANY IN ANY PROGRAM AND AS WE
THINK ABOUT OUR EXPERIENCE HERE
TO THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE-
THE BROADER AT THE RATE THE
BRIGHTER THE ELIGIBILITY ARE AT
WE BELIEVE THAT THE IMPACT OF
THAT IS GOING TO BE THE GREATER
NEEDS THE TO THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE. RELATED TO WHERE AN
INDIVIDUAL IS EXPERIENCING- A
FICTION EXCEPT AROUND ITS BELT
THOSE TRADE OFFS ARE GOING TO
BE THAN RELATED TO THEIR
RESOURCES THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE. GRAMS ARE YEAH DETENTION
THERE WOULD BE THEN HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE BEING SERVED FOR A
LONGER DURATION SHOULD KNOW
WHETHER ADDITIONAL FUNDING- BE
INCLUDED SO THOSE ARE THE
TENSION POINTS ARE RT. THE WHAT
WE WOULD EXPECT TO SEE IF WE
WERE TO BOTH INCREASED DURATION
OR- A CHANGE BROAD KNOWLEDGE
ABILITY REQUIREMENTS- FINALLY I
WAS HOPING YOU COULD COMMENT ON
C. W. D. A.'S- RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING IMPROVEMENTS OF THE
H. S. P. PROGRAM. SPECIFICALLY
THEY NEED TO HAVE AN ACTUAL
OBJECTION NOTICE OR AGAIN THE
LONGER TERM SUBSIDIES JUST
HOPING YOU COULD COMMENT ON
THAT. SURE SUMMER LOOKS
SIMILARLY I WOULD SAY MY
RESPONSE IS THE SAME THAT AGAIN
IF WE WANT TO BROADEN RIGHT NOW
WE ARE AGAIN REALLY FOCUSED ON
ENSURING THAT- WE CAN PREVENT
THAT THAT ELECTION FOR THE
PERSON WHO'S IMMEDIATELY FACING
IT. IF WE WERE TO BROADEN
ELIGIBILITY AND NOT HAVE THAT
KIND OF REQUIREMENTS- THAT WE
WOULD LIKELY SEE ADDITIONAL
NEEDS- IN SUPPORT AND SO AGAIN
EITHER WE'RE GOING TO I ASKED
SERVE FEWER PEOPLE OR PEOPLE
LONGER- OR AT SERVE A DIFFERENT
POPULATION IT NEEDS THE RIGHT
NOW WE ARE PRIORITIZING THOSE
SECOND IMMINENT RISK ABDUCTION.
I THINK WE WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE- WOULD NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE DATA AND- FOR
GAP ANALYSIS BECAUSE IT SOUNDS
AS IF YOU'RE OPERATING UNDER
THE SAME RESOURCES AND- IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH NEED THERE
IS OUT THERE AND WHETHER OR NOT
OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS ARE BEING
RESOURCE APPROPRIATELY AND SO.
I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU HEAR US
ASKING SO MANY QUESTIONS- I
WOULD LIKE TO ELEVATE THE- JOHN
BURTON. ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE TRACKS
LOOKING AT TRANSITIONAL AGE
YOUTH AS THEY ARE PARTICULARLY
SUSCEPTIBLE TO HOMELESSNESS.
BUT I'D LIKE TO END MY
QUESTIONS TODAY IF I COULD WITH
THE- BUDGET BILL PROPOSAL. FOR
RCF FEES I'M- AND FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE TRACKED AT HOME
IT'S ON PAGE FIFTY EIGHT OF THE
AGENDA. AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
FIFTY EIGHT AND HAD STATED THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
FACILITIES THAT CURRENTLY ARE
NOT TAKING SSI RSS P.
RECIPIENTS. AND SINCE WE ARE.
GOING TO BE INVESTING TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND PUBLIC RESOURCES.
IS THERE A WAY FOR US TO HELP
THESE FACILITIES TO INCENTIVIZE
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
TAKEN CARE OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS AS WELL.
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
I THINK YES THAT'S PART OF PART
OF THE- INVESTMENTS IN THESE
FACILITIES WOULD BE AN
EXPECTATION. ADD TO SERVICE THE
POPULATION THAT WE ARE
PRIORITIZING AND SO THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY HOW WE INTEND FOR
THE PROGRAM TO WORK OUT. I
INVITE MY COLLEAGUES HERE CRIME
YOU CAN AND ASK TO JOIN TO ADD
ANY MORE TO THAT QUESTION. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO JUST ADD
THAT ON THE MECHANISM FOR DOING
SO. IS ENVISIONED TO BE THROUGH
USING USE RESTRICTIONS OR
COVENANTS THAT WOULD. REQUIRE
AN ENTITY THAT RECEIVED STATE
FUNDS TO COMMIT TO SERVING OUR
PRIORITY POPULATION- THAT OVER
THE LONG TERM TO MEET. THE
QUESTION THANK YOU AND WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
PANEL BUT BEFORE WE MOVE
FORWARD I WOULD AGAIN LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
REQUEST THAT ARE MADE WITHIN
THE AGENDA AT THE END OF ISSUE
THREE AT THE TOP OF PAGE SIXTY
ONE WHICH ARE FIRST US ASKING
THE DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE
OPTIONS AND AN ASSESSMENT OF
POSSIBLE PROGRAM EXPANSIONS FOR
ALL OF ITS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS SECOND TO
ASK THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROVIDE DRAFT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. RELATED TO ITS OUR
CFE PROPOSAL FOR CONSIDERATION
BY THE LEGISLATURE BY MID APRIL
AND THE LANGUAGE SHOULD LAY OUT
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE USE OF
FUNDS THE EXPECTED RESULTS AND
OTHER OUTCOME INFORMATION TO
TRACK THE PROGRESS AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS PROPOSED
INVESTMENT AND FINALLY WE ASK
FOR THE COMMITTED EFFORT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT TO COLLECT THAT
DATA ABOUT HOUSING INSECURITY
AND HOMELESSNESS IN OUR CASE
LOAD SO THAT. WE CAN HAVE THAT
INFORMATION CAN I ASK IF THERE
IS ANY FEEDBACK OR REACTION AT
THIS TIME FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TO THESE
REQUESTS. THANK YOU AT CHAIR
THE ONLY ONE I WOULD ASK FOR
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
COLLEAGUES TO SPEAK TO WOULD BE
THE REQUEST NUMBER TWO RELATED
TO THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE I
DO FOR THAT THAT ONE TO OUR-
COLLEAGUES THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. YES THANK YOU JUST
INCREASED MARTHA FINANCE- I
THINK WE'LL JUST REITERATE SOME
OF THE COMMENTS WERE MADE
EARLIER REGARDING PROPOSALS
THAT. AT THIS TIME THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES ANY
ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS HERE- SO
IT TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING AS SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HOUSING-
WANTS TO CEMENT A LINE OR SHARE
WITH US IS A LIST OF
PRIORITIES- WE CAN PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE- BUT IT. FOR
REQUESTING DRAFT LANGUAGE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO PROPOSED AT THIS
TIME IT MIGHT BE MORE
APPROPRIATE IF FIVE ALLEGE THE
BASS OFFICE MIGHT ASSIST
RESIDENTS OR OTHERS. WOULD BE
MY COMMENT ON THAT. HAVING A
HARD TIMES IT'S THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
SPEND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT THEY
WOULDN'T. WANT TO PUT OUT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD GO WITH THIS REQUEST AND
INSTEAD WOULD ASK THE L. A- TO
DO THAT SO. I'M HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP OFFLINE BUT IT WOULD SEEM
APPROPRIATE FOR. THE
ADMINISTRATION TO HELP US WITH
THIS TASK SINCE IT WAS YOUR
PROPOSAL. HOW DO YOU TAKE THAT
BACK AGAIN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL IS BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE BUT WE'LL TAKE THAT.
BACK FOR CONSIDERATION- BUT
AGAIN- HAPPY TO CONTINUE
LOOKING AND WORKING ON
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS NEEDED-
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK
VERY MUCH PANEL THREE WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON THE PANEL FOR ON
EQUITY DRIVEN CARE FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. SERVED BY THE
CHILD WELFARE AND FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. WE WILL HAVE NINE
PANELISTS FOR ISSUE FOR WHICH
WILL BEGIN WITH KIM JOHNSON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. DIRECTOR
JOHNSON CAN YOU PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU CHAIR ARAMBULA AND
MEMBERS CAN JOHNSON CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AT THE QUESTION. AB CLOSED IN
THE AGENDA IS RELATED TO THE
TRENDS AND THOUGHTS WE'VE SEEN.
IN TERMS OF CHILD WELFARE
REFERRALS DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND AS MANY OF THE PANELISTS AT
SO FAR. HAVE STATED THE
TREMENDOUS A CHALLENGING BURDEN
THAT- USE. OUR FAMILIES HAVE
FACED- IS ABSOLUTELY
SIGNIFICANT SO APPS ONE OF THE
FACT THAT- AS IT WAS
SPECIFICALLY RELATES TO CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES WE DID- SEE A
PRETTY IMMEDIATE. THE CLIENT
AND THE NUMBER OF REFERRALS
THAT WERE RECEIVED TO THE CHILD
WELFARE HOTLINE. IN MARCH ABOUT
THIS TIME LAST YEAR MARCH APRIL
OF LAST YEAR IT WAS DOWN FORTY
PERCENT- AND- WHAT WE ATTRIBUTE
THAT TO IS THE CLOSURE OF
SCHOOLS WE S. SIMILARLY SAW A
DECLINE IN. THE NUMBER OF
TEACHERS WHO WERE REFERRING USE
AND SO- WHILE WE AND IN THE
RECENT MONTHS WE HAVE SEEN-
THAT THAT REFERRAL NUMBERS
COMING BACK CLOSER TO PRE
PANDEMIC RATES. BUT THEY REMAIN
APPROXIMATELY 20% LOWER THAN
THEY WERE LAST YEAR. IN TERMS
AGAIN THEN OF WHO IS REPORTING
MORE SECOND I'M A MENTION THAT
TEACHERS. HAVE ALSO HAD A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN
REPORTING. WE HAVE SEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS THE PRIMARY- ARE
MANDATED REPORTER OF THESE
REFERRALS WITH AGAIN. AT
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN THAT
SPACE ONE OF BACK- TOOLS AND WE
WORKED OUT WITH THE PARTS
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON THIS
TOOL WAS TO PROVIDE. TEACHERS
EDUCATORS SOME ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTS. TIPS RESOURCES ON.
WAYS THEY COULD POTENTIALLY
SUPPORT THE CHILDREN BUT ALSO
SEE. AN RECOGNIZE DIFFERENCES
SIGNS I INTERVIEW LOOKING BACK
HAVE A THAT HOW DO A- HOW
THEY'RE IN. REALLY WHEN THEY
WORRIED ABOUT STUDENT. WHO MADE
EITHER IS PARTICIPATING M. OR-
OTHER THINGS THAT THEY COULD
LOOK FOR AB ACCENT RESOURCE
THAT WE HAVE AGAIN PARTNERED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
ACT TO RELEASE. WE OBVIOUSLY-
HAVE CONTINUED TO WORK WITH A
NUMBER OF PARTNERS ON-
IMPROVING THAT THE EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES OF FOSTER YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS A
PREPLANNED DIMMICK. AT
CHALLENGE- THAT WE WERE WORKING
TO ADDRESS OF COURSE I WITH THE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES LIKE THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
WHICH IS PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCE INTO DISTRICTS I WOULD
HIRE A PERCENTAGE OF THE
POPULATION. BUT CERTAINLY WE
KNOW AS WE ARE CONCERNED WITH
MANY OF OUR OUR STUDENTS THIS
POPULATION OF YOUTH WE ARE
GOING TO NEED TO FULLY WRAP
AROUND AND SUPPORT- AS WE
RECOVER FROM THIS EFFORT AND
SO- I THINK IT'S A PLACE WHERE
WE WANT TO BE REALLY FOCUSED
OUT CERTAINLY WE HAVE SEEN. AN
INCREASE ABSENTEEISM- AND SOME
OTHER CHALLENGES THAT THE YOU
HAVE EXPERIENCE SO I ALSO WOULD
NOTE THAT WE- WANT TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT OUR OF COURSE NOT
ONLY RECOGNIZING THE SIGNS OF
ABUSE BUT ALSO THE PREVENTION
SO MUCH OF THE CONVERSATION
WE'VE BEEN HAVING. AN EARLIER
PANELS AGAIN I'LL MENTION THAT
THEY CAO WORKS AT HOME
VISITING. PROGRAM AS AN EXAMPLE
OF WHERE WE AND OUR FAMILIES
ARE DEALING WITH SUCH STRESSORS
WHERE ARE THE TOUCH POINTS FOR
RELATIONSHIPS THE CONNECTIONS
THAT THEY CAN HAVE IN
COMMUNITIES TO SEEK HELP WE DID
RESOURCE AND NUMBER OF
INVESTMENTS EARLY ON AGAIN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN SUPPORT SO THESE
ARE. OUR RESOURCES FOR THE CARE
GIVERS THE RESOURCE FAMILY
HOMES- WE PROVIDED SOME
ADDITIONAL CASH IN IN SUPPORT
WE HAD ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS AND
COMMUNITIES TO BE ANOTHER GOOD
AT. BAT. PARTNER I WITH THEM
LEASING GET- IN THE THAT NEED.
AT AT CARE OF AND THEN OF A AND
EMERGENCY. FOR CALPERS OUT HOT
WHY. FOR THOSE WHO WORKS. STE
I'M OF COURSE- SOME ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTS FOR THOSE AT
TRADITIONAL AG WHO WOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE AGED OUT OF FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. I'M IN CEMEX AND
SOME ADDITIONAL STRATEGIES TO
AGAIN PROVIDE THE IMMEDIATE
NEED WE'VE HAD A NUMBER AND I
AM PRIVILEGED. I DO HAVE A
NUMBER OF PLACES AND SPACES TO
TALK WITH RESOURCE FAMILIES TO
TALK WITH YOU. ABOUT THEIR
NEEDS AND AGAIN I WOULD JUST
SAY THIS IS A PLACE WHERE WILL
HAVE CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN
SUPPORT WE DO HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS.
RECENTLY RECEIVED IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WE ARE WORKING ON RIGHT
NOW CHEEKY IS ONE OF THOSE
PLANS SOURCES THAT WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN ADD TO PLAY
VERY QUICKLY TO GET. NEEDS MET
IMMEDIATELY FOR FOSTER YOUTH SO
AGAIN IN TERMS OF THE SCHOOL AT
SPACE AND THE REFERRAL SPACE AS
CERTAINLY THOSE CHANGES. THAT
WERE EXPERIENCED AND WE WILL BE
FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING OUR USE
AS BOTH SCHOOLS RE OPENED AND
OUT WE SEE. ADDITIONAL NEED A
RESOURCE FAMILIES. THANK
DIRECTOR WE WE'LL HEAR FROM
GROW ROWE THIS. DIRECTOR OF
EQUITY AND INCLUSION FOR THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU CHAIR OF
MEMBERS GREG ROSE AGAIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT- YOU'VE ASKED ME
TO SPEAK TO A TO A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS- IT- IN THE AGENDA
ALL DO ALL OBVIOUSLY DO THAT AT
A FAIRLY. HIGH LEVEL BUT IT
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT- WE REMAIN
AVAILABLE TO YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE L.
A. O. I TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE AND- DEEPER-
OUTSIDE OF THAT THE HEARING.
FIRST QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED
IT HAD TO DO WITH- SOME OF THE
RESOURCES THAT- THAT DIRECTOR
JOHNSON SPOKE TO JUST A MINUTE
AGO WITH RESPECT TO- SOME
FINDING. THAT THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE IN THE IN THE SPRING OF
LAST YEAR AND THE QUESTION WAS
BY OUR COUNTY IS CONTINUING TO
USE GINGER SOME OF THOSE
ACTIVITIES. AND WHEN I WOULD
JUST NO ONE IS THAT THESE WERE
LARGELY AFTER TIME CONSIDERED
YOU KNOW KIND OF ONE TIME
ALTHOUGH THE MANY OF THEM ARE
ARE PROPOSED AGAIN FOR THAT.
BUDGET YEAR AT. THE BUDGET
YOU'RE AS AS A DIRECTOR JOHNSON
MENTIONED- BUT THEY WERE
LARGELY- SHORT TERM KIND. AND
DEPARTMENTS MANAGED THE- IT
MINISTER MOST OF THESE
PROGRAMS- WE HAVE A LONG SIDE
WITH OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES WHO.
PROVIDED A NUMBER OF- SUPPORTED
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO CASE WORK
AND TO US ASSISTING. FAMILIES
TO ACTUALLY- BENEFIT FROM SOME
OF THESE SOME OF THESE
INVESTMENTS. WE STATED THAT
DECK DECK THE COUNTIES ARE
CONTINUING TO- TO DO THE CASE
WERE RESPONSIBILITIES- THAT
THAT THEY'VE HAD AND THEY ARE-
ALSO IT. IN THE CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE- LINKAGES AT CHIU
EXISTING RESOURCES NEW ONES
THAT HAVE POPPED UP RELATED TO
THE PANDEMIC AND OTHERS FROM
FEDERAL FUNDING- AND IF THEY
CONTINUE TO FIGHT TO FIGHT TO
PROVIDE A NUMBER OF RESOURCES
INCLUDING- YOU KNOW CASE WORK
RESOURCES. TO THE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO WHAT OR WHO WOULD OR
OTHERWISE AGE OUT OF OUR
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
THE NEXT QUESTION YOU ASK
REALLY HAS SPEAKS TO AN UPDATE
ON OUR CONTINUING CARE REFORM
AND SPECIFICALLY AROUND THAT
CHALLENGE. ADOLESCENT NEEDS
ASSESSMENT THAT TRAVELING DOWN
THE TEAMS AND THE LEVEL OF CARE.
A PROTOCOL THAT WE PUT IN PLACE
WE JUST NOTE HERE ALSO THAT A
GREAT NOT MUCH OF THE DETAIL-
INCLUDING SOME FAIRLY SOME
TRENDS AND DETAILS STATISTICS
ARE IN OUR- R. C. C. R.
OVERSIGHT REPORT THAT WE
PUBLISHED. OUR REGULARLY AND
THAT WE MEET WITH LEGISLATIVE
STAFF ON ON- WITH WITH SOME
FREQUENCY THE MOST RECENT
REPORT SHOULD BE READ- IT
SHOULD BE- PUBLISHED IN THE IN
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS- SO THAT
MUCH OF THE DETAILS- WE CAN DIG
INTO WITH THAT REPORT COMES OUT
SH THAT'S IN THE HEADLINES
REALLY FOR- FOR CFT AND CABINS
ARE. THAT. YOU KNOW AS THE AS
THE AS THE- AS THE QUESTION
SUGGESTS THESE ARE FUNDED. TO
THE SEC ARE- REFORM EFFORTS AND
THEY ARE FOUNDATIONAL TO THE
OUTCOMES THAT- AND SCHEDULES
FOR PRACTITIONERS OF CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES. WITH THAT
SAID- I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
AT THE END OF AUGUST. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY WE HAD A TOTAL
OF FORTY NINE COUNTIES THAT HAD
OPTED INTO- USING THE AUTOMATED
PLATFORM THAT WE CREATED TO. TO
GATHER I THE CARE IS
INFORMATION THAT ARE I'M SORRY
THE CANS INFORMATION THAT'S THE
THAT THE CHILD AND ADOLESCENCE
NEEDS AND STRENGTHS ASSESSMENT
ON THE OTHER LINE COUNTIES ARE
EITHER LARGELY RELYING ON THEIR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARTNERS
WHICH WILL SPEAK ABOUT IN JUST
A MOMENT OR- HAVE. HAVE AN
ALTERNATIVE. TO GATHER THE DATA.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ALL COUNTIES TO IT TOO- MAKE
CARES LIVE AVAILABLE TO THEM. I
SHOULD NOTE THAT. DURING THAT
pTHERE WAS A THERE WAS EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN CANCER ASSESSMENTS AND
AT PRESENT THERE ARE ABOUT
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED A LITTLE
OVER TWENTY SIX HUNDRED IN
PROCESS AND SO- FOR A TOTAL
SINCE THE ACCOUNT WAS
IMPLEMENTED OUT OF NEARLY.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
ASSESSMENTS BY A CHILD WELFARE-
WORKFORCE HERE'S A SIMILAR
NUMBER A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER
THAT WAS AT THAT HAVE BEEN.
CONDUCTED BY HEARTBEAT BY THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
WORKFORCE EITHER THAT THE
COUNTIES THEMSELVES OR THEIR
CONTRACTORS AND THE AND THE
APARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT. OF
SOCIAL SERVICES CAN WORK
TOGETHER ARE WORKING TOGETHER
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
ASSESSMENTS ARE AVAILABLE TO
BOTH WORKFORCE IS TO BOTH- THAT
CHILD WELFARE AND THE CLINICAL
WORK FORCE- NO MATTER WHO I DID
THE ASSESSMENT AND SO- THAT
WORK IS. STILL ONGOING- AND THE
TRENDS FOR CANCER
ADMINISTRATION ARE- ARE ARE.
INCREASING SIGNIFICANTLY- ON.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD NOTE AS
A AS A TRANSITION TO TALK ABOUT
THE LOOK AT THE LEVEL OF CARE
ASSESSMENT PROTOCOL IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT. IS WORKING. ON IT-
IT. IN PARTNERING WITH SOME
COUNTY ON A TO SEE OF TOOL
USING- AND- LARGELY ADVOCATES
SEEM TO BE- VERY- SUPPORT OF
THIS KIND OF TESTING ALL SPEAK
TO A LITTLE BIT OF THAT- IN THE
MOMENTS TO COMMENT. WITH
RESPECT TO THE LEVEL OF CARE-
PROTOCOL- SHOULD ALWAYS JUST
NOTE THAT WE HAVE A- LOT OF THE
LEVEL OF CARE PROTOCOL AS PART
OF OUR INTERIM RATES- PROCESS
AND AS SUCH- WE ARE WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED IN PHASES IN THE
CURRENT PHASE IS. TO GO TO
FINISH GOING COMPLETELY
STATEWIDE- BEGINNING APRIL
FIRST OF THIS YEAR- THAT WILL
ALLOW. ALL FAMILIES NO MATTER
WHETHER WHETHER THEY'RE SERVE
THEIR THEIR- CERTIFIED AND
APPROVED FROM A FROM A MONSTER
FAMILY AGENCY WHETHER THEIR
RELATIVE CAREGIVERS OR WHETHER
THEY'VE BEEN APPROVED THROUGH
OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES. TO TO
BENEFIT FROM. THE LEVEL OF CARE
PROTOCOL. WE MASON SHE TO THE
PROTOCOL- AB DURING THAT THE
THAT KOBE TIME PERIOD. MANY OF
THEM HAVE BEEN HAVE BEEN AND-
SUGGESTED- BY OUR ADVOCATE-
COLLEAGUES AND SOME ARE RELATED
DIRECTLY TO THAT- ISSUES THAT
FAMILIES AND CAREGIVERS AND
YOUNG PEOPLE FACE RELATIVE TO A
DISTANCE LEARNING THE LACK OF
SOME SOCIAL RECREATIONAL
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY PREVIOUSLY
TAKEN INTO. SO THE CURRENT.
ITERATION OF THE LOCAL THE
LEVEL OF CARE PROTOCOL- WILL-
CONTINUE TO GO LIVE UP. IN THE
NEXT IS IT NEXT MONTH WE'RE
STILL FINISHING UP TO SOME
TRAINING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WITHOUT WITH- MORE ON THAT IN
OUR SUBSEQUENT CONVERSATIONS
WITH LEGISLATIVE STAFF. SHOULD
NOTE THAT WE HAVE WITH RESPECT
TO THE INTERIM NATURE ABOUT THE
DEATH OF THE LOW LEVEL OF CARE
PROTOCOL SH WE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT USING THE
INFORMATION THAT COMES FROM THE
KANSAS ASK MET. THROUGH A
DECISION SUPPORT TOOL AND
LOOKING AT ITS VIABILITY
RELATIVE TO- INFLUENCING. THAT
THE RATE SETTING PROCESS AND SO
ON WE WILL BE WORKING WITH NINE
COUNTIES INCLUDING LOS ANGELES
TO TEST OUT OF THAT THAT THE-
ALGORITHM THE PROCESS. OVER THE
NEXT SIX TO NINE MONTHS. NEXT
QUESTION YOU ASKED SPECIFICALLY
HAS TO DO WITH THAT THE FAMILY
FIRST PRESERVATION SERVICES ACT
OFTEN KNOWN AS ACTIVE PSA-
ESPECIALLY WITH RESPECT TO THE
PREVENTION SERVICES AND- SOME
OF THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
WE JUST HIGHLIGHTED. FOR FOLKS
WHO MAY NOT BE. STEVE DID AS AS
MANY ARE THE FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT WHEN IT
SPEAKS OF PREVENTION IT'S
SPEAKING OF PREVENTION INTO
FOSTER CARE AND ARE USING A
CRITERIA OF CANDIDACY SO THAT
IT IN OTHER WORDS THAT- THIS
THIS AND THIS. FEDERAL ACT IN
THE FUNDS ASSOCIATED WITH ART
ARMED RELATIVELY NARROWLY
FOCUSED ON AVOIDING YOUNG
PEOPLE COMING INTO FOSTER CARE
WITH- AND IF THE SYSTEM IF THE
IF THERE ISN'T A PARTICULAR
INTERVENTION THAT THEY WOULD
END UP IN FOSTER CARE- IT-
EMINENTLY. AND SO I JUST WHEN I
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
AS WE THINK ABOUT ALL OF THE
PREVENTION WORK AND THOUGHT
STATE THAT WE HAVE THAT
COUNTIES HAVE THAT STATE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE THE NIGHT OF
THE LEGISLATURE SHARES AND-
ACTUALLY. MOVING THE SYSTEM-
MOVING OUR RESOURCES. FARTHER
UPSTREAM. THE AND PSA- DOES IT
IS A VERY NARROW SLICE OF THAT
AND AS IT IS IT'S AN OPTIONAL
PROGRAM THAT. STATES CAN OPT IN
OPT INTO WITHOUT SETTING UP THE
INTENTION OF THE- OF THE
TRAILER BILL IS REALLY TO- READ
IS TO LOOK FOCUSED ON THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS AROUND
USING EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTIONS. AND ACT AND TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF THE STATE
TO DO EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTIONS AT THE AS
DETERMINED BY. THE CLEARING
HOUSE THE FEDERAL CLEARING
HOUSE SIMILARLY IT'S AND- IT'S
THAT THAT THE TRAILER BILL-
PUTS FORTH AT THE NOTION THAT
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO. LEVERAGE
AND BRAID EXISTING- AND OTHER
FUNDING ALONGSIDE WITH THESE
NEW FEDERAL RESOURCES ALSO SO
FUNDING- FOR EXAMPLE LIKE
PROMOTING SAFE AND STABLE
FAMILIES THAT COMMUNITY BASED
CHILD ABUSE. PREVENTION ACT OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
LOCAL LOCAL REVENUE FUNDS AT
CETERA SH BUT IN ESSENCE. THE
DEED THESE FUNDS WOULD BE. IN
TANDEM WITH FUNDS TO SERVE THE
WORK. I WOULD SAY ALSO JUST TO
THE TRAILER BILL ALSO SPEAKS TO
THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENT THAT
THAT THAT THAT THE START OFF BY
TITLE FORTY FUNDS ARE THE PAYER
OF LAST RESORT. AND THEREFORE
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
WORK- SIGNIFICANTLY WITH THAT
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THERE'S A MECHANISM IN
PLACE TO IDENTIFY- WHERE- SOME
OF THESE- WHERE WHERE MEDICAID
MEDIC CAL MIGHT BE. ALREADY THE
FUNDING SOURCE FOR SOME OF
THESE SERVICES. WELL THE
GENERAL FUND IS AND IS INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL- WE CAN WE MUST WORK
WITH THE COUNTY AND WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS IN IN ESTABLISHING
A PLAN THAT MAKES SENSE FOR
CALIFORNIA AND THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- GENERAL. THE NEXT
QUESTION YOU HAD WAS
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT OUR PROCESS
RELATED TO- MODIFYING AND- THE
TRAILER BILL AS IT FROM ITS
OPEN FROM ITS ORIGINAL.
ITERATION IF YOU SH AND I SAY
THAT JUST KNOW THAT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT DURING THE DURING
THE BUDGET PROCESS THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE. AN INTERNSHIP
PROCESS WITH- STAKEHOLDERS TO-
TO REFINE THE LANGUAGE AS WE GO
FORWARD AND TO THAT END UP
WITH- WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS AND IN THE ATTIC
AND RESULT IN THE MOST RECENT
CONVERSATION. ENDED WITH US
HAVING ASKING STAKEHOLDERS A
BROAD BASE OF STAKEHOLDERS TO
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION. AND
WE S- WITH. RELATED TO THIS
TRAILER BILL AND THAT
INFORMATION CAME IN THIS WEEK
WE ARE PROCESSING IT AND WE'RE
DEVELOPING AN OUTWARDLY FACING-
WEBSITE- THAT WILL INCLUDE-
TIMELINES AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ADDITIONAL ENGAGE. FINALLY THE
LAST QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED ME
TO SPEAK TO WAS- PRESSING NEEDS
IT FOR USE IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM RELATED TO CO TWO CODED
A SPECIFICALLY AND WITH SOME
QUESTIONS AROUND- EMERGENCY
PLACEMENTS. IT'S CENTER OUT. I
SAY THAT- A DIRECTOR JOHNSON OR
TALKED ABOUT MANY OF THESE
THINGS MANY OF THOSE ISSUES-
EARLIER BUT I WOULD SAY WITH
WITH RESPECT SPECIFICALLY WITH
RESPECT TO EMERGENCY PLACEMENTS
THE DEPARTMENT THROUGH ITS
LICENSING ARM AND THROUGH THAT
DARK CHOCOLATE COUNTY SERVICES
DIVISION WORK WITH A NUMBER OF
COUNTIES TO- ADD BASED ON SOME
FLEXIBILITY IS AT WORK- UP THE
PROVIDED IN AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
TO. TO QUICKLY LICENSE-
ALTERNATIVES AND DICK AND
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES FOR- SOME
COUNTIES THAT WERE HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY THE RIGHT MICROBIT-
AND WE WERE IN HIS HAND IN HAND
RECOUNT PLEASE ON THAT CLEARLY-
REGENCY RESOURCES PLACE
RESOURCES WERE IN AND YOU KNOW
UNLIMITED SUPPLY PRIOR TO COLD
AND THE AND THE PANDEMIC
EXACERBATES EXACERBATE AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH WITH
INDIVIDUAL COUNTY SANTA
ASSOCIATION TO TRY TO. MEET THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF ANY COUNTIES-
AS THEY BROUGHT. THEM UP WITH.
WE ALSO JUST SAY THAT KNOW THE-
THE THANK YOUNG IT. HOW HOW HOW
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE NEEDS OF
pAND RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES AND
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE YOUNG
ADULTS WHO HAVE AGED OUT OF
FOSTER CARE- ALL CONTINUE TO
REQUIRE LINKAGES FINANCIAL
SUPPORT AND LINKAGES TO
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES NOW SOME
OF OUR PROPOSALS AND IN THE
PROJECT. LASTLY I'D SAY OUR
SECOND TO LAST I'D SAY THAT WE
HAVE SOME OF THE WAY WE KNOW
THAT WHAT WHAT YOUNG PEOPLE
NEED TO SECURE SURVEYS OF CARE
GIVERS AND WE HAVE DONE SOME
SURVEYS OF CARE GIVERS ON
LARGELY WHAT WHAT DATE THEY
TELL US THEY NEED IS- IS. OUR
DAY CARE. AT THE PRETTY OF DAY
CARE RESPITE SO SIMPSON AB
BECAUSE OF THAT THAT THAT THAT
THAT THAT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES OUT. OF HOME
SCHOOLING- DOING- SUPPORTING A
TELE THERAPIES OF MANY KINDS
AND- AND NOT HAVING SOME OF THE
RESOURCES THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN AVAILABLE ON
CAMPUSES AND IN COMMUNITIES AND
SO. DAY CARE CHIU DURING-
DIFFERENT KINDS OF SOCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL. PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN HIGHLIGHTED. THE
FINAL THING I LIKE TO KNOW IS
THAT- COUNTY TO TEND TO SAY
THAT THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM- BUT TO THE FACT- AND
WAS IMPLEMENTED. ON THAT A TWO
WEEKS AGO ON MARCH FIRST AND
EVEN IN THIS RELATIVELY SHORT
TIME OF TWO WEEKS WE HAVE. GOT
A NUMBER OF SUCCESSES A HANDFUL
OF SUCCESSES I THINK IT'S FAIR
TO SAY IN TERMS OF CARE GIVERS
IN YOUNG PEOPLE'S NOTING THAT
WITHOUT THAT- THAT- THE
STABILITY OF THEIR OF THE
PLACEMENT MIGHT HAVE BEEN IN
JEOPARDY AND SO. ON WE'RE HAPPY
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT PROGRAM
COME UP AND STILL THIS NATION
IS REALLY IMPORTANT. TIME
WITHOUT- ALL ALL PAS. AND OUR
TECHNICIANS ARE AT THE END OF
THE CAPITAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NO. WE'LL HEAR FROM AND-
SHORT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ANALYSTS ARE
AT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- ASSOCIATE IN YOUR
AGENDA THE FIRST QUESTION WE'VE
BEEN ASKED TO RESPOND TO TODAY
IS TO IDENTIFY THE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE PROPOSALS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ON FUNDED FOR CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- BUT THAT
WERE INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL. I'M YOU HEARD
DIRECTOR JOHNSON AND ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR ROSE- TOUCH ON SOME OF
THESE- JUST TO RECAP IN APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY THE
ADMINISTRATION PUT IN PLACE A
NUMBER OF PANDEMIC RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES WITH THE CHILD
WELFARE. THROUGH EXECUTIVE
ORDER. AND THE LEGISLATURE-
SUBSEQUENTLY APPROVED THOSE
ACTIVITIES THROUGH THE SECTION
THIRTY SIX LETTER PROCESS- OF
THE TABLE ON PAGE SEVENTY ONE
OF YOUR AGENDA. JUST TO RECAP
QUICKLY THEY INCLUDE CASH CARDS
FOR FAMILIES AT RISK OF
ENTERING FOSTER CARE FUNDING
FOR FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS.
STATE CONTRACTS FOR LAPTOPS AND
CELL PHONES AS WELL AS SUPPORT
HOTLINES FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND
FAMILIES- UP FOSTER PAYMENT
RATE FLEXIBILITY IS FOR
RESOURCE FAMILIES IMPACTED
DIRECTLY BY CORBETT. GROUP WHO
WILL FUNDING FOR EMERGENCY CARE
GIVERS MY BEST A RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL APPLICATION
PENDING BEYOND ONE YEAR. AND
FINALLY FLEXIBILITY AS
EXPANSIONS FOR NON MINOR
DEPENDENTS AND FORMER NINE NINE
MINOR DEPENDENTS. WHO WOULD
HAVE AGED OUT OR OTHERWISE LOST
ELIGIBILITY. FOR EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE BENEFITS. WITH THE
X. OF THAT LAST ITEM FOR NON
MINOR DEPENDENTS ALL OF THE
DIRECT PAYMENTS TO FAMILIES
THAT WERE THAT WERE IN PLACE
ONLY FROM APRIL THROUGH JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AND THEN RATE
FLEXIBILITY AS WORK SENATOR
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY BUT IN
OTHER WORDS ASIDE FROM THE
FUNDING FOR NON MINOR
DEPENDENCE. ALL OF THE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES INVOLVING
DIRECT PAYMENTS TO FAMILIES
ENDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
CALENDAR YEAR. BUT NOW AS PART
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL AFTER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED TO
RE LAUNCH- THOSE SUPPORTS
WITHIN THE CURRENT YEAR
SPECIFICALLY FROM JANUARY
THROUGH JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
WE WOULD NOTE HOWEVER TO THE
BEST OF OUR UNDERSTANDING THE
ADMINISTRATION- IS STILL
WORKING TO IDENTIFY A FUNDING
MECHANISM. TO BE ABLE TO
AUTHORIZE THOSE ACTIVITIES- IN
THE CURRENT YEAR AND AT THIS
POINT THEY ARE NOT TAKING PLACE.
WE'RE GOING ON- THE SECOND
POINT WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO
ADDRESS- IS TO DESCRIBE ISSUES
WE RAISED AROUND SUPPORT FOR
RESOURCE FAMILIES AND TEST YOUR
TPS DURING THE PANDEMIC. IN A
RECENT ANALYSIS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CHILD WELFARE
BUDGET PROPOSALS. WE RAISED THE
POINT THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WISH TO CONSIDER ADDITIONAL OR
ALTERNATIVE PANDEMIC SUPPORTS
WITHIN CHILD WELFARE. A
SPECIFICALLY THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO PROVIDE TEMPORARY
DIRECT SUPPORT FOR RESOURCE
FAMILIES AND S. T. R. T. P.'S
THROUGH MONTHLY RATE
SUPPLEMENTS. SUCH SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS ARE PROCESSED
CAREGIVERS AND PROVIDERS WITH
THE HIGHER COSTS OF PROVIDING
FOSTER CARE DURING THE PANDEMIC
OF FOR EXAMPLE FOR FOOD
UTILITIES- AND CHILD CARE. AND
REALLY JUST HELP OF PROVIDERS
AND FAMILIES MITIGATE ANY OTHER
ADVERSE ECONOMIC IMPACTS. THEY
MAY BE FACING DURING THE
PANDEMIC. BOTH RESOURCE AND AS
YOUR T. PROVIDE ESSENTIAL CARE
FOR OUR STATE'S FOSTER YOUTH
AND ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO MANAGE
INCREASED COSTS IN LIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC- COULD HELP THE STATE
RETAINED AS THE CENTRAL SUPPLY
OF CARE GIVERS. THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO ONGOING
IMPLEMENTATION OF CCR. AND THEN
FINALLY THE THIRD QUESTION
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO ADDRESS IS
PROVIDER ASSESSMENTS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OF PSA TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. IN RSS MANDAEAN
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO IMPLEMENT THE
REQUIRED TO PROVISIONS OF FF
PSA WHICH AGAIN IS THE FEDERAL
FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICES ACT- TO THE BEST OF
OUR UNDERSTANDING THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE ALIGNS WITH THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS THAT OUR
STATE MUST MEET. BY OCTOBER
FIRST OF THIS YEAR IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE RECEIVING FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR CONGREGATE CARE
PLACEMENTS. THAT SAID WE DO A
NUMBER OF MORE TECHNICAL
IMPLEMENTATION QUESTIONS ABOUT
SPECIFIC COMPONENTS OF THE
PROPOSAL I WISH WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS- TO MORE FULLY
UNDERSTAND. IN ADDITION WE HAVE
SOME HIGHER LEVEL POLICY
QUESTIONS. NAMELY REGARDING
ACTIVITIES AIMED AT PREVENTING
ENTRY INTO FOSTER CARE WHICH
UNDER F. PSA WILL BECOME NEWLY
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL TITLE
FORTY FUNDING- WE NOTE THAT-
AND AS THE ADMINISTRATION
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY ON THIS
PANEL. CURRENTLY THE PROPOSAL
IS THAT COUNTIES COULD
IMPLEMENT PREVENTION SERVICES
AT THEIR OPTION- BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT PROPOSE
ANY GENERAL FUND RESOURCES FOR
THIS PURPOSE. OFFER US
IMPLEMENTING PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES AS A COUNTY OPTION-
RAISES SOME EQUITY CONCERNS
NAME ALLEVIATE SOME COUNTY IS-
MAY NOT IMPLEMENT ANY OPTIONAL
ACTIVITIES DUE TO LOCAL BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS OR JUST DIFFERENT
LOCAL PRIORITIES. AND AS A
RESULT FAMILIES IN DIFFERENT
COUNTIES WOULD THEN BE
RECEIVING DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
SERVICE AND SOME CHILDREN MAY
NOT RECEIVE THE BENEFITS- THE
INTENDED BENEFITS OF PREVENTION
SERVICES AND THEREFORE COULD BE
MORE LIKELY TO ENTER INTO
FOSTER CARE. US SO TO CONCLUDE
IN LIGHT OF THE NUMBER OF
OUTSTANDING TECHNICAL AND JUST
FROM A POLICY QUESTIONS THAT WE
HAVE- ALONG WITH QUESTIONS
WHICH I BELIEVE YOU'LL BE
HEARING MORE ABOUT FROM OTHERS
SPEAKERS ON THIS PANEL
REGARDING F. OF PSA. WE THINK
THAT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
ON PAGE SEVENTY SIX OF YOUR
AGENDA. TO CONVENE A WORKING
GROUP- TO HELP INFORM UPDATED
AT THE FEET OF PSA TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE MAKES SENSE AND WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S- EXPRESSED
OPENNESS TO WORKING WITH US AND
STAKEHOLDERS JUNE TWO AMENDS
THIS LANGUAGE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
JUSTIN FREE TOSS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES
DOESN'T REDUCE THE PROMINENT%
FINANCE- GO AHEAD AND START
ADDRESSING THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE. REQUESTED FOR FINANCE
RESPONSE ON PAGE SIXTY THREE. I
THINK- M. MY COUNT MY COLLEAGUE
OVER THE L. A. O. PROVIDED A-
BASICALLY MY RESPONSE TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU FOR QUESTION
ONE REGARDING. THE CURRENT YEAR
FUNDING AUGMENTATION PROPOSED
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WERE SO
THE PROCESS OF IDENTIFYING A
FUNDING MECHANISM TO AUGMENT.
THE DEPARTMENTS BUDGETS PROVIDE
EASE AND AS ONE IS- IDENTIFIED
WILL COMMUNICATE THAT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. MMHM WITH REGARDS
TO QUESTIONS WHO ARE RELATED TO
THE DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
I DATE THAT IT'S- WAS-
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FOR THE EXTENSION OF. NON MY
NON MINOR DEPENDENT FUNDING FOR
NON MIND INDEPENDENCE THAT THEY
TURN TWENTY ONE AND BEYOND- I
THINK THAT THE SIMPLE RESPONSE
FOR THIS IS THE ADMINISTRATION
KIND OF TOOK THIS APPROACH
ACROSS FROM ON THE BOARD ON
MANY OF THE PANDEMIC. RELATED
PROPOSALS- THE ASSUMPTION IS
THAT ARE AT THE TIME OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS MADE THAT.
THE DECEMBER DEADLINE WOULD BE
AN APPROPRIATE DATE FOR.
LOOKING AT THE PANDEMIC IS
POTENTIALLY ENDING- WITH THE
QUESTION OF WHAT SUPPORT WILL
BE PROVIDED TO HELP YOU PREPARE
FOR THE TRANSITION INTO
INDEPENDENCE. JUST REMIND- THAT
COMMITTEE THAT RESPONSIBILITY
OF THESE ACTIVITIES WAS
INCLUDED IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
REALIGNMENTS- AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
AROUND EIGHT POINT NINE MILLION
TOTAL FUNDS. ON SEVEN HUNDRED
AND GENERAL FUND FOR CHILD
WELFARE SERVICE ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING- THE SUPPORT FOR NOW
MINOR DEPENDENTS WOULD BE THE-
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE PROGRAM.
THERE SHOULD BE ORDER
INCORPORATE AND SOME OF THE
ACTIVITIES OR THE ACTIVITIES
REQUIRE THE COUNTIES ARE DOING
WHEN TRANSITION A YOUTH FROM
THE EXTENDED FOSTER CARE OUT OF
IT'S- WITH REGARDS TO QUESTION
THREE. AS THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERED SEPARATE DIRECT
SUPPORT FOR RESOURCE FAMILIES
AND SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES INCLUDE
THE E. AS WAS MENTIONED THAT'S
INCLUDED I BELIEVE IT WAS ON
PAGE SEVENTY ONE THE CAREER ON
MEDITATION FOR RESOURCE
FAMILIES. I AM AS WELL AS A
BUDGET YEAR THE PROPOSAL OF
ABOUT THREE POINT THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT- THOSE
RESOURCE FAMILIES AND ESTHER
TEEPEES WITH SOME OF THE
IMMEDIATE PANDEMIC RELATED
NEEDS SO. IS THE MINISTRATION
IS CONSIDERED AN. INS INCLUDED
SOME RESOURCES TO THAT. LASTLY
THE QUESTION RELATED TO- THE
ADMINISTRATION NOT EXTENDED PRE
APPROVAL FUNDING FOR THE
EMERGENCY CARE GIVERS- OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS LEGISLATURE
INVESTORS TO WORK CLOSELY ON
IDENTIFYING WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FRAME IS FOR
THE EMERGENCY CARE GIVER-
PROGRAM AND TYPICALLY WE HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION AS WE ARE NOW
DURING THE MAKING PROCESS WHEN
ADDITIONAL DATA. IS MORE
AVAILABLE AFTER THE- THE
PREVIOUS YEARS BUDGETS AND TO
DETERMINE WHAT DATA IS LOOKING
LIKE SO- THE TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN ADDITIONAL
CHANGE IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL FOR FUNDING ON THIS IT
WOULD BE INCLUDED IN THE MAIN
REVISION. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM KATHY SANDERLING
MCDONALD'S THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CWD AT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH CATHERINE
MCCONNELL WITH THE WTA. I THINK
ESPECIALLY AS YOU LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS FOR THE
NINE PANELISTS IT WOULD BE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY THERE'S A
LOT GOING ON RIGHT NOW IN CHILD
WELFARE WORKER APPLING A
SYSTEMIC RACISM CLASSISM AND
INEQUITIES UNDERLIE OUR SOCIAL
STRUCTURES AND ALSO INFLUENCED
MUCH OF OUR SYSTEMS AND STORICA
PRECIOUS CHILD AND FAMILY WELL
BEING. WE'RE WORKING HARD TO
DEVELOP MORE SERVICES FOR
FAMILIES AND CAREGIVERS
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR HEIGHTS
NEEDS CHILDREN AND YOUTH. I'M
TRYING TO WORK WITH COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE HISTORICALLY
OVERREPRESENTED AT REPRESENTED
AT EVERY STAGE OF CHILD
WELFARE. TO REDUCE THOSE
DISPARITIES AND PROMOTE EQUITY
IN OUR SYSTEM. AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO IMPLEMENT THE
STATE'S GROUNDBREAKING
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM. AT
THE SAME TIME WILL SOON BE
IMPLEMENTING NEW FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND OPTIONS AS YOU
HEARD TODAY AND THE FAMILIES
FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES ACT
FF PSA. BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
ALTERNATIVE QUESTIONS POSED IN
THE ABSENT AT FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE L. A. A RECOMMENDATION TO
EXPAND EMERGENCY PLACEMENT
FUNDING. FOR RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS HER WHO'S APPROVALS
ARE PENDING. AS WELL AS THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO CREATE
THE WORKING GROUP TO CONTINUE
LOOKING AT THE VARIOUS
PROPOSALS AND MAKE CONTINUED
RECOMMENDATIONS. AS THE BUDGET
PROCESS GOES ON. FIRST
REGARDING STRENGTHENING THE
PREVENTION COMPONENT OF THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO IMPLEMENT
FAMILIES FIRST. AS YOU KNOW%
PREVENTION IS CRITICAL TO
STOPPING ABUSE AND NEGLECT AND
DONE CORRECTLY IT CAN REDUCE
THE LIKELIHOOD OF PLACEMENT IN
A FOSTER CARE. THE SERVICE IS
AVAILABLE UNDER THE FF PSA
PREVENTION COMPONENT ARE
WELCOME BUT ARE ALSO NARROW
THEY'RE LIMITED TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND IN HOME
PARENTING SKILLS PROGRAM AND
WILL NOT ADDRESS ALL ISSUE THE
FAMILY MAY BE FACING. THE RULES
TO ACCESS THESE FUNDS AS MR
ROVE NOTED ARE ALSO VERY
COMPLEX AND THEY'RE EASY TO RUN
A FOLLOW. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PREVENTION PROPOSAL FRANKLY
MISS IS THE OPPORTUNITY THE
FAMILIES FIRST PROVIDES TO
RETHINK OUR APPROACH TO SERVING
FAMILIES. ESPECIALLY FAMILIES
OF COLOR BEFORE THEY GET TO A
POINT OF BEING BROUGHT INTO
FORMAL FOSTER CARE. THE
PROPOSAL WOULD REQUIRE COUNTIES
TO OFTEN FIND ALL NON FEDERAL
COSTS AND THEN SHOULDER ALL THE
RISK FOR ANY FINANCIAL
LIABILITY. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL IS NEITHER BROUGHT
ENOUGH OR BOLD ENOUGH AN
OPTIONAL PROGRAM WITH ZERO
STATE FUNDING AND ALL THE REST
LATER THE COUNTY DOOR DOES NOT
PROMOTE EQUITY IN OUR SYSTEM.
IN CONTRAST TO THE PREVIOUS
BUDGET PROPOSAL RESPONSE OF
CHILDREN NOW YOU THE FAMILIES
FIRST AS A SPRINGBOARD TO A
BROADER STATEWIDE PREVENTION
SYSTEM. THAT BUILDS AND DRAWS
UPON COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS. WE
CALL FOR GENERAL FUND INVESTS
IN A PREVENTION CONTINUUM ONE
THAT ENGAGES PERSONS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE WITH CHILD WELFARE
AS WELL AS OTHER COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND SERVICE PROVIDERS.
TO BOTH DEVELOP AND EXPAND
AVAILABLE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
TO FAMILIES AND CHILDREN. THIS
INCLUDES TANGIBLE SUPPORT SUCH
AS CASH ASSISTANCE AND HOUSING
AS WELL AS SERVICES THAT ARE
GROUNDED AND RELEVANT TO THE
COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES WE
WORK WITH. SO ARE PROPOSAL
WOULD INVEST FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING
FOR ALL COUNTIES TO ENGAGE IN
ROBUST INCLUSIVE LOCAL PLANNING
AND INVESTMENT. AIMED AT
REDUCING PLACEMENT IN A FOSTER
CARE REDUCING THE DISPROPORTION
AUDI THAT WE KNOW EXISTS IN OUR
SYSTEM AT INCREASING EQUITY.
THIS PROPOSAL IS SUPPORTED BY A
GROWING COALITION OF MORE THAN
FIFTY CHILD AND FAMILY SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS SO FAR. THE
PROPOSAL AND THEY COULD BE
YOURS FOR A BROAD ARRAY OF
SERVICES. THIS INCLUDES
SERVICES THAT ARE MATT BOWL
WITH TITLE FOR A YEAR UNDER THE
CURRENT AFFECT PFA WALLS AS
WELL AS THOSE THAT ARE NOT. THE
FELLOW EVIDENCE BASED IN HOME
PARENTING SKILL BUILDING
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE NURSE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP. AND HOME
BUILDERS WHICH ARE BOTH
ELIGIBLE 450% FEDERAL FUNDING
UNDER AFTER OF PSA RULES TODAY.
ALSO BE INVESTED IN ALONG SIDE
OTHER CULTURALLY REBEL RELEVANT
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE EFFECT OF
BLACK PARENTING PROGRAMS AND
ABRIENDO PUERTAS OR OPEN DOORS.
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
FUNDING RIGHT NOW SO THEY COULD
BE IN THE FUTURE IF WE'RE ABLE
TO ALSO SUPPORT THE EVALUATION
OF THEIR SUCCESSFUL HELP. EACH
OTHER COMMUNITY AND FAMILY
SPECIFIC SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
WOULD BE IDENTIFIED AND
IMPLEMENTED OR EXPANDED. TO
THAT INCLUDES OF LOCAL PET
PLANNING PROCESS. WHAT HAS BEEN
THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL AND
WASN'T ACCOUNTED FOR UNDER THE
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT AT
THE NEXT LAST. THE PURPOSE OF
RFA IS TO UNIFY ALL LICENSING
AND RELATIVE APPROVAL
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS
ADOPTION APPROVAL REQUIREMENTS
INTO A SINGLE STREAMLINED
PROCESS WHILE ALSO SUPPORTING
FAMILIES TO PREPARE THEM FOR
THEIR IMPORTANT ROLE AS
RESOURCE. OURTHANKS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED COUNTY
MARK WHAT WHAT IT WAS MANDATED
STATEWIDE BY THE C. C. R.
LEGISLATION EIGHTY FOUR THREE
PASSED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TO
TWENTY FIFTEEN. TO BE CLEAR THE
RFA PROCESS WAS NOT ACCOUNTED
FOR IN THE TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT AND GREETING YEAH
AGREEMENTS. WHILE THE BILL WAS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND SIX THAT
SOUGHT TO TEST THE IDEA OF
MERGING TOGETHER THE PROCESS OF
LICENSING FOSTER PARENTS AND
APPROVING THEM AS ADOPTIVE
PARENTS. THAT WILL ONLY
AUTHORIZED UP TO FIVE PILOTS
AND HAD NO STATEWIDE MANDATE.
WE ARE REQUESTING EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THE ADDED TO
THE CHILD WELFARE PROGRAM IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. TO REFLECT THE
ACTUAL INCREASE COSTA COUNTY OF
RK PROCESSING REQUIRED
STATEWIDE FOR EIGHTY FOUR OH
THREE AS WELL AS RELATED
GUIDANCE FROM THE STATE TO
COUNTY SINCE BEEN ISSUED SINCE
THAT TIME. AND THE ABSENCE OF
THE FUNDING BEING PROVIDED THE
COUNTIES WILL HAVE TO CONTINUE
SUFFERING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF FUNDS TO THE ARCADE PROCESS.
FUNDS WHAT OTHERWISE BE
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE NEEDED
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS DIRECTLY
TO OUR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
FINALLY RELATED TO TRAINING AND
HOW TRAINING CAN IMPROVE THE
PROVISION OF MORE ADEQUATE
SERVICES AS WELL AS TRYING TO
OVERCOME AND ADDRESS RACIAL
BIAS. FROM MATT AND IMPLICIT
BIAS. TO ADDRESS RACIAL BIAS
AND TOM WITH OUR SYSTEM CDBG A
HAS CONVENE OUR CHILD WELFARE
LEADERSHIP IN A SERIES OF
CONVERSATIONS CHARAKTER PROMOTE
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION.
THIS WORK IS GROUNDED IN THE
STATE REQUIRED INTEGRATED CORE
PRACTICE MODEL WHICH EMPHASIZES
CHILD AND FAMILY VOICE IN
CHOICE AT THE CENTER OF SERVICE
PLANNING TO THE CHILD AND
FAMILY TEENAGE PROSPECTS.
MISTER WOULD TELL WALKER
TRAINING SYSTEM PLAYS A
CRITICAL ROLE IN BUILDING
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
AND CHILD WELFARE. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
TRAINING SYSTEM WAS
PURPOSEFULLY NOT INCLUDED IN
THE TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT.
MEANING THE STATE RETAINED BY
FORTY OVER THE FACT THAT I
DECISION INTENDED TO PROMOTE
CONSISTENCY STATEWIDE. THE
COMPLEX WORK OF CHILD WELFARE
CARD REQUIRES A HIGHLY TRAINED
AND SKILLED WORKFORCE TO MEET
EVER CHANGING MANDATES AND HIGH
EXPECTATIONS FROM THE
COMMUNITY. UNFORTUNATELY THE
TRAINING SYSTEM HAS FALLEN
BEHIND IN GIVING COUNTY STAFF
THE TOOLS TO STRENGTHEN YOUR
FAMILY STORYLINES OF EQUITY AND
ANTI RACIST. TO ADDRESS THIS
GAP CWPA THE NATIONAL SOCIAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND FTI YOU
CALIFORNIA JOINTLY REQUEST AN
AUGMENTATION OF SEVEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR TRAINING
SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS. THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO THE FIVE MILLION
INCREASE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE DO NOT TAKE ISSUE
WITH A COMPONENT OF THAT
PROPOSAL BUT BELIEVE THAT MORE
IMPROVEMENTS UNLESS MORE
INVESTMENT IS NEEDED. OUR
AUTHENTICATION WITHOUT APPROACH
OF THE TRAINING THAT WE TO REAL
PRACTICE CHANGED AS WELL AS
ADVANCED TRAINING IN TARGETED
AREAS SUCH AS WORKING WITH
FAMILIES TO ADDRESS THE EFFECTS
OF SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
INEQUITY. AND EMPOWERING SOCIAL
WORKERS TO RECOGNIZE AND
OVERCOME THEIR OWN IMPLICIT
BIAS FEES AS WELL AS RESPOND TO
THE BIASING OF OTHERS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I LOOK FOR TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM KRISTEN POWER
VICE PRESIDENT WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TODAY ON HOW WE CAN
BETTER SUPPORT TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH THROUGH BEYOND THE
PANDEMIC I'M CHRISTIAN POWER
WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS. IN
RECOGNITION OF THE CHALLENGES
RELATED TO CODING NINETEEN
LEGISLATURE TOOK STEPS LAST
YEAR TO ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING NON MINOR
DEPENDENTS. WHO CANNOT MEET
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENTS AND
TO CONTINUE SUPPORT FOR THOSE
WHO TURNED TWENTY ONE THROUGH
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. FEDERAL LAW HAS SINCE
EXTENDED THAT TIMELINE TO
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
EXTEND THAT TIMELINE TO THE END
OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR. YET THE
SAFETY NET DOES NOT EXTEND TO
THOSE YOU COME TO THE ATTENTION
OF THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AS
THEY APPROACH THEIR EIGHTEENTH
BIRTHDAY. WE'RE SEEKING A
MODEST BUDGET INCREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND TO ENSURE YOU WHO ARE IN
NEED OF SERVICES. BUT WERE
UNABLE TO ENTER FOSTER CARE DUE
TO COURT HEARING OR CHILD
WELFARE INVESTIGATION DELAYS
ARE ABLE TO DO SO DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THE DEPENDENCY COURT
ADJUDICATION PROCESS INVOLVES
MULTIPLE HEARINGS
OVERPRESCRIBED CREATES A TIME
WHICH LEAVES OLDER MINORS
VULNERABLE TO TIMING OUT OF THE
PROCESS IF THEY TURN EIGHTEEN
WHILE WAITING FOR THEIR
JURISDICTIONAL HEARING. THIS
PROPOSAL CALLED THE OLDER YOU
ENTRY INTO FOSTER CARE AND
CHAMPION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON. OFFERS AN EXCEPTION FOR
THOSE OLDER MINORS SO THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THE EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN REMOVED
FROM THEIR HOME THE COURT FINDS
IT IN THEIR BEST INTEREST TO
ENTER EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
PROVISIONS ARE INTENTIONALLY
NARROW TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF OLDER MINORS
IMPACTED BY PANDEMIC RELATED
DELAYS. AND THERE IS A SUNSET
ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. PROVIDING A MUCH NEEDED
LIFELINE DURING THIS PANDEMIC
WHEN AN IDENTIFIABLE LIFE
ALTERING EVENT HAS OCCURRED
LIFE LIKE OF USE OR NEGLECT.
CAN CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY OF A
YOUNG LIFE. STEMMING IN OPEN
PIPELINE TO CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS RELEASED YOU WILL
ALLOW THEM TO SURVIVE AND
THRIVE AS THEY TRANSITION FROM
CRISIS. AND TO OUR NORMAL. IN
ADDITION HOUSING INSTABILITY
AND HOMELESSNESS SIGNIFICANTLY
HINDER THE PURSUIT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT
SELF SUFFICIENCY FOR YOU WE'RE
CURRENTLY OR FORMERLY IN FOSTER
CARE YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND USED UNDER
PROBATION SUPERVISION AS THEY
TRANSITION TO ADULTHOOD. AND
THEN I WILL HAVE DEVASTATING
ECONOMIC IMPACT FOR MANY AND
PARTICULARLY FOR YOU. FOLLOWING
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
RECESSION THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
FOR SIXTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR YEAR
OLD WAS MORE THAN 18% OR TWICE
THE OVERALL UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
FOR BLACK AND BROWN YOUTH IT
ROSE TO THIRTY AND 20%
RESPECTIVELY. AND HOMELESSNESS
AMONG SOME GROUPS OF YOU IS
DISPROPORTIONATE UP 240% OF
HOMELESS YOUTH IDENTIFY AS
LGBTQ. A PRIMARY PURPOSE TO THE
EXTENT OF FOSTER HERE TO
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS AS YOU
ENTER EARLY ADULTHOOD. HOWEVER
WITHOUT SUFFICIENT SUPPORTED
HOUSING THAT VISION AND EXTENT
OF KOSTER HERE'S FALLING FLAT.
FURTHER FAILURE TO SUPPORT
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
RESULTING IN INCREASED CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS AND DISCONNECTION
AS ADULTS. THE CREATION OF A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
FORGIVABLE LOAN PROGRAM TO
CREATE NEW HOUSING FOR YOU
CENTER TWENTY SIX WE'RE
CURRENTLY OR FORMERLY IN FOSTER YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND YOU UNDER
PROBATION SUPERVISION
SUPERVISION. IS TANGIBLE
SUPPORT FOR ARIAN PEOPLE. THIS
LOAN PROGRAM CALLED THE SUPPORT
ACT. SUPPORTING UNDERSERVED
YOUNG PEOPLE FOR POSITIVE RESET
AND TRANSITIONS. IS CHAMPIONED
BY SENATOR WIENER. LOANS CAN BE
USED FOR PRE DEVELOPMENT SIDE
ACQUISITION ARCHITECTURAL
DESIGN COSTS AND CONSTRUCTION
OR REFURBISHING OF SITES.
APPORTION THE FUNDS ARE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED TO YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE AGES TWENTY.
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE. THIS
PROPOSAL KICKSTARTS THE HOUSING
ACQUISITION WE HAVE DEVELOPED A
PROCESS FOR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH INTEREST FREE
FORGIVABLE LOANS TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY SHELTER AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. REMOVING
FINANCIAL BARRIERS FOR SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS WILL ADDRESS
BOTH THE PRE EXISTING HOUSING
CRISIS AND PERSISTENT HOUSING
NEEDS RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC
FOR POLITICAL TRANSITION EIGHT
YEARS. BY REDUCING CONSTRUCTION
FINANCING TIMELINES TO MORE
QUICKLY DEVELOP NEW SPECIALIZED
HOUSING INVENTORY. I ALSO WANT
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THE PANDEMIC CARE COVER
STATEMENT AND EMERGENCY TRACK
YOUR BRIDGE PROGRAM EXPANSION
WHICH MY CALLING THIS METHOD
WILL DETAIL AND URSEL
LEGISLATURE TO CREATE A FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES BACK
WORKING GROUP. TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY INTO THE TRAILER
BILL DEVELOPMENT AS NOTED IN
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION. WE'RE
WORKING WITH PARTNERS PROVIDE
SUGGESTIONS THE TRAILER BILL
AND KNOW MUCH MORE WORK NEEDS
TO BE DONE. FOR EXAMPLE TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR TRAVEL
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY PARTICIPATE AND
SHOW MORE HOW WE CAN BETTER
SUPPORT TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
THROUGH AND BEYOND THE PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM SUZANNE ON IF AN DIRECTOR
OF CHILDREN NOW. MISS NIVEN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
SONORA NELSON DIRECTOR OF CHILD
WELFARE POLICY AND CHILDREN NOW
THAT'S PRAYER SPEAKERS AND
NOTED COMING HIS ABANDONED OUR
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM COURT
SHOWDOWN IN THE INITIAL DAYS
WE'RE SLOWLY TRANSITION
VIRTUALLY AND SOME CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE. BACKLOGS AND DELAYS
IN THE AREA. DISTANCE LEARNING
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN TO NAVIGATE
NEW TECHNOLOGY AND REMAINING
GAUGE AND LEARNING DESPITE
DISRUPTING ACADEMIC SUPPORT.
COMINFORM SERVICES IN SOME
PARTS MANAGER REMOTE DELIVERY
OR SOPPED ALTOGETHER
DESTRUCTIONS TO ROUTINES AND
VISITATION WITH FAMILY HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATING TO CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE. OUR
CAMERAS ARE STRUGGLING TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THESE CHILDREN
WHILE BALANCING INCREASING
RESPONSIBILITIES AND COPING
WITH SEVERELY LIMITED ACCESS TO
CORPORATE CRITICAL SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES. MANY CARE GIVERS ARE
OLDER HAD HIGH RISK OF BECOMING
BUT CONTINUE TO OPEN THEIR
HOMES TO CHILDREN AND INTERACT
WITH A VARIETY OF FAMILIES
PROVIDERS IN CASE WORKERS. SOME
OF LOST INCOME AND EMPLOYMENT
AS A STRUGGLE TO MEET
INCREASING NEEDS OF CHILDREN IN
RWANDA GEN SCHOOL OR OTHER
PROGRAMS OUTSIDE THE HOME.
SOCIAL WORKERS. INTERACTIONS
WITH SERVICE PROVIDERS AND SHE
ONLY VISITATION REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL TIME PLANNING AND
SAFETY PROTOCOLS. SOME WATER
HAS BEEN PROVIDING FOR THOSE
WHO ARE DIAGNOSED WITH CAROLINE
AND FOR USING THE EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM POLICIES
THAT WERE VITALLY NEEDED AND
ARE GREATLY APPRECIATED.
HOWEVER THE MAJORITY OF
CHILDREN ABUSED IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS AND LARGELY
OVERLOOKED. IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET. WE ARE SO
REGISTRATION AND ADMINISTRATION
PROVIDE TEMPORARY AND DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL. OSTRACH
HERE TO PROMOTE STABILITY AND
NEED TO HAVE DONE. FIRST WE
RECOMMEND EXCITING'S A HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MONTH PER CHILD FOR
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THIS FUNDING WOULD BE PROVIDED
TO CHILDREN LIVING IN FAMILY
HOMES THIS WILL COST AN
ESTIMATED FORTY NINE POINT TWO
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING. IN
ADDITION WE RECOMMEND
EDUCATIONAL STIPENDS OF A
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER MONTH FOR
ALL K. TWELVE STUDENTS IN
FOSTER CARE TO ACCOUNT FOR
ADDITIONAL TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT
AND OTHER REMOTE LEARNING
REQUIREMENTS THIS IMPOSSIBLE
ESTIMATED TWENTY FOUR MILLION.
IN ONE TIME FUNDING. CHILDREN
NOW URGES. THE EMERGENCY BRIDGE
PROGRAM AS WE ARE BY GREG
WELLS- I JUST REALLY NEED TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO CHILDCARE
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE TO INCREASE FUNDING BY
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION I'M GOING.
TATIAN THE BRIDGE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN AN INCREDIBLE SUCCESS
ALLOWING CHILDREN TO BE PLACED
IN HOMES THAT BEST MEET THEIR
NEEDS INCLUDING WITH RELATIVES
AND CAREGIVERS WHO ARE KNOWN TO
THEM. AND IT ALSO SUPPORTS
PARENTING USE IN FOSTER. CARE
AS THEY WORK OR ATTEND SCHOOL.
ALMOST TO SHOW TWENTY BILLION
JANE TEMPERATURES AND GLOBAL
FOR THIS CRITICAL PROGRAM. JUST
LAST WEEK I RECEIVED A CALL
FROM MY COUNTY IS ALLOCATION
FOR PROJECT FUNDING WAS
EXHAUSTED HALFWAY THROUGH THE
YEAR. THE REQUESTED MORE FUNDS.
THE PROPOSAL SEATS AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CHILD
CARE NAVIGATORS WHO WORK WITH
CARE GIVERS TO FIND IN SECURING
LONG TERM CHILD CARE. AND
EXTENDS TO SIX TO TWELVE MONTH
TIMELINE DUTY INCREASED
AVAILABILITY. OF CHILDCARE
DURING THE PANDEMIC. FINALLY
THE PROPOSAL'S AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR MILLION. DURING TRUMP
TRAINING AVAILABLE FOR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS THIS TRAINING
NOT ONLY SUPPORTS CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE. ALL CHILDREN WHO
ARE STRUGGLING TO PROCESS THE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC. IN
CLOSING I WOULD KNOW TO
FOLLOWING CHILDREN NOW IS KIND
OF SPONSORING THE FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES AFTER
POUNDS ALL PRESENTED BY CEDAR
BDA AND WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO FORM A
WORKING GROUP. TO ALLOW TIME
FOR STATE. I TO FIND IT YES A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. WE ALSO.
REMOVING THE SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE ATTACHED TO FIND
CRITICAL CHAO WILL FOR PROGRAMS.
AND THAT INCLUDING FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM WHICH IS
NOTED EARLIER I WHICH PROVIDES
USE AND THEIR CAREGIVERS AND
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TRAUMA
INFORMED SUPPORT NEEDED NOW
MORE THAN EVER. LASTLY I REMAIN
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE ROLL
OUT THE FLAWED LEVEL OF CARE
PROTOCOL THIS TO. MY CHILDREN
AND YOUTH WITH THE RESOURCES
REQUIRED TO MEET THEIR NEEDS I
WE ASK THE STATE WORK QUICKLY.
AND COLLABORATIVELY. CALIBRATES
IS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
TODAY CALIFORNIA HAS ASSUME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MORE THAN
SIXTY THOUSAND CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE. EACH PRIORITIZE
THEM IN THE STATE BUDGET. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM CHRISTINE STONER MERTZ WHO
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
OF CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHEER
ARAMBULA I DO HAVE A
PRESENTATION THAT I AM. LOOKING
TO PULL UP SERVE JUST ONE
MOMENT IF I COULD. WE SEE THE
GREAT VERY GOOD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ABOUT YOUR ARAMBULA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND CHRISTINE
STONER MERTZ. THE CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED FIFTY
NATIONALLY ACCREDITED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SERVE
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES
INTO A WELFARE ADOPTIONS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH EDUCATION
JUVENILE JUSTICE. SYSTEMS AS
WELL AS PROVIDING PREVENTION
SERVICES WE SEE FIRSTHAND THE
CHALLENGES OF THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM THROUGH THE EYES OF
OUR MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS THE
VISION OF C. C. R. WHICH HAS
BEEN FOCUSED ON CHILDREN
FAMILIES REMAINING TOGETHER
WHENEVER POSSIBLE AND REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF FOSTER YOUTH IN
RESIDENTIAL CARE. DOES NOT
MATCH THE REALITIES THAT THOSE
PROVIDING SERVICES ARE
EXPERIENCING. RACIAL
DISPARITIES AS MANY OF SAID
CONTINUE TO EXIST IN THE FOSTER
AND PROBATION SYSTEMS AND WE
NEED TO IDENTIFY CONCRETE STEPS
TO RECTIFY THIS THROUGHOUT THE
CONTINUUM. IMPLICIT BIAS AND
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM MUST BE
ADDRESSED AT EVERY DECISION
POINT IN A CHILD'S LIFE IN
ORDER TO HOLD OURSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE TO ADDRESSING THESE
DISPARITIES. THEN MY SLIDE ONE
OUTLOOK MAPS. APOLOGIES I'M NOT
SURE WHY YEAH. WELL- GAPS THAT
WE SEE IN THE IN THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE THAT ARE IMPACTING. A
CHILDREN OF COLOR. INCLUDE
LIMITED RESOURCES AND EFFORTS
TOWARDS FAMILY FINDING AN
ENGAGEMENT THE IMPACT
PERMANENCY FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH WHILE A STATED PRIORITY
WHAT IS EXPERIENCED BY
PROVIDERS YOUTH AND FAMILIES
DOES NOT ALWAYS REFLECT THIS
THERE IS WIDE VARIATION
REGARDING WHAT CONSTITUTES THE
MINIMUM THAT SHOULD BE DONE.
SECONDLY A LACK OF RESOURCE
FAMILIES PARTICULARLY FOR OLDER
YOUTH L. G. B. T. Q. AND TRANS
GENDER YOUTH AND YOUTH WAS
SPECIALIZED CARE NEEDS. THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR MORE
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER CARE
FAMILIES AND WORK TO DEVELOP
THERAPEUTIC FOSTER CARE.
THIRDLY THE TO THE STABILITY OF
SOCIAL WORKERS AND FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES THE HIGH
TURNOVER THE FFA'S EXPERIENCE
IN SOCIAL WORKERS IMPACTS THE
CHILD IN FOSTER FAMILY WHO
COUNT ON THE SOCIAL WORKERS TO
BE AVAILABLE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
AND SUPPORT THEM THROUGH MANY
UPS AND DOWNS. ADEQUATE SUPPORT
BOTH FINANCIAL AND SYSTEMIC
SUPPORTS FOR STR T. P.'S. AN
ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF THE
CONTINUUM OF THESE ARE THE MOST
INTENSIVE SERVICES AVAILABLE
APART FROM CRISIS SERVICES AND
HOSPITALIZATION YET THE LACK OF
SUPPORT ACROSS THE SYSTEM TO
ENSURE. THAT THEY REMAIN VIABLE
HAS RESULTED IN SOME OF OUR
MOST EXPERIENCED AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE SERVICE PROVIDERS
CLOSING. THE NEED FOR CRISIS
SERVICES. CHILDREN'S CRESSIDA
RESIDENTIAL CRISIS PROGRAMS
CRISIS STABILIZATION AND MOBILE
CRISIS TEAMS THAT CAN ADDRESS
THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS TO
STABILIZE. THOSE SITUATIONS AND
FINALLY WE NEED TO INTERROGATE
OUR SYSTEMS TO ENSURE THAT OUR
PUBLIC SERVING CHILD AND FAMILY
SYSTEMS ARE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE. THERE'VE BEEN SO
MANY IMPACTS YOU'VE HEARD FOR
MANY ABOUT THESE- OF CODE ON
OUR PROVIDER. COMMUNITY
SERVICES STAFF AND OPERATIONS
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED PROVIDERS
MOVE TO A VIRTUAL SERVICES
WHENEVER POSSIBLE TO LIMIT
EXPOSURE FOR BOTH STAFF YOUTH
AND FAMILIES BUT MANY EMPLOYEES
PARTICULARLY THOSE AND FFA'S
AND S. T. R. T. P. ISN'T
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY IN PERSON SERVICES
REQUIRED TO MEET CHILDREN'S
NEEDS DISTANCE LEARNING HAS
MEANT ADDED COSTS FIRST YEAR
TEEPEES AS ADDITIONAL STAFF
HAVE BEEN REQUIRED DURING
SCHOOL HOURS TO SUPPORT YOUTH
DIRECT SERVICE STAFF WORKING IN
BOTH FFA'S AND ASKED YOUR GP'S
ARE AT RISK AND ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WHO ARE ALSO OFTEN FROM
THE COMMUNITIES. THAT ARE
HARDEST HIT BY THE PANDEMIC.
OPERATIONALLY THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS HAVE EXPERIENCED COLD
OUTBREAKS AND HAVE HAD TO
REDUCE CAPACITY DUE TO PUBLIC
HEALTH CLOSURES. IN ORDER TO IN
ORDER TO INCREASE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE HOME BASED CARE
INCREASE PERMANENCY AND STABLE
I SERVICES FOR THE MOST AT RISK
FOSTER YOUTH WE MUST ADDRESS
THE IMMEDIATE STABILITY THE
BEST YEAR TWO PEAS AND FFA'S.
AND DEVELOP A PROCESS FOR
CLOSING ALL GAPS IN THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE. AS WE
IMPLEMENT THE FAMILY FIRST
SERVICES ACT WE MUST BE
INTENTIONAL IN OUR APPROACH TO
SYSTEM AND CULTURE CHANGE. WE
SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION OUTLINED ON PAGE
SEVENTY SIX TO DEVELOP A WORK
GROUP TO ADDRESS THE COMPLEX
AND INTERRELATED QUESTIONS
RAISED IN THE CURRENT TBL. THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE HAS TO
BUDGET REQUESTS THE FIRST OF
WHICH IS TO ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIATE STABILITY OF FFA'S.
WE ALSO HAVE DEVELOPED
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR A PATH
FORWARD TO CLOSE AN ADDITIONAL
GAPS IN THE CONTINUUM OF CARE.
THIS PICTURE REFLECTS THE IN
IMPACT ON CHILDREN'S PERMANENCY
WHEN THEY HAVE MORE THAN ONE
SOCIAL WORKER. FFA SOCIAL
WORKERS MUST HAVE A MASTER'S
DEGREE BE AVAILABLE 24788% OF
THEM ARE FEMALE AND MANY OF
THEM ARE FROM A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. COMMITTED TO
GIVING BACK. TURNOVER IS THAT
59% R. FOR FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR STATE GENERAL
FUND ALLOCATION REQUEST. WHICH
IS COSPONSORED BY NSW WILL HELP
SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF HIGH
FOSTER FAMILIES SOCIAL WORKER
TURNOVER. FFA'S PROVIDE HOMES
FOR ALMOST ONE THIRD OF ALL
FOSTER CHILDREN IN HOME BASED
CARE AND 1100% OF ALL CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN INTENSIVE SERVICES
FOSTER CARE THIS REQUEST
INCREASES THE SOCIAL WORK
COMPONENT OF THE RATE BY FIFTY
DOLLARS PER CHILD PER MONTH AND
THIS WILL GO DIRECTLY TO SOCIAL
WORKERS WE WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO FOR BEING
OUR CHAMPION IN THIS MULTI YEAR
EFFORT. TO SUPPORT FFA SOCIAL
WORKERS. AND FINALLY OUR ONE
TIME URGENT COVERT NINETEEN
REIMBURSEMENT REQUESTS FOR EST
HERE TO PIECE OF FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLAR STATE GENERAL
FUND WILL HELP ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIATE RISK OF MORE PROGRAMS
CLOSING. HELP TO STABILIZE
STAFFING AND ADDRESS THE
CURRENT EMERGENCY NEEDS OF
THESE NONPROFIT PROVIDERS
CARING FOR THE HIGHEST NEEDS
YOU. AND WHO HAVE TAKEN FIFTY
FOUR OF THE OUT OF STATE USE
THAT HAVE RETURNED TO
CALIFORNIA. THE COST PER
ADDITIONAL STAFFING
QUARANTINING YOUTH AND STAFF
INCREASED HOURLY RATE SUPPLIES
AND EQUIPMENT AND SIGNIFICANT
REVENUE LOSSES RELATED TO
PUBLIC HEALTH CLOSURES OF
FACILITIES AND BILLABLE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE AT WORST DO TO
REDUCE CAPACITY ALL OF THESE
PROGRAMS TO BE AT SERIOUS RISK.
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS FOR CHAMPIONING
CHAMPING THIS REQUEST WHICH
REFLECTS HIS COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
OUR DEEPEST GRATITUDE TO YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OUR FINAL PANELIST FOR
ISSUE FOR JORDAN SOSOK
STATEWIDE LEGISLATIVE AND
POLICY MANAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION.
PLEASE BEGIN. AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
FOR ME TO SPEAK AND TODAY'S
PANEL MY NAME IS JORDAN SOSA
AND I'M A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
HERE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION. AS THE
STATEWIDE LEGISLATIVE AND
POLICY MANAGER. FOR OVER THREE
DECADES C. Y. C. HAS BEEN A
PLACE FOR CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH FROM ACROSS THE
STATE TO COME TOGETHER TO
TRANSFORM CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
YOUR LEGISLATIVE POLICY AND
PRACTICE CHANGE ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
INTENDS TO REMOVE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH FROM THEIR PARENTS
CUSTODY ONLY WHEN NECESSARY FOR
THEIR WELL BEING OR THE PUBLIC
SAFETY C. Y. C. MEMBERS DON'T
FIND THIS TO BE THE CASE. WHAT
IS THE CASE IS THAT THERE IS A
CULTURE OF PUTTING POLICIES
OVER A UNITS WHITE. AS A YOUTH
LED ORGANIZATION C. Y. C.
ADVOCATES FOR A SYSTEM THAT
WILL HONOR AND NOURISH EVERY
INDIVIDUAL IMPACTED BY FOSTER
CARE AND HOLD ASSISTANCE
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN IT'S NOT
SUPPORTING THE STABILITY OF
YOUNG PEOPLE. WHILE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH ARE BEING TAKEN AWAY
FROM THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITY OF ORIGIN WE ARE
FORCED TO INHERIT A SYSTEM
WHERE BLACK AND BROWN YOUTH ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BE PLACED IN A
CONGREGATE CARE SETTING WHEN
THEY FACE ADDITIONAL TRAUMA. OR
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
WHEN EXPERIENCING MULTIPLE
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT CHANGES.
THREE THE AGE OF KOBE NINETEEN
THE C. WEISS COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
ADVOCATING DIRECT CASH AID FOR
CURRENT FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
ADDRESSING THE INTERSECTION
MALADY OF THE WAR ON DRUGS WITH
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
ENGAGING WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
VIRTUALLY SHARING GO FUND ME
PAGES FROM FUNERAL EXPENSES OR
FOR LEGAL FEES DUE TO BEING
ARRESTED AND SUPPORT FOR BLACK
LIBERATION. AND CONNECTING WITH
AVAILABLE RESOURCES LIKE FY I
HOUSING VOUCHERS THANK
TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT WITH AYE
FOSTER .ORG AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WE SEE RACIAL INEQUITIES.
THAT WE ARE THEY USE ARE BEING
LABELED BASED ON CASE NOTES AND
NOT FROM EXPERIENCES. IN APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY I PERSONALLY
ATTENDED A CHILDREN FAMILY TEAM
MEETING FOR A C. Y. C. MEMBER
ADVOCATE AND SUPPORT WHEN THEY
WERE ISSUED A FOURTEEN DAY
NOTICE. A FOURTEEN DAY NOTICES
WHEN A FOSTER CARE AGENCY. THE
COUNTY THE YOUTH THE FAMILY ARE
NOTIFIED WHEN THE YOUNG PERSON
HAS TO MOVE TO A NEW FOSTER
CARE PLACEMENT. BUT IT'S MORE
THAN JUST THE POLICY. IT'S
FOURTEEN DAYS TO SAY THEIR
GOODBYES TO THEIR FRIENDS.
THEIR FAMILIES BECAUSE YOU
NEVER KNOW HOW FAR THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM CAN REFUSE
RELATIONSHIPS OR CONNECTIONS.
FOURTEEN DAYS TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT LIFE IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE. WHAT SCHOOL TO ATTEND OR
WHO ARE GOING TO BE THE NEW-
PUBLIC SERVICE PROFESSIONALS.
TO BILL A NEW REPORT WITH.
THERE'S ALSO A FEAR OF BEING
PLACED IN AN EMERGENCY. SHELTER
DURING THE PANDEMIC. CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT CURRENTLY COLLECT.
DATA ON PLACEMENT CHANGES IN A
WAY THAT FACILITATES A DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING ON WHO. WHAT
WHERE WHEN AND WHY THEY ARE
HAPPENING. WE HAVE SUSPICION
BASED ON ANECDOTES AND SEE WHY
THESE MEMBERS PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES. THE DIESEL BROUGHT
PLACEMENT CHANGES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
INDIVIDUALS WHO IDENTIFY AS
LGBTQ. YOUTH WITH MENTAL HEALTH
DIAGNOSIS YES WITH A DISABILITY
AND YOUTH OF COLOR. I DO I
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTION REGARDING SERVING YOU
THROUGH AN EQUITY LANCE AND
TOPPING AT STATE WHITE LITTLE
LEADERSHIP PLATFORM AND
IMPLEMENTED WITH A FULLY
RESOURCE COUNTY PARTNERSHIP.
ADOPTING A STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP
PLATFORM WILL BE THE FIRST STEP
IN CARING USE WITHIN EQUITY
LETS. YOUNG PEOPLE RIGHT NOW
ARE STRUGGLING THROUGH I'M
PRESIDENTE CRISIS AND NEED HELP
MORE THAN EVER ISSUES AFFECTING
YOUTH HAVE BECOME MORE PRESSING
SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH. ECONOMIC
ECONOMIC INSTABILITY AND RACIAL
INJUSTICE AND YOUNG PEOPLE FIND
THEMSELVES FRUSTRATED WITH THE
LACK OF PARTICIPATION IN
SHAPING THEIR FUTURES. THAT'S
WHY C. WAITING MEMBERS ARE
COSPONSORING ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTY SIX AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS WHICH
WILL ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE
ADVISORY BODY TO THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT COMPRISED SOLELY OF
YOU. OVER TWENTY OTHER STATES
IN THE US HAVE A STATEWIDE
YOUTH ADVISORY COUNCIL WRITTEN
INTO STATE STATUTE. ASIANS
MISSION THE POWER UNDER
REPRESENTED YOUTH WITH FORMAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENGAGE IN
CALIFORNIA CIVIC PROCESS. IN
REGARDS TO IMPLEMENT A FULLY
RESOURCE COUNTY PARTNERSHIP I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE SOME SEE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS FROM C. Y.
C. MEMBERS FOR COUNTIES TO
ENGAGE AUTHENTICALLY WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE ONE NO A WALLS. ALSO
USES A FOSTER CARE SHOULD STOP
ASSOCIATING PROTEST WITH
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR
CRIMINALIZATION STIGMATIZES
ADVOCACY. TO ALLOW ACT ACCESS
TO ADVOCACY PLATFORMS ALLOW YOU
TO EXPRESS THEIR PROTEST EVEN
IF YOU ARE UNABLE TO
PARTICIPATE PERCENT SIGN
PETITIONS ATTEND VIRTUAL TOWN
HALLS IN CONFERENCES LIKE RIGHT
NOW I CALL OFFICIALS I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE TO NOT USE ADVOCACY
AS A TOOL TO DISCIPLINE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND CARE. THREE PROVIDE
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES IF YOU
START ATTENDING IN PERSON
DEMONSTRATIONS BE SUPPORTIVE
PROVIDE FACEMASK SNACKS WATER A
LIST OF THE AVAILABLE RESOURCES
FOR PROTESTS AND DISCUSS SOCIAL
DISTANCING BEST PRACTICES WE
RECOGNIZE THE MANY YOU DON'T
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO STAY AT
HOME TO PARTICIPATE AND BLACK
LIBERATION AND ADVOCACY. AND
FOR THE BALLOT CURRICULUM AND
TRAINING ADDRESSING RACISM AND
PRIVILEGES WE WANT INDIVIDUALS
TO SPEAK WITH YOU AND STOP
ABOUT RACISM. THAT EXISTS
WITHIN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
CHALLENGE AND INDIVIDUALS WHAT
PRIVILEGES TO UNDERSTAND THE
USE PERSPECTIVES AND HOW THEY
SEE THEMSELVES AS PART OF THE
CONVERSATION ON RACE. I WOULD
LIKE TO CAN INCLUDE THAT
CHILDREN AND YOU DON'T HAVE
CONTROL OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT PUT THEM INTO THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. WE MAY BE BORN
INTO POVERTY WE MAY BE BORN
INTO A COUNTRY FILLED WITH
STRIFE AND SYSTEMATIC RACISM WE
MAY EVEN CONFRONT THE FEELINGS
OF OUR OWN PARENTS. BEFORE
FASCIAS THEY HAVE ADDITIONAL
HURDLES TO OVERCOME FROM STIGMA
THIS FORCED ASSIMILATION OF
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES THE WAR
ON DRUGS THE LEGACY OF SLAVERY
JIM CROW. FEDERAL STATE
POLICIES DISCRIMINATING ASIAN
COMMUNITIES THE PERSECUTION OF
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES THE
FIGHT FOR THE RIGHTS OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY FACING THE
PRISON INDUSTRY PRESENT
INDUSTRY COMPLEX AND THE
ONGOING PROBLEMS OF
DISCRIMINATION. IT'S TIME FOR
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY AND LISTEN TO
THE YOUTH ESPECIALLY YOUTH OF
COLOR THE FACE RASH RACIAL AND
ETHNIC BIAS I BELIEVE. WE EACH
EXPERIENCE OUR OWN HARDSHIPS
BUT WE DON'T LISTEN AND EMPOWER
YOUNG PEOPLE AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS THEN THE SYSTEM IS
ACCEPTING THESE. IN EQUITIES TO
BE PERMANENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU JORDAN AND- I COULDN'T HAVE
SAID IT ANY BETTER MYSELF AND-
IF I COULD JUST ECHO YOUR
COMMENTS I WOULD JUST SAY IT'S
LONG PAST TIME FOR US TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION SO. WITH THAT
I WILL NOW BRING IT UP TO THE
DíAS FOR ANY MEMBERS QUESTIONS
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AS A SPONSOR OF
THE BUDGET REQUEST I AM ASKING
FOR FIVE POINT FORM- MILLION.
DOLLARS IN STATE GENERAL FUND
TO INCREASE PERMANENCY
OUTCOMES. FOR FOSTER CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BY REDUCING FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY. SOCIAL WORKER
TURNOVER. I IT IS MY HONOR TO
CONTINUE FIGHTING FOR FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS.
THE DATA IS ALREADY AVAILABLE
THAT REDUCING TURNOVER IMPROVES
OVERALL HEALTH AND ACHIEVEMENT
OUTCOMES FOR FOSTER YOUTH. THE
RESILIENCY OF OUR FOSTER YOUTH
IN THE FACE OF COVERT NINETEEN
CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED. HOWEVER
PROVIDING FOR THEM SHOULD NOT
COME AT A FINANCIAL BURDEN TO
THOSE WHO DEDICATE THEIR LIVES
TO KEEPING THEM SAFE. AS WE RE
OPEN THE STATE. THE NUMBER OF
CASES OF CHILD ABUSE IS
EXPECTED TO RISE. WITH ACCESS
TO COURT MANDATED REPORTERS AND
WHEN THE NATURAL. SUPPORT OF
SCHOOLS. MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS
SPORTS COMMUNITY AND RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ARE AND EXTRA
CURRICULAR ACTIVITIES RETURNED.
CALIFORNIA WILL NEED EXPERIENCE
SOCIAL WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN
ESSENTIAL EMPLOYEES ON THE
FRONT LINES TO BE PREPARED.
THESE ARE THE CURRENTLY BEES OF
FOLKS ARE CURRENTLY THE LOWEST
PAID OF ALL CHILD SOCIAL WORKER
PROFESSIONALS. THIS MODEST ASK
WOULD REMEDY THE DELAND RATE
CHANGES FOR FFA'S THAT THE
STATE POSTPONED FROM TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. I'M ASKING THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND MY
FELLOW BUDGET SUB ONE MEMBERS
TO PRIORITIZE BRIGHT PRIORITIZE
THE FOSTER CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BY REALLY INVENT IT REINVESTING
THE FFA SOCIAL WORKER TIME
STUDY SAVING BACKED. UP INTO
THE SOCIAL WORKERS WHO ARE
CRITICAL TO THE WELL BEING AND
PERMANENT NANCY EFFORTS TO
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER YOUTH AND
CHILDREN. I DON'T I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK SPONSORS. AT THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES AND THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
FOR THEIR WORK AND MEETING WITH
ALL RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES AS
WELL AS BUDGET STAFF IN THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY- THESE
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE CRITICAL TO
THE WORK THAT WE DO. I AND I
KNOW WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THEM FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS I
CAN NOT UNDERSTAND AGAIN THE
IMPORTANCE OF THEIR WORK WITH
OUR FOSTER KIDS. THE ONE ISSUE
IF I MAY. THE OTHER ISSUE IS-
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR
THOUSAND FROM GENERAL FUND.
HEALTHY FUTURES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH I AND I HAVE A BILL AB
SIX. THREE SIXTY SIX- ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH AND
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW LAW I AM REQUESTING SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO ESTABLISH AN
EARLY INFANT SUPPLEMENT FOR
EXTENT THE EXPECTANT FOSTER
YOUTH. THREE MONTHS BEFORE THE
BIRTH OF THEIR CHILD. PRENATAL
INCOME SUPPLEMENTS ARE SHOWN TO
BE. NO MORTALITY STILL BIRTH.
AND THE LENGTH OF HOSPITAL STAY
FOLLOWING A COMPLICATED. LIFE
BIRD. YOUNG PEOPLE AND FOSTER
CARE ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THE
CURRENT CAL WORKS PRENATAL
INCOME BENEFIT. MANY OF THE
YOUTH IN CARE IDENTIFY AS BLACK
LATINO NATIVE AMERICAN ASIAN
AMERICAN OR PACIFIC ISLANDER.
ALMOST HALF OF FEMALE YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE IN CALIFORNIA WILL
HAVE BEEN PREGNANT AT LEAST
ONCE BY EIGHT BY EIGHT TO
NINETEEN. AND THAT RATE IS MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE RATE OF YOUNG
WOMEN WHO ARE NOT IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. PROVIDING THIS
BENEFIT WILL PUT A DIRECT END
TO PREVENTABLE DEATH AMONG
PARENTING YOUTH AND ADDRESS
EXISTING RACIAL AND GENDER
INEQUITIES IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. THIS IS AN UNFORTUNATE
EXAMPLE OF HOW THE INEQUITIES
DISCUSS TODAY. LEAD TO ENTER
GENERATIONAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
WITHOUT THIS BENEFIT CALIFORNIA
IS SAYING THAT BEING A FOSTER
YOUTH AND BEING A PARENT OUR-
COMORBIDITIES. CALIFORNIA IS
FAILING AS A PARENT. AND
GRANDPARENT TO THESE YOUTH WE-
ARE WE AS LEGISLATORS CAN DO
MORE TO IMPROVE HEALTH AND
BIRTH OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH IN
CARE AND THEIR CHILDREN AND
THEN THE SAME STEP EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS. I'M
ASKING THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND MY FATHER BUDGET
SUB ONE MEMBERS TO PRIORITIZE
HEALTHY FUTURES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH BY EXTENDING THE INFANT
SUPPLEMENT. CALIFORNIA CAN DO
MORE TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND SUPPORT THEM AS
HEALTHY YOUNG FAMILIES.
ADDITIONALLY CALIFORNIA
ENCOURAGE HIGH MEDICAL COSTS
RELATED TO MATERNAL MORTALITY
AND MORBIDITY STILLBIRTH
MISCARRIAGE AND COMPLICATED
PREGNANCIES THIS MODEST
EXPENDITURE WILL MORE THAN PAY
FOR ITSELF AND FUTURE SAVINGS
AS AN INVESTMENT TO PREVENTIVE
CARE. THROUGH ENDORSING THESE
ADVOCATES AND HAVING MET WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE GOAL IS
FOR THESE THESE MODEST ASKEDTO
BE INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE BUDGET. AGAIN DURING
THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE SEEN THE
DISPARITY BETWEEN THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE OFFER FOR OUR FIRST
YEAR THEY MIGHT REALLY THINK
THAT WE NEED TO INVEST NOW LOOK
TO PREVENT- MORE. TO PREVENT-
MORE DISPARITY IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO I WILL- NO MOVE TO
ASK A QUESTION OF KATHY
SANDERLING MCDONALD IF I CAN I
WAS HOPING THAT YOU COULD
EXPLAIN HOW THE RFA THAT
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESS RELATES TO PROP THIRTY
AND HOW THIS RESULTS IN YOUR
CONTINUING REQUEST. THANK YOU
MISTER SURE I'D BE HAPPY TO DO
THAT AT THE CENTER LANE WITH
THE WPA. SO OPPOSITION THIRTY
IN A NUTSHELL IS THAT ANY NEW
REQUIREMENT ENACTED. POSTED
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT. THAT
PROPOSITION THIRTY WHICH IS
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS OF
CONSTITUTIONAL RELATES TO THAT
HAS THE OVERALL EFFECT OF
INCREASING COSTS AND REALIGN
PROGRAM NEED ONLY BE
IMPLEMENTED TO THE EXTENT IT IS
FUNDED. AND SO IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT PROPOSITION THIRTY
REQUIREMENTS WERE MET WITH THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE FOR
LEGISLATION THAT LEGISLATION
INCLUDED A TRUE UP PROCESS. TO
ENSURE THAT NEW COSTS THAT ARE
COUNTY WOULDN'T HER ON THE
MARGIN WE'RE GOING TO BE
COVERED BY THE GENERAL FUND.
AND SO- IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
ORIGINAL CONTINUING CARE BILL
EIGHTY FOUR OH THREE IT CREATED
REQUIREMENTS ALL OVER THE PLACE
THAT WERE EXPANDED BUT THEY'RE
OFTEN BUILT ON THE TYPES OF.
ACTIVITIES ARE WORKERS ALREADY
DEAD SO- IN MOST COUNTIES THAT
FOR EXAMPLE WE DID ALREADY
APPROVED RELATIVE CAREGIVERS
AND DID SOME LICENSING OF NON
RELATIVE FOSTER PARENTS AS WELL
AND SO THE ADDITIONAL
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE IF THEY
REQUIRED WOULD BE THAT MARGINAL
COST INCREASE FOR THAT
PARTICULAR COMPONENT. OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IS A COUNTY%
TITLE BODIES OF THEIR LARGEST
COUNTY BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT THEY ACTUALLY DIDN'T
DO ANY OF THEIR OWN LICENSING
PRIOR TO THE C. R. SO TAKING ON
THAT ROLE WOULD. BE ENTIRELY
NEW FOR THEM FOR EXAMPLE. SO-
I'M THE PROPERTY THIRTY ALSO.
NOT DOES JUST APPLY TO STATURE
CHAIN. IT ALL APPLIES.
INSTRUCTIONS THE STATE ISSUES
SO ALL COUNTY LETTERS ALL
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTOR LETTERS
WHICH ARE TO. KEY WAYS THAT
THAT STATE COMMUNICATES WITH
OUR COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
DIRECTORS ALSO HAVE THE FORCE
OF LAW AND THEREFORE THEY ARE
ALSO COVERED BY PROPOSITION
THIRTY. SO THE QUESTION A LOOK
AT IN DECIDING HOW PROPOSITION
THIRTY APPLIES TO SOMETHING
LIKE THE RFA IS TO SEE. WHAT
WAS- EXPANDED REQUIRED AS A
RESULT OF THE LEGISLATION AND
THEN IT ALSO ANY SUBSEQUENT
INSTRUCTIONS THAT WERE PUT
TOGETHER. SO IRATE REFERRED
BRIEFLY TO THAT'S IN MY
TESTIMONY THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION THAT CREATED THE
IDEA OF MERGING TOGETHER THESE
PROPHECIES OF ARMS WIFE
SOMETHING OR APPROVING A FOSTER
PARENT. ALSO DOING PROPHECIES
RELATED TO HOME STUDIES THAT.
FORUM ADOPTION OR OTHER
PERMANENT THE THAT USED TO BE
DONE WAY DOWN THE LINE- WHAT WE
DECIDED- YES THIS CHILD IS NOT
GOING TO BE REUNIFIED
UNFORTUNATELY SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE INTO A PERMANENCY PLANNING
PROCESS. THOSE THINGS ARE
PRETTY SEPARATE IT SO THE IDEA
OF RFA WAS TO MERGE ALL THAT
TOGETHER. THAT LEGISLATION
WHICH WAS CARRIED BY WANTING
HIM LOCKED IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
AND SPONSORED BY CWPA CREATED
FIVE PILOT PROJECTS IT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH A STATEWIDE
MANDATE OF. THE SYSTEM BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T REALLY KNOW AT THAT
POINT IN TIME EXACTLY WHAT WAS
REQUIRED- BUT ASPECTS WOULD BE
NEEDED. AND SO THEN TWENTY
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT HAPPENED A
PROPOSITION THIRTY WITH ENACTED
AND THEN IN TWENTY FIFTEEN. AB
FOUR THREE CREATED THE
CONTINUOUS CARE FORM AND IT IS
THAT BILL PLUS THE SUBSEQUENT
INSTRUCTIONS THAT WERE SENT OUT
BY THE STATE THAT CREATED THE
STATEWIDE. MANDATE AND PUT MUCH
MORE STE AFTER A- THE OR PA AND
LAW SO WHEN THE ADMIN. SAYS NO
WE DO NOT NEED TO FOR YOU FOR
THE IN ACT RELATED TO OUR FAITH
BECAUSE IT EXISTED BEFORE THE
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT IT'S
JUST AN ACCURATE AND IT'S ALSO
INCONSISTENT I HAVE TO SAY WITH
ITS OWN PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INSTRUCTIONS. THAT STARTED
BEING ISSUED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT EVEN THEMSELVES
CLEARLY LIKE THE STATEWIDE
MANDATE WITH AB FOR A THREE NOT
WITH THAT EARLIER LEGISLATION
AND THAT'S WHY WE THINK THAT
OUR FAA DOES BELONG IN THE TRUE
UP AND ARE ASKING FOR THAT
FUNDING. I'M I MANAGED THE
DEPARTMENT TO RESPOND TO WHAT
CWD AID JUST SAID- AND IF YOU
WANT TO BRING IN DEAL LEFT
THAT'S OKAY AS WELL. THANK YOU
CHAIR KEN JOHNSON- MISTER
SERVICES MY WILL I DEFERRED MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I THINK YOU JUST
INCREASES BERMAN FINANCE- I
WILL I WOULD LIKE TO ADMIT THAT
I- THAT IT'S- MISTER IRVING
DIDN'T. PROVIDE AN ACCURATE
REPRESENTATION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN REALIGNMENT
THAT. UNDER PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN ANY NEW REQUIREMENTS
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES RELATED
ACTIVITIES AROUND LINES THAT'S
ENACTED AFTER THE AFTER TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. COUNTIES ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO UTILIZE OR DO
THAT WORK IN LAST PROVIDED
DEQUATE GENERAL FUND RESOURCES
TO THAT WORK- WITH REGARDS THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROGRAM I THINK THAT THE
CHALLENGER THE DIFFERENCE AT
THE- READING MINISTRATION IS
TAKING. HIM TO CBA'S POSITION
IS THAT I IS THE TIMELINE OF
LEGISLATION THAT ENACTED IT SO-
BROKE FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESS WAS ESTABLISHED
CORRECTLY AS AS WAS KNOWN AS A
PILOT PROGRAM. IN CHAPTER FOUR
SIX WERE STATUES UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN. INCLUDED THOUGH
AFTER THAT IN THE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN REALIGNMENTS- SB TEN
THIRTEEN WAS THE CHANGING
DIRECTION THAT I INCLUDED
AMENDING LANGUAGE AND DIRECTION
FOR COUNTIES ON WHAT
RESPONSIBILITIES WERE
REALIGNED. AND INCLUDED IN THIS
WAS A CHANGE FROM I MEAN ARE
EXCUSE ME AMENDING LANGUAGE
FROM PILOT COUNTIES TO EARLY
IMPLEMENTATION COUNTIES. SO
THIS RE CHARACTERIZATION OF THE
PILOT PROGRAM FROM BEING AN
INITIAL PHASE TO A PERMANENT
STATEWIDE PROGRAM HAS BEEN- SO
FOR THEM IN THE POSITION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH REGARDS TO
THE COMMENTS ON A BEFORE I DO
IS AB FOUR THREE THOSE RELATED
TO THE CONTINUING CARE REFORM-
PROGRAM THROUGH. THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES A LOT OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND SPECIFICALLY THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
RELATED TO THAT WERE MORE
TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
AMENDMENTS ARE RELATED TO S. B.
TEN THIRTEEN OF TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE SO. ON RECOGNIZING THAT
DAY THERE IS- CONTINUE
DISCUSSION MORE LIKELY GOING TO
CONTINUE ON THIS- I BELIEVE A
LOT OF IT COMES DOWN TO- THE
TIME I OF ONE. NGUYEN THE- WAS
AND- WHEN IT WAS CHANGE FROM
BEING A PILOT FOR. TO FOR
STATEWIDE CAN AMPLE. PROGRAM
AND ALL OF THE TAKEN TO BEFORE.
TO THE ELEVEN AND THEN THAT
BEING INCLUDED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN REALIGNMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES. I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION
OFFLINE I FOUND A PART OF THAT
RESPONSE- TROUBLING BUT WOULD
BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION WHERE. WE CAN HAVE
A PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE IN IT OR
HAVE PROCESS THAT'S RIGHT. BUT
BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD I'D LIKE
TO. EMPHASIZE THAT THE SUB
COMMITTEE REQUESTS THAT ARE
MADE IN THE AGENDA AT THE END
OF ISSUE FOR ON PAGE. SEVENTY
SIX AND- IF WE CAN. THOSE ARE
FIRST THAT WE FORM A WORKING
GROUP REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS INCLUDING
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS.
LEGISLATIVE STAFF THE L. A. O.
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE IN
PRINCIPLE CHILDREN'S ADVOCATES
AND TO MEET ON A REGULAR BASIS
BETWEEN NOW AND THE RELEASE OF
THE GOVERNORS MAY REVISION.
THIS WORKING GROUP WOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMPLEX AND INTERRELATED
QUESTIONS SUMMARIZED ABOVE
ABOUT C. C. R. IMPLEMENTATION
PANDEMIC RESPONSE AND THE
FAMILIES FIRST PROTECTION ACT.
TRAILER BILL TO BE RELEASED.
EXCUSE ME FAMILIES FIRST PRINT.
PROTECTIVE SERVICES ACT
IMPLEMENTATION AND PLANNING
WHICH WE ARE GOING TO WANT TO
THROUGH AN EQUITY LENS SECOND
WE'RE GOING TO ASK AS AN
OUTGROWTH OF THE ABOVEMENTIONED
WORKING GROUP AN EXPECTATION
WOULD BE SET FOR A SECOND
MODIFIED VERSION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RECENTLY
RELEASED FF PSA TRAILER BILL TO
BE RELEASED BEFORE OR WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION. THE
FEEDBACK ALREADY RECEIVED FROM
SOME OF THE ADVOCATES IS
SUBSTANTIAL AND COMPLICATED AND
THIS WOULD AFFORD THE
ADMINISTRATION AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ABSORB THE SUGGESTIONS AND
MAKE ANY NECESSARY CHANGES CAN
I ASK IF THERE IS ANY FEEDBACK
OR REACTION AT THIS TIME FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION TO THESE
REQUESTS. YES JUST PRAYS FOR
PLANTS CAN I JUST REITERATE OUR
COMMENTS EARLIER ABOUT
PRIORITIES- AND THEN- I'LL TAKE
THESE BACK FOR CONSIDERATION.
GREAT THANK YOU WITH THAT WE
WILL. THANK VERY MUCH PANEL FOR
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
FINAL PANEL OF THE DAY PANEL
FIVE ON FIRST STEPS TOWARDS
REALISING THE GOALS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN OF
AGING. WE HAVE FIFTEEN
PANELISTS FOR ISSUE FIVE
BEGINNING WITH DIRECTOR JOHNSON
DIRECTOR JOHNSON CAN YOU PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAN JOHNSON CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
I'LL START WITH PROVIDING US
SOME OF THE DEMOGRAPHICS THE
POPULATIONS THAT ARE SERVED IN
BOTH OUR IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES PROGRAM AND THOSE
RECEIVING SSI AND S. S. P. I
TREMENDOUS AND ADULT CRITICAL
ESSENTIAL PROGRAMS FOR OUR
POPULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA. OF
THE OVER SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE THOUSAND I. HSS RECIPIENTS
I WOULD WEEKS WE CAN LOOK AT AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOGRAPHICS
COMPARED TO THE I JUST LAST
POPULATION WE SEE OVER
REPRESENTATION IN THOSE THAT
ARE SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER- AGAIN
THE PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
SERVE. OUR ELDERS AND THOSE
WITH DISABILITIES ARE BACKED AT
IN TERMS OF SPECIFICS AND I
BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE DOES HAVE
POWER POINT SLIDES THAT HAS
THIS IN DETAIL- USE OUR
CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO SEVENTEEN
AS RECIPIENTS ARE 8% OF ALL I
JUST S. RECIPIENTS THOSE
EIGHTEEN TO FORTY FOUR FOURTEEN
PERCENT. AND AGAIN FORTY FIVE
ALSO TO SEVENTY FIVE- IS ABOUT
40% AND SEVENTY FIVE AND OLDER-
IT'S OVER 35% IN TERMS OF THE-
AT GENDER. ARE THERE IS NO FOR
OVERREPRESENTED. OF FEMALE
FEMALES IN I JUST AS PROGRAM AT
FIFTY NINE PERCENT. OF THE
POPULATION. M. S. 50% OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S THE OVER
REPRESENTATION IN TERMS OF RACE.
WE SEE IN TERMS OF RATES OVER
REPRESENTATION OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN POPULATION AS COMPARED
TO THE STATE'S POPULATION AS
WELL AS- THOSE AT THEIR THAT
COULD INCLUDE MULTIRACIAL IN
OTHER CATEGORIES MORE
SPECIFICALLY ALL AT ALL I JUST
AS RECIPIENTS 30% OUR
CONCLUSION OR WHITE 21% ASIAN
AMERICAN 30% TO SPINNAKER
LATINO. 14% AFRICAN AMERICAN
I'M A LITTLE LESS UNDER 1%
NATIVE AMERICAN AND AGAIN WE
HAVE- ABOUT 4% THAT ARE NOT
IDENTIFIED IN TERMS AT SS I SS
P. ONE POINT OVER ONE POINT ONE
MILLION RECIPIENTS. I WE SEE
54% ARE FEMALE- AND AGAIN
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF AN OVER
REPRESENTATIO BASED ON THE
STATE'S POPULATION IN TERMS OF
AGE WE SEE THAT THOSE ZERO TO
SEVENTEEN ARE 8% OF THOSE
RECEIVING SSI EIGHTEEN TO FORTY
FOUR FOURTEEN PERCENT- 4526422%
6527520% IN THOSE SEVENTY FIVE
AND OLDER. AGAIN AT ABOUT 35%
AND IN TERMS OF RACE FOR THIS
POPULATION. WIDER CARCASE IS
18% ASIAN AMERICAN 10% HISPANIC
OR LATINO 13% AFRICAN AMERICAN
OR BLACK EIGHT PERCENT. AND WE
DO HAVE A VERY LARGE PORTION OF
THAT ARE NOT IDENTIFIED BY RACE
OF OVER 50% SIDE I'LL NOTE THAT
FOR THE DEMOGRAPHICS. THE
QUESTION WAS ALSO OPPOSED TO
THE DEPARTMENT RELATED TO
CONCERNS WHETHER WE HAVE
CONCERNS AROUND ACCESS TO
EITHER OF THESE RESOURCES AND
BENEFITS. AND AS MENTIONED
EARLIER IN THROUGHOUT THIS-
PANEL IN TODAY. WE OBVIOUSLY
ARE ALWAYS OPEN AND ALWAYS
THINKING THROUGH HOW WE CAN
REFINE OUR APPROACHES TO ACCESS
ENSURE THAT THAT'S READILY
AVAILABLE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC WE DID SEE A
SLIGHT DECREASE IN CASELOAD IN
THE I JUST S. AT PROGRAM THAN
WHAT WE ANTICIPATED. HOWEVER
THE CASE LOOK QUICKLY ABOUNDS
BACK WE PROJECT A TWO POINT 7%
INCREASE IN BUDGET. AND OF
COURSE THAT NUMBER WILL BE
UPLOADED EXCUSE ME UPDATED IN
BAY REVISION. IN TERMS OF THE
SS I SS P. CASELOAD WE HAVE
SEEN A SLIGHT DECLINE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND THAT'S
MAINLY DUE TO THE FACTORS.
AROUND ELIGIBILITY REMAINING IN
AND CHANGED SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE SO WE PROJECT A
DECREASE OF A LITTLE OVER 1% IN
BUDGET YEAR AND AGAIN WE'LL
UPDATE THAT NUMBER IN MAY
REVISION. OF COURSE WE DO HAVE
SOME FOCUSED EFFORTS IN THE
SPACES AROUND CONNECTION TO THE
COMMENTS AGAIN OF A PREVIOUS
PANEL- ARE R. H. STAFF PROGRAM
AND OTHERWISE IN AGAIN AS I
MENTIONED ALWAYS LOOKING TO
REFINE OUR ABILITY TO REACH
THOSE THAT ARE ELIGIBLE. AND
THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM DEBBIE
THOMPSON THE ADULT PROGRAMS
DIVISION DEPUTY DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA. DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. HI DIDN'T
AFTERNOON CHAIR. THANK YOU OUR
MEMBERS. I AM GOING TO BE
ADDRESSING THE QUESTIONS FROM
THE AGENDA INCLUDING. THE ARMS.
THE AFFECT OF THE 7% HOURS
REDUCTION WHAT THAT WOULD HAVE
ON THE ISS PROGRAM IF IT WERE
IN ACTED- JUST TO BE. REALLY
CLEAR THE 7% REDUCTION HAS NOT
BEEN IMPLEMENTED FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS AND IS NOT A PROPOSED
TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. ON IT HAS PREVIOUSLY BEEN
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO-
IMPLEMENTED AND WE KNOW THAT IT
IS A CHALLENGE FOR OUR OUR
RECIPIENTS CENTER PROVIDERS
WHEN THAT OCCURS. SO WE'RE VERY
SENSITIVE TO THAT TO THAT
SITUATION. AND THEN WITH
REGARDS TO THE PURCHASING POWER
FOR THAT AS A SITE G. SS I SS
PETE GRANT AND HOW THAT CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND- HOMELESSNESS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS ON THAT
RECEIVE THAT BENEFIT- WE KNOW
THAT THAT. BENEFIT HAS
CONTINUED TO BE VERY CLOSE TO
THE POVERTY LEVEL AND THAT THAT
PRESENTS A LOT OF CHALLENGES
FOR FOLKS THAT ARE AREN'T
RECEIVING THAT BENEFIT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. LOOKS AT THIS
ISSUE REGULARLY A COUPLE YEARS
AGO NOW- THERE WAS A CHANGE
THAT- THAT ALLOWED NASA SCIENCE
IS THE RECIPIENTS TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS CALFRESH WE BELIEVE THAT
WAS. A POSITIVE- IMPACTS TO
THAT POPULATION AND BEING ABLE
TO HAVE BETTER FOOD SECURITY
AND WE KNOW THAT THE NEW
PROPOSAL THAT IS THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION- FOR
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION TO
HELP. MITIGATE THE STABILITY OF
THE BOARDING CHAIRS- AND THAT'S
THE SCIENCES P. RECIPIENTS-
ACCESS TO THAT. THOSE OF THE
SOUL ARE NEEDED AND ALSO PUT
HOW SOME. SOME BENEFIT TO THEM
IS A FOCUS OF DISCUSSION
ONGOING LEE AND WAS A PART OF
THE DISCUSSION WITH THE MASTER
PLAN AND WE CONTINUETO LOOK
FOR WAYS TO SUPPORT THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND- HELP THEM BE
STABLE WITH WITH MEETING THEIR
HOUSING AS WELL AS- FOOD AND
OTHER. NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO BE
STABLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL MOVE NOW TO DIRECTOR
KIMBERLY MCCOY WADE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM QUITE AWAY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN
AND BUDGET AND DEPARTMENT OF
AGING. OFF FIRST YOU ARE
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT BUDGET
INVESTMENTS FOR THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING IT AGAIN AS YOU HAVE
HEARD ARE THERE ARE MANY
LAYERED INTO DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND SOCIAL
SERVICES. I SEE A COUPLE THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO LIFT UP. OUR FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PLACEHOLDER FOR
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
IMPLEMENTATION PARTNER BEIJING-
PLAYS THE ROLE OF SUPPORTING
ALL DEPARTMENTS AND ALL
AGENCIES IMPLEMENTING THEIR
AGING AGENDAS AND COORDINATING
IT AND EVERYBODY ACCOUNTABILITY
AND STAKEHOLDER OVERSIGHT AND
INPUT. ALSO THAT'S OKAY A KEY-
BUDGET INVESTMENT AS WELL AS
THE NEW GOVERNOR'S OFFICE A
SENIOR ADVISER ON AGING
DISABILITY AN ALICE HYMERS HIS
PROPOSED. A SECOND- AND- WE
WOULD SAY MARQUIS PROPOSAL IS
TO CREATE THAT NO WRONG DOOR
SYSTEM STATEWIDE. SO THAT ANY
OLDER PERSON OR PERSON
DISABILITY OR FAMILY CAREGIVER
CAN EASILY FIND THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO NAVIGATE TO THE
SERVICES THEY NEED- THE NO
WRONG DOOR EIGHTY R. C. IS
PROPOSED TO GO STATEWIDE IN IN
THE BUDGET. I WOULD THROUGH
THROUGH GRANTS TO OUR NETWORK
OF- AREA AGENCIES ON AGING AND
APARTMENT REHABILITATION'S.
NETWORK OF INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS. FATHERS ALL THE IT
CONTINUE. OF THE- SEVENTY POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR NUTRITION
SUSPENSION DATAS ARE SHIFTED AS
ASTHE OVERALL BUDGET APPROACH
AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER YEAR OF
INVESTMENT ARE CRITICAL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS- AND THEN
SOMETIME EXTENSION TO SPEND.
THE ONE TIME INVESTMENT OF
FALLS PREVENTION MONEY ARE
CRITICAL TO KEEPING. OLDER
ADULTS SAFE AT HOME. OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY. ARE THERE ARE YOU
MENTIONED- AND MRS P. AND- BUT
THOSE ARE NOT SPECIFICALLY-
INVESTED. IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND THEN JUST ONE QUICK
NOTE ON THE OVERALL CONTEXT- AS
WE'VE HEARD FROM OTHER
DIRECTORS. THE FORCED- FEDERAL
AID PACKAGE IS ON ITS WAY UP
WITH THE LATEST ONE ARE
PROVIDING AT CLOSE TO A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION. DOLLARS FOR
THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT PROGRAM
SO THERE CONTINUES TO BE I
NEEDED. A AND VITAL. FEDERAL
SUPPORT IN THE MIX AS WELL. YOU
ALSO HAVE SPECIFICALLY BUT HER
SHE WOULD SHOWS REMAIN OUR
LARGEST PROGRAM. LIKE ALL MEALS
PROGRAMS WE EXPANDED AND OF
COURSE COMMITTED FROM A MIX OF
HOME DELIVERED. AND CONGREGATE
MEALS LIKE YOU MIGHT SEE A
SENIOR CENTER ARE THOSE ALL
WENT HOME- AND SO I'M VERY
PROUD OF OUR NETWORK THAT NOT
ONLY DID WE PUT IT TO BE
ENTIRELY HOME DELIVERY. WE GREW
BY CLOSE 260% A YEAR TO YEAR SO
WE WENT FROM EIGHTEEN MILLION
MEALS IN 201-922-0222 TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION MEALS IN TWENTY
TWENTY. ON NEARLY 60% INCREASE
AND THAT WAS A COMBINATION OF
FACTORS THAT WAS PEOPLE WE
ALREADY SERVE WHO NEEDED MORE
MEALS THEY STAYED HOME. IT WAS
PEOPLE WHO WERE STAYING HOME I
TEMPORARILY WHICH COURSE
DRAGGED ON FOR CONTINUE TO DRAG
ON. AND SO NO WAIT NO LONGER
ABLE TO GO TO CONGREGATE MEAL
SITE OR MAYBE HAVE FAMILY
SUPPORT OR DO GROCERY SHOPPING.
WE HAVE FOLKS NEED NEWLY IN
NEED OF AND THAT IS GOING TO
PERSIST BECAUSE OF A HEALTH
CHANGE OR FAMILY SITUATION
CHANGER HOUSING CHANGE. AND
THEN OF COURSE WE JUST HAVE A
WHOLE LOT MORE AWARENESS-
THANKS IN PART TO. THE GREAT
PLACE PROGRAM AND OTHER
PARTNERSHIPS THAT REALLY
EXPANDED MEALS WHEN PEOPLE
NEEDED IT. SO WE ARE. VERY MUCH
MINDFUL OF. THE OLDEST EXPAND
IN THE- FOR FINE. WHETHER IT'S
IN TELL. GRAY PLACE TO THE
OLDER MAN. ACT OF MEALS ON
WHEELS PROGRAMS HOW DO WE
CONTINUE TO MEET THE NEED MATCH
THE RIGHT. NUTRITION SUPPORT
WITH WITH FOLKS WHEN AND WHERE
THEY NEEDED. AND WE HAVE OUR
EYE ON A COMING CLIFF OF
FEDERAL FUNDS AGAIN WITH THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN WE'VE GOT.
MORE FUNDS AND MORE TIME BUT
REALLY WANT TO MANAGE- AT THAT
AND SO THAT NEEDS ASSESSMENTS
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US GOING FORWARD IN THE POST
CODE LANDSCAPE. AND THEN
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT OUR
NETWORK. WITH BETTER DATA
SYSTEMS AND INFRASTRUCTURE SO
WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO MEET THE
NEEDS. THE LAST QUESTION YOU
ASKED. ABOUT BOTH- MYSELF AND
MY COLLEAGUE LONG TERM CARE-
BUT CERTAIN HIGHEST PRIORITY
CHALLENGES. AND HERE'S THE
THREE THAT WERE FOCUSED ON.
RECOVERING FROM KOBE NINETEEN
THE DEVASTATING IMPACT ON OLDER
CALIFORNIANS THAT OUR FAMILIES.
OUT RENDERING INEQUITIES BY
RACE AND AGE AND GENDER THAT
ARE OUT. REALLY MAKING AGING
EXPERIENCE VERY DIFFERENT AND
VERY LIKABLE IN CALIFORNIA. IN
THREE REBUILDING BETTER WE'RE
NOT GOING BACK TO THE WAY WE
DID THINGS WE HAVE LEARNED TOO
MUCH INCOME TO FAR SO HOW DO WE
REBUILD BETTER SO WE'RE GONNA
BE LASER FOCUSED ON HOME AND
COMMUNITY SERVICES THAT ALLOW
PEOPLE TO STAY AT HOME. AND
AVOID UNNECESSARY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE PROGRAMS THE
FOOD PROGRAMS THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS THAT HELP
PEOPLE THRIVE AT HOME AND THEN
AS I HANDED OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE TO THE STATE LONG
TERM CARE ON BUT- ALSO THE
SECOND PRIORITY IS- WHAT CAN WE
DO TO INTEGRATE IN A
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES BASED
NURSING HOME SPACE. WHERE OF
FAR TOO MANY NEARLY A THIRD
240% OF DEATHS THAT HAPPEN
DESPITE BEING LESS THAN 1% OF
THE POPULATION. SO THERE'S SO
MANY LESSONS TO LEARN TO GO
FORWARD IN OUR NURSING HOME AND
RESIDENTIAL SPACE- AND THEN
LASTLY. WE TAKE OUR ROLE VERY
SERIOUSLY AS UP ENGAGING AROUND
AGING COMMUNICATING AROUND AGE
AND THAT DOESN'T JUST MEAN
INFORMATION ABOUT SERVICES AND
ASSISTANCE IT ALSO MEANS
COMMUNICATING ABOUT AGEISM AND
RACISM AND OF COURSE AT THIS
MOMENT THE PARTICULAR TAX ON. A
OLDER API'S IN IN OUR STATE AND
OUR NATION AND SO THAT THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE FOCUSED IS
ADDRESSING AGEISM- INNOVATING
IN NURSING HOMES AND EXPANDING
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES SO WE CAN ALL THRIVE
IN THE HOMES WE CHOOSE. SO WITH
THAT- I WILL SAY ALL OF THAT
WORK DEPENDS ON DEEP DEEP DEEP
PARTNERSHIPS. WITH OUR LOCAL
LEADERS AGING IS IN YOUR HOME
IN OUR COMMUNITY SO I WANT TO
JUST THANK IN ADVANCE OUR
PARTNERS IN PARTICULAR FROM
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING IN
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS BUT
ALSO THE COUNTIES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES HAVE
BEEN TREMENDOUS PARTNERS IN
RESPONDING TO COBIT AND
THINKING ABOUT THE WAY FORWARD
AND OF COURSE THE COMMISSION ON
AGING. SO WITH THAT I'LL FINISH
AND JUST I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT- AS- GEORGIE GETS COMES
NEXT ALL HE HAS BEEN OUR STATE
LONG TERM CARE ON BUT FOR
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS. AND I WILL
BE RETIRING SHORTLY SO THIS
WILL BE LAST UP HERE AND WITH
THE WHICH IS. TO AT TAKE THIS
PHONE TO POP THANK HIM FOR HIS
SERVICE AND THING YOU FOR THE-
TO DO SO. THANK YOU DIRECTOR-
WITHOUT ADO JOE RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ANYWAY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
DIRECTOR WAIT FOR THOSE
COMMENTS- THE MISSION OF THE
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM IS TO SEEK RESOLUTION
OF PROBLEMS AND ADVOCATE FOR
THE RIGHTS OF RESIDENTS OF LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES. IT WITH
THE GOAL OF ENSURING THEIR
DIGNITY THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE
AND THEIR QUALITY OF CARE. WE
MONITORING ADVOCATE FOR CHANGES
IN LAWS AND REGULATIONS. AND
POLICIES TO BENEFIT RESIDENTS
BY TAKING POSITIONS ON BILLS
THE PROVIDING TESTIMONY TO THE
LEGISLATURE. SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED THROUGH THIRTY FIVE
LOCAL OMBUDSMAN ENTITIES WITH
TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE PART TIME
AND FULL TIME PAID STAFF AND
FIVE HUNDRED AND. EIGHT
VOLUNTEER OMBUDSMEN
REPRESENTATIVES. I WOULD YEAR
REPRESENTATIVES RECEIVED
TRAINING ON HOW TO SAFELY
CONDUCT VISITS WITH THE
APPROPRIATE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED
TO US BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES. DESPITE
BEING LOCKED OUT OF LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES A YEAR AGO AND
FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THIS
PAST YEAR ALMOST
REPRESENTATIVES INVESTIGATED
MORE THAN TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
COMPLAINTS. MADE BY OR ON
BEHALF OF RESIDENTS. WE
PROVIDED INFORMATION AND
ASSISTANCE TO MORE THAN SIX
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
AND THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
FACILITIES STAFF. WE MADE
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND FOURTEEN
SIXTY FOUR VISITS TO LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES TO MONITOR.
MONITOR CONDITIONS AND
FACILITIES AND RESPOND TO
COMPLAINTS. LOCAL ALARM BUZZER
PROGRAMS REPORT THAT OVER THE
PAST YEAR ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THEY HAVE FACED IS TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND AND EXPLAIN ALL THE
GUIDANCE THAT HAS BEEN ISSUED
BY THE LICENSING AND REGULATORY
AGENCIES. HE NEED TO CARE
LICENSING AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ISSUEDEIGHTY
PROVIDER INFORMATION NOTICES
WHILE LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE EIGHTY
FIVE ALL FACILITY LETTERS SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF TWENTY TWENTY.
A RELATED CHALLENGE WAS HOW
THAT GUIDANCE WAS INTERPRETED
DIFFERENTLY BY REGULATORS
FACILITIES STAFF AND ENVOYS AND
REPRESENTATIVES. INITIALLY
VOLUNTEER ON BUT THE
REPRESENTATIVES WERE VERY
RELUCTANT TO GO INTO LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES THE FEAR OF
CONTRACTING CORONAVIRUS.
RINGING THE VIRUS INTO THE
FACILITY ARENA VIRUS HOME TO
THEIR FAMILIES. MANY ON BUT THE
REPRESENTATIVES ARE IN AT RISK
GROUPS. MANY STAFF OR OLDER
ADULTS THEMSELVES AND COULD BE
RELUCTANT AS WELL. IN JUST ONE
YEAR WE HAVE LOST TWO HUNDRED
NINE VOLUNTEERS WERE RESIGNED
MOSTLY BECAUSE OF A RELUCTANCE
TO GOING TO FACILITIES. LOCAL
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO
BE MORE RELIANT ON STAFF TO
CONDUCT THE WORK OF THE OFFICE.
LOCAL PROGRAMS WILL NEED
RESOURCES TO HIRE STAFF UNTIL
WE ARE ABLE TO CONDUCT A
STATEWIDE VOLUNTEER RECRUITMENT
INITIATIVE. VIRTUAL VISITS
WHICH WE PERMITTED TO DURING
THE PANDEMIC USING SMARTPHONES
AND TABLETS ARE NOT AN IDEAL
FORM OF COMMUNICATION. MANY
RESIDENTS ARE RELIANT UPON
FACILITIES STAFF TO FACILITATE
THIS CONTACT. CONCERNS ABOUT
PRIVACY AND CONFIDENTIALITY ARE
RAISED BY THIS PRACTICE. IT MAY
BE ALSO DIFFICULT FOR SOME
RESIDENTS TO HEAR SEE OR
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS BEING SAID
INVICRO. OVER THE PAST YEAR
TESTING FROM BUZZING
REPRESENTATIVES IT'S BEEN A
STRUGGLE AT TIMES DEPENDING ON
THE AVAILABILITY OF TESTING AND
THE FREQUENCY OF TESTING.
REPRESENTATIVES MAKING VISITS
TO FACILITIES NOW ARE TESTED
WEEKLY. WHEN POSITIVITY RATES
IN THE COUNTY EXCEEDED 10%
RESIDENT REPRESENTATIVES WERE
BEING TESTED TWICE A WEEK.
DURING THE HOLIDAYS THIS BECAME
A REAL CHALLENGE. I AM
ENCOURAGED BY THE VACCINATIONS
OF RESIDENTS FACILITIES STAFF
NUMBERS AND REPRESENTATIVES
CASES ARE DOWN CONSIDERABLY
VISITS TO DISABILITIES BY ON BY
THE REPRESENTATIVES ARE GOING
UP. WHEN WE FINALLY RESTARTED
OUR VISIT IN JULY OF LAST YEAR
WE MADE APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY VISITS A
MONTH OF JULY. LAST MONTH
FEBRUARY ON BY THE
REPRESENTATIVES MADE MORE THAN
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED VISITS TO
FACILITIES. WITH THE CENTERS
FOR MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
SERVICES RECENT DIRECTION THE
FACILITY SHOULD ALWAYS ALLOW
RESPONSIBLE INDOOR AND OUTDOOR
VISITATION FOR ALL RESIDENTS
REGARDLESS OF VACCINATION
STATUS OF THE RESIDENT FOR THE
VISITORS. I'M HOPING THAT WE
TURNED A CORNER AND RESIDENTS
WILL BE ABLE TO SEE AND HOLD
THEIR LOVED ONES AGAIN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU STERN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PUBLIC SERVICE. NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FROM JACKIE
BOROUGH SEAL FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
HEY JACKIE BURKE ROCHELLE WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE. I'M
IN RESPONSE TO THE FIRST
QUESTION IN THE AGENDA AND THIS
PAST FALL OUR OFFICE LOOKED
INTO LTSS PROGRAM CAPACITY IN
THE STATE IN WHICH WE FOUND
THAT THE AVAILABILITY AND
UTILIZATION OF LTSS PROGRAMS IS
UNEVEN ACROSS THE STATE I'M AS
IT RELATES TO AVAILABILITY SOME
LTSS PROGRAMS- ARE NOT
AVAILABLE IN ALL COUNTIES AND
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT CAN
BE SERVED IN SOME PROGRAMS IS
CAPPED. IN TERMS OF UTILIZATION
WE LOOKED AT WHAT SHARE OF
MEDICAL SENIORS AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES ARE ENROLLED
IN DIFFERENT LTSS PROGRAMS IN
EVERY COUNTY AND IN COMPARING
THOSE UTILIZATION RATES ACROSS
COUNTIES WE FOUND THAT LTSS
UTILIZATION TENDS TO BE LOWER
AND EASTERN SIERRA COUNTIES.
AND UTILIZATION RATES TEND TO
BE HIGHER AND I'M THREE
PARTICULAR URBAN COUNTY
SPECIFICALLY SAN FRANCISCO LOS
ANGELES AND ORANGE THE
VARIATION IN UTILIZATION RATES
ACROSS COUNTIES MAY BE
INDICATIVE AB ACCESS ISSUES
EITHER BECAUSE PROGRAMS ARE NOT
AVAILABLE IN SOME COUNTIES OR
THERE MAY BE POTENTIAL BARRIERS
AND PROVIDING SERVICES TO ALL
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS IN CERTAIN
AREAS. AS FAR. OF FUTURE DEMAND
WE IDENTIFIED- CERTAIN ELEMENTS
THAT MAY IMPACT DEMAND TRENDS
SUCH AS- THE FACT THAT THE
SENIOR POPULATION IS PROJECTED
TO INCREASE AT A FASTER RATE
THAN THE STATE'S POPULATION AS
A WHOLE. ALSO THE FACT THAT THE
SENIOR POPULATION IS BECOMING
MORE RACIALLY AND ETHNICALLY
DIVERSE AND SENIORS ARE
PROJECTED TO LIVE LONGER AND
THAT MATTERS BECAUSE FOR THOSE
PARTICULAR SUBGROUPS. I'M THEY
TEND TO HAVE HIGHER DISABILITY
RATES MEANING THAT THE SHARE
SENIORS OR THE NUMBER OF
SENIORS I'M IN PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES THAT MAY REQUIRE
LTSS SERVICES- MAY BE GREATER
IN THE FUTURE. IN DETERMINING
THE OF THE ABILITY OF THE STATE
OF STATE LTSS PROGRAMS TO THEN
RESPONDS TO POTENTIAL RISING
DEMAND WE ASSESS THE
FLEXIBILITY AND ADAPTABILITY OF
CURRENT PROGRAM DESIGN AND
RULES. FOR EXAMPLE LIKE I
MENTIONED BEFORE SOME PROGRAMS
ARE CONSTRAINED- IN THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT THEY CAN STARVE-
ADDITIONALLY SOME PROGRAMS ARE
CONSTRAINED- IN PROVIDING
SERVICES ANY FIXED FACILITY
SETTING. ADDITIONALLY SOME
PROGRAMS MAY BE SUBJECT TO
CERTAIN MEDIC CAL ELIGIBILITY
RULES I'M THAT LIMIT THE NUMBER
OF SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES THEY CAN START.
WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATORS THAT START UP
COSTS ARE A BARRIER TO
EXPANDING SERVICES IN NEW
COUNTIES AND ADDITIONALLY
REGIONAL VARIATION IN THE
AVAILABILITY OF PROVIDERS- ALSO
PRESENTS A CHALLENGE I'M IN
MEETINGS NOT ONLY CURRENT
POSSIBLY FUTURE PROGRAM DEMAND.
MOVING ON TO THE SECOND
QUESTION- WHEN IT COMES TO
ACCESSIBILITY WITHIN THE I JUST
AS ENORMOUS AS P. PROGRAM AND I
JUST SAYS WE HAVE HEARD
ANECDOTALLY THAT THE
AVAILABILITY OF PROVIDERS I'M
SPECIFICALLY IN AREAS IN WHICH
RECIPIENTS ARE EIGHT AND IT FOR
RECIPIENTS THAT LIVE IN
ISOLATED AREAS OR HAVE COMPLEX
CARE NEEDS- MAYBE- LIMIT.
ACCESSIBILITY LEVELS AND IN THE
CASE OF M. S. S. P. THE FACT
THAT THE PROGRAM IS NOT
AVAILABLE IN ALL COUNTIES BUT
ALSO- PARTICIPATION IS CAPPED
ALSO PRESENT ACCESSIBILITY
ISSUES. WHEN IT COMES TO
FRAGMENTATION BEYOND THE
LIMITED AVAILABILITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY ISSUES I'VE
ALREADY DISCUSSED ANOTHER
FORMER FRAGMENTATION THAT OUR
OFFICE HAS EXPLORED THAT
APPLIES TO ALL LTSS PROGRAMS
INCLUDES FRAGMENTATION IN THE
AND TAKE AN ASSESSMENT PROCESS.
SO WHILE LTSS PROGRAMS MAY HAVE
SIMILAR ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AN INDIVIDUAL
NAMED STILL NEEDS TO GO THROUGH
SEPARATE INTAKE ASSESSMENT
PROCESS SEES FOR EACH PROGRAM.
SO NOT ONLY DOES THAT PRESENT-
DUPLICATIVE ADMINISTRATIVELY
INEFFICIENT PRACTICE SAYS BUT
FOR THE RECIPIENT AND MAY ALSO
PRESENT CARE COORDINATION
ISSUES IF THE INFORMATION
COLLECTED IN ONE PROGRAM IS IT
NECESSARILY ACCESSIBLE OR
SHARED WITH- CARE PROVIDERS-
CARE COORDINATORS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS. THAT WOULD THEN HELP
TO BETTER ASSESS ANY POTENTIAL
SERVICE GAPS FOR THAT RESPOND
FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL AND WHEN IT
COMES TO DEMOGRAPHICS AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE THE SENIOR
POPULATION IS PROJECTED TO BE
MORE RACIALLY IN COAL AND I'M
CULTURALLY DIVERSE AND THAT
JUST RAISES QUESTIONS. FOR ALL
LTSS PROGRAMS ON LANGUAGE
ACCESS AND CULTURAL COMPETENCY
OF CULTURAL COMPETENCY OF CARE.
ALSO THE INCREASING NUMBER OF
SENIORS WITH DISABILITIES AND
POSSIBLY MORE SENIORS WITH
COMPLEX CARE NEEDS RAISES
QUESTIONS ABOUT HAVING THE
ADEQUATE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS TO
NOT ONLY MEET THAT POTENTIAL
INCREASING DEMAND OF SERVICES
BUT ALSO THE SPECIFIC CARE
NEEDS OF EACH INDIVIDUAL.
MOVING ON TO THE THIRD
QUESTION. ONE WAY IN WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CHANGE
PROGRAM AVAILABILITY- IS BY
CHANGING THE PROGRAM RULES AND
DESIGN ELEMENTS THAT I LISTED
BEFORE. I'M THAT COULD INCLUDE
INCREASING OR REMOVING I'M JUST
A PARTICIPATION CAPS FOR SOME
PROGRAMS IT COULD ALSO INCLUDE
EXPLORING ON THE BENEFITS AND
TRADE OFFS OF PROVIDING SOME
LEVEL OF STATE ASSISTANCE TO
PROGRAMS SO- SO THAT THEY CAN
EXPAND TO OTHER COUNTIES- BY
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE WITH THOSE
START UP COSTS- AND THINGS LIKE
THAT. MOVING ON TO THE FOURTH
QUESTION- WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SUSPENSION LANGUAGE OUR OFFICE
VIEWS THE SUSPENSION MECHANISM
AS TREATING ONGOING PROGRAM
COST AS TEMPORARY WHICH
FUNDAMENTALLY UNDERSTATES THE
TRUE ONGOING COST OF THE
STATE'S POLICY COMMITMENTS IN
THOSE PROGRAMS. FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE CASE OF I JUST LAST WHICH
IS AN ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM THE
SUSPENSION LANGUAGE TREATS A
PORTION OF THE I. JUST A
SERVICE HOURS. AS TEMPORARY
WHEREAS I JUST A SERVICE HOURS
REFLECT BE ASSESSED LEVEL OF.
I'M SERVICES NEEDED BY AN
INDIVIDUAL ON AN ONGOING BASIS
TO REMAIN IN THEIR HOME.
ADDITIONALLY AUTOMATING THE
SUSPENSION OF FUNDING FOR
CERTAIN PROGRAMS HINDERS THE
LEGISLATURE- FROM WEIGHING THE
TRADE OFFS OF ALL POSSIBLE
OPTIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
CONSIDERING HOW TO MANAGE ANY
PROJECTED BUDGET SHORTFALL THAT
COULD MATERIALIZE IN FUTURE
BUDGET YEARS. THUS WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO MAINTAIN
THE BUDGET BILL SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE. I'M MOVING ON TO THE
FIFTH QUESTION WITHIN THE
AGENDA- WE WOULD JUST FLAG THAT
DURING COLD IN NINETEEN THE
STATE HAS IT AND DID
IMPLEMENTED MANY PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITIES TO REDUCE FACE TO
FACE. INTERACTIONS AND MAINTAIN
SERVICE DELIVERY FOR RECIPIENTS
FOR EXAMPLE- WITHIN THE I JUSTAS PROGRAM THE STATE
ESTABLISHED AN EMERGENCY BACKUP
PROVIDER SYSTEM IN EVERY COUNTY
OVERALL THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO REQUEST FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION A LIST OF THOSE
COPING NINETEEN PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITIES ACROSS- I JUST
SAYS EXERCISE IS P. R. A. P. S.
WHAT IMPACT DID THOSE
FLEXIBILITIES HAVE. ON
RETAINING INDIVIDUALS WITHIN
THE PROGRAM AND WHAT ARE THE
BENEFITS AND TRADE OFFS AND
MAINTAINING THOSE PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITIES. BEYOND COPE AT
NINETEEN. AS FOR THE LAST
QUESTION. AND THE I JUST US
RECIPIENT I JUST AS RECIPIENTS
WHO LOSE THEIR MEDICAID
ELIGIBILITY BECAUSE- THEY DID
NOT COMPLETE THE ANNUAL MEDICAL
RENEWAL PROCESS I'M CURRENTLY
ARE EXPECTED TO BE MANUALLY
TERMINATED FROM THE I JUST US
PROGRAM I'M MEANING THAT THEY
CAN ONLY RETURN ONCE THEY RE
ESTABLISH THEIR MEDIC CAL
HOWEVER NOT EVERYONE WHO LOSES
THEIR MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY IS
MANUALLY TERMINATED FOR MIGHT
JUST US. SO WHEN THAT HAPPENS
THE RECIPIENT IS- INTERNALLY
TRANSFERRED INTO THE I JUST AS
RESIDUAL PROGRAM MEANING THAT
SERVICES ARE BEING FULLY PAID
FOR BY THE STATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WOULD
AUTOMATE THE TERMINATION
PROCESS FOR I JUST SAYS WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL DOES LOSE THEIR
MEDICAID ELIGIBILITY I'M SO
THAT EFFECTIVELY THEN
ELIMINATES THE POSSIBILITY THAT
A RECIPIENT WHO LOSES THEIR
MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY DUE TO NOT
COMPLETING THE MEDIC OUR NEW
ALL PROCESS- THEY WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE SERVICES
THROUGH THE I JUST RESIDUAL
PROGRAM- AND ENSURES THAT EVERY
RECIPIENT WOULD THEN NEED TO
FIRST RAIN ROLL INTO MEDIC CAL.
BEFORE THE- BEGIN TO RECEIVE
PAID SERVICES. THROUGH I JUST
US AGAIN. THE ADMINISTRATION IS
THAT ALL I JUST AS RECENT AND
BY THIS ITEM PROCESS. BE
REINSTATED INTO MEDIC CAL WILL
RETURN TO AYE IT JUST SAYS WILL
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE SERVICES
FROM THEIR PROVIDER DURING THAT
GAP IN MEDIC CALLIN I JUST AS
ELIGIBILITY AND THAT THE
PROVIDER WILL BE RETROACTIVELY
REIMBURSE FOR THOSE SERVICES
PROVIDED IN THE GAP. IN
ELIGIBILITY HOWEVER IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT SOME RECIPIENTS
MAY EXPERIENCE THE DESTRUCTION
CARE OR MAY NOT RETURN TO
MEDICAL OR I JUST SIZE- SO IF
THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO ADOPT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
WE WOULD SUGGEST ASKING THE
DEPARTMENT TO MONITOR AND
REPORT BACK ON ONE. HOW LONG IT
TAKES A RECIPIENT TO REINSTATE
THEIR MEDIC HAL AND I JUST
ELIGIBILITY. TO WHAT EXTENT DID
RECIPIENTS EXPERIENCE OF
DESTRUCTION AND CARE AND THREE
THE NUMBER OF RECIPIENTS HOLDEN
BELIEVE MAY NOT HAVE RETURNED
TOO MANY CALORIES JUST LAST.
ALL IF THE LEGISLATURE DID NOT
ADOPT THAT GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
IT COULD CONSIDER WHETHER THE I
JUST AS RESIDUAL PROGRAM- COULD
SERVE AS A TEMPORARY SAFETY NET
FOR ALL RECIPIENTS WERE
TEMPORARILY- HER TERMINATED
FROM MEDIC HELL AND NO LONGER
RECEIVE I JUST ASK AS A MEDICAL
BENEFIT. AS FOR THE SECOND HALF
OF THE QUESTION IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT SINCE
CURRENTLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS SUSPENDED MEDI
CAL RENEWALS FOR THE DURATION
OF THE COLBERT NINETEEN
DECLARATION. THAT ESSENTIALLY
MEANS THAT NO RECIPIENT IS AT
RISK OF LOSING I JUST ASK- DUE
TO LOSING THEIR MEDIC HOW- BY
NOT COMPLETING THE RENEWAL
PROCESS. BUT WHILE MEDICAL
RENEWALS ARE TEMPORALLY
SUSPENDED IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT SOME
RECIPIENTS MAY STILL BE
RECEIVING THEIR MEDICAL RENEWAL
PACKETS. AND IT'S UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT'S LARGELY DUE TO THE
FACT THAT IN SOME COUNTIES THE
MAILING OF THOSE PACKETS IS-
AUTOMATICALLY CODED WITHIN THE
SYSTEM. HOWEVER AGAIN
RECIPIENTS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
FILL OUT OR SUBMIT THOSE MEDIC
CAL ANNUAL RENEWAL PACKETS BUT
IF THEY DO COUNTIES ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO PROCESS THOSE
PACKETS. HOWEVER ONCE AND THE
NATIONAL DECLARATION ENDS IT IS
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT BASED
OFF OF RECENT FEDERAL GUIDANCE
THE STATE WILL BE REQUIRED TO
GO BACK AND COMPLETE THOSE
RENEWALS THAT WERE TEMPORARILY
SUSPENDED WITHIN A SIX MONTH
TIME PERIOD. SO THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO REQUEST ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON. HOW WILL
ENSURE THAT RECIPIENTS ARE
AWARE OF THAT MEDICARE WOULD
NEW WILL RETURN TO TAKE RETURN
WE DIRT REDETERMINATION CHANGE
AND THE POSSIBLE INTERACTING
AFFECTS BETWEEN. COUNTIES
PROCESSING THAT BUILDUP A MEDIC
CAL RENEWALS WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AUTOMATED
I JUST S. TERMINATION PROCESS.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM JOHN
LEWIS THE AUDIT PRINCIPAL FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- JOHN LEWIS
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE I'VE BEEN ASKED TO TALK
ABOUT OUR FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM OUR
FEBRUARY. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AUDIT OF THE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM I'M
GONNA FOCUS ON THREE AREAS- IN
THE PRESENTATION I'M GOING TO
TRY TO BE AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE-
WE'LL TALK ABOUT HOW THE NEED
FOR CARE IS GROWING. THE DELAYS
IN APPROVAL AND PROVISION OF
CARE AND THE FACT THAT I AGES
OF WORKERS MAKE- AT OR NEAR
MINIMUM WAGE WHICH IS FAIRLY
FAR OFF FROM A LIVING WAGE IN
CALIFORNIA- THE WRONG THINGS
THAT WE WERE ASKED TO LOOK AT
BY THE LEGISLATURE- IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND.
RECIPIENTS ON AVERAGE EACH
MONTH DID NOT RECEIVE CARE.
THIS NUMBER IS UP FROM TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHEN IT WAS ABOUT
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND. A PERSON
PERSPECTIVE OVER THE FIVE YEAR
PERIOD THAT AMOUNTS TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO MILLION
HOURS OF CARE. THAT WERE
APPROVED. BUT HAD NOT BEEN
PROVIDED. ARE THESE GAPS IN
CARE CAN OCCUR FOR A LOT OF
REASONS. INCLUDING ANY
INABILITY TO HIRE A CARE GIVER
OR- AN INSTANCE WHERE A
RECIPIENT HAS MOVED. AND
THEY'RE HAVING TROUBLE FINDING
A NEW CARE GIVER. STATE LAW
REQUIRES COUNTIES TO ENSURE THE
CARE IS PROVIDED. THROUGH IHS
TO ALL RECIPIENTS- AND THIRTY
TWO OF FIFTY ONE COUNTIES THAT
WE SURVEYED ABOUT THIS
RESPONDED THAT THEY LACKED A
SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF CARE
GIVERS TO PROVIDE ALL
RECIPIENTS WITH APPROVED
SERVICES. THIS IS BECOMING MORE
IMPORTANT AS ABOTH LOCAL
SERVICES IN THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE POINTED OUT
BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF THE
INDIVIDUALS OVER SIXTY FIVE IS
GROWING. AND THEY ALSO
REPRESENT THE MAJORITY OF IT
JUSTICE RECIPIENT- WE ESTIMATE
THAT BY THE END OF THE DECADE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE SERVED
THROUGH I. HFS COULD GROW FROM
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND. TO
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
THAT'S A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
JUMP- AND IT WILL REQUIRE MORE
CARE GIVERS. B. WE FOUND IN OUR
AUDIT THAT- COUNTIES ARE TAKING
AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT SEVENTY TWO
DAYS. TO APPROVED APPLICANTS
FOR I. H. AT THE THIRD OF THE-
SO PER THE REQUIRED COUNTY TO
DO THIS IN ABOUT THIRTY DAYS
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SOME
EXCEPTIONS. WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTDOESN'T TRACK THOSE
EXCEPTIONS- MORE SPECIFICALLY
MOST RECIPIENTS COMING TO THE
PROGRAM RECEIVE SERVICES FROM A
FAMILY MEMBER OR FOR SOMEONE
CLOSE TO THEM BASICALLY THEY
COME TO THE PROGRAM WITH A
RECIPIENT. HOWEVER A LARGE
NUMBER OF ABOUT 15% OF THE
RECALL DON'T. AND THAT NUMBER
IS LIKELY TO GROW OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS OF THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
REPORTED THE DEMOGRAPHICS ARE
ARE JUST GETTING OLDER BUT
THEY'RE CHANGING YOU HAVE
FAMILIES WHERE THEY'RE LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE BEEN MARRIED OR
LOOK LIKELY TO HAVE CHILDREN
WHO WOULD BE WATCHING THEM THIS
IS GOING TO REQUIRE AN EVEN
GREATER FOCUS ON NON FAMILY
CAREGIVERS ON GETTING
RECIPIENTS MATCHED WITH CARE
GIVERS. THEY DON'T ALREADY KNOW
THAT THEY HAVEN'T ALREADY
ARRANGED FOR- ONE OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS IS THAT
COUNTIES BEGIN TO CONDUCT
PLANNING AROUND. THE PROVISION
OF CARE. THIS IS ACTUALLY
REQUIREMENT IN STATE LAW AND
IT'S BEEN IN STATE LAW FOR
QUITE SOME TIME. BUT COUNTY IS
NOT A COUNTIES NORTH OF FOCAL
BERMAN COULD PROVIDE US WITH AN
EXAMPLE OF ANY ANY ANNUAL
REPORT THAT ANY COUNTY HAD DONE
IT'S BEEN SO LONG SINCE THEY
DONE DAYS- SO WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THE COUNTIES BEGIN
DOING SO IMMEDIATELY AND THAT
THEY INCLUDE IN. THESE ANNUAL
REPORTS- AN EXAMINATION OF.
WHAT FUTURE NEEDS MIGHT BE- IN
OUR SURVEY ONLY TWO COUNTIES
REPORTED CONDUCTING ANY KIND OF
PLANNING FOR CURRENT OR FUTURE
CARE GIVER NEEDS BUT AGAIN NO
ONE HAD SUBMITTED THESE PLANS
OFFICIALLY TO SOCIAL SERVICE.
BOB DE FINAL ELEMENT WE LOOKED
AT WAGES CAREGIVER WAGES
COMPARE THEM TO THE LIVING WAGE
AS CALCULATED BY THE
MASSACHUSETTS INSTITUTE OF
TECHNOLOGY- ON AVERAGE ACROSS
THE STATE IN TWENTY NINETEEN
CARE GIVERS EARNED A LITTLE
OVER TWELVE DOLLARS AN HOUR.
THE LIVING WAGE AT THAT TIME
WAS ABOUT TWENTY ONE DOLLARS AN
HOUR THAT'S A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT GAP- IN THE FOUR
COUNTIES THAT WE LOOKED AT IN
DETAIL THEY ALL HAD SIMILAR
GAPS. THE RESULT OF THIS IS
THAT AS COUNTIES NEED TO
RECRUIT CAREGIVERS IN THE
FUTURE THESE LOWER WAGES MAY
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO FIND CARE GIVERS ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE BROUGHT UP WAS
THAT- SOME ELEMENTS OF STATE
LAW PENALIZE COUNTY THAT GET
AHEAD OF THE MINIMUM WAGE AND
TRY TO RAISE CAREGIVER WAGES A
LITTLE BIT IN ADVANCE OF WHEN
THE MINIMUM WAGE GOES UP. AND
BECAUSE OF THAT A LOT OF
COUNTIES HAD BACKTRACKED YOU.
JUST PROVIDING MINIMUM WAGE- I
JUST THE CARE GIVERS ALTHOUGH A
RECENT CHANGE IN LAW HAS HAVE
RELAXED THAT SOMEONE IN THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF COUNTIES NOW
THAT HAVE PAID TO THEIR- AGES
AS WE DO. TO THE MINIMUM WAGE.
AND THEY'RE A TO ALLOW HIM TO
RAISE THEM A LITTLE BIT ABOVE.
THE MINIMUM WAGE. BUT WHEN
THESE WAGES STAY THAT LOW. THEY
ARE COMPETITIVE WITH OTHER LOW
WAGE JOBS AND SO FINDING THESE
CARE GIVERS CAN BECOME A
CHALLENGE- OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THIS AREA INCLUDED- AGAIN
GETTING RID OF THIS PENALTY
THAT- COUNTIES HAVE TO PAY
EXTRA IF THEY GET AHEAD OF THE
MINIMUM WAGE. AND ALSO- THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER
SOME BUDGET AUGMENTATION FOR
COUNTIES ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH
A WIDE GAP BETWEEN. THE
CAREGIVER WAGES IN THE LIVING
WAGE YOU TO HELP THEM RAISE
CAREGIVER WAGES SO. MIKE HELLO
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM BEVERLY YOU
STATE GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR THE UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS ASK ME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST BEVERLY YOU ON
BEHALF OF YOU W. ASKED ME LOCAL
THREE NINE THIRTY REPRESENTING
OVER A HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
HOME CARE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
IN THIRTY NINE COUNTIES THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
HEARING TODAY AND THANKS ALSO
TO THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
FOR WORKING WITH US REQUEST THE
AUDIT. AS YOU JUST HEARD FROM
MR LEWIS THE IG SAYS PROGRAM IS
IN CRISIS BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF PREPARATION AND LOW WAGES
THE NEED FOR CARISBROOKE FAR
FASTER THAN THE CARE WORKFORCE
CAN MEET. UNLESS WE TAKE ACTION
NOW TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
PROVIDERS THOUSANDS OF OLDER
ADULTS INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES MINGLING CARED FOR
FACE UNNECESSARY INSTITUTIONAL
CARE. IN REGARDS TO THE
QUESTION WHICH INITIATIVES
PROVIDES THIS PROGRAM ONE OF
THE BEST WAYS TO GROW TO CARE
WORK FORCES TO MAKE CONDITIONS
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL CONDUCIVE
TO PAY INCREASES THEIR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
HISTORICALLY THE NON FEDERAL
SHARE OF COSTS FOR LOCALLY
NEGOTIATED WAGE AND BENEFIT
INCREASES I JUST AS HAS BEEN
65% PAID BY THE STATE. AND 35%
PAID BY THE COUNTY. SB EIGHTY
TWENTY NO. THE FUNDING FORMULA
WILL SLIP IN JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. IS THAT CALIFORNIA
SHOULD MAINTAIN ITS
RESPONSIBILITY AS 65% AND A
COUNTY HAVE SIXTY ACT 35%
EXCUSE ME IN ORDER FOR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS TO REACH ANY
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS. ALONG
WITH SEIU IN THE COUNTIES WE
PROPOSE RESCINDING THE SIXTY
FIVE THIRTY FIVE COST FLIP
MAINTAINING THE 10% OVER THREE
YEARS SCHOOL AND THE STATE CAN
ALSO PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
ADDRESSING THIS CARE CRISIS BY
PERMANENTLY RESTORING THE 7%
CUT TO ENSURE RECIPIENTS DON'T
LOSE ANY ADDITIONAL HOURS TO
CARE AS IDENTIFIED BY THE AUDIT.
MOVING ALONG TO DRESS THE
QUESTION CAN EFFECTIVE SENTENCE
BE CREATED TO FACILITATE LOCAL
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS NUMBER OF I JUST AS
WAGES AND BENEFITS. OUR ANSWER
IS ABSOLUTELY. WELL YOU W. S.
YEAH YOU SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING GOING TO THE COUNTIES
TO MAINTAIN EXISTING BARGAINING
TOOLS. BOTH UNITS ARE
REQUESTING YOUR CONSIDERATION
FOR A STRONGER PENALTY FOR
COUNTIES THAT DO NOT BARGAIN IN
GOOD FAITH TO BRING THESE
COUNTIES TO THE TABLE. THE
TOOLS WE AREREQUESTING WITH
THE COUNTY SHOULD NOT BE A
SUBSTITUTE FOR THE PENALTY AS
THE COUNTY'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THE LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED A
1% FISCAL COUNTY ON COUNTY SAID
DO NOT BURKE IN GOOD FAITH. AS
WELL AS A FACT FINDING
MEDIATION PROCESS. IS TALL
EXPIRED JANUARY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR IT DIDN'T WORK BECAUSE IT
WASN'T STRONG ENOUGH. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE PROOF TAKE A LOOK AT
KERN COUNTY THAT HAS A HAD A
CONTRACT FOR THREE AND A HALF
YEARS. YOU COUNTY FOR SIX AND A
HALF YEARS AND LASSEN COUNTY AS
THE ONLY COUNTY THAT HAVE THE
1% PENALTY ASSESSED. NEVER
REACH THE CONTRACT. WHAT WILL
WORK TO GET THIS THESE WERE.
COUNTY TO COME TO THE TABLE IS
A 10% FISCAL PENALTY. I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THE ONLY COUNTIES WILL
FAIL TO BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH
WILL. BE IMPACTED BY THIS
PENALTY. AND THE PENALTY WITH A
SENSE. LOWERING THE AMOUNT OF
FOR. THE COUNTY WE RECEIVE FROM
THE STATE FOR THE I JUST AS
PROGRAM. BY 10% ANNUALLY ON
AUTOMATICALLY SO LONG AS THERE
ISN'T A CONTRACT IN PLACE. THE
REASON WHY WE ARE SEEKING THIS
PROPOSAL IS BECAUSE WE HAVE NO
OTHER LEVERAGE AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE. WE NEED YOUR
HELP TO HOLD CERTAIN COUNTIES
ACCOUNTABLE. OVER FORTY
PROVIDERS HAVE WRITTEN INTO
THIS COMMITTEE DAY HUNDREDS
EXPRESSING SUPPORT. A PROVIDERS
ARE PREDOMINANTLY WOMEN OF
COLOR J. MINIMUM WAGE FOR JUST
ABOUT MIDDLE WAYS FOR HELPING
OVER HALF A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVE AT HOME AND
COMFORT AND DIGNITY. WAGES HAVE
GONE UP BECAUSE OF THE STATE
MINIMUM WAGE SCHEDULE AND
THERE'S STILL A FRACTION OF THE
ACTUAL LIVING. THING WHICH WAS
COUNTIES TO OFFER HEALTH
BENEFITS PAID TIME OFF
RETIREMENT BENEFITS PROVIDERS
ONLY QUALIFY FOR THE ANNUAL PAY
SICK LEAVE BENEFIT OF TWO DAYS
AND THANKFULLY TEMPORARY
PANDEMIC PROVISIONS. ARMADA'S
PROPOSALS ARE TREATED
INAPPROPRIATELY IN SOME
COUNTIES WITH LACK OF SERIOUS
ENGAGEMENT. WE RECOGNIZE THAT
BY AND LARGE COUNTIES ARE
HONEST BROKERS AND BARGAIN IN
GOOD FAITH WITH US AND HE'S CON.
AND CONTRACTS. AT THIS POINT
THERE ARE ONLY THREE COUNTIES
OF OUT OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
THEY'RE GOING TO FACT FINDING
IN OUR MEDIATION THIS IS LASSEN
CURRENT VIEW AGAIN. AND WHICH
WE WOULD CONSIDER USING THIS
TOOL AND THIS TOOL WILL NOT
AUTOMATICALLY TRIGGER COUNTY
FOR COUNTIES IT IS TRULY A LAST
RESORT AFTER LENGTHY
NEGOTIATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE BE
COUNTY THAT'S HAD A CONTRACT
EXPIRED OVER SIX AND A HALF
YEARS. HASN'T EVEN MOVED TO THE
FACT FINDING PROCESS YET. IN
ORDER FOR THE PENALTY MOVED
FOR. WARD AFTER DECLARING
IMPASSE MEDIATION FACT FINDING
THE FACT FINDER WHO IS THAT YOU
ALREADY HAVE TO ROLL NAY YES
FAVOR AND RESULTS ARE NON
BINDING. THE COUNTY ALSO AT
LEAST HAS NINETY DAYS AFTER THE
RELEASE OF THE FAX FACT
FINDING- RECOMMENDATIONS TO
REACH AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
UNION. AND EVEN AFTER THE UNION
FILES FOR THE PALI WITH CURB
THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL APPEALS
PROCESS FOR THE COUNTY TO
JUSTIFY THEIR CLAIMS BEFORE PER
MAKES A DETERMINATION. WE
BELIEVE A 10% FISCAL POLICY
SHOULD BE A REASONABLE TOOL
WITH DUE PROCESS THAT WOULD
HELP ENCOURAGE A VERY SMALL
NUMBER OF COUNTIES WERE
BARGAINING IS PROVING TO BE
DIFFICULT TO MOVE NEGOTIATIONS
FORWARD. I WANT CLOSE BY SAYING
THAT I JUST PROVIDERS ARE
FRONTLINE. FOR TO BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THE WAGE INEQUITIES THE
CHALLENGES RECRUITMENT
RETENTION OF THIS WORKFORCE AND
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR
SUBPOENAS TO THIS PROPOSAL
TAKES STEPS TOWARDS THE MASTER
PLAN CALLS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO TIFFANY WHITEN SENIOR
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ADVOCATE
WITH SEIU. ANY RIGHT BUT THAT'S
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
LONG TERM CARE UNION
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND NURSING HOME WORKERS
PRIVATE AGENCY AND I'D JUST AS
WORKERS I WILL BE RESPONDING TO
THREE QUESTION TODAY. FIRST
WHAT ARE THE CRITICAL WORKFORCE
NEEDS FOR AGES SAYS AND WHAT
WOULD IMPROVE THE SITUATION FOR
THE PROGRAM EXISTING AND
ANTICIPATED WORK FOR SHORTAGES
AND HOME CARE COVER OVER THE
COMING YEARS UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE AGES THAT'S
WORK WORK FORCE AND THE NEED TO
ALLEVIATE AND LEVERAGE THEIR
ROLE IN HELPING TO KEEP
CONSUMERS SAFE IN THEIR HOMES
AND COMMUNITIES. DON'T GROWING
AGING POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA
MAKES HOME CARE ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING OCCUPATIONS IN
THE STATE WITH PROJECTED GROWTH
OF 32% BETWEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AT TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
ACCORDING TO EIGHTY DELAYED
MARKET STATISTICS I JUST AS
WORKERS PLAY A KEY ROLE IN
BALANCING A HISTORIC
INSTITUTIONAL BIAS AND HELPING
CONSUMERS REMAIN IN THEIR
PREFERRED SETTING. BUT THIS JOB
BUT THERE'S JOB PRINCE
PRESCRIPTIONS WITH IN HOME CARE
AND I IT JUST SAYS ARE
CHALLENGING TO ADDRESS GROWING
DEMAND ALONGSIDE. RESTRAINTS
APPLY IT SHOULD BE A LITTLE BIT
BACK OF RETURN THREE
OPPORTUNITY AND RETIRED
SECURITY. I THE AUDIT
HIGHLIGHTS. LIVING WAGE ARE NOT
PROVIDED IN THE PROBE. WITH
ALMOST ALL COUNTY AFTER THEM
WAGE. THE MULTIPLY EFFECT I
THINK WAGE FOR THIS IS. LOW
INCOME. IS A STEP. RETIREMENTS
IS OUT OF REACH FOR MANY I.
PROVIDERS PER. THE MAY PARA AND
SPOUSE. WHO ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR SOCIAL. WHICH IS ALSO NOT
AN ADEQUATE SOURCE OF
RETIREMENT INCOME ON ITS OWN.
THERE'S NO CAREER LADDER AND
LIMITED TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN AYE HE JUST SAYS AND I
JUST SAYS PROVIDERS MUST LOOK
OUTSIDE OF HOME CARE IF THEY
WANT CAREER ADVANCEMENT. ONLY
SERVING TO REINFORCE THE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. TRAINING
HAS SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS ON
CONSUMER AND PROVIDER STATUS
THE SATISFACTION AND CREATING
CAREER PATHWAYS CAN HELP WITH
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION.
TRAINING HAS ALSO BEEN SHOWN TO
IMPROVE CONSUMERS HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND UTILIZATION RATES
BENEFITS THAT HAVE BROADER COST
SAVING IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
STATE'S HEALTH CARE COSTS.
THESE TYPE OF INVESTMENTS WITH
STABILIZE THE WORKFORCE AND
IMPROVE CARE DELIVERY AND HAVE
FAR REACHING IMPACTS ON THE
STATE'S HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. AND
SOCIAL SAFETY NET- THE SECOND.
WHAT WERE THE COME. OF OUR
REDUCTIONS THAT OCCURRED AS
PART OF PAST BUDGET DEALS AND
WHAT ARE THE LESSONS WELL
REDUCTIONS IN HOURS IN PREVIOUS
BUDGETS HAVE HAD DEVASTATING
IMPACTS ON ARE YOU JUST AS
CONSUMERS AND PROVIDERS.
CONSUMERS AND PROVIDERS HAVE TO
MAKE IT DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE DECISIONS ON WHICH
SERVICES TO CUT SERVICES THAT
WERE FUNDAMENTAL TO BEING ABLE
TO REMAIN SAFELY IN THEIR HOMES
SUCH AS BATHING PARAMEDICAL
SERVICES LAUNDRY AND HOUSE
CLEANING. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
MANY PROVIDERS WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK THE SAME AMOUNT OF HOURS
EVEN AFTER CUTS WERE INSTITUTED.
IS CENTRALLY MOVING THE WORK
UNDERGROUND SO IT WENT
UNRECOGNIZED. AND UNPAID TO
CARE FOR THEIR CONSUMER. AND I
AM JUST SO DUMB THE OF HOURS IS
TO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE THE
PROGRAM DOES NOT PAY FOR TWENTY
FOUR HOUR CARE SO IF THE
PROVIDER IS TAKING CARE OF
SOMEONE WITH DEMENTIA OR
SOMEONE WHO NEEDS PROTECTIVE
SUPERVISION. BUT THEY ARE OFTEN
PROVIDING MANY HOURS OF CARE
THAT ARE THAT ALREADY GO UNPAID
SO WE HAVE LEARNED THAT
REDUCTIONS IN HOURS JUST AS LOW
WAGE WORKERS TO DO MORE WITH
LESS. AND PUSHES THEM FURTHER
INTO POVERTY BY THE CONSUMER
GOES POTENTIALLY WITHOUT VITAL
SERVICES. PASS REDUCTIONS HAVE
FORCED SOME PROVIDERS TO LEAVE
THE WORK FORCE. ULTIMATELY
CONTRIBUTING TO THE WORKER
SHORTAGE ISSUE EVEN MORE WELL
WE APPRECIATE THE EXTENSION OF
THE 7% SUSPENSION AND THIS
YEAR'S PROPOSED BUDGET TODAY A
7% REDUCTION IN HOURS WHAT
AMOUNTS TO OVER FIVE MILLION
HOURS PER MONTH. THAT WILL GO
UNMET FOR CONSUMERS AND I'M
PAID TO THIS LOW WAGE WORKFORCE
THERE ARE OVER FIFTY SIX
ORGANIZATIONS ASKING FOR A
REMOVER OF THE SUSPENSION DATE
AND A PERMANENT RESTORATION. OF
THE SEPARATE FOR THINK CUT. SO
THE- LESSONS LEARN FROM K. IS A
SPEECH NOT BALANCE ITS BUDGE.
ON THE BACKS OF WAGE WORKERS
AND DOUBLES PARTNER. TO HANG
THIS CUT- OVER WELCOME. AND
PROVIDERS THE OUT YEARS SIMPLY
BROUGHT THANK. I'M AN
UNACCEPTABLE. THIRD AND LAST
WEEK HOW DOES OR SHOULD AGES AS
AS A PROGRAM IT INTO THE
THINKING AROUND- THE MASTER
PLAN. I DO JUST AS IS THE
STATE'S CORNERSTONE LTSS
PROGRAM FUNDING STABILITY FOR
THE PROGRAM THAT PROMOTES PRO-
FUNDING STABILITY FOR THE
PROGRAM THAT PROMOTES PROGRAM
PROGRAMMATIC THE BILL-
SUSTAINABILITY IS VITAL ONE OF
THE FIVE BOLD GOALS OF THE NPA
IS TO CREATE CARE GIVING THAT
WORKS. WITH THE TARGET OF
CREATING ONE MILLION HIGH
QUALITY DIRA CARE JOBS OVER THE
NEXT DECADE. REACHING THAT
TARGET WILL BE NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE WITHOUT FOCUSING ON
THE AGES AS WORKFORCE A LARGE
MAJORITY OF THE AGES THAT'S
WORKFORCE ARE WOMEN OF COLOR
AND IMMIGRANTS. IF THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE ARE IN FACT
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING LTSS TO
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE.
THROUGH A LENS OF EQUITY IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE AGES AS
WORKFORCE BE PAID LIVABLE WAGES
WITH BENEFITS AND SAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS. THE STATE OWES IT
NOT ONLY TO THE PROVIDERS OF
THE SERVICE BUT ALSO THOSE
RECEIVING THE CARE AS WELL.
HISTORICALLY I HSS HAS BEEN
CARVED OUT OF FEDERAL AND STATE
BENEFITS THAT OTHER WORKERS
RECEIVE EXAMPLES INCLUDES SICK
LEAVE AND OVERTIME.
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT REIMAGINE
AGING AND OUR STATE OVER THE
NEXT DECADE WITHOUT INCLUDING
AYE AGES AS PART OF THE
DISCUSSION. AS THE CABINET
LEVEL WORKGROUP CONCLUDED IN
THE FINAL IN PA. THE CARE
GIVING WORK FORCE. CAN BE GROWN
THROUGH CHARACTER TRAY. AND
PROFESSIONAL THE- I. ALONG WITH
LIVABLE BY. JOB PLACE SUPPLY
AND IMPROVE JOB. HI WAGES WILL
HELP PAY CARE GIVERS WORK
TOWARD FINANCIAL. ALLEVIATE
ECONOMIC DISPARITIES AND BETTER
REFLECT THE VALUE OF THEIR WORK
THIS INCLUDES THE AGES THAT'S
WORKFORCE I'M THANK YOU SO MUCH
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. I
APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT YOU
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU
HAVE GIVEN TO ME TODAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM JUSTIN GARRETT
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. THANK
YOU I CHAIRED MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY MY NAME'S
JUSTIN KERR I'M THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO SPEAK TO ACT
OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING BUT
JUST WANT TO QUICKLY- YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE BROAD SCOPE OF THIS
PANEL ON THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING JUST WANT
TO. SHARE THE COUNTY THEY'RE
FULLY COMMITTED TO PARTNERING
WITH ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE ALIMENTATION AND
EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY.
I MOVING TO THE FOR QUESTION I
THE- FOR COUNTY JUST QUIT
BARGAIN. THE MINISTER AND LET.
INDICATING YEARS STRONG. IN AN
INCREASED NUMBER OF COLLECTIVE.
AGREEMENTS I'M PLEASED TO
REPORT THE COUNTY JUST THERE IS
SICK. INTO CROP. AND REACH
COLLECTED BY AGREEMENT TO
INCREASE WAGES IN BENEFITS FOR
I JUST PROVIDERS. FORTY SIX
COUNTIES COVERING MORE THAN 95%
OF THE ACTORS PROVIDE WORKFORCE.
I PERSONALLY INCREASE WEIGHT IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND INVESTED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN COUNTY FUNDING FOR WAGE
INCREASES. THAT'S PROGRESS
STARTING WITH THE INTRODUCTION
OF NEW COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
TOOLS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. I'M
XCELERATED BY THE LOWERED
COUNTY I SEVEN MILLION TWENTY
NINETEEN WITH TWENTY SIX COUNTY
REGION AGREEMENT. THAT EMILY
WAS AN ACTIVE. AS SIGNIFICANTLY
ABOVE THE STORE PAYS FOR NEW.
FOR THOSE TWELVE REMAINING. WE
ARE CURRENTLY TO GO. SIX ARE
WAITING FOR THE NEED TO. COUNTY
OR- TO REACH AND ONLY THREE
HAVE GONE TO FACT FINE OR ME.
THANK QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
THAT'S MAY. THERE'S OF THEM
HAVE LED THE THINK NUMBER
AGREEMENTS. AFTER HE DOES.
SHARING RATIO WITH A COW PAYS
FIVE. IN THE STATE 60% OF THE
NON SHARE COSTS FOR LOCAL AGE
CREASES TO THE STATE INSPECTION
CAP. SECOND IS THE SUPPLEMENT
TO WHICH WAS QUITE SEVENTEEN
AND ALLOWS COUNTIES INCREASE.
AND HOW A PERMIT FLOAT. ABOVE
THE- IN STATEMENT WAGE. AND TO.
PAY IN TWENTY. IS KNOWN AS- 10%
OF THREE YEARS TOOL AND ALLOWS
THE COUNTY TO. STATE ABOVE THE
A. K. OF THE CAP WITH A DEFINED
AMOUNT OF PERCENT OF THE COUNT
TOTAL DOESN'T BENEFITS. SO ALL
CAN THAT HAVING WAY TO TWENTY.
IF UTILIZED THE WEIGHT THE- TO.
AND HAS BEEN FIFTH COUNTY THAT
IT HAD. THE CAP AND THE NEEDED
THE TEMP. OF THREE YEARS TO ON.
I THE LAST QUESTION OF THE UP
TO CHANGES IN OUR- AS- NOTED BY.
YOU NEEDED UP ON JAN. FIRST
TWENTY TWO TWO. AT TWO OF THE
SUN MEXICAN MACINNES. ARE GOING
CHANGE A WAY THAT WILL IT MORE.
TO REACH AGREE. AS AND HOW
SHARING. WILL AND COUNTIES ARE.
WITH TO BE AND AT THE YOU. ON
THE CALL BUDGET PROPOSAL THE
WOULD INSTEAD KEEP THE CURRENT.
STATE COUNTY SHARE RATIO. THE
SECOND COMPONENT OF OUR JOINT.
IS TO ALL MAINTAIN THE
TEMPERATURE. OVER TO YEARS TO
ALL. I WANT TO THANK. MEMBER
THE HOUSE HIS LEADER. ON THIS
BUDGET AT. THE CURRENT LAW
COUNTY MUST. EIGHT YEAR PERIOD
BY. FOR TWENTY TWO IS LIMITED
TO YOU OF THIS TOOL. I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO COUNT THERE ABOVE
OR NEAR THE- POTENTIALLY. TO
AND THEN NEGOCIE. WE PROPOSE
THAT THE BEST B. X. BE. GENDER
FIRST TWO TWENTY. AND A COUNTY
WILL BE ABLE TO YOU THAT TO.
THAN TWO. WITHOUT THE- OF THE
SPA MAKING. PRAGUE AND I THAT'S
CLICK TO BARGAINING LIKELY JUST.
ASK COSTS RELATING. WERE NEARLY.
I WOULD NO LONGER BE SUSTAIN.
AND BECAUSE THE GOAL OF A FIVE
THAT CAN. I IN TWENTY NINE. AT
THIS ALSO THAT IMPACTS FOR
OTHER PROGRAMS WILL REALIZE.
CODING PUBLIC HEALTH AND-
HEALTH. CAN INCREASE WAGES EVEN
DURING TIMES WHEN THE EMILY BUT
NOTHING A BILL. WHEN THERE WAS
NO PENALTY PROVISION IN PLACE
AND DURING THE PANDEMIC INDUCE
RECESSION. BUT DESPITE ALL THE
PROGRESS ON COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING THERE IS NOW A NEW
PENALTY PROPOSAL. THAT IS TEN
TIMES GREATER THAN WHAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY AGREED TO LESS THAN
TWO YEARS AGO. ALL COUNTY
THEY'RE COMPLYING WITH THE LAW
CONTINUE NEGOTIATING GOOD
FAITH. WITH LOCAL PROVIDER
UNION EVEN THOUGH COUNTY THAT
HAVE NOT YET REACHED AGREEMENT.
ALL THE FROM UW'S WHOLLY
INAPPROPRIATE BECAUSE OF
REPRESENT THE STATE DICTATING
THE OUTCOME OF LOCAL COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AND WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. IN THE STATE'S
INTERNIST INTERESTED IN
MANDATING A HIGHER WAGE FOR ALL
LICENSED PROVIDERS. THERE ARE
OTHER OPTIONS TO ACHIEVE THAT
GOAL. THIS INCLUDES THE STATE
ASSUMING RESPONSIBILITY FOR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING OR
PROVIDING DEDICATED STATE
REVENUES FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. BOTH IDEAS AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HAS BROUGHT UP
PREVIOUSLY IN. THE WAY TO
ENCOURAGE AND SUPPORT FUTURE
GREEN BUSINESS TO ADOPT THE
COALITION BUDGET PROPOSAL. TO
PROVIDE A POSITIVE FISCAL
INCENTIVE RATHER THAN A
PUNITIVE APPROACH. ADOPTION OF
I DON'T BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL
SUSTAIN THE STATE'S COMMITMENT
AND CONTINUE THE CURRENT
FUNDING MECHANISMS THAT ARE
NEEDED. IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
FURTHER PROGRESS RIGHTS OF
COLLECTIVE. BARGAINING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FOR KATHY
SANDERLING MCDONALD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH CWDM. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
HELLO FIVE FIVE KATHY SAID
KNOWING THE BATTLE WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON THIS
PANEL. FIRST WE APPLAUD THE
WORK OF THE ADMINISTRATION AND
ESPECIALLY DIRECTOR MCCOY
WAITED PARTICULAR FOR THEIR
WORK ON THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING WHICH ARTICULATED A
COMPREHENSIVE AND THOUGHTFUL
PLAN TO STRENGTHEN SERVICES TO
OLDER ADULTS INCLUDING ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES. MEETING WITH
A IN THIS AND EMBRACE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IDENTIFIED IN
THE PLAN INCLUDING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
SAMPLED SEPARATELY ADDRESSED BY
THE L. T. S. S. TASK FORCE. NOT
ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
ON THE AGENDA. FIRST OF ALL
RELATED TO THE EXPERIENCE OF
IMPLEMENTING HOME SAY. HOME
SAFE AS I PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
AS A PART OF THE OVERALL ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM AND
WAS INITIALLY CREATED AS A
THREE YEAR PILOT OPERATING IN A
SUBSET OF COUNTY. THE PROGRAM A
THREE EXPIRES AT THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR. WE'RE PROPOSING TO
MAKE IT PERMANENT AS WELL AS
EXPAND FUNDING TO ENABLE MORE
COUNTIES TO JOIN IN THE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. THROUGH A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION. IT WAS BORN OUT
OF A GROWING HOUSING CRISIS
AMONG OUR OLDER POPULATION.
RESEARCH BY MARCUS STYLE AND UC
SAN FRANCISCO DEMONSTRATES THAT
THE FASTEST GROWING SEGMENT OF
OUR HOUSING CRISIS IS THE OLDER
POPULATION. AND MOST OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS BECOME HOMELESS FOR
THE FIRST TIME AFTER AGE FIFTY
IT'S NOT CHRONIC. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT FINDING AFFORDABLE SENIOR
HOUSING AS A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE. BECAUSE OF THAT THE
MOST EFFECTIVE USE OF OUR
SERVICES AND HOME STATE HAS
BEEN TO SUPPORT CLIENTS HIS
HOUSING IS AT RISK. RATHER THAN
THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY HOMELESS
PREVENTION IS KEY. HOME IS AN
INTERESTING STORY. RENDON
FACTION OVER CHEAPER TWO
HUNDRED OLDER DEPEND ADULTS
ACROSS TWENTY FIVE COUNTIES
HAVE RECEIVED HELP AND SUPPORT
AND OTHER SERVICES TO THE HOME
SAFE PILOT. AND IT'S BEEN WELL
WORTH THE INVESTMENT AND WE
URGE THAT IT BE CONTINUE. WE
RECEIVED A NUMBER OF CLIENTS
STORIES FROM INDIVIDUAL
COUNTIES THAT WE WILL SHARE
WITH THE SUB COMMITTEE STAFF
AND SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS. SOME
COMMON THEMES OF THESE AND
OTHER STORIES. THESE ARE
VULNERABLE OLDER ADULTS MANY
LIVING IN POVERTY ON FIXED
INCOMES WERE FACING CHALLENGES
OF CHRONIC OR SERIOUS HEALTH
ISSUES. MENTAL ILLNESS AND
ISOLATION SUCH AS THE DEATH OF
RELATIVES. LIVING IN PROPERTIES
THAT HAVE FALLEN INTO DISREPAIR
AND ARE BEING EITHER TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF OR HARASSED
SOMETIMES BY THEIR LANDLORDS OR
THEIR OWN FAMILY. IN FRESNO FOR
EXAMPLE A CLIENT WAS LIVING IN
A TRAVEL BAN IN THE MOUNTAINS
OUTSIDE OF THE HOME SHE AND HER
HUSBAND BUILT TOGETHER. PASSED
AWAY BEFORE THEY CAN MOVE IN
AND RETIRE. IT TURNED OUT WHEN
WE WILL LOOK INTO THE SITUATION
THAT OUR CLIENT WAS ALSO A
HOARDER. THROUGH THE USE OF
HOME SAFE RESOURCES ARE COUNTY
WAS ABLE TO GO AND CLEAN OUT
THE HOME AND REPAIR THE ROOF.
AND IN THE PROCESS OF ALL OF
THAT OUR STAFF FOUND THE QUIET
WEDDING RING THAT HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN LOST. SO NOT
ONLY TO THE CLIENT MOVE BACK
INTO THE HOME SHE ALSO MOVED IN
WITH HER LONG LOST WEDDING RING.
FURTHER WAYS THAT WE CAN-
STRENGTHENS THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM AND
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE DID NOT
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
THE KEY AREAS FOR STRENGTHENING
APRS FOR HER PROGRAM AND POLICY
EXPERTS PERSPECTIVE IS TO
ENSURE WE CAN PROVIDE A
SUFFICIENT LEVEL OF CASE
MANAGEMENT. TO HELP THOSE IN
NEED OF THE DEPRESSED AND
SERVICES AND TO ENSURE A STEADY
FUNDING SOURCE THAT WILL HELP
US KEEP UP WITH GROWING DEMAND.
WITH REGARD TO SERVICES THE
CASE MANAGEMENT. HISTORICALLY
THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN ROUTED IN
SHORT TERM INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT. PROGRAM WAS NEVER
FULLY FUNDED FOR ESTIMATES OF
NEED MADE IN THE LATE NINETEEN
NINETIES WHEN THE AUTHORIZING
STATUTE WAS ENACTED. AND SO A
SYSTEM THAT OPEN AND CLOSE
CASES WITHIN A RELATIVELY QUICK
PERIOD OF TIME HAS BEEN THE
NORM. IN FACT TIME OUR OLDER
POPULATION HAS GROWN
SIGNIFICANTLY ALONG WITH OUR
POPULATIONS OF INDIVIDUALS
DISABILITIES WITH THE
FACILITIES YOU MAY BE
VULNERABLE TO ABUSE NEGLECT.
ALONG WITH COGNITIVELY IMPAIRED
AT ALL. MANY MORE OF THESE
ADULTS ARE ALSO FACING HOUSING
CRISES AS YOU KNOW IN ADDITION
ISOLATION AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC
WALKED DOWN. RACE GENDER AND
SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY AND EQUITIES ALSO
PROCESS FOR MANY OF OUR OLDER
ADULTS. AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES AS THEY NAVIGATE
SYSTEMS OF CARE AND SERVICES
THAT ARE OFTEN ARE LACKING IN
SUPPORT TO BEGIN WITH. WITH
REGARD TO INCREASE THE NEED AND
THE FUNDING TO MEET THAT NEED
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING A GROWTH
IN DEMAND FOR THE PROGRAM. IN
JUST TEN YEARS SINCE TWENTY
ELEVEN TWELVE COUNTY APS
PROGRAMS A FEW REPORTS OF ABUSE
OR NEGLECT INCREASED BY SIXTY
ONE POINT 3% FOR REFERENCE
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT
REVENUES TO THE PROTECTIVE
SERVICES FROM A CATHOLIC
COUNTY. WHICH INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR A PS. I'VE ONLY GROWN BY
FORTY FIVE POINT SIX PERCENT.
IN THAT SAME PERIOD OF TIME.
THERE IS NO ONGOING SOURCE OF
FUNDING AT THE STATE OR FEDERAL
LEVEL. OTHER THAN A ONE TIME
ACTUALLY IT'S NOW BECOME A TWO
TIME NINE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT OF FEDERAL FUNDS AND
ACTED AS PART OF THE TWO MOST
RECENT RELIEF PACKAGES. AND
THESE REPRESENTS THE FIRST TIME
THAT FEDERAL MONEY HAS EVER
COME INTO THIS PROGRAM OTHER
THAN THE OCCASIONAL ABILITY TO
MATCH OUR MEDICAID FUNDING FOR
SERVICES PROVIDED. ARE PROPOSAL
WOULD ALLW FOR A PS TO SERVE
OLDER ADULTS EARLIER AT AGE
SIXTY INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT
SIXTY FIVE CONSISTENT WITH
OLDER AMERICANS ACT PROGRAM. IT
WOULD ALSO PROVIDE LONG TERM
CASE MANAGEMENT TO RECIPIENTS
OF GREATER NEEDS. AND WE WOULD
BE BETTER ABLE TO HONE IN ON
OLDER ADULTS INDEPENDENT ADULTS
AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS. BY
EXTENDING HOME SAFE. INCLUDING
THE THIRTY MILLION NOTED
EARLIER FOR HOMESTAY. THE TOTAL
OUR CLASSES ONE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND I'M GOING.
OUR CORRESPONDENTS INCLUDE
EXPERTS IN OLDER JUSTICE COUNTY
PARTNERS AND LABOR INCLUDING
JUSTICE IN AGING THE CALIFORNIA
ELDER JUSTICE COALITION AT THE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIA. THE FACT
URBAN COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC
GUARDIANS AND PUBLIC
CONSERVATIVE. IF WE DON'T
ADEQUATELY FUNDED YET THE
GROWING POPULATION WILL QUICKLY
OUTPACED OUR CAPACITY TO SERVE.
A LARGE AND GROWING NUMBER OF
OLDER ADULTS AT RISK OF ABUSE
OR NEGLECT WON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED AND CHANCES
ARE THEY WILL END UP TOUCHING
OTHER SYSTEMS WHEN THINGS
BECOME MORE DIRE. SUCH AS LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. AND FINALLY WITH REGARD
APR OF THE MASTER PLAN AN AGING
POINTS OUT. ONE OF THE GREATEST
THREATS TO FULL INCLUSION AND
EQUITY FOR ALL AGES. OLDER
ABUSE. WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT
FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE THE
INVESTMENT OUR COALITION OF
ASKING FOR IT. IS NOT VERY
REASONABLE AN EXTREMELY
CRITICAL FOR INCLUSION AND
EQUITY. HELLO I HAVE A QUESTION
REGARDING- WHAT COULD BE
POTENTIALLY DONE TO EASE
ENROLLMENT ACCESS TO ITEMS
THAT'S BOTH DURING THE PANDEMIC
IN AFTER. AS I DISCUSSED DURING
THE PANEL ON RACE AND EQUITY
BEING AWARE OF HOW THIS PROGRAM
STRUCTURE CREATES INEQUITIES
AND BARRIERS TO KERR IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO INCREASING
ENROLLMENT AND ENHANCING
ACCESS. I JUST HOPE IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF A PROGRAM THAT IS
SOLD PRIMARILY AROUND
COMPLIANCE WITH RULES AND
REQUIREMENTS THAT PRESENT
BARRIERS TO COVERAGE. IN THE
SHORT RUN THE QUICKEST AND
EASIEST THING WE CAN DO IT
SUPPORT CONSUMERS AND PROVIDERS
TO QUICKLY GET THEIR FORMS
RETURNED TO COUNTY THEIR ONLINE
PORTALS. THIS CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED BY INVESTING IN
TECHNOLOGIES USED FOR ELECTRIC
FORMS AND SIGNATURES. THIS
SIMPLE STEP WILL INCREASE
SAFETY FOR CONSUMERS FOR MAKING
MORE EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
PROGRAMS PROSPECT THESE AND WE
HAVE A VERY MODEST BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT PROVIDES FUNDING
FOR THIS. IN A LONGER TERM
GIVEN ONE AN AXE FOR THE
ALLEN'S OF FOR I THAT. WE CAN
CONSIDER OTHER OPTIONS. SOME OF
WHICH- ARE IDENTIFIED IN THE
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
AGING MASTERPLAN REPORT. REALLY
WHAT THIS ENTAILS IS LOOKING AT
OUR POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO
SEE WHAT'S TRULY NECESSARY FOR
EFFECTIVE OPERATION OF THE
PROGRAM. AND WHAT COULD BE
SHORTENED OR ELIMINATED
ALTOGETHER JUST A FEW EXAMPLES
INCLUDE. REVIEWING MEDICAL
POLICIES AND THEIR IMPACT ON
THE OLDER ADULT POPULATIONS
SUCH AS THE ASSET LIMIT. AND
CONSIDER PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY FOR SOME
POPULATIONS GENETIC CAL INDOOR
I JUST ASK FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
BEING DISCHARGED FROM HOSPITAL
FUNDING. REVISING CRIMINAL
ABOUT BACKGROUND CHECK POLICIES
THAT CAN BE A BARRIER FOR
PROVIDERS THE UNDERLYING RACISM
CONTRIBUTING TO A GREATER
LIKELIHOOD. OF RELATIVELY MINOR
CRIMES BY TODAY'S STANDARDS
BEING A PROVIDER APPLICANTS
HISTORY PARTICULARLY FOR
POPULATIONS OF COLOR. ALSO THE
STAGE TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
COVER THE COSTS OF CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR POTENTIAL
ITEMS THAT'S PROVIDE. AND
FINALLY ADEQUATELY FUNDING THE
WORKLOAD FOR COUNTIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT I JUST
ASKED PROGRAM CASELOADS FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS REMAIN
INCREDIBLY HIGH WHICH REDUCES
THE TIME OUR STAFF HAVE TO
SUPPORT CONSUMERS AND- HIGHLY
ACCESSING SERVICES. AND HAVING
THEIR APPLICATIONS PROCESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I APPRECIATE
THE TIME. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM CLAIRE RAMSEY
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
JUSTICE IN AGING. YOUR NUMBERS
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING WE HAVE A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY AT THIS
MOMENT TO INVEST IN A BOLD
EQUITABLE FUTURE FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. MY NAME IS CLEAR
RAMSEY AND I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
JUSTICE IN AGING WE ARE
NATIONAL LEGAL NONPROFIT THAT
USES THE POWER OF LAW TO FIGHT
TO YOUR PROPERTY WE WORK TO
STRENGTHEN THE SOCIAL SAFETY
NET. AND TO REMOVE THE BARRIERS
LOW INCOME SENIOR SPACE IN
ACCESSING THE SERVICES THEY
NEED WITH A PARTICULAR FOCUS ON
ADVANCING EQUITY. SEVERAL OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND I AT JUSTICE IN
AGING WE'RE VERY INVOLVED IN
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. AS WE
BEGIN THAT PROCESS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE KNEW HOW IMPORTANT
IT WAS TO LIFT UP THE ISSUES
FACED BY OLDER CALIFORNIANS.
AND THAT STATE DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGES ALONE WE'RE GOING TO
REQUIRE EQUITABLE THOUGHTFUL
EXPANSIVE AND HOLISTIC PLANNING.
WHAT WE COULDN'T HAVE IMAGINED
OR PREDICTED WITH A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC THAT WOULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY INFECTED AND
KILLED OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES. ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN THE BLACK WHAT NEXT
INDIGENOUS AN API COMMUNITIES
WOULD RIP TO THE STATE NATION
AND WORLD. IN CALIFORNIA NEARLY
74% OF KOBE GAS. IN ADULTS
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER EVEN
THOUGH THEY CONSTITUTE LESS
THAN 11% OF CONFIRMED CASES.
KOBE NINETEEN CRISIS HAS
REVEALED AND EXACERBATED THE
SHORTCOMINGS IN CALIFORNIA'S
SAFETY NET SYSTEMS FOR ALL
POPULATIONS. BUT ESPECIALLY FOR
OLDER ADULTS. BUT IT HAS ALSO
SHOWN HOW MUCH WE CAN DO AND
HOW QUICKLY WE CAN DO IT WHEN
WE ACT WITH RESOLVE.
CALIFORNIA'S HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE OLDER
ADULTS INCLUDING HSS MSSP APS.
AS A SCIENCE IS P. AND SENIOR
NUTRITION PROVED HOW VITAL THEY
WERE AND ARE TO INSURE IN OLDER
ADULTS CAN LIVE SAFELY IN THE
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY DURING A
PANDEMIC. ON THE INVESTMENT
SIDE IS REQUIRED THE
LEGISLATURE TO HOLD THE LINE
AGAINST CUTS TO THESE PROGRAMS
LAST YEAR EVEN WHEN
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET SITUATION
SEEM DIRE. FINDING THAT POINT
AND WINNING WAS INSTRUMENTAL TO
ENSURING THAT WE WERE NOT.
THERE WERE NOT EVEN MORE DIRE
EFFECTS FROM KOGAN. NOW THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE CHANCE TO
EXPAND ITS COMMITMENT TO THESE
PROGRAMS. AND TO THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SUPPORT. BY
FIRST PERMANENTLY RESTORING THE
7% I JUST LAST CAUGHT. THAT WAS
ENACTED SOLELY FOR BUDGETARY
REASONS ACROSS THE CLIPBOARD
CUTS LIKE THIS ARE BAD POLICY.
THE PANDEMIC SHOWED US IN
UNMISTAKABLE TERMS THAT PEOPLE
NEED ROBUST ACCESS TO HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. I
JUST AS IS THE BACKBONE OF OUR
EACH CBS SYSTEM AND IT SERVES
MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ALMOST 70% OF
WHOM ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR. THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE ITS
COMMITMENT HEDIS CRYSTAL CLEAR
BY REPEALING THE TOP
PERMANENTLY SO DOES NOT
CONTINUE TO HANG OVER I JUST AS
RECIPIENTS AND PROVIDERS HEADS.
SECOND WE SHOULD EXPAND ACCESS
TO ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
AND HOME STATE PROGRAM. APS HAS
BEEN CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED
BUT WE NOW HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO RECOGNIZE THE COMPLEX AND
UNIQUE NEEDS OF OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
MEETING THOSENEEDS. INCREASING
FUNDING FOR IT YES IN HOME
STATE ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO LOWER
HOMELESSNESS IN THE OLDER ADULT
COMMUNITY WHICH
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
BLACK CALIFORNIANS TO WORK TO
ADDRESS THE ENDURING NEGATIVE
EFFECTS OF RACISM AND SEXISM.
AND EXPANSIVE CORPORATE PEOPLE
LIVING WITH COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENTS. THIRD WE SHOULD
INCREASE THE SS I SS P. GRANT
UP TO A 100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. WE KNOW THAT
WOMEN BLACK LATIN ACCENT
IMMIGRANT OLDER ADULTS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO AGE INTO POVERTY THAN
WHITE MEN. CALIFORNIANS WHO
RECEIVE SSI S. B. GRANTS HAVE
STRUGGLED MORE THAN TEN YEARS
TO LIVE IN AN EXPENSIVE STATE
UNLESS IN A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH. THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TOOK AN IMPORTANT STEP
TO SUPPORT THESE CALIFORNIANS
IN THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS.
BUT NOW IS THE TIME TO RAISE
GRANT LEVELS PERMANENTLY AND
MOVE MORE THAN ONE POINT TWO
MILLION CALIFORNIANS OUT OF
POVERTY. FINALLY WE SHOULD
INVEST MORE IN SENIOR
NUTRITION. CALIFORNIA FUNDS AND
RUNS A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS TO
HELP INSURE OLDER ADULTS HAVE
ACCESS TO FOOD BUT IT IS NOT
ENOUGH. IN FACT CALIFORNIA HAS
ONE OF THE LOWEST UPTAKE RATES
OF SNAP BENEFITS IN THE
COUNTRY. WE'VE SEEN A HUGE
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
SENIORS EXPERIENCE INCLUDING
SECURITY. WE NEED TO INVEST NOW
TO ENSURE IT NO OLDER
CALIFORNIAN GOES HUNGRY. BY
MAKING THESE INVESTMENTS IN
THESE CORE HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS AND THE OTHERS THAT
ARE BEING DISCUSSED TODAY WE
CAN CHART A NEW PATH TOWARD AN
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. WE CAN DECIDE THE
LOSS OF LIFE AND THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE PANDEMIC WILL
NOT BE FORGOTTEN. WE CAN DECIDE
THAT NOW IS THE TIME TO
EQUITABLY PRIORITIZE THE NEEDS
OF ALL LOW INCOME OLDER
CALIFORNIANS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
ANDREW SHANE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS. WHO IS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR SSI COALITION.
THANK YOU TO WONDER WHAT YOUR
NUMBERS ARE- I WILL- GIVE MY
REMARKS BRIEF I APPRECIATE THAT
THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS IMAGE
CERTAINLY ALIGNED IN THE
COALITION'S WITH THOSE BY THE
RAMSEY OF MY CURLED AND OTHERS
EARLIER TODAY- I AN INTERCHANGE
I AM REPRESENTING COALITION OF
MORE THAN. TWO HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE- WHO DO
OUR BEST TO THE ABOUT US
WITHOUT US I'M REPRESENTING
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND SO I WILL END
WITH A SHORT PERSONAL STORY.
I'M QUICKLY I WOULD ALSO SIGNAL
TO COALITION STRONG SUPPORT FOR
DIRECTOR MCQUAY- AND THE
POLITICAL IN THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING OF AFFORDABLE AGING
FOR ALL AND. HUNGER AND POVERTY.
YOUR RELIGIOUS AND MINISTRY TO
ACHIEVE THAT. FIRST OFF THANKS
FOR INCLUSION OF SSI RECIPIENTS
IN THE RECENT GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS I REQUEST THAT IF
THERE ARE ANY FUTURE STIMULUS.
PACKAGES AGAIN BUT THOSE TO
INCLUDE SSI S. B. RECIPIENTS AS
THE COSTS ARE EXTRAORDINARY DUE
TO CORPORATE FROM THE DELIVERY
OF FOOD AND MEDICINE. PAYING
FOR RIDES WITH DIMINISH PUBLIC
TRANSIT OR SIMPLY PAYING FOR
JOBS IN ORDER FOR OLDER ADULTS
TO STAY HOME AND SURVIVE IT'S
CLEAR AND HE JUST SPOKE TO
INCREDIBLE MORBIDITY. SECOND WE
ARE. AGAIN OTHERS ON RAISING
ISIS I SS P. GRANTS THE STATE
BACK TO TWO THOUSAND NINE
THEY'RE LOOKING OVER DO. AS
WELL AS EARLIER BY DRUCKER
JOHNSON THAT I RAISING
ENROLLMENT IN S. I. S. T. WE
CAN DRIVE DOWN MILLIONS IN
FEDERAL DOLLARS MOVING FOLKS-
OFF OF GHG ARE ON TO AS AS I AM
GIVING THEM A BRIGHTER FUTURE.
SO WE HOPE IN A WAY THAT THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS IS STEP
ONE TOWARDS RESTORING THOSE
CUTS BECAUSE SS I RECIPIENTS
WERE IN CRISIS BEFORE AND ARE
TRULY. CRITICAL CONDITION NOW.
THIRD FOR SIXTY. AS WELL AS THE
VISION TO TRULY HARMLESS. AS A
SCIENCE IS B. HOUSEHOLDS WITH
THAT ARE CELEBRATED HISTORIC
POLICY CHANGE AND CERTAINLY DR
ROMULUS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
ONGOING LEADERSHIP IN THE SPACE.
WE CELEBRATE THE EXPANSION AND
THE HARD WORK IDEA S. S. C. WGA
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS SEVERAL
OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS TO
EXECUTE THAT- BUT HOUSEHOLDS.
IT NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS AS
WE HEARD EARLIER OFTENTIMES
CALIBRATION IS NOT ENOUGH- AND
IT STILL HASN'T REACHED OUT ALL
AS A SAY AS PURE CIVILIANS.
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROGRAMS WE MUST YOU
TWO THINGS THERE IS AN URGENT
NEED TO STAND SURE IN THIS
PROGRAM I APPRECIATE THE
EARLIER DISCUSSIONS ABOUT CHURN
AND EXITS. IN PARTICULAR FOR
THIS PROGRAM THERE IS NO WAY TO
COME BACK DUE TO THE
UNFORTUNATE STRUCTURE OF THE
TNB PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR-
WHERE'S COMPARABLE COST
CALFRESH HOUSEHOLDS OFTEN HAVE
TWO TO THREE YEAR CERTIFICATION
PERIODS AND NINETY DAYS TO
RETURN TO THE PROGRAM- THERE IS
A SIX MONTH CERTIFICATION
PERIOD. AND ONLY A THIRTY DAY
CUT OFF WHICH LEADS TO A
LIFETIME BAR IF THOSE
CONDITIONS ARE MET AND I THINK
WE'VE ALL DISCUSSED TODAY THAT
EVEN SIMPLE PAPERWORK CAN BE A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER INCLUDING
DURING THE PANDEMIC. SO WE BOTH
CALL A TEMPORARY FIX IN ORDER
TO PAUSE- SORT OF
RECERTIFICATION AND ENSURE THAT
ALL CAN BE HOUSEHOLDS CAN-
MAYBE IN TEN ELIGIBILITY AS
WELL AS PROVIDE SOME VERY CLEAR
COMMONSENSE PERMANENT
IMPROVEMENTS. EXTENDED
CERTIFICATION PERIODS
LENGTHENING THE NUMBER OF DAYS
THAT FOLKS HAVE TO COME BACK
AGAIN FOR FILLED THAT
COMPARABILITY WITH WITH
CALFRESH. SECOND TO REPLACE
BENEFITS DURING DISASTER WHEN I
HOUSEHOLDS IN THOSE WHO
BENEFITS MOST IF SOMEONE LOSES
THEIR POWER FOR MORE THAN FOUR
HOURS OR IF THERE IS A MOVE
FASTER- BLACKOUT OR PS PS EVENT
THERE ARE PROVISIONS REPLACE
CALFRESH BENEFITS BUT NOT FOR
THE S. N. B. N. T. N. B.
BENEFITS ARE MEANT TO HOLD
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS. HARMLESS
AGAIN- SINCE THIS ARE PRETTY
SEAMLESS AND STRAIGHTFORWARD
FIXES THERE AND WE APPRECIATE
THE INPUT BY THE. COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS AND THE
DEPARTMENT ON THAT. SO I JUST
WITH A FEW COMMENTS- A
NECESSARY CAN SITUATE FROM THE
DISK. BECAUSE REPORTS THE HER
EX. LIVING ON US. IS VERY TO. I
DON'T THINK ANYONE IN THE WORLD
WE WANT TO BE IN A SOCITY
BECAUSE OF THE TASK OF JUST
SURVIVING EVERY DAY. FOR A LOT
OF US JUST THE THOUGHT OF
HAVING TO GO ON A SITE RAISES A
LOT OF ANXIETY BECAUSE YOU
ALREADY KNOW THAT'S NOT ENOUGH
TO LIVE ON. WITH ITS RISING THE
COST OF FOOD RISING NOT TO
MENTION MEDICATION YOU HAVE TO
MAKE AN IMPORTANT DECISION I
MUST WHAT YOU NEED. A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAY RENTS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING. BUT IF YOU
DONATE THEN YOU'RE NOT GONNA
SURVIVE INTO A PLACE TO LIVE IF
YOU CHOOSE YOUR FOOD OVER
MEDICATION YOU PUT YOUR LIFE AT
RISK. THERE ARE MANY OF US TO
TRY TO SURVIVE DDNS ASIDE. WE
BEG LANDLORDS TO BACK OFF RENT
WE GO TO MULTIPLE FOOD BANKS
BECAUSE JUST ONE WILL NOT BE
ENOUGH FOOD. WE CENTER PHARMACY
LINES TODAY WHICH MEDICATION I
PICK UP. AND DURING THE
PANDEMIC BEING THAT OUR SOCIETY
HAS BEEN A LOT HARDER THAN
BEFORE. WITH STORE SHOOTING
DOWN ALL OVER AMERICA PEOPLE
ORDERING EVERYTHING ONLINE BUT
THEY FORGET ABOUT THE PEOPLE
UNNECESSARY WHO BARELY HAVE
ENOUGH TO LIVE. THANK YOU AGAIN
SURE FOR EUROPE AND THEN IN THE
SPACE. AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. THANK
YOU. NOW WE WILL HEAR FROM.
KEMPF EXECUTIVE. OF THE SENIORS
COUNCIL. OF SANTA CRUZ AND SAN
BENITO COUNTIES. WHO IS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING. HI THANKS FOR HAVING ME
HERE AND SO MANY OF MY PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS GREAT COMMENTS ARE THE
FIRST OF MY FOUR QUESTIONS ASKS
ABOUT QUARTER SERVICES DIDN'T
THERE'S ANYTHING PARTICULAR
THAT NEEDS TO BE STRENGTHENED
TO OUR MASTER PLAN FOR AGING TO
SUCCEED. AND I'LL JUST CALL OUT
THAT OVER THE PAST DECADE
ACCORDING TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE SIXTY PLUS
POPULATION IN THE STATE HAS
GROWN BY 40% WHILE THE UNDER
SIXTY POPULATION HAS GROWN BY
LESS THAN ONE PERCENT. SO I
THINK THAT GROW. ALONE POINTS
OUT THE NEED TO- LEFT OUT ALL
PROGRAMS REGARDING AGING THAT
THERE'S JUST A HUGE DEMAND THAT
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT QUITE A BIT
I'M ALL CALL OUT A COUPLE OF
THEM. ONE IS JUST- AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING WHICH ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DELIVERY OF
A LOT OF COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES ARE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- OUR BASELINE FUNDING IS
THE SAME AS IT WAS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY OR EIGHTY ONE. FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR ON
THAT NOW BUYS ABOUT SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF
SERVICES THE STATE HAS
CURRENTLY MADE NO INVESTMENT IN-
TRIP AWAY BASED ON FUNDING SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE FUNDING
REQUEST THAT WE'RE ASKING THAT
THERE BE SOME SORT OF MINIMUM
CONTRIBUTION AND WE THINK OF
TRIPLE A.'S- WHO ARE INTEGRAL
TO. THE PROVIDING OUR SERVICES
TO VULNERABLE THE ADULTS IF
WE'RE GOING TO EXCEED AND ARE
SERVING THIS POPULATION IN IN
MASTER PLANNED FOR AGING GOALS
THAT PART OF THAT IS TO HAVE AT
LEAST SOME. RESOURCES IN ORDER
TO DO SO. ONE OF THE THINGS
FOUND DURING THE PANDEMIC WAS
THAT THE STATE BASELINE FUNDING
WHICH UNTIL THIS PAST YEAR WAS
ACTUALLY REDUCED FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS AFTER THE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT PROGRAMS ACTUALLY
ELIMINATED FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT- DAD LEFT
THEIR ORGANIZATIONS. AND
SERVICES WITH REALLY POOR
INFRASTRUCTURES TO MOVE FORWARD
I TRYING THE INCREASED MEDIA
ACCOUNTS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
DESPERATE WHEN WE WERE
OPERATING ON. I FACILITIES THAT
HAD NOT BEEN UPGRADED OR
EXPANDED FOR SEVERAL DECADES
REALLY I BROUGHT TO THE FORE
ARM FOR FRONT THAT THERE WAS
JUST A HUGE NEED I REALLY COST
BY NICK LACKS. SURROUND ITEMS
SUCH AS NUTRITION AND OTHER
SERVICES I REALLY THINK THAT
PART OF RESPONDING TO THE NEXT
PANDEMIC OR JUST TO THE GROWTH
OF THE POPULATION IS GOING TO
REQUIRE SOME OF THESE. CORE
SERVICES TO BE INTERESTED IN
BOOK THAT I'M MORE SERIOUSLY
AND SPEAKING COURSE SERVICES
YOU KNOW WE ALL HAVE OUR
FAVORITES YOU KNOW. I MENTION-
AGENCIES ON A SO WE COULD GO
THROUGH THE BUT REALLY MASS.
AND I THINK WHAT MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING- COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
WHICH I WAS ONE I RECOGNIZE IS
THAT. PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS THAT WE
PROVIDE THE BASIC NECESSITIES
OF LIFE THAT WE LOOK AT WAYS TO
MAKE SURE SENIORS HAVE SHELTER.
TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE FOOD AND
TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO SERVICES AND ACCESS CAN BE
INTERPRETED A NUMBER OF WAYS.
INCLUDES ESSENTIAL
TRANSPORTATION THAT ALSO
INCLUDES METHODS BY WHICH TO
GET INFORMATION OR TO BECOME
ELIGIBLE FOR SERVICES BECAUSE
THAT'S OUR PART OF. LIFE
SUSTAINING PROGRAMS WITHOUT
GOALS ANY OTHER INTERVENTION
THAT WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
ATTEMPT IS GOING TO FAIL IT'S
DOOMED TO FAIL. NAVIGATION OF
OUR COMPLEX SYSTEM IN MULTIPLE
FUNDERS IS A HUGE CHALLENGE
THAT OLDER ADULTS FACE ARM ON
ONE HAND HOWEVER IT'S
IMPORTANT. THAT THERE CONTINUE
TO BE MULTIPLE FOUNDERS WE WANT
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS TO BE
INVESTED IN OLDER ADULTS WE
WANT VETERANS SERVICES TO MAKE
SURE THE OLDER VETERANS GET
SIR. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S ADEQUATE HEALTH CARE
FOR OLDER ADULTS ADEQUATE FOOD
PROGRAMS THAT THAT AT SANDRA SO
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A LENGTHY
AN EXTENSIVE LIST OF THESE
UNFORTUNATELY SILO PROGRAMS
REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE DO. THE
PROGRESS WE CAN REALLY MAKE
THAT I THINK WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANT IS ADDING AS MUCH
FLEXIBILITY AS POSSIBLE WITHIN
EACH OF THOSE SILOS SO WE DON'T
CREATE THESE FALSE BARRIERS TO
SERVICE BECAUSE OF SOME
REGULATIONS. AND THE WAY WE'RE
GONNA GET THROUGH THIS IS
ANOTHER PART OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSALS THAT I'VE SEEN FOR A
IS PROMOTING- DIRECTOR WADE
WERE REFERENCED ONE OF THIS AND
IT'S HIGHLIGHTED IN MASTER
PLAN. AND THAT IS THE CREATION
OF A NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEM AGING
AND DISABILITY RESOURCE CAN
ACTIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE PERSON CENTERED SYSTEMS OF
NAVIGATION THAT WE HAVE
SOMEBODY TO HELP A PERSON WHO
NEEDS HELP GET THAT HELP. AND
FOCUS ON THE NEEDS OF THE
PERSON RATHER THAN THE NEEDS
ARE REQUIREMENTS OF ANY
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM. SO HAVING
THAT SINGLE POINT OF ENTRY I
THINK IT'S PART OF OUR
RECOMMENDATION AND SOMETHING WE
REALLY WANT. I'M GONNA SKIP TO
MY LAST QUESTION AND THEN COME
BACK BRIEFLY TO THE THIRD ONE
WHICH IS SHOULD WE FIND
TRADITIONAL PROGRAMS FOR SHOULD
BE FINED- INNOVATIONS. AND THE
ANSWER IS KIND OF OBVIOUS WE
WANT TO DO BOTH WE WANT TO FUND
PROGRAMS THAT WORK AND MAKE
SURE THEY'RE FOUNDED AND NOW SO.
THAT THEY CAN WORK BUT ALL ALSO
LOOK AT. KIND OF SIMPLE THAT WE
CAN PUT INTO. LONG FRUIT THE
WERE PART IS FALSE PREVENT. A
SINGLE FALL ON WITH A BROKEN
HIP WILL TYPICALLY COST A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN OUR
MEDICAL COSTS AND PERSONAL
CLASS NOT TO MENTION THE LOSS
OF RESOURCES FROM FAMILY
MEMBERS. HAVE TO STEP UP AS
CARE GIVERS OR THE EMOTIONAL
LOSS FLOOR ON THE INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS EMOTIONAL
SUFFERING. SO THAT'S ONE
PROPOSAL WE WANT TO LOOK
FORWARD RIGHT NOW WE THINK THAT
IT IS WELL WITH MASTER PLAN FOR
REACHING. ARM IN REVISITING
HEALTHCARE. AND THEN LET HOW DO
WE AFFORD ALL THIS BECAUSE NONE
OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE FREE. HOW
MAY MAY BE CHEAP BUT THEY'RE
NOT FREE SO I THINK THERE'S TWO
PIECES ABOUT THE FIRST ONE IS
THAT WE LOOK AT HOW MUCH IT
WILL COST US. TO CONTINUE THE
SERVICES THAT ARE ARE MANDATED
TO BE PROVIDED. AS THE
POPULATION AGES AND WE COULD
JUST DO SOME SIMPLE MATH AROUND
THAT AND CALCULATE HOW MANY
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS ARE GOING TO
BE NEEDED AS THE POPULATION.
DOUBLES ON AND THEN LOOK AT
WHAT THAT NUMBER IS AND REALLY
PLAN AROUND WHAT'S THE BEST USE
OF THOSE DOLLARS IT IS A TO
CONTINUE AS WE'RE DOING NOW. OR
THERE'S SOME INNOVATIONS OUT
THERE THAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT
WHICH WOULD IMPROVE BOTH
QUALITY OF LIFE AND- DECREASE
THE COSTS. IN THAT CAN LEADS TO
MY FINAL COMMENT THAT WE SHOULD
ALWAYS BE ASKING IS NOT JUST
WHAT'S THE COST OF PROVIDING
SERVICE. BUT WHAT'S THE COST OF
NOT PROVIDING SERVICE WHAT
HAPPENS IF WE DON'T DO
ANYTHING. AND HI. FAR WILL
CLASS ESCALATES ON BOTH THE
FINANCIAL SIDE OF THINGS BUT
ALSO THE HUMAN. ASPECTS SO THAT
WRAPS UP MY TIME- I DO WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMAN ADRIAN IS
ALREADY IN FOR SPONSORING THE-
BUDGET REPORTS THE RING BACK OR
THE BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS THAT
ARE REQUESTED BY OUR
ASSOCIATION AND I'LL STAY HERE
FOR QUESTIONS MY COACH. THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
DENISE LIKE KERR VICE PRESIDENT
OF INDEPENDENCE AT HOME HE
SCANNED COMMUNITY SERVICE.
ADRIN MY NAME IS DENISE LIKE-
AND I AM VICE PRESIDENT OF
INDEPENDENCE AT HOME SCANNED
COMMUNITY SERVICE OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. I AM ALSO HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE MSSP
SITE ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT
THE MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM. MSSP IS
IMPORTANT PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
OLDER ADULTS SAFETYNET OF CARE
WITH THIRTY NINE SITES ACROSS
THE STATE. THE MULLAH CARE
UTILIZES A PROFESSIONAL
INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAM OF
SOCIAL WORKERS AND REGISTERED
NURSES. WORKING TOGETHER IN THE
CLIENT'S HOME WITH FEET ON THE
GROUND. DELIVERING CARE
MANAGEMENT CARE COORDINATION TO
THE FREE LISTING POOREST
NURSING HOME ELIGIBLE MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITIES. WE WORK TO
DO IT ALL HELPING THAT PERSON
REMAIN AT HOME AVOIDING ANY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION. MSSP
STAFF MARSHAL EVERY RESOURCE
AVAILABLE THREE PERSONS CURRENT
BENEFITS THE COMMUNITY AND AS A
LAST RESORT. WE CAN PURCHASE
GOODS AND SERVICES TO AVOID
UNNECESSARY ER VISITS HOSPITAL
STAYS IN PREMATURE NURSING
FACILITY PLACEMENT. THESE
PURCHASES INCLUDE ANYTHING FROM
OBTAINING REFRIGERATORS TO
STORE MEDICATIONS TO OBTAINING
CRITICAL LIFELINE SERVICES SUCH
AS MEDICALLY NEEDED
TRANSPORTATION AND FOOD. MSSP
PROVIDES CLIENT CHOICE AND
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE CARE WE
ARE PROVEN MODEL AND THE
RESOURCE OF LAST RESORT FOR
NUMEROUS SENIORS. THIS YEAR WE
ARE BROUGHT FORTH A BUDGET
ASKED TO CONTINUE THE CURRENT
ANNUAL RATE PER CLIENT A FIVE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX OR- FIVE FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY WITH THE SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS AREA.
MSSP RECEIVED A THREE YEAR ONE
TIME ONLY SUPPLEMENT IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET WHICH
EXPIRES IN TWENTY TWENTY TO.
PLEASE NOTE THE PRIOR TO TWENTY
NINETEEN MSSP HAD NOT RECEIVED
A COST OF LIVING INCREASE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX. ONLY TO
SEE THE PROGRAM FUNDING THEN
CUT BY MORE THAN 22% ACROSS TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT AND TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. WITHOUT
CONTINUATION OF THIS RATE MSSP
WHICH SERVES NEARLY TWELVE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS PER YEAR.
FACES A HIGH POTENTIAL FOR
DESTRUCTION OF CARE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. EXAMPLES OF IMPACT
INCLUDE AT LEAST TENEMENT MSSP
PROVIDERS HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT
SITE CLOSURE IS A HIGH
PROBABILITY. FOR SITES NOT
CONSIDERING CLOSURE. THEY HAVE
IDENTIFIED IMPACTS SUCH AS
LAYOFFS REDUCTIONS IN WAGES AND
HOURS INCREASED AND AS WELL AS
INCREASED WORKLOADS. BUT TOUCH
A BENEFICIARY IMPACT INCLUDES
BREAKS IN SERVICE TO THE SITE
CLOSURE. INCREASED WAIT TIMES
FOR ENROLLMENT AND SERVICES AND
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON LIVING
SAFELY IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
CAN LEAD TO NURSING HOME
PLACEMENT. KEEP IN MIND THAT
INVESTMENT OF FIFTY THREE FIFTY
SIX PER YEAR PER BENEFICIARY.
VERSUS THE MORE THAN SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
NURSING HOME PLACEMENT. IS A
SAVINGS THAT CANNOT BE IGNORED.
CONTINUANCE OF THIS RATE
PRESERVES THE VIABILITY OF MSSP
AND ENSURES CONTINUOUS DELIVERY
OF CARE. BECAUSE M. S. AS P. AS
IN THE COMMUNITY WE PLAY A
PIVOTAL ROLE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IMPACTED
BY NATURAL DISASTERS
EMERGENCIES AND NOW A PANDEMIC.
GIVEN THAT WE ARE ON THE GROUND
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE
NIMBLE AND EXPEDIENT. EXAMPLES
INCLUDE THROUGH COVERT NINETEEN
WE KEPT PARTICIPANTS AT HOME.
WE OBTAINED AND PROVIDED
CRUCIAL PP. WE COMBATED SOCIAL
ISOLATION AND LONELINESS AS
WELL AS CONNECTED BENEFICIARIES
TO THEIR PROVIDERS FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS BY PROVIDING LAPTOPS
AND TABLETS WITH COACHING. AS
WELL SO YOU HAVE SUPPORT OF
COAL PROGRAMS TO ENSURE THEIR
SAFETY. WE DELIVER FOOD TO
THEIR DOORSTEPS WE ASSISTED
WITH FINDING AND HIRING
CAREGIVERS DURING A DRASTIC
SHORTAGE OF WORKERS. AND NOW WE
ARE SYSTEM WITH ALL ASPECTS OF
FIGHTING SCHEDULING ACCESSING
VACCINE APPOINTMENTS. WHEN
THERE'S WILD FIRES AND POWER
OUTAGES WE CREATE GO BAGS FOR
DISASTER EVACUATION WE HELP
WITH RELOCATION AND EMERGENCY
HOUSING. WE CREATE EMERGENCY
PLANS LIKE BACK UP BATTERIES
FOR MEDICAL CORRECT EQUIPMENT
AND PLANNING FOR FOOD. MSSP
MOVES TOWARDS CRISIS WE DO NOT
RETREAT OR RUN AWAY. AS WE LOOK
TO THE MASTER PLAN AND CAL IN
PROCESS. THAT ARE BUILDING
TOWARDS THE FUTURE CARE FOR OUR
SENIORS. WE MUST KEEP IN
MISSISSIPPI IS A SEPARATE
BENEFIT PROVIDING CHOICE AND
HOW ARE NURSING HOME ELIGIBLE
SENIORS RECEIVE ASSISTANCE TO
REMAINING IN THE COMMUNITY. AS
WE LEARN FROM THE CORNER CARE
INITIATIVE. THE INDIVIDUALS AT
MSSP STIRS. CHOSE MSSPS PROVEN
TRUSTED COMMUNITY BASED MODEL
FOR THEIR CARE COORDINATION AND
SUPPORT. ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT
ALL. MSSP SHOULD BE EXPANDED TO
BECOME A MANDATORY OPTION OF
CARE WITHIN THE SAFETY NET AND
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR
THE STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITY DWELLING OLDER ADULTS.
WE RECOMMEND A TWO PHASED
APPROACH TO THIS. FIRST RESTORE
THE TWO THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND NINETY SEVEN CLIENTS LOTS
ELIMINATED IN THE- EIGHT OH
NINE RECESSION. THIS WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED ANY
CURRENT WAIT LIST FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN NEED OF SERVICES AND
ALLOW FOR MORE ROBUST OUTREACH
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. SECOND
EXPAND MSSP STATEWIDE BY
BRINGING THE PROGRAM TO THE
FOURTEEN COUNTIES WE CURRENTLY
DO NOT SERVE. MSSP IS A PROVEN
COST EFFECTIVE MODEL OF CARE
THAT CAN BE LEVERAGED AS PART
OF BOTH THE MASTER PLAN AND CAL
LANE. STABILIZING THE RATE
EXPANDING THE PROGRAM TO ALL
COUNTIES INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF SLOTS. TAKING A MODERNIZED
APPROACH TO PROGRAM DESIGN AND
UTILIZING THE EXPERTISE OF THE
HOST AGENCIES THROUGH
ADDITIONAL CONTRACTING. WE CAN
ENSURE THAT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
SENIORS ABSOL APPROVING CARE
NOW AND IN THE FUTURE. MSSP CAN
SERVE MORE. AND WE WANT TO DO
SO BECAUSE OUR SENIORS I MEAN A
LOT TO US IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM SERRA STEVE
HOWSON SENIOR POLICY ADVISER
WITH THE SCAN FOUNDATION. THANK
YOU GOOD EVENING CHEN ARAMBULA
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY
AND TO CONTRIBUTE TO SUCH A
THOUGHTFUL AND IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION I WILL BE SPEAKING
TO THE BROAD THEMES REGARDING
THE POTENTIAL AND PROMISE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MASTER PLAN FOR
AGENT. TO BEGAN AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE CLLR RAMSEY SO
ELOQUENTLY STATED WE HAVE SEEN
HOW COVERED NINETEEN HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
OLDER ADULTS PARTICULARLY BLACK
LATINO ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS
AND INDIGENOUS POPULATION.
WHILE ALSO BRINGING TO OUR
ATTENTION TO OUR SYSTEM
SHORTCOMINGS AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF CHARTING AN EQUITABLE PATH
FORWARD. AND AS DIRECTOR MAKORI
WADE SAID EARLIER EQUITY REALLY
IS THE FOUNDATION OF THE MASTER
PLAN AND IT SHOULD BE BAKED
INTO ALL ASSOCIATED POLICY AND
PROGRAM ELEMENTS. SO I'M GONNA
REFLECT ON THE THINGS THAT I
HEARD THAT ARE CRITICAL PATH
FORWARD WHICH OF THE FOLLOWING
SEAMLESS SERVICE DELIVERY DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE. WORKFORCE AND
LEADERSHIP. SO THE FIRST NAME
ABOUT SEAMLESS SERVICE. AND WE
NEED TO RE FRAME HOW SERVICES
ARE DELIVERED SEEING THEM AS
PART OF A SEAMLESS CONTINUUM OF
CARE NOT SILENCE STRUCTURES.
INTO THIS AND EQUITY AN AGING
RELIES NOT ONLY ON GOOD MEDICAL
CARE BUT ALSO ON ACCESS TO
SOCIAL SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND
OTHERS. YEAH AS DISCUSSED BY
MISPRINT YELL AT LANL WE MAKE
IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO
ACCESS SERVICES WITH VARIOUS
ASSESSMENTS AND ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS WE HAVE TO BREAK
A LONGSTANDING SYSTEM
FRAGMENTATION. THAT INHABITS
ACCESS TO SERVICES AND INSTEAD
WE NEED TO DEVELOP A MORE
STREAMLINED INTEGRATED SYSTEM
OF CARE. THE SECOND THEME IS
ONE OF THE DATA AND HAS A PRIOR
SPEAKER SAID IN ANOTHER PANEL
THE ONLY WAY TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM IS TO DEFINE IT. AN
EQUITABLE CHARGE FORWARD RELIES
ON BETTER DATA SYSTEMS THAT
TRACK HOW SERVICES ARE UTILIZED
INCLUDING HEALTH CARE LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS HOUSING
AND TRANSPORTATION AND OTHERS.
IN THE GRIP INTEGRATED DATA CAN
BETTER CAN PROVIDE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHO IS FALLING
THROUGH THE CACKS AND WHERE
THE GAPS ARE IN SERVICE
DELIVERY. UNTIL WE HAVE A
BETTER PICTURE OF THE NEED
ACROSS THE SYSTEM IT WILL BE
HARD TO TARGET RESOURCES IN AN
EQUITABLE MANNER. THE THIRTY
THING I THINK IS INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE WE HEARD FROM
TODAY'S PANELISTS ABOUT
TREMENDOUS UNMET NEED ACROSS
OUR CORE HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES. WHETHER DUE TO
LONG WAIT LISTS UNDER FUNDED
PROGRAMS OR LACK OF
AVAILABILITY. BUILDING THE
STATE ROAD MAP FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT WITH
THE NECESSARY INVESTMENTS IS
CENTRAL TO A SUCCESSFUL MASTER
PLAN FOR AGENT. THE FORCED FOR
THEME BUT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
IS THAT OF THE WORK FORCE SO
EVEN IF WE BUILD OUT OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOP THE DATA
AND FULLY FUNDED PROGRAMS
WITHOUT A WORK FORCE PEOPLE
HAVE NOTHING I THINK OUR PRIOR
SPEAKERS EXPRESSED IT SO WELL.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A CULTURALLY
COMPETENT WELL TRAINED
WORKFORCE WITH QUALITY PAY BUT
HE BELIEVES IN I HAVE SOME OF
OUR INVESTING OUR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR TO. PROVIDE ADULTS IN THEIR
HOME. THE FINAL THING I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT REALLY UNDERCURRENTS
ALL OF THE MONSTER AND
AFTERWARDS AND THAT'S IT THAT
IS THE THEME OF LEADERSHIP
LEADERSHIP IS THE FOUNDATION OF
SYSTEM CHANGE AN EXAMPLE OF
EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE LEADERSHIP
HAS BEEN- DIRECTOR MCQUAY
WADE'S READ IN. I'M CALLING FOR
THE MASTER IN AND DEVELOPING A
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING BUT A
SUCCESSFUL LAUNCH OF THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING ALSO REQUIRES
ENGAGEMENT AND COLLABORATION
BETWEEN STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE PRIVATE SECTOR. THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE PLAYS A
CRITICAL ROLE. IN FILLING OUT
FOR TOGETHER TO DO THIS AND
MUST PLAN FOR ASIANS COMMITMENT
TO ESTABLISHING A SENIOR
ADVISER FOR AGING DISABILITY
AND OUTSIDERS WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS THE FIRST
CRITICAL STEP. TO ENSURING
CONTINUED PROGRESS IN THESE
EFFORTS. SO INCLUDING THESE
FIVE THEMES OF SEAMLESS SERVICE
DELIVERY DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
WORKFORCE AND LEADERSHIP ARE
EACH CRITICAL TO OUR MASTER
PLAN EFFORTS AND THESE ISSUES
ARE SIMILAR SIMILAR TO THOSE
ELEVATED ACROSS ALL PANELS
TODAY. ON ISSUES LIKE POVERTY
AND ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY
SHOWING THAT THE CHALLENGES
CONFRONTING OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
SIMILAR TO THOSE IMPACTING
CHILDREN IN FAMILIES. THE
SOLUTIONS MY VERY BUT THE
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES MUST BE CONSISTENT
ACROSS POPULATIONS. THERE WAS
TREMENDOUS HOPE THAT THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING ILL
FUNDAMENTALLY RE FRAME THE WAY
WE COLLECTIVELY FEEL AND START
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE TO PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. ENDING THE SIX
STIGMATA SOCIAIS DID WITH AGING
BECAUSE IN REALITY AGING IS ALL
OF US IT TOUCHES INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES COMMUNITIES EMPLOYERS
AND INSTITUTIONS THESE ISSUES
ARE EVERYONE'S ISSUES. THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TO BE HERE
TODAY AND I'M HAPPY. TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL NOW
BRING IT TO THE FOR QUEST AND-
I'M GONNA START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TIE- YOU. MUST ADMIT
TO BEING SURPRISED SEEING YOUR
REACTION TO THE AUDITORS-
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WANTED TO
GET AN UNDERSTANDING FROM YOU
IF YOU COULD OR GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO EXPLAIN FURTHER.
THANK YOU CHAIR KIM JOHNSON
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND DAD JUST START BY
SAYING THAT- WHILE WE DON'T
NECESSARILY AGREE WITH EVERY
RECOMMENDATION RAISED IN THE
REPORT WE STRONGLY STRONGLY
AGREE WITH THE GOAL OF ENSURING
THAT ALL. AGES THAT'S
RECIPIENTS TO THE STATE
RECEIVED THAT PROMPT APPROVAL
FOR SERVICES AND RECEIVE ALL
THE SERVICES THAT THEY'VE BEEN
APPROVED FOR SO. I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT- WE FULLY RECOGNIZE-
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT WE'VE HEARD
IN THIS PANEL AROUND THE
TREMENDOUS WORK THAT MANY MANY
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE COME TOGETHER
TO DEVELOP IN THE MASTER PLAN
OF AGING. AT THAT THE NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO GO LONG TERM
SERVICES SUBCOMMITTEE THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED ASK AGAIN ON THIS
PANEL- IT'S ABSOLUTELY ARE
CRITICAL OF PRIORITY WE HAVE A
FORMAL RESPONSE AS YOU AS
YOU'VE ALLUDED TO ADD TO THE
AUDIT IN THE SPECIFICS. SOME OF
THE- SPECIFICS WERE EVEN RAISED
IN TERMS OF WHAT THE AUDITOR I
DESCRIBED ON THE CONTEXT FOR
EXAMPLE OF WHY AN INDIVIDUAL
MAY NOT HAVE RECEIVED HOURS
WITHIN A GIVEN MONTH AGAIN
IT'LL WE ALLOW FOR RETROACTIVE.
PAYMENTS ONCE THE PROVIDER IS
IDENTIFIED NON LINE SO AGAIN-
BUT LOOK AT FULLY APPRECIATES
THE GOAL OF THE REPORT AT AND-
CERTAINLY- LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES RAISED WITH AN EX. AND
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. ACROSS THE STATE
THANKS. IF I CAN FOLLOW UP HOW
DO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE AND IT
IF WANNA- TOSS IT TO DENISE
THOMPSON THAT'S OKAY AS WELL.
BUT HOW DO WE ACHIEVE GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND QUALITY
WITHIN THIS PROGRAM I THINK-
FOR MANY OF US WE- LOOK
TOWARDS- WHAT IS IN STATE LAW
AND- BEHIND- BOTHERED AGAIN BY
WHAT THE AUDITOR STATED AND-
THE LACK OF INFORMATION WE HAVE
IS A LEGISLATURE. TIM GLAD TO
GLAD TO SUPPORT FELLOW
PANELISTS AND IN AT PROVIDING
THEIR OWN RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE SPACE BUT- AGAIN IN TERMS
OF ASSESSMENT IN TERMS OF THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST YEAR. TO ENSURE THAT THERE
WERE ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
TO ABBY ASSASSIN ALLOW FOR SOME
ABOUT TO OCCUR REMOTELY. THESE
ARE ALL WAYS THAT AGAIN WE ARE
ENSURING ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM.
AND CERTAINLY IN TERMS OF
TIMELINESS AS THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING
FROM THE STATE HAS BEEN A KEY
COMPONENT OF FACT THAT
CERTAINLY WOULD WELCOME AT AGE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND GLAD TO
CONTINUE EXPLORING WAYS TO
IMPROVE- MISS THOMPSON ARE YOU
ABLE TO COMMENT ON THIS. THE
GOOD EVENING HAS CERTAINLY- I
THINK THAT WE CERTAINLY DO
AGREE WITH THE PROMISE OF
SUPPORTING AND HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE AND ENSURING THAT
THINGS ARE BEING DONE IN THE
APPROPRIATE WAYS THAT SERVICES
ARE GETTING- CONNECTED TO OUR
RECIPIENTS AS THEY BECOME
ELIGIBLE I THINK THAT IT WAS-
SOME MIS UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE- PARTICULAR. LAND THAT'S
BEING REFERRED TO BY THE
AUDITOR IS REALLY AN OLD ARM.
AN OLD PLANNING TOOL THAT WAS
UTILIZED WHEN THEY COUNTIES
WERE ACTUALLY USING HOMEMAKERS
AND COUNTY STAFF WERE- THE
PROVIDERS OF SERVICE THE WAY
THAT WE DO PLANNING NOW AND THE
WAY THAT WE WORK WITH THE
COUNTIES AND ENSURING THAT
RECIPIENTS AND PROVIDERS ARE.
CONNECTED AND THAT SERVICES ARE
BEING PROVIDED IS A DIFFERENT
PROCESS NOT THAT ONE DOESN'T
EXIST AT ALL AND SO THAT IS A
CRITICAL THING THAT COUNTIES
WORK ON REGULARLY AND THAT WE
WORK WITH THEM ON ENSURING IT
IS HAPPENING. SO HOPE THAT
HELPS I'M I'M MAY MOVE US ON
AND- ASK NOW IF I CAN ABOUT THE
AUTOMATED TERMINATIONS THAT ARE
OCCURRING FOR HIGH HSS WANNA.
REDETERMINATION IS NOT
COMPLETE- I WILL- SHARE THAT-
FAMILY MEMBER OF MINE HAD AN
AUTOMATIC TERMINATION WHEN SHE
WAS IN AN I SEE YOU GOING
THROUGH- CRITICAL MOMENT BEFORE
SHE PASSED. AND IT WAS HARD FOR
US AS A FAMILY TO RECEIVE THE
AUTOMATIC TERMINATION FOR HER
NOT COMPLETING THE PAPERWORK
WHILE SHE WAS- GOING THROUGH
THAT AND SO I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND PREVALENT THIS IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT WE. CAN YOU
SPEAK TO WHY WE HAVE THE
NECESSITY FOR THE AUTOMATIC
TERMINATION. SO CURRENTLY
ACTUALLY THE AUTOMATED
TERMINATION IS NOT IN PLACE. IT
IS NOT IN POLICY AND DOES
HAPPEN TO COUNTY- PROCESSES
ALREADY SO IT'S NOT A NEW
POLICY AND WHAT IT REALLY IS
DRIVEN BY IS MEDIKAL
ELIGIBILITY AND IT REALLY HAS
TO DO WITH- EIGHT. ALIGNING IT
TO SILENCE AND MEDIKAL SO THAT
WHEN MEDICARE WAS TERMINATED AS
EVERY OTHER I AM MEDICAL
BENEFIT IT OCCURS THAT THAT
BENEFIT IS ALSO I'M NOT
AVAILABLE WHAT WE REALLY ARM
HAVE FOUND AND I'VE- WORKED IN
THIS PROGRAM IN THE COUNTY FOR
MANY MANY YEARS ALSO. AND WHAT
WHAT HAPPENS IS OFTENTIMES THE
LOSE MEDIC HOW AND NOT- AND NOT
BE AWARE OF IT WHEREAS A
OFTENTIMES WHEN THEY GET I HSS
NOTICES THEY BECOME AWARE THAT
SOMETHING HAS HAPPENED WITH
PARAMEDIC HOUSE AND THAT
ACTUALLY PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO RECONNECT THEM
WITH MEDIC COW BECAUSE WITH I
JUST AS THERE IS A SOCIAL
WORKER THERE IS COUNTY STAFF
THAT ARE AVAILABLE. TO HELP
FACILITATE THAT PROCESS THE
INTENT IS TO GET PEOPLE BACK ON
TO THEIR MEDICARE OUT AND THE
AUTOMATION ACTUAL WE WILL ALSO
AUTOMATICALLY RECONNECT PEOPLE
WHEN THEY ARE- REESTABLISH
THEIR MEDIC HOW RATHER THAN
REQUIRE- THE CURRENT PROCESS
WHICH IS MANUAL THAT WHEN THEY
RE ESTABLISH. THE IT REQUIRES
THE COUNTY TO TAKE AN ACTION TO
REESTABLISH THEIR AYE IT JUST
SUCKS SO WE HOPE THAT THAT ON
MATT NATION WILL ALSO SUPPORT
THAT. RECONNECTION IN A MUCH.
MORE EFFICIENT WAY AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANSWER BUT I
STILL BELIEVE THERE IS A BIT OF
CONFUSION AND SO I MAY ASK FOR
A MEETING SOON BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT STAFF L. A. N. O.
AND C. W. D. A. SO WE CAN WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE ISSUES IF
YOU'RE AMENABLE TO THAT. I'M OF
COURSE HAPPY TO HAVE ANY
CONVERSATIONS WOULD LIKE TO
TRANSITION NOW IF I CAN TO THE
7% FOR HIGH HSS AND- REALLY WAS
STRUCK DURING THE COMMENTS THAT
THIS WAS THE PREVIOUS RECESSION
NOT TE CURRENT RECESSION THEN
WERE END AND I'M WONDERING WHEN
WE PLAN ON REMOVING THE 7%
REDUCTION- FROM THE BOOKS. SOON
THERE IS NOT A CURRENT PROPOSAL
TO REMOVE THAT FROM THE
STATUTE. ON THAT AS WE TALKED
ABOUT IT HAS NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED IT IS CONTINUED TO
BE SUSPENDED. ON SO I DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANY OTHER. OFFER HI
I WOULD HIGHLIGHT THE- FINDINGS
FROM THE AUDITOR'S REPORT ABOUT
PAY FOR THOSE WHO I HSS WORKERS
AND I JUST RECOMMEND THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE- BEING
INTELLECTUALLY HONEST. ABOUT
THE PROPOSALS THAT WE'RE
PUTTING FORWARD- IF I CAN I
WILL NOW MOVES ON TO THE
PERCENTAGE CHANGE AND WANTED TO
GET AN UNDERSTANDING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION REGARDING THE
SIXTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE. SPLIT
AND WHY IT WAS BEING SHIFTED
AND- JUST YOUR THOUGHT PROCESS
BEHIND THAT. I'M WONDERING IF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MIGHT
BE IT THE BETTER- RESPONDER ON
THIS I DON'T KNOW IF JUSTIN
STILL HERE- I CAN CERTAINLY
EXPLAIN THE- YOU KNOW WHAT'S IN
THE CURRENT STATUTE AS FAR AS
HOW IT HOW IT WORKS. HAPPY TO
DO THAT AND THEN IF YOU WANT TO
ADD ANYTHING ON SO. I IN THE
LAST- REALIGNMENT LOOKING AT
THE REALIGNMENT REPORT AND THE
LAST REVIEW BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- HOW THE AND- WE'VE
WORKED ON THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF- ANALYSIS. TO DETERMINE THE
BEST APPROACH TO INCLUDING
DISCUSSIONS WITH WITH C. STARK
AND- COUNTIES TO DETERMINE THE
BEST APPROACH TO THE FUNDING
STRUCTURE FOR THE PROGRAM AS
YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE FOR MANY
MANY MANY YEARS IT WAS A
STRAIGHT SPLIT UP THE PROGRAM
COSTS BETWEEN. THAT THE FEDS
AND THEN THE REMAINING SHARE
BEING SPLIT SIXTY FIVE THIRTY
FIVE BETWEEN THAT STATE AND THE
COUNTIES- IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE WE BEGAN TO THE
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT AND BACK
THEN WAS REPEAT RE BASED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND THEN.
REVIEWED AGAIN- AS A PART OF
THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
PROCESS THERE WAS THE AND OUT
THE- REQUIREMENT TO DO AN
ANALYSIS FOR THAT- REALIGNMENTS
FUNDING AND TO LOOK AT THAT.
AND THAT THEN THE NEW ARE
NINETEEN TWENTY WAS IMPLEMENTED
THE MOST RECENT MLB- THAT
INCLUDES THE ANNUAL INFLATOR
FOR THE COUNTIES AND THEN THERE
UP PARTICIPATION IN ANYTHING
THAT'S LOCALLY BARGAINS. OUT OF
AN INCREASE AND THE INCREASED
DATA OUR SWITCH- TO A SIXTY
FIVE COUNTY THIRTY FIVE STATE-
AND IT ALSO REMOVED THE
PARTICIPATION CAP. SO THAT THE
STATE WILL PARTICIPATE IN
ANYTHING THAT'S BARGAINED BY
THE COUNTIES AT 35% WHEREAS
WITH THE PARTICIPATION CAP.
ANYTHING ABOVE- I THAT STATE
CAP WAS A HUNDRED CHEN FUND OF
THE OF THE NON FEDERAL. SO
THAT'S- AND OF WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW AND I INVITE FINANCE
IF THEY HAVE ANYTHING TO AND-
I'M NOT. YES DOESN'T REYES
FORMER FINANCE- I'M ACTUALLY
GOING TO NEED TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF
THE STRUCTURE OF CITIES HEARING-
THERE ARE A LOT OF CROSS OVER A
CROSS CUTTING ISSUES THEY HAD
DIFFERENT AREAS AND THIS
UNFORTUNATELY IS ONE OF THE
ONES THAT I DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION FOR YOU AT THE
MOMENT DOCTOR AND NOT SO- IF
IT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR STAFF. ON
GETTING THAT RESPONSE WERE YOU.
HAPPY TO- THANK YOU FOR THAT. I
WILL. I WILL LEAVE IT THERE FOR
NOW IF THAT'S ALRIGHT- I WILL
ASK- FOR KATHY SANDERLING
MCDONALD'S WITH CWD EIGHT TO
COME INTO THE CONVERSATION I'D
LIKE TO GET HER PERSPECTIVE-
REGARDING A FEW OF THE THINGS
WE JUST SPOKE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT SPECIFICALLY
I'D LIKE TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS
ON AUTOMATED TERMINATIONS FOR
HSS WHEN. WE DETERMINATION IS
NOT COMPLETE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'M HAPPY TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS ON THAT ON THAT
PROPOSAL. WE THINK THIS
PROPOSAL NEEDS SIGNIFICANT WORK
IF IT'S CONSIDERED AN ALL IN
PARTICULAR THE IDEA THAT A
PERSON LOSING THAT ACCOUNTS AND
ALSO AUTOMATICALLY LOSE AYE TO
FAST. AND ONLY BE REINSTATED
AFTER THEY ARE PUT BACK ON TO
THE SYSTEM OF MEDIC HEALTH IS
HIGHLY INEQUITABLE TERM
RECIPIENTS AND WOULD RESULT IN
A LOSS OF SERVICES. OUR
RECIPIENTS HEALTH AND WELL
BEING IN SERIOUS JEOPARDY.
REMEMBER OUR RECIPIENTS MUST
MEET AND INCOME TAX TO QUALIFY
FOR THE SERVICES THEY ARE NOT
WELL OFF. THE IDEA THAT THEY
COULD SOMEHOW COME UP WITH
FUNDS TO PAY PROVIDERS IN THE
TIME BETWEEN A MEDICAL
DISCONTINUANCE AND
REINSTATEMENT AS- THE LEADER
THINKING AND SO THAT SOME OF
THE IDEA THAT A PROVIDER. CAN
CONTINUE WORKING FOR FREE IN
THE HOPE THAT THE RECIPIENT
WILL BE REINSTATED TO THE
PROGRAM- I MEAN PEOPLE HAVE TO
MAKE A LIVING THEY CAN'T WORK
FOR FREE. THE PROVIDERS WILL
HAVE TO GO FIND ANOTHER
RECIPIENT TO WORK FOR FIND A
NEW JOB IF THEY'RE NOT BEING
PAID FOR POTENTIALLY MONTHS
BEFORE THAT PERSON IS
REINSTATED. AT A MINIMUM WE
COULD SAY IF THIS IS
CONSIDERED. RECIPIENTS SHOULD
RECEIVE SERVICE RECEIVE
SERVICES FOR A MUCH LONGER
GRACE PERIOD. THE NAVY
CONTEMPLATED. FOR OUR WE'VE
BEEN TALKING EARLIER RIGHT THAT
MEDICARE RECIPIENTS NOW HAVE A
NINETY DAY GRACE PERIOD. TO BE
REINSTATED AFTER DISCONTINUING
SO THEY MAY BE DISCONTINUED AND
THREE MONTHS LATER THEY COME
BACK IN. WITH THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY COULD NOT PROVIDE-
MOST OFTEN IT IS THAT. FAILURE
TO PROVIDE A DOCUMENT OR SOME
PIECE OF INFORMATION TO BE ABLE
TO RENEW THEIR COVERAGE.
COUNTIES ARE THEN HELP THEM GET
ON TO MEDICARE ALL. SO WHY
WOULD WE NOT WAIT. CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR PERSON AND
I HAD TO FIVE. AND GIVEN THAT
PERIOD OF TIME FOR THEM TO BE
REINSTATED AGAIN IF WE EVEN IF
YOU'RE EVEN CONSIDERING KIND OF
GOING FORTH WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
I THINK THE L. A. O. DOES. I
WAS. PRETTY NEW STAFFER AT
CEDAR BDA WHEN WE BEGAN TO
REFINANCE THE ITEMS THAT'S
PROGRAM WHICH AT THAT TIME. WAS
STILL RELATIVELY SMALL BUT HAD
STARTED TO GROW ESPECIALLY AS A
RESULT OF THE REQUIREMENT FOR
COUNTIES TO DO THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WITH OUR- ITEMS
THAT'S PROVIDERS. AND SO- AS A
STATE EVERYONE BE KIND OF YOU
KNOW KIND OF BEGAN LOOKING
AROUND. AND SO WAS OVER TIME IN
A NUMBER OF CHUNKS THAT WE RE
AND YOU KNOW WE FINANCED THE
PROGRAM TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THE RESIDUAL
PROGRAM WAS WHAT WAS LEFT- UP
UNTIL THIS POINT. I'VE NEVER
REALLY THOUGHT ABOUT IT BEING-
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULDN'T JUST
MOVE PEOPLE INTO IF THEY WERE
FASTER MEDICARE I'LL- AND THEN
HOPEFULLY GET THEM REINSTATED
MOVE THEM BACK INTO THE REGULAR
PROGRAM. RATHER THAN JUST YOU
KNOW COMPLETELY CUT THEM OFF. I
THINK INCLUDING IT SEEMS LIKE
WE SHOULD JUST AFTER SOME OF
THE FIFTH IS THIS REALLY THE
TIME WE WANT TO BE KICKING.
ADULTS AND CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES OFTEN PROGRAM THAT
IS DESIGNED TO HELP IT WOULD
SAFELY AT HOME. I MEAN WE'RE IN
A GLOBAL PANDEMIC THAT HAS MOST
THAT OUR ELDERS AND INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES LIVING IN
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES. AND
THIS JUST SEEMS LIKE MAYBE NOT
THE TIME. TO CUT PEOPLE OFF
FROM SERVICES THEY NEED
ESPECIALLY SERVICES ARE GETTING
TO HELP AVOID THAT TYPE. OF
CHARACTER FIRST PLACE. I AGREE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE RESPONSE-
WOULD TO IF I COULD. UP AND GET
YOUR IF YOU. ON THE AUDITORS
FINDINGS- AND THE RESPONSE THAT
WE HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. HELLO SIR I AM
HAPPY TO ALSO PROVIDE- SOME
BOTS FIRST. MISTER CHAIR
BANKING YOUR INDULGENCE I DO-
JUST WANT TO- HI I CAN. EARLIER
I CONCLUDE MY REMARKS WITHOUT
REMEMBERING CHECKS PRIVACY TO
BE A SUPPORT FOR THE SHARING
RATIO PROPOSAL THE JACKSON
GARRETT FROM C. SACK PRESENTED
AND ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH
HIS REMARKS IN OPPOSITION TO
THE PENALTY PROPOSAL THAT MEANS
YOU PRESENTE- QUICKLY I JUST
ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS YOU.
SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON THE AGENDA
AND FINALLY THE SINCERELY THANK
YOU ON BEHALF OF OUR COALITION
YOUR CHAMPIONING OF THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE END
OF THE SUMMER REGARDING A STATE
AUDIT WORK CONTINUING TO
EXPLORE THE AUDITORS FINDINGS
BUT CAN ALSO SURELY THAT COUNTY
ONE OF THE ALL ITEMS THAT
CONSUMERS RECEIVE THE SERVICES
THEY ARE AUTHORIZED TO RECEIVE.
WE DO SUPPORT THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION TO USE THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS TO
ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
COUNTIES TO INCREASE WAGES FOR
PROVIDERS AS WELL. AND
OBVIOUSLY WE ALSO NOTED IF YOU
DID A LONG PERIOD OF TIME IT IS
TAKING TO PROCESS INCOMING
CASES. WE JUST THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE HERE THE
RESOURCE CONSTRAINTS UNDER
WHICH COUNTIES OPERATE ITEMS
THAT'S ON THE STATE THAT. WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THE LACK
OF SOCIAL WORKER RESOURCES IN
ADDITION TO THE BURDENSOME
PAPERWORK REQUIREMENTS WE'VE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THAT
STRETCH THE ENROLLMENT PROCESS.
OUT FOR THE LEVEL FOUND IN THE
AUDIT. I NEED TO MADE UNDER FOR
THAT CAR OF OUR STAFF. DURING
MOST OF THE- REVIEW BY THE ON
THAT FIVE TO TWENTY NINETEEN.
NINETY EIGHT. COSTS WERE FUNDED
AT TWO. THREE THOUSAND AND ONE
STAFF CLASS LEVELS. MORE THAN
FIFTEEN YEARS BEHIND THE ACTUAL
COST OF DOING BUSINESS DURING
THOSE YEARS. THE STAFFING COST
ASSUMPTIONS WERE FINALLY RE
BASED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUT IT WAS USING
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BETA. AND
SINCE THAT TIME THE COST OF NOT
BEEN UPDATED AGAIN THERE'S NO
MECHANISM TO DO SO
AUTOMATICALLY AND COUNTIES WERE
OVERALL HOLD STAGNANT FOR
COUNTY ADMINISTRATION FUNDING.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO WE
FELL BEHIND IN THE CLASS OF
ACTUALLY ADMINISTERING THE
PROGRAM NOT JUST STAFFING
COSTS. SO THEY'RE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET THAT
YOU'RE NOW CONSIDERING PROPOSAL
TO CATCH COUNTIES UPPER CASE
LOAD GROWTH. BUT NOT FOR THE
ACTUAL COST OF THE COUNTY
WORKER SO ALREADY BEFORE YEARS
BEHIND OUR ACTUAL COSTS WHEN
YOU ADOPT THE BUDGET THAT
YOU'RE CONSIDERING. SO AS YOU
CAN SEE THE STOPS AND STARTS A
COUNTY ADMIN FUNDING AND THE
HISTORIC UNDERFUNDING OF ACTUAL
STAFF COST. SIMPLY DO NOT MAKE
IT EASY FOR COUNTIES THE PLAN
OF OUR- TO FULLY SERVE OUR
CLIENTS AND REQUIRED TIMELINES
AS WE. WOULD LIKE TO DO. THANK
YOU. I WILL JUST A FIVE CAN IF
THAT PERCENTAGE CHANGE COAST.
I'M TO ECHO THAT COMMENTS AND
CONCERN REGARDING PUBLIC HEALTH%
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
THAT THE COUNTY WILL BE
PROVIDING AND HAVING TO. NOW
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT. WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO NOW AS MY FINAL
QUESTION OF THE L. A. O. AND
I'D LIKE TO- SIMILARLY AS WE
DISCUSSED BEFORE- CAN YOU HELP
US. TO CAN YOU DISCUSS WHAT
FUNDS CAN BE MADE AVAILABLE- IN
ADVANCE OF THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING IN THE RECENTLY APPROVED
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. SURE I'M
HAPPY TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO THAT
QUESTION I THINK AS PANELIST
HAVE MENTIONED THERE ARE FUNDS
THAT ARE DIRECTLY YEAR MARKED
TO- AGING PROGRAMS LIKE THE
OLDER AMERICAN ACTS PROGRAMS
THAT INCLUDE NUTRITION SERVICES
AND LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN.
I'M ADDITIONALLY THERE'S-
FUNDING PROVIDED TO INCREASE
THE FOR A MEDIC CAL F. MAP FOR
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS. THAT COULD POSSIBLY
NOT ONLY ASSIST THE STATE IN
MAINTAINING SERVICE LEVELS BUT
TO ENSURE WE EXPAND ACCESS TO
THESE LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS WHICH IS A
RECOMMENDATION WITHIN THE
MASTER PLAN- FOR AGING IDENTIFY
WAYS TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
LTSS. BUT BEYOND TO THOSE I'M
FUNDS THAT ARE DIRECTLY YEAR
MARKED- FOR AGING PROGRAMS- OUR
OFFICE IS STILL EVALUATING THE
AVAILABLE USES OF THE MORE
GENERAL STATE PUBLIC NINETEEN
RELIEF FUNDS- BUT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED IN THE RECENT FEDERAL
ACTION- INITIAL QUESTIONS THAT
COME TO MIND WHAT AS THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONSIDERING.
POSSIBLE USES FOR THOSE MORE
GENERAL FUND INCLUDE WELL ONE
HOW RESTRICTIVE- ARE THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS ON THE
APPROPRIATE USES FOR THOSE
FUNDS I'M COULD THOSE FUNDS
POSSIBLY BE USED TO PROVIDE I'M
DIRECT FUNDING PAYMENTS TO
RECIPIENTS OF STATE PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS LIKE WE DID
UNDER THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS- THERE'S A QUESTION OF
WHETHER THE LEGISLATURE. SHOULD
TARGET THE RESOURCES TO
INDIVIDUALS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
OTHER FEDERAL STIMULUS PAYMENTS
IN THE PAST- BUT THEN ALSO
THERE'S A QUESTION OF COULD
THESE FUNDS BE USED TO EASE THE
RAMP DOWN. OF PREVIOUSLY
PROVIDED TEMPORARY FEDERAL
FUNDS- AT GOT INCREASED TO
SERVICE DELIVERY LEVELS. FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE SENIOR NUTRITION.
BUT AGAIN AND ARE JUST A PART
BACK TO MY IN OUR OFFICE I WILL
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE
CONCRETE COMMENTS AS WE-
CONTINUE TO REVIEW THE ACT AND
ALSO REVIEW ANY GUIDANCE THAT'S
PROVIDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON EXACTLY WHAT THE
FEDERAL FUNDS CAN BE SPENT ON.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT IF I
COULD AND HIGHLIGHT ONE OF THE-
BEST DATA POINTS I HEARD TODAY
AND IT WAS FROM HER DIRECTOR
60% INCREASE IN MEALS DELIVERED
FROM EIGHTEEN MILLION TO.
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION I JUST DO
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING GOOD WORK
AND- WANTED TO MENTION THAT.
FOR WE MOVE FORWARD I'D LIKE TO
NOW EMPHASIZE THE SUB COMMITTEE
REQUESTS THAT ARE MADE IN THE
AGENDA AT THE END OF ISSUE FIVE
THAT ARE ON PAGE ONE HUNDRED
AND THREE. THESE ARE THAT WE
REQUEST THAT THE L. A. O. MAKE
A LISTING OF THE ACTIVE
PROPOSALS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. ADVOCATES LABOR
PARTNERS AND COUNTIES THAT
MENTIONED IN THE AGENDA AND HOW
EACH ONE MAY OR MAY NOT HELP US
TO MEET. THE GOALS OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING. IT IS
REQUESTED THAT THIS LISTING
COME BACK TO THE SUB COMMITTEE
BY THE END OF APRIL. CAN I ASK
IF THERE IS ANY FEEDBACK OR
REACTION AT THIS TIME FROM THE
L. A. O. OR ADMINISTRATION TO
THIS REQUEST. THIS IS JACKIE
I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH STAFF.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THAT
INFORMATION TO YOU I WILL MAKE
A PLUG FOR THE STAKEHOLDERS
THAT ARE IN THIS PANEL BUT
ALSO- THAT ARE LISTENING IF YOU
DO HAVE A PROPOSAL THAT'S
RELATED TO THE MASTER PLAN. I'M
PREACHING PLEASE SEND IT TO US
IT WILL DEFINITELY HELP US WITH
THIS REQUEST. THANK YOU AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO- THAT FOLLOW
UP- WITH THAT I WILL THANK- ALL
OF PANEL FIVE IN ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS THUS FAR. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
COMMENT. AS A REMINDER WE
WELCOME PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY
ISSUE IN THE AGENDA INCLUDING
THE NON PRESENTATION ISSUES
WHICH ARE CONTAINED IN PART TWO
OF THIS AGENDA. WE HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND THEREFORE I
WANT TO URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS BRIEF SO THAT WE CAN
HEAR FROM EVERYONE. ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE- THERE ARE
NOT ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
CURRENTLY IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
TOO SO WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINE. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AS A REMINDER THE PHONE NUMBER
TO CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND ALSO SHOULD BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER
IS TOLL FREE ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AT 916-319-2090
NINE. AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU. OPERATOR WE ARE
READY TO BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT
ON OUR FIRST CALLER. THANK YU
SEE LIKE TO ASK PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND OUR FIRST CALLER BE
FROM LINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANKS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY I AM CHRIS BURNS TO
GET EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF BOYS
AND GIRLS ARE REPUBLIC SERVING
OVER HUNDREDS OF STR KIKI USE
FROM A DOZEN COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM ANGELES
SHORT AND THE BUDGET REQUEST OF
COURSE STONER MERTZ AS TIER TWO
KEYS ARE THE I. C. U. OF THE
SIX YEAR CONTINUE ON PROVIDING
CRITICAL THERAPEUTIC
INTERVENTION. FOR FOSTER YOUTH
NEEDING THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
CARE THAT ADDRESSES THEIR
TRAUMA AND MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
IN A TEMPORARY RESIDENTIAL
SETTING MUCH LIKE ICU NURSES
AND DOCTORS DURING AND JUST
ENDEMIC USE NEEDS WERE
EXTRAORDINARY AND HINGED UPON
THE UNWAVERING COMMITMENT OF
THIS YEAR TO BE STAFF COMING TO
WORK EACH DAY. IN FEAR FOR
THEIR OWN HEALTH TO PROVIDE
CARE NECESSARY TO ASSIST THESE
TRAUMATIZE YOU THAT DAILY
COMMITMENT CAME A TREMENDOUS
FINANCIAL EXPENSE THAT POSES A
THREAT TO OUR OPERATIONS WHEN
TREATMENT NEEDS FOR OUT OF
STATE YOU AND THOSE
TRANSITIONING FROM DJJ ARE
INCREASING NEED FOR HIGH
QUALITY OF SECURITY PLACEMENTS.
BUT AN INDESCRIBABLY
CHALLENGING HERE TO DELIVER
THESE SERVICES BUT THEY WERE
DELIVERED CONTINUOUSLY AND
ENCOURAGE THEM TO SUPPORT THE
HEALING OF THESE YOUTH AND
FAMILIES DESPITE THE
OVERWHELMING COSTS. I THANK YOU
AND REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCES ONE TIME
CODE NINETEEN REIMBURSEMENT
REQUEST TO REIMBURSE US HERE TO
PLEASE CRICKLEWOOD NINETEEN
RELATED COSTS TO ENSURE THE
ONGOING STABILITY HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF YOUTH FAMILIES AND
STAFF THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
MEADOW COME FROM ONLINE- NINE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DRAW AND
I WANTED SOME WERE THE HSS.
NUMBER FIVE- THE AGENCY THAT'S
CONNECTED TO MY PUBLIC ATTORNEY
NINE GALLATIN CARE SERVICES
REFUSED TO PROVIDE ME SERVICES
WHEN I HAD CALLED AND I WAS
TOLD BY THE REGISTRY- AND
EMPLOYEE THAT IT WAS WITHIN
THEIR CONTRACT REFUSED TO
REFUSED TO GIVE SERVICES TO-
PEOPLE THAT ECOBANK TESTING.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO- HAVE
PEOPLE NOT NOT GIVE SERVICES
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE UNDER
CONTRACT WHEN PEOPLE NEED
SERVICES THE MOST THAT'S NOT
RIGHT- SECOND OF ALL I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT. CURRENTLY THE
REGISTRY SYSTEM DOES NOT WORK-
IF YOU'RE LOOKING TO GET ANY
REGISTRY IT'S DISPENSED AND
GIVE INDEPENDENT WHICH IS VERY
RARE. SYSTEM ONLY WORKS NINETY
FIVE AND WE NEED TO REGISTRY
SYSTEM THAT IS TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN BECAUSE OUR LIVES OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES DON'T
END AT FIVE O'CLOCK. AND ALSO
THE- THE LIFT AND- REPUBLICANS
ALREADY BACKUP SYSTEM EXCLUDES
SERVICES FOR THOSE WITH PARA
MEDICAL NEEDS. AND WE I ALSO
JUST WANT TO ADD DEBT- WE NEED
DIFFERENT TO WAIT IS FOR
PROVIDERS WORKING FOR PEOPLE
WITH SEVERE DISABILITIES AND
SENIORS. WHEN THE RECIPIENT HAS
LOCAL PROVIDERS AND WHERE AT
LEAST ONE IS A NON RELATIVE AND
IF WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THIS
SYSTEM. EQUITABLE WE NEED TO
FIND- WEEK YOU ONLY GET WAGES
AND FIND WAYS TO INCENTIVIZE.
PEOPLE TO BE CARE GIVERS
BECAUSE- A LOT OF MY CHECK YOUR
RESERVE SEVENTY PLUS AND WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO GET
PEOPLE TO BECAUSE THAT. YOU
KNOW TO INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO
BECOME CARE GIVERS AND GIVE
THEM A LIVING WAGE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WELCOME LINE OF ONLINE.
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELLIE DANIEL
WITH THE CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE
WE ARE HUMAN SERVICE AGENCIES
SEVEN LOS ANGELES COUNTY FOR US
IT'S SIMPLE EVERY CHILD TEEN
AND ADULT DESERVES TO LIVE A
HEALTHY AND HAPPY LIFE CENTRAL
CORE WORKING DAHLE GENERATION
WRAPAROUND STRATEGY PROVIDING
TRAUMA INFORMED RESTRICTED.
ABOUT PERSONAL FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY CAPACITY FOR HEALING
WELL NOT EXACTLY I REMEMBER THE
TRUTH AND JUSTICE AND HOW
BEFORE COALITION A COLITION OF
DOZENS OF COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
AND DRIVER'S LICENSE
SUSPENSIONS FOR INABILITY TO
PAY CHILD SUPPORT ENSURE THAT
1100% OF ALL CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS GO DIRECTLY TO
CHILDREN AND ELIMINATE
GOVERNMENT- CHILD SUPPORT GAS
AND 10% INTEREST PAYMENTSON
THIS DEBT. BUT CHILDREN WE
BELIEVE THAT 1100% OF CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS SHOULD BE
DIRECTED TO A CHILD BY DOING
THAT INSURES THAT THE WELL
BEING OF THE WHOLE FAMILY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU. AND
THAT'LL COME FROM LINE OF THAT.
YEAR LINE OF. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M KEVIN MCALLISTER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR MILTON WILL
SACRAMENTO IN PRESIDENT OF
MEALS ON WHEELS CALIFORNIA
DURING THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC MEALS ON WHEELS
PROGRAM SAW SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN OPERATING COSTS
DUE TO THE PROFOUND INCREASE IN
THE LEVEL OF FOOD ASSISTANCE
NEEDED IN OUR COMMUNITY- AS YOU
HEARD EARLIER THERE IS ALSO A
60% INCREASE IN THE DELIVERY OF
MAILS ACROSS CALIFORNIA DURING
THE FIRST YEAR THE PANDEMIC.
ALSO THIRTEEN MEALS ON WHEELS
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE HAVE
INCREASED OUR NUMBER OF MEALS
SERVED BY MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT. SACRAMENTO WE ARE
DELIVERING TWELVE THOUSAND
MILES PER WEEK AND SERVING OVER
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED SENIORS
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED WITH THE
GREAT PLATE PROGRAM'S EVENTUAL
ENDING AN UNMET NEED THAT WILL
REMAIN. OTHER ADULTS HAVE
SUFFERED ENORMOUSLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND THEIR NUTRITIONAL
NEEDS WILL ONLY INCREASE DUE TO
PROLONGED ISOLATION MELVIN
SOCIAL CONNECTION WE PROVIDE
THEM FOR ALL THAT IS KEEPING
THEM FROM HUNGER AND ISOLATION
THESE REASONS WE HAVE REQUEST
THE DOUBLING OF THE STATE
INVESTMENT INTO NUTRITION AT A
MINIMUM. BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THAT ADMINISTRATION TO
ENSURE ADEQUATE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY FOR
SENIORS ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. CUNEDDACOME
FROM ONE OF TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE OF OUR FIFTY TWO I'M SORRY
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS SUSAN
BULLARD AND I'M FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND I'M A
RETIRED FOSTER CARE NURSE WHO
COORDINATED THE HEALTH CARE OF
THE BALL DURING PROBATION YEARS
FOR PARKING AT LEAST EIGHTEEN
YEARS. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION OF A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ORGANIZATION. SPREAD
SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND HEALTHY
FUTURES FOR FOSTER YOUTH
PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE INFANT
SUPPLEMENT. YOU MAY NOT REALIZE
IT BUT OFTENTIMES CHILDBIRTH.
AND PRENATAL CLASSES ARE NOT
FREE. I DID CARTHY CALLS FROM A
HUNDRED TO THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. A MONTH SUPPLY OF
DIAPERS CAN BE AS MUCH AS SIXTY
DOLLARS AND THESE ARE JUST A
FEW OF THE CENTRAL OF NEEDED
BACK PREGNANT AND PARENTING
TEENS. THE MAIN REASON HOW
REFER THIS FUNDING IS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO PREVENT
MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY. I'VE
PERSONALLY PARTICIPATED IN
CHILD DEATH REVIEW TEAM WHERE
WE REVIEWED A PREGNANT KING'S
DEATH THAT WAS TOTALLY
PREVENTABLE. PREGNANCIES ARE
HIGH RISK AND THEY DESERVE OUR
SUPPORT TO REDUCE THAT RISK
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU. THE NEXT ONE WILL COME
FROM NINE OF THE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE. SIXTY
FIVE- MY NAME IS NANCY RECORD
LISA I YEAH MARKET PROMOTER
FROM PEOPLE TO ALASKA IN
COLLABORATION WITH IBM I AM
ALSO A PARTY WITH A GUY IN THE
FOURTH GRADE. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE GIRL.
OF THE GLORIA GRAHAM PROGRAM. I
NOT WANT TO GO. I SAID. I KNOW
DAY OF CHALLENGES I NEED FOR A
CURRENT. THE SUN WILL PROVIDE
FAMILIES WITH THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED TO ADDRESS INEQUITIES
OKAY SEVEN. WE IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF THE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND WE NEED TO ALSO
SAVE FORTY WAITED FUTURE FOR
OUR CHEATING. I HAVE COME TO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO
REPLICATE IS A WELCOMING
NEIGHBORHOOD MODEL TO ALLOW
CALIFORNIA. THEY FAMILIES NEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES WITH YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS OFFLINE SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD SEVEN
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS SETH
BERMAN AND I AM A DIRECTOR AT
THE UNITED WAY OF ANY AGO
COUNTY AND NUMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CRADLE TO CAREER
COALITION. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR CRADLE TO CAREER
GRANT PROGRAM THAT WILL
STREAMLINE SERVICES IN TARGET
NEEDED RESOURCES TO COMMUNITIES
HI. UNITED WAY IS ALIGNED WITH
PARTNERS WHETHER THEY BE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
PRIVATE SECTOR BUSINESSES OTHER
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
AND EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN. BUT
THE INTENTION OF LEVERAGING OUR
RESOURCES SO WE NEED TRANSFORM
COMMUNITIES FOR THE BETTER.
IT'S QUITE A CAREER GRANT
PROGRAM THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS. WELL
MEANS THERE ARE MORE RESOURCES
FOR US TO LEVERAGE IN SUPPORT
OF OUR COMMUNITY THAT NEED IT
MOST. IT WILL EMPOWER COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND ALLOW FOR A MORE
COORDINATED SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITY TO JUST
TRY TO ADDRESS CHILD POVERTY SO
AGAIN I EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS GRANT PROGRAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE TURN TO
LINE EIGHT FIVE. EIGHT FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JULIA DIMARTINO- RESIDENT K.
WHAT CALIFORNIA- COMMUNITY
LEADER AND SELF PROMOTER OF
PEOPLE STILL BAPTIST HEALTH
CENTER I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR THE FUNDING FOR
CRADLE TO CAREER GRANT PROGRAM
AT THE COLLABORATIVE WORK CARRY
OUT BY THOSE PARTNERS INVOLVED
IN WHAT IS KNOWN AS HE WHAT
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD. PROVIDING
A VARIETY OF SERVICES THAT
TRULY MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
THEIR FAMILY'S LIFE FROM
CONNECTING THEM WITH FELLOW
EDUCATION HEALTH SERVICES
ACADEMIC SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN
WHAT IS THE CASE YOUR
OPPORTUNITIES AND A CHANCE TO
DEVELOP LEADERSHIP SKILLS AND
CIVIC PARTICIPATION AS WELL.
OUR COMMUNITY INCLUDING MYSELF
HAVE RECEIVED NOT ON HELP BUT-
BUT STILL NEEDED TO TRANSFORM
OUR FIVE MINUTES LIKE WE WANT
THESE WHAT TO CONTINUE AND THAT
SPREAD TO OTHER COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. IT'LL COME FROM
OF SIX FIVE YOUR LINE OPEN. IN
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU HAVE A SON MUTE. OKAY WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT LINE OF
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS CAROLYN
NEVER YOUR FAULT WRITTEN.
COMEDIAN FIVE AMELIA THOUGHT UP
TO A COMBAT CENTER WE I THINK
WE ARE A COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTER. THIRTEEN THE
UNDERSERVED POPULATION FOR
FIFTY YEARS. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THE CRY
TO CAREER GRANT PROGRAM. HE
THAT WOULD ALLOCATE FIFTY GIGS
PER MONTH. PROVIDES CRITICAL
RESOURCES IN THE ECONOMY HI YOU
NEED IN OUR COMMUNITY. THIS
GRANT FUNDING WILL BE YOU SHINE
I'M COMEY POVERTY AND HELP TO
CLOSE THE- GAP ACTUALLY TO
HEALTH AND EDUCATION. A PERSON
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH OUR
COMMUNITY I KNOW THAT COMMUNITY
INVESTMENT LED THE CROWD TO
CAREER GRAHAM PROGRAM IS
NEEDED. YOU GOT TO HELP TO
REDUCE CHILD ON COMEY PUBLICLY
YOU WOULD HAVE TO EMPOWER WOMEN
AND TRANSFORM. COMMUNITIES OR-
THE QUALITY I'M BUT MEDIA AGAIN
THEIR WAY OKAY. IT WOULD BE.
I'M PEOPLE HOW A LOT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALL PLEASE THANK YOU AND
THAT'LL COME FROM CHINA ONE OF
FIVE YOUR LINER OPEN. THIRTY MY
NAME SHERMAN WITH THE CORPORATE
FOR OF HOUSING MY ORGANIZATION
AND TO HER MILLION I HUNT.
MEMBERS THE CALA HOME COLD AS
URGE LET'S JUST TO TRY THE
WORST TO HER. TO INCORPORATING
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY ONE THE
BUDGET THE STATE NEEDS A
COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS WE NEED TO BUILD
AND FUNDAMENTAL SYSTEM SERVICES
AND INTERMENT OUR PENSIONS AND
THE SET ASIDE FOR YOU. WE NEED
PREVENTION THAT IS HIGHLY
TARGETED TO THOSE MOST LIKELY
TO BECOME HOMELESS AND JUST ON
ONE POINT THAT SEVERAL SPEAKERS
SPOKE TO THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ADDICTION PREVENTION
AND HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION AB
SEVENTY ONE PROVIDES THE
LATTER. WE ALSO NEED CHANGES IN
OUR STATE STRUCTURE TO FOSTER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CREATE
INCENTIVES FOR LOCAL
COOPERATION AND RESOLVE
FRAGMENTATION. AMONG AGENCY
RESPONSE. MOST IMPORTANTLY WE
NEED HAVE ON FUNDING ONE TIME
FUNDING IS HIGHLY INEFFECTIVE
AND HAS NEVER EXCEEDED ONE HALF
OF 1% OF THE STATE'S BUDGET. TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. AB
SEVENTY ONE WILL IMPLEMENT
ONGOING REVENUE SOURCES AND
TRANSFORM THE STATE'S RESPONSE
THE GREATEST MORAL CHALLENGE OF
OUR TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU AND THAT'LL COME FROM LINE
A ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CANNELLA
MARKED ON THE PROVIDER IN BUTTE
COUNTY AND THE COUNTY RAP
PROJECT THAT PROVIDES TO YOU W.
I CAN'T THAT PROVIDERS ARE
MAKING MINIMUM WAGE FOR THE
CARE THEY PROVIDE. TO THEIR
CLIENTS AND INCLUDES COUNTY
WHERE A LIVING WAGE IS OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND NOW WILL WE
HAVE NOT SEEN A WAGE INCREASE.
FOR MORE THAN EIGHT FOR MORE
THAN SIX YEARS. I AM IN SUPPORT
OF IMPOSING A 10% PENALTY. ON
COUNTY RIGHT IN THAT HAVE
FALLEN THAT HAVE FAILED TO
NEGOTIATE. IN GOOD FAITH
WITHOUT. THANK YOU. AND THE
NEXT LINE WILL COME FROM WIND
OF ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FEEDLOT. I'M SORRY. ONE
THIRTY FIVE. I'M SORRY. YOU
HAVE TO RE QUEUE UP ONE ONE
THIRTY FIVE WILL GO TO LIKE
NEXT LINE OF ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING.
LADIES COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF MY NAME IS MONICA CALLING
FROM THE POLITICAL SELF
DESTRUCT TRUSTEE FOR THE
CARPENTERS. COUNTY I'M CALLING
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE BUDGET REQUEST A FIVE
POINT ONE BILLION. THE STATE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS TO
INCREASE. PERMANENCY OUTCOMES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND CHILDREN.
BY REDUCING TURNOVER OF A
FOSTER. FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKERS. I ECHO WITHOUT SAYING
THAT STOOD HE INTERRELATE THIS
VERY SUPPORT TO THEIR HEALING
AND DEVELOPING TRUSTING
RELATIONSHIPS. ASK THE LOSS AND
TRAUMA THAT FOSTER YOUTH
EXPERIENCE IT'S COM COMPOUNDED
EACH AND EVERY TIME THERE WAS A
SOCIAL WORKER. OUR CURRENT
FUNDING IS WOEFULLY INADEQUATE
TO RETAIN THE HIGHLY SKILLED
AND COMMITTED SOCIAL WORKS THAT
ARE FOSTER USED DESERVE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE DEEPLY TO
AND INVESTED IN THE VERY
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM.
WE FEEL COMPELLED TO POINT OUT
THOUGH THAT THE NEED TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF RESOURCE
FAMILIES AND OUR OTHER DAYS OFF
EVER BE REALIZED WITHOUT
ADDRESSING INFERTILITY. TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE APPETITE
SOCIAL WORKER TURNOVER ISSUE.
CONSPECIFIC I. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT TO THIS
BUDGET REQUEST AND I THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THEIR COMPOUND LINE A ONE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING THANK YOU TO THE TURN
MEMBERS FOR CONSIDERING THE
ISSUE PUT FORTH I'M DOCTOR LARA
FINDS THE L. S. STANFORD HERE
YOU'VE BEEN FAMILIES. PROVIDING
FOSTER AND ADOPTIVE HOMES AS
WELL AS INTENSIVE MENTAL HEALTH
BEHAVIORAL AND YOU COULD NOT
JUST THE SERVICES THE NEARLY
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED YOUTH AND
FAMILIES IN THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO REGION. I AM ALSO A
LIFELONG ADVOCATE FOR FOSTER
YEARS I'M HERE TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES NUMBER FOUR IN
PARTICULAR I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN A REQUEST FOR AN
ADVOCATE SOCIAL WORK. RATE
INCREASE AT THE CONSISTENCY AND
SOCIAL WORKERS AND THAT SENSE
OF CONNECTION FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE THOSE FOSTER YEARS IS SO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN
SECURING PERMANENCY WE MUST
INVEST IN THE SOCIAL WORKERS TO
GUIDE AND SUPPORT. BOXER YOU IN
THEIR CAREGIVERS OF PARENTS TO
TRULY SHOW WE VALUE OUR FOSTER
YOUTH WE MUST VALUE THOSE WHO
WORK FOR THEM THE EFFORT FACED
SOCIAL WORKERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. OF THE SFA RATE
INCREASE. THANK YOU MA'AM. YEAH
AND THEN I CALLED FROM MY ONE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THAN
YOU CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF MY NAME IS YURI CAMERON
AND I AM A FORMER FFA SOCIAL
WORKER AND NOW PROGRAM DIRECTOR
CAMPUS HERE YOUTH AND FAMILY. I
SUPPORT THE BUDGET REQUEST
BUNCH BY FAMILY MEMBER RUBIO TO
SUPPORT FFA SOCIAL WORKER
STABILITY- AS DOCTOR HUNT JUST
NOTED- SUCH WORK STABILITY
POSITIVELY IMPACTS PERMANENTLY
RATE FOR OUR FOSTER YOUTH IN
CARE. WHEN I THINK WITH OUR
RESOURCE FAMILY THEY STAYED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT THE
STRONG RELATIONSHIP THEY HAVE
WITH SOCIAL WORKERS AND THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY GET FROM
THEM- INCLUDING AFTER HOURS ON
THE WEEKEND ON THE HOLIDAY EVEN
DURING A GLOBAL PANDEMIC. AS
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS THEY
ARE SATISFIED AND ABLE TO
SUPPORT STABILIZE YOUTH IN
THEIR CARE. IT HAS A SOCIAL
WORKER STABILITY GREATLY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE RETENTION OF
OUR RESOURCE PARENTS THAT WE
CRITICALLY NEED. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT NOT ONLY PRETTY AT THE
PAPER ALSO WORKERS BUT FOR THE
S. T. R. T. P. RESOURCE
FAMILIES DURING CO THAT. THE
INFANT SUPPLEMENT INCREASE AND
THE- CHILD CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU NEXT OVER LINE
OF ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
TANYA CIRCLE TEAM I AM ON I HSS
PROVIDERS FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE 10%
PENALTY ON CONICAL REFUSED TO
COME TO A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT WITH THAT PROVIDER.
I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT OF KEEPING
THE CURRENT 6535% SHARE OF COST
IN PLACE. IF THE POLITICAL
INTERSECT THE COMPANY'S COST.
OR ARE YOU JUST SAID WAGE
INCREASE WILL GO UP BY THIRTY
PERCENT. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM. GIVE NEXT WILL
COME THE LINE OF ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
LADIES MAN SAYS ON BEHALF OF
SEIU CALIFORNIA I WANT TO START
BY EXPRESSING APPRECIATION FOR
THIS WONDERFUL AND STOP ALL
HEARINGS AND THE PHENOMENAL
ANALYSIS PREPARED BY STAFF-
EXCEL IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE
SURE THAT THE MOST VULNERABLE
AMONG US HAVE SUPPORT AND
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED.
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC AND
BEYOND WHAT WE HAVE SEEN-
DURING THE PANDEMIC AS IT
RELATES TO CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES IS A DRAMATIC
REDUCTION IN THE CALL TO
EMERGENCY RESPONSE HOTLINE FROM
DAY ONE WHEN MANDATED REPORTERS
NO LONGER HAVE THEIR EYES AND
EARS ON EACH KIDS TO TYPICAL OF
BEING SHUT DOWN MORE
ANTICIPATING WHAT ONE CRITICAL
THREE OPEN. THAT THE- INTENSITY
OF THAT INVESTIGATIONS REQUIRED
FOR MANY OF THESE KIDS WHO HAVE
NOT BEEN SEEN FOR OVER A YEAR-
AS A RESULT OF THE SHUTDOWN
WILL REQUIRE A GREAT DEAL OF UP
FRONT PREVENTATIVE WORK BECAUSE
OF THAT WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT.
A FEW WTA'S PROPOSAL FOR THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT- FOR
AFFECT U. S. A. FOR PURPOSES OF
MAKING SURE THAT PREVENTATIVE
SERVICES CAN BE GIVEN AND
PROVIDED THESE KIDS TO KEEP
THEM OUT OF THE CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES SYSTEM WE ALSO ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THE RSA-
PROPOSAL. FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BY THREE WTA AND- PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR THE SOCIAL WORKER
TRAINING INVESTMENT- WE ALSO-
WHAT ARE THE KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS BY COMMITTEE
STAFF. REGARDING EXPLORING
OPTIONS FOR MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE THE GREATEST LEVEL
UPTAKE FOR CATTLE WORKS
RECIPIENTS. AND ALSO SUPPORT BY
A PROPOSAL TO GET RID OF THE
SUSPENSE. TREKEARTH- YOU CAN
NEXT- THAT THOSE FIVE PROGRAMS
ARE PERMANENT- WHEN THE MESSAGE
SERVICES PROGRAM. FINAL I LIKE
TO REQUIRE TO BE PROPOSED ON
PAID SEVENTY. TWO STOP AND YES
THEY WERE GROUP. INCLUDE THE-
RECOGNIZED EXCLUSIVE
REPRESENTATIVE OF CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN FOR THIS MARVELOUS
HEARING AND FOR ALL OF YOUR
THOUGHT YOU CARE- FOR ALL OF
THE PROGRAMMING. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE
OF ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MEDIT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MARKET GUERRERO REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND I'M CALLING ON
A NUMBER OF ITEMS TODAY WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR IMMIGRATION
SERVICES. IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES MEDICAL ADMINISTRATION
HELP FRESHEN PROJECT HOME KEY
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
RECOMMENDED INVESTMENTS ARE
TELL WELFARE PROGRAMS AND WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE CHILD SUPPORT
DIRECTORS BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS
UP THIRTY ONE POINT SIX MILLION
ABOUT THE TWENTY FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET. WE SUPPORT CHILDREN NOW
WE MORTGAGE HEALTHCARE BRIDGE
PROPOSAL AND- LEFT IS- POSE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR CAL
WORKING ALTERCATION AND REJECT
THE BUDGET REDUCTION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF ONE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS JIM ROBERTS ON THE
CEO AND FOUNDER OF THE FAMILY
CARE NETWORK WE HAVE BEEN
SERVING H. JANICE OBISPO AND
SANTA BARBARA COUNTIES THE
THIRTY FOUR YEARS PROVIDING.
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF SERVICES
TO CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES.
I'M HERE TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT- ASSEMBLY WOMAN OF
BROUGH BOC AB ONE THIS IS ONE
ZERO ZERO SIX. BASICALLY. TO
OUR MATTER INCREASE THE L.
SOCIAL WERE GREAT- AGENCY IN
THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS WE HAVE
LOST 38% OF OUR- MASTER'S LEVEL
LICENSED THERAPIST IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS WE HAVE LOST 74% HOW
IS THIS GOOD FOR KIDS WHEN THEY
CONSTANTLY HAVE A TURNOVER IN
STAFF SERVING AND SUPPORTING
THEM- THE END OF THE REASON IS
THAT WE BASICALLY BECOME A
TRAINING GROUND. FOR JANET DID
GOOD TO STATE OUR GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES- TO HIRE STAFF AT UP
250% MORE THAN WE CAN PAY AND
THE REALITY IS THAT YOU KNOW WE
HADN'T GOTTEN A RATING CREASE
FOR NEARLY TWENTY YEARS. TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE THEY TOOK-
10% BACK. AND- AND WE'RE
STRUGGLING ON A ONE TIME MY
AGENCIES SERVE ALMOST UP TO
HUNDRED FIFTY FOSTER KIDS- THAT
ANY GIVEN TIME NOW IT'S AT
THIRTY OR LESS AND THE REASON
IS BECAUSE WE CAN'T HIRE.
SOCIAL WORKERS AND RETAIN THEM
AND IT IS DOING A DISSERVICE TO
OUR CHILDREN YOUTH AND
FAMILIES- AND SO I JUST REALLY
WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE RATE INCREASE TO
SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE AFTERMATH
CARE BRADEN THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING TO YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF ONE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS AUDREY
MANY AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT RANCHO SAN ANTONIO
BOYS HOME A LARGE AT THE R. T.
P. AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AT
THE R. T. P. ARE CHARGED WITH
PROVIDING CRITICAL MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THERAPEUTIC
INTERVENTION TO THE HIGHEST
NEED YOU. YOU THREE THIRDS IT
THEIR TEMPORARY HOME AND WHILE
THEY'RE THERE WE TAKE THIS
RESPONSIBILITY VERY SERIOUSLY.
FIRE TO THE PANDEMIC S. T. R.
T. P. WERE ALREADY
SUPPLEMENTING OUR STATE FUNDING
WITH FUND RAISING DOLLARS TO
GIVE ARGUES THAT THAT SERVICE I
MEAN ALL UNFUNDED MANDATE. AND
THE PANDEMIC R. COSTA INCREASE
AS A RESULT OF A ROUND THE
CLOCK STAFFING WITH YOUTH
DISTANCE LEARNING FROM OUR
FACILITY. IT MEANT TO
FACILITATE TELEHEALTH AND
TELEVISION P. P. AND INCREASED
STAFFING COSTS TO COVER
ISOLATION AND QUARANTINE UNIT.
MY AGENCY HAS BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR ALMOST NINETY YEARS AND I
HAVE BEEN THERE FOR TWENTY FOUR
OF THOSE YEARS I FIND AT MY
CALLING TO ADVOCATE FOR
DISENFRANCHISED YOUTH AND OUR
DEDICATED STAFF THAT ARE HERE
TO PROPEL OUR MISSION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AGAIN FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE DR
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS WENDY
AWAY FROM HATHAWAY SYCAMORES A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
OPERATES THE HIGH QUALITY S. T.
R. E. N. L. A. COUNTY WE ARE
CALLING PERSISTENCE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP US CONTINUE
TO CARE AND TREAT POSTURE YOU
SOMEWHAT SOMEWHAT HIGH ACUITY.
FOR OUR F. E. R. T. PM WE HAVE
CREATE ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
CODE RELATED COSTS TO KEEP
ARGUES AND STAFF HEALTHY AND
STATE SINCE LAST MARCH. THIS
NUMBER INCLUDES PP SUPPLY
HAZARD PAY TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO
HELP YOU WITH THIS LEARNING
MODULE FOR STAFF WHO HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO CO THAT THIS
REPRESENTS ONLY A SAMPLE OF OUR
INCREASED COSTS NEEDED TO FIGHT
THE DEADLY PANDEMIC. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION ABOUT
ONE TIME A CLASS OF FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT S.
T. R. T. PEACE DURING CALVET.
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU NXR
GOAL LINE OF LINE ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME- THIS
IS BILL RICHARDSON I WORK WITH
POINT ANY OF FAMILY SERVICES
THAT I HAVE BEEN A SUPERVISING
SOCIAL WORKER FOR OVER FIFTEEN
YEARS. SO ON A SUPPORT THE
INCREASE SO THAT WE CAN GIVE
SOCIAL WORKERS BETTER PAY- JUST
WANT TO COMPLIMENT JIM
ROBERTSON MONEY SAYING WEEK
WE'VE BEEN TRAINING SOCIAL
WORKERS FOR OTHER INDUSTRIES
FOR MANY YEARS AND- WE'D SURE
LIKE TO KEEP A MAY BE GREAT. I
ALSO LIKE TO SUPPORT THE S.
HERE TV ONE TIME INCREASE WE
HAVE LOST A LOT OF MONEY DUE TO
LOW NUMBERS. EXCESSIVE COSTS
WITH PP AND STAFFING DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY KOBE CRISIS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU NEXAVAR LINE
A ONE NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEP THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS
GERRY JOHNSON I'M A PROGRAM
DIRECTOR WITH QUEENIE A FAMILY
SERVICES I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
WORK FOR THIRTY THREE YEARS AND
IT'S BEEN POINTED OUT
PREVIOUSLY THAT THESE KIDS
BECOME A FOSTER HAVE A LOT OF
TRAUMA THEY HAVE A LOT OF LOS.
AND WE'RE ALSO A FOSTER AND
FOSTER ADOPT AGENCIES SO WE
HIRE M. S. W.'S WELL WE HAVEN'T
HAD RATE INCREASES FOR SO LONG
MS DEPUTIES ARE GREAT DEGREE
TAKEN GET CHOPPED IN THE
HOSPITAL MENTAL HEALTH CLINICS
THEY CAN HANG THEIR OWN
SHINGLES. AND WE CAN'T COMPETE
WITH THEM AND IT'S CRITICAL
THAT THESE KIDS HAVE SOMEBODY
THEY CAN HANG ON TO IN CONTRAST
AS LONG AS THEY'RE IN CARE IN
AB ONE ZERO ZERO SIX WOULD HELP
THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU FOR THE LINE
A ONE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME MY NAME IS LAURA
RICHARDSON AND I WORK FOR A
STATE WIDE PROCTOR FAMILY
AGENCY AND F. P. R. T. P.
PROVIDER. WE THIRD THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN EACH YEAR
WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
FOLLOWING PROPOSALS FUNDING TO
HELP STABILIZE THE FFA SOCIAL
WORKER WORK FORCE. SO CHAU
WORKERS STABILITY IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR FACTORS FOR ACHIEVING
STABILITY FOR FASTER USE. AN
ADDICT INADEQUATE FINDING AND
ASKED FROM PAIN AND RETAI
SOCIAL WORKERS RESULTING IN
HIGH TURNOVER IN NEGATIVE
IMPACTS FROM FOSTER YOUTH
PERMANENCY DURING THE THIRD
SPECIALLY CHALLENGING TRYING TO
SHOW WORKERS STABILITY IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER BEFORE
DOCTOR YOU. IN ADDITION AS AN
AT T. R. T. P. PROVIDER WE'VE
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
COBIT NINETEEN I REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ONE KIND FUNDING TO
HELP STABILIZE THEIR PROGRAMS
DO YOU TO COOK AT NINETEEN JEFF
AN EXPENSE IT'S AN IMPACT. I
LIKE TO AGAIN THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND YOUR STAFF. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND THESE AND OTHER
CRITICAL BUDGET REQUEST
IMPACTING CHILD WELFARE
INCLUDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR RESOURCE FAMILIES. GET A
CODE NINETEEN IMPACT. THE
INTENT SIMPLEMENTE AND CHILD
CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU NEXT
WILL GO LINE A ONE NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE
NINE EIGHT. ONE YEAH HI THIS IS
WHAT I DO IS TO APPROVAL IN
SEVENTY SEVEN SINCE. YES MA'AM.
ONE YES WE HAD WE CAN HEAR YOU
HI I'M THE CEO OF WOMAN FOUND
THE SERVICES TO A TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING IS UP THE CAT AGES EACH
THAT PROVIDE SERVICES TO SOME
OF THE MOST VULNERABLE HOUSTON
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND I WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY AND I WOULD. WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT AND
IMPROVING PREGNANCY OUTCOMES
FOR FOLKS TO USE BY REINVESTING
IN FFA SOCIAL WORKERS. WE CAN'T
TO SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
USED INCLUDING MANY WITH
MEDICAL NEEDS AND SOCIAL WORKER
STABILITY IS SO IMPORTANT. IN
INCREASING THE CHANCES VALUES
MOVING MORE QUICKLY TOWARDS I
HAVEN'T SEE SPOKE TO
UNIFICATION IF THAT IS NOT
POSSIBLE TOWARD THE FOREVER
FAMILY TO ADOPTION. I'M ALSO
HERE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
PREVENTION. COSTS TO YOU
BECAUSE THIS THIS PROPOSAL
WHICH WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
FUNDING DURING CODE AND BEYOND
HOUSING SUPPORT STOCK CURRENT.
AND FORMER BUT THE- IN ADDITION
I WHAT THEY SUPPORT INITIAL FOR
THE FOLKS IS TO ADDRESS BECAUSE
HE DIDN'T. THE IMPLICIT INTENT
TO INCREASE THE CHILD CARE
WHICH COULD. THANK YOU MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT A LINE OF ONE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL GOOD
EVENING- MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DESMOND PRESCOTT I AM AND I HSS
PROVIDERS FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY
ALSO DISTRICT VICE CHAIR FOR
YOU W. ON PHYSICAL PENALTY- I
HSS PROVIDERS WILL CONTINUE TO
BE PAID JUST OVER MINIMUM WAGE.
UNLESS WE IMPOSE A 10% PENALTY
ON COUNTIES WHO REFUSE TO
BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH. A RECENT
REPORT BY THE STATE AUDITOR
FOUND THAT I JUST AS CARE
GIVERS MAKE ONLY 58% OF THE
LIVING WAGE STATEWIDE FOR THAT
REASON I SUPPORT THE 10%
PENALTY. ON COUNTY TO REFUSE TO
BARGAIN WITH US. IN ADDITION ON
OUR SHARE OF COST LIVE FOR MANY
YEARS THE 6535% SHE OF COST AYE.
WAGE AND BENEFIT INCREASES HAS
WORKED FOR BOTH THE STATE AND
COUNTIES I AM HERE TO SUPPORT
MAINTAINING THE SHERIFF CALLED
OTHERWISE MY COUNTY MAY NEVER
COME. TO A CONTRACT AGAIN AND
LAST ON RESTORING THE SEVEN
PERCENT- EVEN WITH TEMPORARY
RESTORATION I JUST SAYS
PROVIDERS OR RECIPIENTS HAVE
HAD THE 7% CUT TO SERVICE HOURS
HANGING OVER OUR HEADS FOR
YEARS NOW. I H. AT THAT SHOW
THAT IT IS BECOMING MORE AND
MORE IMPORTANT EACH AND EVERY
YEAR AND THAT IS WHY WE WORK
PERMANENTLY RESTORING THE 7%
CUT. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT ONE WILL
COME TWO OO TO YOUR LINE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THAT
DAVID THAT WHEN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR A LOT YOU
KNOW I NEED TO DO IT WE PROVIDE
THE KERR AND OPTIONS SERVICES
TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH. I WANNA
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER STAFF
AND THANK YOU TO OUR FAMILY
WOMAN ARE. BLANCA RUBIO FOR
CHAMPIONING VIA THIS PROPOSAL I
WE ARE ASKING FOR A RATE TO
BOARD FOR THE SFA SOCIAL
WORKERS I CAN BRIEFLY TELL YOU
LOOK AT ARE YOU WHERE ARE
SOCIAL WORKER DURING AND THEN
MAKE. MAKE SURE THAT EIGHT YOU
THAT WITH THAT RATE OF NOT.
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
STAND NUMBER HI. IN REYES
STATES MAKE SURE THE WOULD COME.
ALL OF THE ACT. THAT WERE
NEEDED. IN ORDER FOR HER TO- TO
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND BE
ENROLLED. IN JUNIOR COLLEGE I
HAD THE WORK AND THE SUPPORT
FROM OUR SOCIAL WORKERS YOU
START. A RATE INCREASE AT OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE- I SHARE WITH YOU
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO RETAIN.
OUR SOCIAL WORKER SO THEREFORE
I WE'RE ASKING FOR THE PUBLIC'S
HELP WORKING TO HELP OUR
CHILDREN IN ARE YOU. I WANNA
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I ALSO WANT TO
SUPPORT THE EXPECTED TO SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR RESEARCH PERRANCE
DURING CALL THE IMPACT. OF THE
PARTY CREE IN CHILD CARE RATES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU SIR JUST A REMINDER FOR
CALLERS WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY CALLERS WHO CURRENTLY
ARE IN QUEUE. OPERATOR WE'RE
READY FOR THE NEXT COLOR. THANK
YOU AND THAT'LL COME FROM ONE
TWO OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'D BE SITTING RIGHT HERE RIGHT
NOW. LIKE THEIR- HELLO LINE
GLOBAL FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THANK YOU FOR- TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEN AND- THE STAFF FOR
LETTING US EACH A- FOR HOLDING
THIS- MY NAME IS JASON DELL AND
I AM FOSTER CARE PROVIDER LOS
ANGELES THROUGH THE
EXTRAORDINARY FAMILIES. AGENCY
AND I WANT TO JUST ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT INCREASED FUNDING FOR
THE FFA SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE
BUDGET- THESE WORKERS PROVIDE
STABILITY AND THE RESOURCES FOR
OUR CHILDREN IN OUR CARE THEY
ALSO PROVIDE. RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT FOR US DOING THE
CARING- QUITE HONESTLY WE
COULDN'T DO IT WITHOUT THEM
THEY ARE THERE ARE TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
FOR US AND ESPECIALLY IN THESE
UNCERTAIN TIMES PANDEMIC THEY
HAVE REALLY STEPPED UP AND
PROVIDED. A LIFELINE TO ALL OF
US- SO I REALLY WOULD LIKE TO
ASK YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT THEM-
AND SUPPORT S. T. R. T. P. AND
ALSO ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
RESEARCH FAMILIES TO ADDRESS A
COVERT IMPACT THE INFANT
SUPPLEMENT INCREASED AND THAT
CHILD CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM WHICH
IS SO CRUCIAL FOR ALL OF US. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU NEXT LINE
WILL COME FROM MY TWO OH EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
ANYTHING CORRECT REPRESENTING A
COUPLE CLIENTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEAR
CLINICS BETTER SUPPORT FOR THE
MONTHLY CHILD CARE BRANCH.
PROGRAM BEING CHAMPIONED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS DOWN AND THE
OLDER YOUTH ENTRY INTO FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM- SUPPORTING
UNDERSERVED YOUNG PEOPLE FOR
POSITIVE RECEPTION TRANSITION
OR THE SUPPORT ACT. REFERENCE
BY THE ON YOUR CHILDREN'S
RIGHT. AND BIRTH AND I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE HER SUPPORT FOR THE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKER RATE INCREASE IN THE
PETRI CLASS RATE INCREASE. I'M
AND BOTH PLANES CONCUR WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND DOCUMENTATION
AROUND THE FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES WORKING
GROUP AND- I WANT TO WEIGH IN
ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF THAT
TRAILER. BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU NEXT
COME FROM ONE OF. TWO TWENTY
TWO YOUR LONG IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING THANK YOU SIR CHAIRMAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND STUFF MY
NAME IS CAPTAIN MIGHT BE OUT ON
THE SENIOR DIRECTOR WITH TLC
CHILD AND FAMILY AFTER. SERVING
FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS. I'VE BEEN
PERSONALLY COMMITTED TO FOSTER
AND ADOPTION FOR OVER TWENTY
FOUR YEARS IN THE NORTH BAY.
AREA IT IS MY GREAT HONOR THAT
I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF ON ANY YOU
CAN USE AND LYFT SACRIFICING
HARDWORKING RESOURCE FAMILY AND
STUFF- MY TENURE I'VE HEARD
MANY MANY STORIES FROM YOUTH
AND FAMILIES OF Y. AS A SOCIAL
WORKER STABILITY. AND
CONTINUITY IS VITALLY IMPORTANT
TO YOU SIX ALPHA. AND HOW
LOSING A SOCIAL WORKER
DESTRUCTS PERMANENTLY PLANS AND
INCREASES TO YEARS OF TRAUMA
PROVIDING A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND LYFT
LINE. CONVERSELY I BELIEVE THAT
HAVING THE SAME SOCIAL WORKER
DURING THE CHILD THE CHILD-
TIME IN FOSTER CARE CREATE A
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIP AND
INCREASES THE CHANCE. CHANCES
FOR REUNIFICATION GUARDIANSHIP
AND ADOPTION I'M ASKING YOU TO
SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS PLEASE
SOCIAL WORKERS AND OTHER
CRITICAL BUDGET REQUEST SUCH AS
INCREASING RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
OUR EFFORTS PLEASE SOCIAL
WORKERS INCREASING RETENTION
QUALITY OF LIFE ENCOURAGING
CONTINUITY OF SUPPORT. REDUCING
SOCIAL WORK TURN OVER
DESTRUCTION IN PLACEMENT AS
WELL AS THE THING EXTREMELY
VITAL RELATIONSHIPS FOR ARE YOU
WITH THEIR SOCIAL WORKERS
ADDITIONALLY FUNDING FOR.
RESOURCE FAMILIES TO CONTINUE
ADDRESSING THE ONGOING COLD IT
IMPACT CREE SUPPORT SYSTEM TO
STABILIZE AND SUPPORT ARE A FEW
OUR GP'S DURING COLD READ AS
WELL AS INCREASING THE
INFLUENCE SUPPLEMENT AND LASTLY
BUT NOT LEAST ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. FOR THE CHILD CARE
BRIDGE PROGRAM THANK YOU AGAIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ASSEMBLYWOMAN
BLANCA RUBIO AND STUFF FOR
ALLOWING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE AND SUPPORTING OUR
REQUEST. YOU. HAVE A GREAT
EVENING THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU NOT LOCAL LAW OF TWO.
ALLIANCE OPEN. GOOD EVENING
SHERIFF'S TO CAST BEHALF OF THE
ROLE CAN RECORD OF. IN IRVINE
COUNTY THAT. PURSUANT COUNTY
SUPPORT OF SEVERAL INVESTMENT
TO SUPPORT SENIORS AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES INCLUDING
EXPANSION OF ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICE PROGRAM AN EIGHT PAGE
SIXTY SIX RUNNING A HOME STATE
PROGRAMS THE PROPOSAL TO
PRESERVE I. HFS WAITING TEN
TIMES INCLUDING KEEPING THE
SHARING RATIO. 67% STATE AND
35% COUNTY I ONE OF THE MAIN
FUNDING SOURCE COMES FROM
REALIGNMENT WILL BE ASSURING
RATIO WOULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON AVAILABLE FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND BEHAVIOR HOW.
I REMAIN INTENT ON IT AND WE
NEED A STRONG PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR YEARS TO COME. SECOND RURAL
AND URBAN COUNTIES ARE OPPOSED
TO PUTTING A PENALTY STATUTE
RELATED TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AND I. HFS. THIRD
EARNING COUNTY SUPPORT THIS HE
W. DIEGO COASTAL FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
HUMAN SERVICES PLAYED A HOUSING
PROGRAMS IN THE FLEXIBILITY TO
BE IMPLEMENTED BE A TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ANYTHING LIKE
HOUSING FOR CHILDREN AND
SENIORS. FINALLY IRVINE KIND OF
THE CORPORATE DALY FIRST
PREVENTION PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
FIFTY MILLION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND HUNDRED MILLION I'M
GOING TO THE LOCALLY DRIVEN
SERVICES. AND SUPPORTS FOR
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES AT
RISK OF ENTERING FOSTER CARE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU. AND THAT
WELCOME LINE OF TO SO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
COMMITTEE AND STAFFS MY NAME IS
CHRISTOPHER MAHER AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
TO ALIGN OUR POSITION WITH-
PREVIOUS MEMBERS ON THIS CALL
WE SUPPORT- I FISCAL PENALTY
FOR COUNTIES THAT FAIL TO
BARGAIN WITH HSS PROVIDERS IN
GOOD FAITH WE SUPPORT THE
CONTINUANCE OF THE SO CALLED
10% TOOL FOR COUNTIES. THAT
NEGOTIATED I. HFS WAGES ABOVE
THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE PRIOR TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE RESEND THE
INCLUSION OF THE STATE COUNTY
HFF SHARE OF COST. AND WE URGE
PERMANENT RESTORATION OF P. 7%
HFS CUTS THAT HAVE LOOMED OVER
RECIPIENT AND CARE GIVERS FOR
NEARLY A DECADE. THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE WORK TO PROTECT IN
STRENGTH AND CALIFORNIA'S
SOCIAL SAFETY NET. THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU NEXT TO COME
FROM LINE OF TWO THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
STAFF. MY NAME IS LUCY MANAGER
I'M A SENIOR DIRECTOR OF FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHILD SERVING
AGENCIES TLP TUB AND FAMILY
SERVICES. WE ARE PROUD MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES.
AFTER CARE ADOPTION SERVICES IF
YOU KEY PROGRAM AND AFTER T.
PROGRAM AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGET
REQUEST PROPOSED BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN RUBIO TO INCREASE
FUNDING. FOR FFA SOCIAL WORK
WAGE INCREASES. AS ALLIANCE CEO
DOWNHAM HIGHLIGHT DURING HER
PRESENTATION CLOSER WORK
STABILITY IS DIRECTLY
CORRELATED OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN. I CAN SPEAK FIRSTHAND
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE FFA
SOCIAL WORKER AND THE STABILITY
OF PLACEMENTS AND FOSTER HOME.
IN OUR PROGRAM I HAVE ONE
SOCIAL WORKER WHO'S BEEN WITH
MY AGENCY FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS
SHE HAD REPORTED ONE FAMILY FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS. YOU'RE A FOSTER
CARE ADOPTION AND GUARDIANSHIP
OR SEVERAL CHILDREN SHE'S HIRED
TIRELESSLY SUPPORTED THEIR
FAMILY TO ALL OF THEIR NEEDS
INCLUDING MOST RECENTLY AND I
ACCEPT THE PLACEMENT OF THE
YOUNG MAN WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS AND SIGNIFICANT. MEDICAL
NEEDS. I ANOTHER WHOSE WITH MY
PROJECT YEARS PROVIDING CARE TO
THREE SIBLINGS WHO AND I AFFECT
THE PROGRAM. THEY HAVE HAD FIVE
DIFFERENT SOCIAL WORKERS. A
LONG TERM OUTCOME OF THAT
PLACEMENT IS CURRENTLY IN
JEOPARDY ALONG WITH THE
PREDICTED OUTCOME FOR THOSE
CHILDREN. WE NEED YOUR HELP.
KEEP DURING THE CRUCIAL WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE REQUESTED FUNDING
FOR THE CARINGBRIDGE PROGRAM
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR THE S. R.
T. P. THE RESOURCE FAMILY
COVERED EXPENSES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU NEXT
OVER THE LINE OF TWO THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
NANCY VOEPEL CONDITIONALLY
SERVICE FROM ANGELES. GIVEN THE
LATE HOUR I'M JUST GONNA SAY
THANK YOU AN ECHO OF PREVIOUS
COMMENTS ABOUT THE INCREDIBLE
QUALITY OF TODAY'S PANEL AND
THE STAFF ORK AND DOCTOR
ARAMBULA YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
FULLY SUPPORT THE NSS HE
INVESTMENT. AS WELL AS THE
OTHER INVESTMENT IN MEETING THE
NEEDS OF OLDER ADULTS SO THAT
THEY CAN AGE. WITH SAFETY
HEALTH AND INDEPENDENT THANK
pNEXT OVER THE LINE OF TWO
THIRTY SIX THE LINE IS OPEN. HI
I'M DOCTOR STEVE NELSON DOES
YOUR AMERICA SO CASA PACIFICA
CENTERS FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. THE CURRENT SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
ARE YOU'RE YOU'RE GONNA SUPPORT
THE TO BUDGET ITEMS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE BOTH
DIRECTED AT CARING FOR OUR
AMAZING CARE GIVERS IN WAYS
THAT IMPROVE SERVICES AND
PERMANENT SEAT FOR YEARS. YEP
OKAY SOCIAL WORKER INCREASE
WHICH SOLVES A LONG ISSUE AND
THE ONE TIME BUDGET ASTERISK
HERE TO PIECES SERVE THE MOST
VULNERABLE YOU IN OUR COMMUNITY
CENTER AMHERST BY THE PANDEMIC.
AWAITS ME- HAZARD PAY OVER TO
AND DOUBLE TIME PAY FOR. HIM
DEMOCRATS VACANCY TEMPORARY
LODGING FOR STAFF. YES POTS AND
ARE UNABLE TO CALL HOME THE
COST OF P. EIGHTEEN TESTING
PURCHASE OF COMPUTERS AND
LAPTOPS FOR ONLINE TRAINING AND
SUPERVISION I'M FINALLY LOST
REVENUE DUE TO HOLD
CONNOTATIONS PLACED BY COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES TO COVER
THAT WOULD BREAK. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU DOCTOR.
THANK YOU AND THEN I FIND WILL
BE COME FROM TWO THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CHEN ARAMBULA THIS CHAIR AND
CALL WITH EURUSD CALIFORNIA MY
COMMENTS ARE IN REGARD
OPPORTUNITY COULD SIMPLIFY ACT
CALFRESH AND ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
DID THIS AND FOR EMIGRATE
CALIFORNIA. FIRST IN REGARD TO
HELP FRENCH. PDF THAT HAS THE
FULL AUTHORITY NOW TO CREATE A
SHORTER SIMPLER BY CALPERS
APPLICATION FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WE NEED A
BUDGET REQUEST TO FUND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THAT PROVIDE
APPLICATION I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT REQUEST ALIGNS WITH THE.
MASTER PLAN FOR EIGHTEEN
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND EN ROUTE
TO PUT ARE IN THAT TOM FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RECALL CENTER IN HIS
REMARKS WE NEED TO BRING.
FORSAKEN SAFETY NET BY ENACTING
LONG TERM. TO ADDRESS ON
DISPARITIES ARE NEEDED TO THE
SYSTEM IS SHOULD MODERNIZE THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD. PROGRAM TO
PERMANENTLY PROVIDE NUTRITION
BENEFITS THE CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE INELIGIBLE PROTECT FOR
CALFRESH SOLELY DUE TO THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. WE NEED TO
ENSURE. FOOD FOR ALL THANK YOU.
THE YOU. THANK YOU AND I FINAL
COME FROM TWO THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE NAME DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DR SYLVIA CHANG AND
I AM A PEDIATRICIAN IN
SACRAMENTO. TODAY I AM
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
IN CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
FIVE THOUSAND BOARD CERTIFIED
PEDIATRICIAN. IS THE PART OF
THE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY NIN
THOUSAND DOLLARS HEALTHY
FUTURES FOR FOSTER YOUTH
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THAT INTO
DIPLOMATIC SPACE WE SHE HAVING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRANSPORT
TOPICS. LIKE SECOND SPONSOR YOU
MOM THOUGHT THE REPORT THAT THE
OTHER PROTECTIVE FACTOR IN
TERMS OF OFFERING THEM A
MEANING TO LIFE. THEY CAN
POTENTIAL BARRIERS THE COUPLE
PREGNANCY AND INCLUDING HIGHER
RATES OF MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
DRUG ABUSE. THE TERM BIRTH LATE
PRESENTATION PRENATAL CARE AND
HIGHER RISK OF LOSING THEIR
CHILD YEAH STE ABSOLUTELY FINE
SACRAMENTO EVERY THE SPONSOR
YOU FOR PARENTING I REALLY SOME
OF THE- THAT CONNECTICUT
CONTRIBUTE TO KARPINSKI.
EMPLOYED LAKHAN I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. SO MUCH THANK YOU
DOCTOR. THANK YOU NOT COME FROM
FIFTH ONE YOUR LINE OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MY IS CO I FROM CAR AND
I AM BOSS YOUTH I'M IN FOR TO.
INCLUDE HELPING ACROSS THE-
WHICH INCLUDES THE INSIDE OF
WOMEN BEGINNING THE SEVEN MONTH
OF. FOR EXPECTING FOR. THIS
ITEM IS THE TIME PERCENT ASIDE
FOR YOU TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. I EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS AND THE USE AND
FOUND THAT THERE WERE NO
SERVICES FOR ME I ALSO WANT TO
ADD THAT I AM CURRENTLY SEVEN
MONTHS PREGNANT WITH MY FIRST
CHILD AND HAVE EXPERIENCED THE
STRUGGLE. OF PREPARATION AND
EXPENSES FOR THESE REASONS I
URGE YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OR
YOU CAN LIVE WITH THE PROPER
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU MAKES MY WILL
COME FROM TWO THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING THE
CANNOT I WOULD CHILDREN LOCKED
IN- CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER REPRESENTS ALL OF THE
CHILDREN I'M A FAN JUST
SACRAMENTO PATRICK COUNTY'S
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. THE CARD OF
THE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLAR HEALTHY FUTURE
FOR FOSTER YOUTH PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND THE INCIDENT PROBLEM
AND- THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
EXPECTING YOU CURRENTLY RECEIVE
THE INCOME SUPPLEMENT THREE
MONTHS PRIOR TO CHILDBIRTH. IN
OUR EXPERIENCE THE SMALL
INVESTMENT HAS MADE A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE
ABILITY OF OUR CLIENTS. TO
PREPARE FOR THE UPCOMING GROWTH
OF THEIR CHILDREN. THE SUPPORT
HAS GIVEN THEM THE ABILITY TO
PURCHASE NECESSITIES SUCH AS
CAR SEATS DIAPERS WIPES YOU FOR
CLOSE COULD AND OTHER ITEMS
THAT ARE REQUIRED OF THE
PARENTS THE MOMENT THEY LEAVE
THE HOSPITAL. WITHOUT IT
WITHOUT IT THEY'RE LESS
GRAMBLING CORRIDORS THIS OTHER
DIFFICULT AND STRESSFUL TIME IN
THEIR LIFE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU NEXT WILL COME
PAULINE OF TWO FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS MARA DECLARE I FROM
PUBLIC COUNCIL WHEREIN IS
SENIOR SOCIAL WORKER ON OUR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS PROJECT
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH TEAM. I
FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING EXPECTED
IN PARENTING YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE AND IT IS A TRUE PRIVILEGE
TO WORK WITH THESE NEW
RESILIENCE IT'S TRULY
REMARKABLE. I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF A COALITION OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
EXPRESSED SUPPORT. FOR THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLAR HEALTHY FUTURES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH PROPOSAL TO
EXTEND THE INFANT ON THAT. THE
EARLY INFANT SACRAMENTO IT'S
REALLY A CRUCIAL INVESTMENT IN
YOUNG PARENTS AND FOSTER CARE
AND THEIR BABY. IT'S
STRENGTHENS THE GROWING FAMILY
INSURING THESE NEW MOTHERS CAN
ACQUIRE THE BASIC ITEMS THE NEW
BOARD NEED. THAT CAN CAUSE. WHY
OVER A THOUSAND DOLLARS. BASIC
THING SUCH AS STATE COLLECTED.
A CO SEAT DIAPER WIPES CLOTHES
AND MORE. WHAT THE EARLY AND
TOP OF. IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT
FOR FOX USED TO. THE SITE. AND
THIS ONE. ADD TO THE SIGNET
LIFE YES IS THERE UP AND FACING.
A LACK OF SOCIAL SUPPORT. CHILD
CARE I'M PROBABLY PLAY
STABILITY BUT THE EARLY IN
SUPPLEMENT FUNDS IN HAND THANK
YOU CAN FOCUS ON COMPARED TO
THEIR NEW ROLE OF THE PARENT.
IT'S AN INVESTMENT IN FAMILIES
THAT WILL PAY OFF NOT ONLY FOR
THE VIEWS. BUT ALSO FAR LARGER
COMMUNITY. FOR YOUNGER YOU KNOW
WITH GIVERS THIS WILL ENSURE
THE FOSTER PARENT WILL NOT HAVE
TO MAKE THE DIFFICULT CHOICE
BETWEEN PROVIDING HERE FOR THE
YEAR. OR FOR THEIR BABY. FOR
ALL OF THESE REASONS WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLAR HEALTHY FUTURES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH PROPOSAL AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU AND NEXT
FINAL COME FROM TWO FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOE
JOHNSON AND I WAS SUBJECTING
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM I MEAN
IF I BECAME A JOHN BURTON
BASKET THREE YEARS AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
ORGANIZATIONS TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION. PREVENTING AND
REDUCING CULTURE HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL A LARGE AMOUNT OF USED
TO VANISH OUT OF FOSTER CARE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AND ON
CABLE HOUSING. FOR PEOPLE WHO
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO CHANGE AGENTS
WHO ADVOCATES RENTAL HOUSING TO
FIND EMPLOYMENT IN CHANGING
FRIENDSHIPS. THEY ARE MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
ABUSE VIOLENCE MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
SCHOOL GROUNDS PROGRESSION AND
COMPLETING A CHECK RATHER THAN
BEING FACED WITH HOMLESSNESS
AND UNSTABLE HOUSING. GIVING
RESTRUCTURING IS THE MOST
WANTED OUT OF THE CHANGE THEIR
LIVES FOR THE BETTER. HOW CAN
ONE CONSCIOUSLY ALLOW ARE YOU
OUR CHILDREN TO BE LEFT ALONE
TO FACE THE BURDEN OF
HOMELESSNESS. IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY. TO ACT
ACCORDINGLY. BUT IF NOT WE ANY
LONGER TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
COMMERCE BUT THE THOUGHT YOU
MARK. IF THEY- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TIME COME
FROM TWO FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I THINK YOU- MISTER CHAIR
MISTER CASTING DOWN ON THE
NUMBER OF PRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION FOR
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF B. INTENT
SUPPLEMENT- THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO IS- IS-
REQUESTING- YOU KNOW THIS IS.
IT'S JUST SIMPLY A BRAINER YOU
KNOW THIS IS A SEVEN HUNDRED
AND TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IT'S NOT MUCH OUT OF
THE BUDGET. AND IT WILL END UP
SAVING SO MUCH MORE MONEY THAN
THE STATE WILL SPEND- JUST IN
BIRTH OUTCOMES ALONE LET ALONE
PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR THESE
YOU. WHO THAT JUST DON'T HAVE
THE COMMUNITY AROUND THEM TO
SUPPORT THEM AND HELP THEM OUT
IN THE FEW MONTHS BEFORE THEY
GIVE BIRTH SO- THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR TIME AND- APPRECIATE- ALL
YOU DONE TODAY WITH THE HEARING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU NOT OVERLY UP TO NINE
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR RONALD KOEMAN HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HELP AT WORK HERE ON A
FEW NON PRESENTATION ITEMS FROM
THE PART TO AGENDA WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED HEARING THAT SENATE
RACIAL EQUITY ON ISSUE ONE
APART TO AGENDA ON CENTER FOR
DATA INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION.
SHEEP AND SUPPORTS BEIJING TO
BUDGET NEUTRAL REQUEST TO
ESTABLISH THE CENTER ABOUT IT
IMPACTING INNOVATION THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT
HIGHLIGHTED THE EXISTING
DISPARITIES CAUSED BY SIXTEEN
GRAYSON DISCRIMINATION IN
ACCESS. TO REAL TIME PATIENT
DATA IS ACCURATE DISAGGREGATED
BY RACE ETHNICITY LANGUAGE IN
OTHER DEMOGRAPHIC VARIABLES
ENABLE THE STATE AND COUNTY
DETECTIVE RESPONDED DISPARITIES
AND- IN DISEASE OUTBREAKS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS MONITOR
PUBLIC POPULATION HELPING
PREVENT UNDERLYING HEALTH
CONDITIONS SUCH AS DIABETES
OBESITY AND HYPERTENSION.
BEFORE THEY LEAD TO MORE SEVERE
OUTCOMES FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY SUPPORT THAT
PROPOSAL ON ISSUE ONE ON EQUITY
CENTERED PROGRAMS BCP WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE MINISTRY OF
DURING THE RETROSPECTIVE
ANALYSIS OF THE INTERSECTION OF
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
HEALTH DISPARITIES. AND EQUITY
WE ALREADY KNOW SPECIFIC
INVESTMENTS THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN MADE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE ONLY
RATED HEALTH DISPARITIES AND WE
THINK THAT WE WILL COULD BETTER
USE THIS- MONEY FOR- PLANNING
TO MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS- WE
APPRECIATE THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
LANGUAGE ACCESS POLICY
DEEPENING WESTERN CENTER HAVE A
PROPOSAL FOR AN INVESTMENT OF
ONE TIME FUNDS OF ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR FIELD TESTING IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO WERE
TRANSLATED TO THAT ACCOUNT
MATERIALS AND ONGOING THIRTY
THOUSAND FOR FIELD TESTING TO
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF
TRANSLATED GOING TO NOTICE IT
THERE AFTER RIGHT NOW ADVOCATES
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS ALIKE A
MAJORITY FROM ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR BASICALLY PROVIDING FREE
LABOR TO THE STATE BUT DEAL
TESTING MATERIALS TO ENSURE
THEIR CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE-
THAT'S A DOCUMENTS AND WE CAN
DO MUCH BETTER THAN THAT. WE
ALSO THINK AS PART OF THE
AGENCIES D. C. T. THAT AS THEY
DEVELOP IN EQUITY DASHBOARD WE
SHOULD ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE UPGRADING DH CS IS A
MEDIC CAL ELIGIBILITY DATA
SYSTEM. TO ALLOW FOR THE
COLLECTION AND REPORT ADDING OF
DATA ON THIS. TO ANYMORE
GRANULAR DEMOCRATS DATA ON AGE
RACE ETHNICITY LANGUAGE OR-
GENDER IDENTITY DISABILITY
STATUS BY TEACHING AND MEDICARE
MEDICARE PLANS. YOU THE FEDERAL
TWENTY TO. OFFICE OF NATIONAL.
WELCOME TECHNOLOGY STANDARDS
FOR ELECTRONIC ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORDS AND FINALLY WHEN
ISSUE FIVE ON DSS OFFICE OF
EQUITY B. C. B. C. PRINCIPLE
WORKS THIS REQUEST FOR FUNDS TO
DEVELOP A DEPARTMENT WIDE
LANGUAGE ACCESS QUALITY. WE
URGE TO CDSS AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
READABILITY AND COMMUNITY
REVIEWS OF TRANSLATED FORMS THE
MATERIALS. AT THIS WILL HELP TO
ENSURE FORMS ARE EASY TO READ
AND UNDERSTAND WE WOULD ALSO
APPRECIATE THE MORE DETAILS ON
HOW CDSS INTENDS TO USE THE
FUNDS TO ADDRESS OTHER ISSUES
RAISED BY STEVEN AND OTHER
PARTNERS. AT THE OFFICE OF
CIVIL RIGHTS HEARINGS IN
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY MOVING
FORWARD WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
REQUIREMENTS CD. AFFECT REPORT
BACK THE LEGISLATURE ON HOW THE
FUNDS ARE SPENT. AND COOK AND
HOW PROGRESS IS BEING MADE TO
ENSURING GREATER ACCESS TO
SERVICES FOR CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK. YOU SIR. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU COME
FROM OF FIFTY THREE LINE IS
OPEN. DR RAM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND STAFF THIS IS JULIE SNYDER
WITH THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE WE
LIKE TO COMMENT ON TWO ITEMS
UNDER ISSUE THREE. FIRST WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT BOARD AND
CARE HOMES WHICH WILL HELP
MAINTAIN A VITAL HOUSING AND
CARE OPTION FOR ROUGHLY FORTY
THOUSAND PLUS SSI RECIPIENTS
LIVING WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. WITHOUT BOARDING
CARES THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE AT
HIGH RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS
DUE TO THEIR EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME COMBINED WITH COMPLEX
MEDICAL CONDITIONS WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO EXPLORE
WHETHER THESE FUND SHOULD BE
ALSO BE MADE AVAILABLE FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL MONTHLY PAYMENTS.
TO FACILITY SERVING SSI
RECIPIENTS. WELL NOT A LONG
TERM SOLUTION TO LOW PAYMENT
RATES THIS ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY COULD HELP MAINTAIN
STABLE HOUSING FOR THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS THIS COMING YEAR.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE ELIADE'S
RECOMMENDATION TODAY FOR
ADDITIONAL DATA GATHERING TO
HELP SHE GREW LONGER TERM
SOLUTIONS. TO THIS ISSUE.
SECOND IN THE WITH THE L. A. O.
RECOMMENDATION TO DEVELOP A
CLEAR LONG TERM STRATEGY TO END
HOMELESSNESS WE URGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO INCORPORATE AB
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF THE THREE OF US INTO A
TRAILER BILL. DESPITE THE
TREMENDOUS GROWTH IN PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES THIS STATE HAS NEVER.
COMMITTED A SIGNIFICANT LEVEL
OF ONGOING RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE EXPRESSED
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CAO
WORKS FAMILIES PEOPLE LIVING
WITH A SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS
PRETTY ASTONISHING 40% OF THIS
POPULATION WHO ARE BLACK. AB
SEVENTY ONE WHICH GENERATE TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO HELP FAMILIES. AND
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND THE COST COULD
BE COVERED BY THE WEALTHIEST
MULTINATIONAL AND NATIONAL
CORPORATIONS WHO SWIPED DURING
THIS PANDEMIC AND NOW EARN
RECORD PROFITS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY AND
HAVE A GOOD EVENING THANK YOU
MA'AM. JUST FOR THE FUTURE
COLORS WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
SIXTY COLORS AND QUEUE AT THE
MOMENT. WE'RE READY FOR THE
NEXT COLOR OPERATOR. Q. AND
THAT'LL COME FROM LINE TO SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE GOOD
EVENING ZAKHAROVA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
JUST WANT TO COMMENT BROADLY ON
THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING A CITY
APPLAUDS THE EFFORTS OF THE
STATE TO RESTRUCTURE AND
PRIORITIZE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR SENIORS. THE
INITIAL STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO
THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING
UNDERSCORED THE MYRIAD OF
INTERCONNECTED NEEDS AND
CONCERNS FOR AGING CALIFORNIANS
AS WELL AS THE PRACTICAL
CHALLENGES AND PRIORITIZING AND
ADDRESSING THEM. IT ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED THAT ORAL HEALTH
CARE NEEDS WHICH GROUP WITH AGE
ARE OFTEN NOT TOP OF MIND MOST
PEOPLE AND CAN TOO EASILY BE
OVERLOOKED WITH THAT IN MIND AS
THE STATE GATHERS TOGETHER A
NEW GROUP OF PROFESSIONALS AND
EXPERTS TO SUPPORT THE PLAN'S
IMPLEMENTATION. CITY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
REPRESENTATION ON THIS GROUP
AND IN THIS PROCESS ENSURING
THE CONTRIBUTION OF THE
PERSPECTIVE UNIQUE TO
PROTECTING ORAL HEALTH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU THA FINAL COME FROM
TO TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING. YOU KNOW WHY THE
HARD WHAT WAS A R. P.
CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT TO START
BY SAYING THANK YOU- AND NUMBER
TWO SUCH A THOUGHTFUL WIDE
RANGING CONVERSATION TONIGHT- I
NEED A WHILE TO OUR ONE OF A.
R. P. CALIFORNIA WE ARE A
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION OF
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
MEMBERS. ARE WE REPRESENT OVER
CALIFORNIANS I WOULD LIKE TO DO
RIGHT NOW JUST OUTLINED SOME OF
OUR PRIORITIES IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR OF COURSE- STAFF HAS.
RECEIVED OUR FULL LIST. WE
SHOULD COME FROM. AT ALREADY
WAY UP FROM OF THE ISSUES. SO
FAR OF ALL WE ARE A CROWD.
NUMBER OF THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING VARIOUS GIVEN AND THE
GREAT WORK THAT WE DID WITH OUR
PARTNERS. ARE CLEARLY WE
SUPPORT THE ALLOCATION OF FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM AFTER PLAN
FOR AGING IMPLEMENTATION.
REALLY ALONGSIDE THAT- AND I
WANT TO THANK HIM FOR HIS PLEA-
TESTIMONY EARLIER- THE
ALLOCATION OF MONEY TO EXPAND
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CENTER. AND CREATED A WELL
NEEDED AND MUCH NEEDED NO ONE
DOOR SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. WE
ALSO SUPPORT NUMBER AT ANOTHER
PARTNERJUST RAISES UP THE
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS TO PURCHASE
AND REHABILITATE ADULT
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES. AS
WELL AS RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY AS A
MEANS TO INCREASE HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR OLDER ADULTS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES- THEY.
ARE PLEASE STAND- WITH OUR
PARTNER- IN TERMS OF NEED ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF YOUR ABOUT
THE PLUMBING MEMBERS OF SEVENTH.
OUR CAR IN IN HOME SUPPORT SO.
WE HAVE A SUPPORTIVE THAT-
WEBER SO YEAR OF REJECTION TO
DO- I ALSO WANT TO RAISE UP OUR
CONTINUING SUPPORT FOR THE HOME
SAFE. PROGRAM CURRENT AND
FUTURE OUR- FOR THE IMPORTANT
PROGRAM THAT WILL FIRST OF ALL
HOW BY INDIVIDUALS- UP BELOW
THE AGE OF ELIGIBILITY AND
SIXTY AND EXTEND. THE PROGRAM-
MAKING A PROMINENT- FINALLY IN
TERMS OF NUTRITION ACCESS YOUR
P. SUPPORTS THE ALLOCATION OF
MONEY TO EXPAND THE SENIORS
FARMER MARKET FARMERS MARKET
NUTRITION PROGRAM. AS WELL AS A
NEW FARM FIRST TO JUNIORS
PROGRAM. AND WE SUPPORT. PLEASE
ONE BILLION UP UP FOR UNDER TEN
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL. TO CREATE
A SIMPLIFIED CAL FIRST
APPLICATION FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES IN
ORDER TO INCREASE CALPERS
ENROLLMENT IT'S IMPORTANT
PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING
TO HELP OLDER CALIFORNIANS OF
PERSONS WITH. DISABILITIES
CONTINUE TO REMAIN IN THE HOMES
AND COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY WANT
TO BE THANK YOU AND HAVE A
GREAT EVENING. THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE WILL COME
FROM TWO SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS I'M STACY%
HERE AMATO DIRECTOR OF RAM COAL
THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC MENTAL
HEALTH DISPARITIES COALITION WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR CONDUCTING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING ON CRITICAL
BUDGET ISSUES. THAT ARE EVEN
MORE URGENT THIS YEAR DUE TO
THE COLD BED AND OTHER CURRENT
EVENTS. WE ESPECIALLY APPLAUD
TO FOCUS UNDER ISSUE TWO
ADDRESSING CRITICAL STEPS
TOWARDS RACIAL EQUITY. THE
BACKGROUND INFORMATION IN THE
PACKET AS WELL AS THE PANEL OF
SPEAKERS AT THE MOST IMPORTANT
POINTS RELATED TO ISSUES OF
EQUITY AND RACIAL RECKONING. WE
ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS LISTED ON PAGE
FIFTY. WE DO WANT TO GIVE A
QUICK THANKS FOR MENTIONING
THAT CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT ON FORTY
EIGHT AS A PRIOR COLLABORATION.
SUPPORTED AND FUNDED BY SEVERAL
STATE- BODIES. THANK YOU KNOW
WE ARE WORKING TO SUSTAIN THIS
PROJECT THAT DOES TOUCH AND
RELATE ON ALL THE ISSUES AT
THIS HEARING SUCH AS
ELIMINATING RACIAL BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION. POVERTY
HOMELESSNESS AND THE SPECIAL
POPULATIONS SUCH AS CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SURVIVE THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AND OLDER
ADULTS. AND ELDERS. IN ADDITION
THAT RUN CO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO'S BUDGET REQUEST
SPONSORED BY NSW THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER AND THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES OVER A FIVE POINT ONE
FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION. STATE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS TO
INCREASE PERMANENCY OUTCOMES
FOR FOSTER CHILDREN AND YOU BY
REDUCING FFA SOCIAL WORK TURN
OVER WE BELIEVE THIS WILL HELP
MANY CHILDREN AND BE SUPPORTED
BY OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU I LIKE
FINAL COME FROM TWO SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE TWO
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING EVENT THAT ASSETS
WITH UP WITH FAMILY SERVICES
THE STATE WHY CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TONIGHT
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION BUDGET REQUEST TO
INCREASE PERMANENCY OUTCOMES
FOR FOSTER CHILDREN YOU. BY
REDUCING SOCIAL WORKER TURNOVER
THIS REQUEST WILL PROVIDE A
POWERFUL AND CONSISTENT LINK
BETWEEN SOCIAL WORKERS AND
CHILDREN WHO HAVE ALREADY
EXPERIENCED TRAUMA AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY LEADS TO GREATER
PERMANENCY OUTCOMES FOR FOSTER
KIDS WITH SUPPORT CHILDREN
RECEIVED. AND THE RELATIONSHIP
THEY DEVELOP WITH SOCIAL
WORKERS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF HEALTH
INTERESTING RELATIONSHIP AND
THE FUTURE SUCCESS WHICH IS
WHAT WE ALL WORKED VERY HARD TO
ACCOMPLISH I WANT TO SPECIALLY
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO FOR
HER FIERCE COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF SOCIAL WORKERS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE WILL COME FROM TO TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ I'M
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE REPRESENTS SOCIAL
WORKERS WITH THEIR DEGREE IN
SOCIAL WORK FROM AN ACCREDITED
SCHOOL OF SOCIAL WORK WE- THERE
ARE SO MANY WAYS THE PROPOSAL
THAT WE DISCUSSED TODAY BUT I'M
ONLY GOING TO MENTION A FEW.
FOR COSPONSORING TO BUDGET
PROPOSAL ONE IS A SUPPORT FOR
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKERS TO INCREASE CLINICALLY
OUTCOMES FOR FOSTER CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BY REDUCING. DR
GRAMLEY AGENCY- SOCIAL WORKER
TURNOUT TURN UPWARD THE SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE DEDICATED
PROFESSIONALS WITH A MASTER'S
DEGREE WHO HAVE IN MANY
INSTANCES COME FROM COMMUNITIES
OF PROPERTY THEMSELVES TURNOVER
IS HIGH BECAUSE THAT MAY BECOME
UNTENABLE TO CONTINUE IN THE
JOB THEY MADE LOVE THAT IS NOT
ADEQUATELY SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES. AS YOU HEARD FROM
OTHERS DISINFECT THE PROMINENT
THE OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH WHICH
COMES WITH MANY BAD OUTCOMES
FOR A FOSTER CHILDREN ANY
CHANCE OF THE WAS ALSO
COSPONSORING THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
WHICH IS AN INNOVATIVE AND
SUCCESSFUL PROJECT. WHAT
PROGRAMS FOR RACIAL ETHNIC IN
LGBT COMMUNITY WE HAVE TO
EXTEND THE PROJECT FOR THREE
YEARS TO HELP REDUCE WELL
DOCUMENTED. MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES. WE ALSO WANT TO-
URGE THAT. BY AS WITH YOU.
REYES TWO HUNDRED OF THE POWER
LEVEL AND IS WHAT. INCLUDE AND
FUTURE DANIEL AT THEY HAVE
CURRENTLY. DURING AT NIGHT- AND
HAVE HAD OUT MORE MONEY TO HAVE
BILL. IN OAKLAND- LAPSLEY WE
JUST WANT TO AND SUPPORT WORKER
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT WAS
MENTIONED AND ALSO ONE OF THE
PORT THE PROPOSAL PUT FORTH BY
MIKE CARROLL FOR THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
CONCERNING CAL WORK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU AND
OUR NEXT QUESTION COMES FROM
THE LINE AT TWO SEVEN FIVE LINE%
TWO SEVEN FIVE YOU'RE GOING TO
NOW OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S
GETTING CHERRY NON MEMBERS MY
NAME INCLUDES MODERATE. I'M THE
DIVISION DIRECTOR WITH THE
SPIRIT AND THEN- WE'RE STATE
WHERE THEY CAN SEE HOW RUNNING
FROM ANGELES NUMBER NINETY NINE
SURROUNDING COUNTIES. COVERING
THE ENTIRE CENTRAL VALLEY ARE
THE WAY UP TO SACRAMENTO AND-
I'M HERE I'M TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION PREVENTING AND REDUCING
FOSTER. FROM INSTAPUNDIT NEEDS
PROPOSAL- YOU GUYS HAVE ALL
HEARD FROM THE LINE AND I DON'T
WANT TO REPEAT IT I'M IN IT TO
THE TRAUMA THAT THIS POPULATION
THAT EXPERIENCE. AND YOU KNOW
THESE. DO YOU THINK CHILDREN
WERE REMOVED FROM THEIR PARENTS
CARE. AND BECOME A REPLY OUR
RESPONSIBILITY LET'S WORK
TOGETHER SO THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO THE ADDED TO THEIR
ALREADY COMPLEX LIST OF TRAUMA
THAT THEY HAD EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS. AGAIN HERE
SUPPORT FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT.
TWO MILLION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU AND OUR NEXT.
COMIC COMES FROM THE LINE OF.
TWO TWO FOUR ONE ONE TWO FOUR
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN NOW
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO.
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA TORRES AND
I'M A HUGE ADVOCATE WITH JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YEARS I AM
UNITS. SUPPORT FOR EIGHTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION. PROPOSAL
WHICH WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
FUNDING DURING COLLEGE AND
BEYOND FOR HOUSING SUPPORT. FOR
KERN A FORMER FLASHY AS A
FORMER VARSITY AND ADDS UP ON
THE HOME WITH YOU. I FEEL THAT
THIS IS A CRITICAL TIME THAT
POSSIBLY NEED ALL THE HELP THAT
THEY CAN BUT ALSO IT'LL GIVE
THEM A SENSE OF. STABILITY
WITHIN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
BEING HOMELESS AND NOT OKAY- I
WAS HOMELESS FOR A WHILE AND I
WAS ALSO IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. SO FOR ME BEING HOMERS
AND ALSO BEING IN THE SYSTEM I
BELIEVE NOW IS THE TIME TO ACT-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
WILL. APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU AND OUR NEXT.
I NEXT QUESTION OR COMMENT
COMES FROM THE LINE OF TWO
SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS TAMMY WILSON I'M WITH A
GREAT CENTER ON THE CEO OKRA
WITH THE SEVENTY SIX BED S. T.
R. T. P. IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE. I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMAN RAMOS FOR HIS
SUPPORT OF THE COVER NINETEEN
ONE TIME RELIEF BILL. R. COSTA
RISEN TREMENDOUSLY IMPACT THIS
PAST YEAR WE LOST THE MILLION
TURNER FIVE. FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND ELEVEN DOLLARS AND THE
RTC ALONG THAT SACRIFICE WAS
WORTH IT DUE TO THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE PANDEMIC
AND THE VERY DESERVING YOUTH WE
SERVE. IT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT
SUSTAINABLE WE HAVE BEEN
SEVERITY. HEALTH STABILITY
SAFETY CONNECTIONS MOVING
TOWARD PERMANENCY THOSE ARE
ALSO IMPORTANT WHEN DEALING
WITH THIS VERY SEVERELY
DISTURBED COPULATION. THE KIDS
THAT WE WORK WITH HAVE CHANGED
ABUSE TRAUMA TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGES MANY YEAR WITHOUT
FAMILIES DURING A PANDEMIC WHEN
WE WERE SHALL TERM PLACE AND
HAVE THEM FOR SO LONG. DO YOU
FELT EVEN MORE ALONE AND
REMAINING CONNECTED WITH SO
VITALLY IMPORTANT WHEN THEY
DON'T HAVE FAMILIES. MANY OF
THESE FOSTER KIDS- THAT WOULD
NORMALLY ATTEND PUBLIC SCHOOL
BUT WHEN PUBLIC SCHOOLS CLOSED
WE BECAME. TEACHERS WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING IN ADDITION
TO BEING AN THAT PARENT ROLE WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THE COSTS
RELATED TO COMPUTERS EXTRA
STAFF IN. PPP EQUIPMENT NEEDED
SUPPLIES WAS JUST TREMENDOUS
NOT TO MENTION STAFFING COST
INCLUDING RECOGNIZING THAT THEY
WERE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO WERE
TRULY MAKING SACRIFICES LEAVING
THEIR OWN FAMILIES. MAYBE EVEN
WHEN THEY DON'T WANT TO THAT TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SAFETY AND
SECURITY HERE THAT INCLUDED
ALSO TREATING POP COVERED
POSITIVE PATIENTS WHO HAD NO
FAMILY TO. GIVE THEM ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT WE ALSO BROUGHT BACK
YOU FROM OUT OF STATE WHO HAD
MANY CHALLENGES ARE REQUIRED A
GREAT DEAL OF ADDITIONAL HELP.
WE'RE VERY VERY PROUD OF THE
MANY SUCCESS STORIES INCLUDING
TO YOU TO JUST GRADUATED THIS
IN THE PAST TWO WEEKS.
SUCCESSFULLY LAUNCHING
LAUNCHING INTO ADULTHOOD AS
FOSTER YET. WE DO REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF COVERED RELIEF IS AS
A- FOR COTTON. SO WORKER
PROVIDE OUR FAX FOSTER DOWN
AGENCY. AND ONE TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- TO THESE YOU ON OUR
TEAM. THANK MA'AM. YOU AND OUR
NEXT TIME IT COMES FROM THE
LINE TWO EIGHT Q. NINE Q. EIGHT
Q. YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND STAFF MY
NAME IS PATRICIA DANIELS. AS A
MATTER IF THEY PROGRAM DIRECTOR
FOR SPEARING AT SOUTH BAY AREA
I HAD SEEN A HIGH TURNOVER OF
SOCIAL WORKERS IN OUR SERVICE
AREA. AND MANY OF THE CHILDREN
USE THAT SERVE SEAT AND TYPES
OF SERVICES FOSTER CARE THESE
YOU TYPICALLY HAVE EXTENSIVE
HISTORY OF TRAUMA AND NEED A
SOCIAL WORKER WITH WHOM THEY
CAN DEVELOP A TRUSTING
RELATIONSHIP YEAH COULD DIP
DOWN CAN DEPEND ON FOR
CONSISTENT CARE. DUE TO THE
LOWER RATE OF PAY FOR FSA
SOCIAL WORKERS IT IS DIFFICULT
TO HIRE AND RETAIN QUALIFIED
SOCIAL WORKERS THE LOSS OF
SOCIAL WORKERS HAS A NEGATIVE
EFFECT ON OUR FOSTER. YOUTH AND
FOSTER FAMILIES. THE BUDGET OUR-
WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
SUPPORT FOR FFA SOCIAL WORKERS.
WHO MAKE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON THE PERMANENCY OUTCOMES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. I WANT TO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR SUPPORT. FOR
FSA SOCIAL WORKERS AND OTHER
CRITICAL BUDGET REQUEST SUCH AS
HELPING RESOURCE FAMILIES.
DURING PREVENT AND HELPING TO
STABILIZE S. T. R. T. P.'S
CLEARING COPAYS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU OUR
NEXT. COMIC COMES IN LINE Q.
SEVEN FOUR TWO SEVEN FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND STAFF MY NAME IS
JEANNIE I NúMERO AND I AM THE
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER GROWTH
HERE AND THAT WERE STATEWIDE
PROVIDER OF FOSTER CARE
ADOPTION TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
SERVICES BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PREVENTION AND SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT THIRTY
SAID. THIS EVENING I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE ONE
TIME REQUEST IN SUPPORT OF
SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROVIDER. THE STATE
HAS A GROWING DEPENDENCY ON
PROVIDERS NOT ONLY SURVIVING
DURING THIS TIME BUT THE
WRITING IN ORDER TO MEET THE
INCREASING NEED AROUND THE
FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICES BACK AND THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM BOTH WHICH HAVE
PROMISING OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE IF WE CAN YEAH STEADFAST
AND PROVIDE. THIS VERY COSTLY
TIME AND OTHERS HAVE SPOKEN
WELL TO THE INCREASED COST AND
I WANT TO SAY THAT THAT HAS
REALLY BEEN FOCUSED ON THE WELL
BEING OF OUR YOUTH AND OUR
STAFF BECAUSE WE CAN'T DO THIS
WORK WITHOUT OUR STAFF AND THEY
HAVE MADE THIS- SACRIFICES
ESSENTIAL WORKERS IN A TWENTY
FOUR HOUR SETTING DURING THIS
TIME. I AM ALSO HERE ON BEHALF
OF THEIR REQUEST TO SUPPORT
PERMANENCY- AND IN SUPPORTING
AND RETAINING OUR SOCIAL WORKER
STAFF AND FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY
THE REQUEST FOR A RESOURCE
PARENTS WHO HAVE BEEN VERY VERY
IMPORTANT DURING THAT TIME. AND
CHILD CARE AND CHILD CARE
BRIDGE THE INFANT SUPPLEMENT AT
20% OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE IN OUR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM OUR PARENTS CAN
USE. IN AND IN ADDITIONALLY THE
HOUSING SUPPORT FOR FOSTER
YOUTH GOING FORWARD THANK YOU
AGAIN AND HAVE A GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU MA'AM. OPERATOR WE'RE
READY FOR THE NEXT COLOR. THANK
YOU NINE TWO EIGHT FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN NINE TWO EIGHT
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO
EIGHT FOUR CAN YOU HEAR US.
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT ONE
LINE IT. ONE FIVE FOUR NINE ONE
FIVE FOUR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FIVE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
EVENING. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS JEFF ANY OTHER CASSELLS. I
AM THE REGIONAL MANAGER FOR THE
UNITED ABOUT THE WORKERS
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF- I
JUST AS WORKERS IN KERN COUNTY-
I HAVE PARTICIPATED IN
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN OUR UNION
AND KERN COUNTY FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS. AND I TO THE
PROVIDERS AND KERN NEED THE
STATE HELP IN ENSURING THAT THE
COUNTY MANAGES THE ITEMS THAT
PROGRAM IN AN ADEQUATE MANNER.
MOST COUNTIES UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF THE H. OF THIS PROGRAM
IN A WAY THAT THEY WILL MAKE AN
EFFORT TO INVEST IN IT. HOWEVER
SOME COUNTY LIKE KERN. WILL
MAKE EVERY EFFORT NOT TO FIND
IT. AND ONLY DO FOR THE I JUST
AS PROGRAM WHAT IS MANDATED AND
NOTHING ELSE. FOR TEN YEARS I
HAVE WITNESSED THE COUNTY OF
KERN MAKE EXCUSES FOR NOT
INVESTING IN THE AGE OF THIS
PROGRAM. EVEN WITH INCENTIVES
THAT WE'RE ALL PROPOSING TO
EXPAND. WHEN COUNTY LIKE KERN
COME TO THE TABLE WITH THEIR
MINDS ALREADY MADE AND NO
INTENTION TO OFFER A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THE
EYES OF THIS PROGRAM. DOESN'T
HELP ANYONE. AND TO SOLELY HAVE
INCENTIVES IS NOT ENOUGH.
THAT'S WHY I'M SPEAKING AND
STRONG SUPPORT TODAY FOR THE
10% FISCAL PENALTY TO COUNTIES.
THAT DO NOT BARGAIN IN GOOD
FAITH WHAT I JUST AS WORKERS SO
ENSURE ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR THE
CARE THAT CONSUMERS NEED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
ALIGN IT TWO SIX FOR YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN LINE TWO SIX FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
I'M A COMMITTEE MEMBER. MY NAME
IS FLORENCE PROPANE AND I'M AYE
HFS PROVIDER FOR MOST
ACCOUNTING. I'M ALSO UW'S
DISTRICT FOR CHAIR. I'M GOING
TO BE FIRST ON THE SHERIFF
COSTS SPLIT. IF THE 6535% LET
GOES INTO EFFECT THE COUNTY
COSTS FOR I'D JUST WAITING
CREEK WILL GO UP BY THIRTY
PERCENT. THIS IS NOT GOING TO
WORK OUT FOR IS YOUR SAYS THE
PROVIDERS OR THE RECIPIENT WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. TO KEEP THE
CURRENT FORMULA IN PLACE. WE'VE
BEEN TO RESTORE THE 7% CUT I
JUST AS OURS HERE AFTER YEAR.
OKAY NINETEEN HAS. THAT I CAN'T
THAT IS NEEDED NOW MORE THAN
EVER WHICH IS WHY I SUPPORT
PERMANENTLY RESTORING THE 7%
TAX ONCE AND FOR ALL. WAXWING I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. HELLO DATING
A 10% PENALTY I'M COUNTY TO
REFUSE TO COME TO A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT WITH IDEAS
THAT PROVIDERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT COMIC COMES IN.
TWO SIX NINE NINE TWO SIX NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWO SIX NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GETTING NO RESPONSE WILL GO TO
THE NEXT FINE. LINE TWO SEVEN A.
ONE NINE TWO SEVEN ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN PEOPLE HERE.
YES THANK YOU- GOOD EVENING
CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ASTRAZENECA
I AM AN AGENT THAT PROVIDER
FROM CATAPULT COUNTY AND THE
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT. OF UT
W. THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING TODAY. I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT AT THE 10% BUCKLE
PENALTY FOR COUNTY TO FAILED TO
BARGAIN WITH OUR UNION IN GOOD
FAITH. WE ARE PAID LOW WAGES
FOR LIFESAVING WORK AND IT'S
TIME FOR COUNTY TO INVEST IN I.
HFS AND PAINT PROVIDERS A
LIVING WAGE. I UPSET AT TO MANY
AN ASSOCIATION TABLE WHERE WE
HAVE NEGOTIATED OVER PENNIES
PER YEAR AND THAT IS RIDICULOUS
AND WRONG. AND FOR THAT AND
MANY OTHER REASONS WHY I AM
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF KEEPING THE
CURRENT 6535% SHARE COSTS IN
PLACE. IF THIS HAPPENS IT IS.
GUARANTEED BUT I IT'S JUST A
PROVIDER. WILL NEVER RETURN.
WITH THE COUNTY EVEN FUTURE.
THAT WILL BE. ANYWHERE NEAR A
LIVABLE WAGE. IN ADDITION TO
DIS THE 7% CUT WOULD PUT IN
PLACE NEARLY A DECADE AGO. AND
IT IS LONG OVERDUE FOR
RESTORATION. I JUST SERVICES
ARE NECESSARY TO KEEP SOME OF
OUR COMMUNITY BOTH VULNERABLE.
OLDER ADULTS.AND THOSE LIVING
WITH DISABILITIES FACE. WE THE
STATE TO QUIT. BUDGETS THEIR
BACK. YOU SEE YEAR AFTER YEAR
WHETHER AT THE STATE OR COUNTY
LEVEL WE ARE CONSTANTLY HAVING
TO FIGHT TO THE VERY BASICS.
THAT IS WHY WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT US ON ALL OF THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM. CONNECT
COMMENT COMES FROM MINE FIVE
NINE NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING- GETTING A MIXTURE
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ELAINE QUEEN AND SHIFT
PROVIDER FOR AMERICAN COUNTY I
TAKE CARE OF MY MOTHER AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THE 10% FISCAL
PENALTY FOR COUNTIES WHO FAILED
TO BARGAIN WITH OUR UNION IN
GOOD FAITH- I HAVE SAT ON THE
BARGAINING COMMITTEE AND I'VE
SEEN HOW LONG IT TAKES. FOR
THEM TO NEGOTIATE WITH OUR WE
ARE PAID LOW WAGES FOR
LIFESAVING WORK AND IT'S TIME
FOR THE COUNTIES TO INVEST IN
MY DEFENSE. AND PAINTS A LIVING
WAGE. ALSO IN A- FOR MANY YEARS
THE SIXTY FIVE BY 35% SHARE
COSTS FOR A DEFENSE WAGE AND
BENEFIT INCREASES. HAS WORKED
FOR BOTH THE STATE AND THE
COUNTIES. I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
MAINTAINING THAT SHARE COST
OTHERWISE MY COUNTY MAY NEVER
COME TO A CONTRACT AGAIN. AND
EXPLORE SB 7% THE 7% CUT WAS IN
PLACE NEARLY A DECADE AGO. AND
IT IS LONG OVERDUE FOR
RESTORATION. I TOOK A SERVICES
ARE NECESSARY TO KEEP OUR OLDER
ADULTS AND THOSE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES SAFE AND WE URGE
YOU ALL TO SUPPORT RESTORING
THE SEVEN PERCENT. CUT
PERMANENTLY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM.
OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES ONLINE.
TWO ONE ZERO NINE TWO ONE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS DAN OPEN BECAUSE PUBLIC
POLICY MANAGER OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR AND
THAT WE CAN CENTERS. WE ARE
STATEWIDE MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATION MAPLE TWENTY TWO
CALIFORNIA'S 28-7 CENTERS- WE
SUPPORT SPENDING PRIORITIES
LISTED IN ISSUE FIVE DATED
GENDER. THIS IS A CLEAR BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS OFFERED BY MARTIN
DURING AN UNSUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING- WE SUPPORT
NEED INCREASE EIGHT YEARS HE-
BUDGET BEYOND WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED AND THEN OR
EXPAND AND MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITY. WE ASK THAT YOU
UPPORT THIS- AUGMENTATION I
REQUEST WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING UNION STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THIS IS
ITEMS WE FUNDED THANK YOU FOR
TIMES RIGHT. THANK YOU SIR. AND
OUR NEXT COMPANY COME THROUGH
THE LINE. TWO ONE SEVEN NINE
TWO ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS BOTH A VERY EXPONENTIAL
CONTROLLER CONVENTION CENTER
AND GOES HOME. WE ARE- IF YOU
HAD TO BE AGENCY- WE HAVE BEEN
HELPING. ARE YOU LOS SINCE
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE. LIKE
MANY OTHER CFPB AGENCIES WHO
RUN SHOW EXPERIENCING
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL LOSSES
DUE TO THE- SCOPE OF NINETEEN
CREATED- FOR US TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO OUR YEARS. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
APPROVAL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE ONE POUND COVERED BY
TO REQUEST TO REIMBURSE IF
YOU'RE A KEY PIECE FOR BOTH
COLD NINETEEN EXPENSES. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR. CONSIDERATION
TWENTY. THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU LINE TWO SEVEN EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN MIND TO SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE- MY NAME IS JAMIE I AM A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN
CURRENTLY IS SOCIAL WORKER WITH
EACH FAMILY SERVICES IN
SACRAMENTO. I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE EIGHT POINT TWO
MILLION PREVENTING AND REDUCING
FOSTER YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL WHICH WILL PROVIDE
CRITICAL FUNDING DURING
COVIDIEN BEYOND FOR HOUSING
SUPPORTS FOR CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOU. LAST YEAR'S
TRANSITIONING INTO ADULTHOOD
ARE OFTEN FORCED TO RELOCATE
OUT OF COUNTY. DUE TO THE HIGH
HOUSING COST OR TO REMAIN IN
THEIR CURRENT COUNTY FACING
HOMELESSNESS INVESTING IN
HOUSING PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
WOULD BRIDGE THE GAP FOR YEARS.
WANTING TO REMAIN IN HEIR
CURRENT COUNTY AND THEREFORE BE
CLOSER TO THEIR SUPPORT SYSTEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. I
NEXT COMIC PENSION LINE Q.
EIGHT ZERO NINE TWO EIGHT ZERO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING I'M JODY GUN
REPRESENTING THE FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM OF ALL THINGS THE
FISCAL CHURCH IN BATH. IN
PASADENA WHERE A LARGE
CONGREGATION THAT WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH DR HOUSTON THE
LARGER LOS ANGELES AREA. I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLAR PREVENTING
AND REDUCING FACTOR YOU
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL WHICH
PROVIDES CRITICAL FUNDING FOR
COVERT AND BEYOND FOR HELPING
SUPPORT. FOR CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. I NEXT TIME IT COMES
FROM LINE. SIX ONE NINE SIX
ONE. WHEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MCEACHERN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARIA BEACH I'M AND I
EXECUTIVE PROVIDER IN THE
COUNTY. AND A MEMBER OF THE
YEAR DELIVERY THIRTY NINE
THIRTY AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY. PENALTY FOR
COUNTING FIFTEEN KERN
PROPELLING THE COME TO THE
BARGAINING TABLE AND REGARD CAN
INCREASE IN WAGES AND BENEFITS.
LIVING FOR CALIFORNIA- AND
CURRENTLY HAVE BEEN ANYWHERE
BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY ONE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. YEAH WE ACCEPT
WORKERS ARE ONLY PAID A LITTLE
OVER MINIMUM WAGE. INCOME
CONGRESS PEOPLE HAVE REFERRED.
TO IT AS PRESERVATION WAIT CHEN.
IT WOULD COM THAT OF A- AND
CURRENT GOAL CARE A MONTHLY.
AND THAT ONLY DO TWO- THE LOW
WAGES AND PROVIDERS ARE PAID
EQUALLY. I'M CURRENTLY BEING
PUT MULTIPLE HEALTH ISSUES AND
LOCAL WITH MINIMAL ISSUE THAT-
SO I BELIEVE THAT THAT. A
DISCREPANCY RIGHT I STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT OFMONETARY
INCENTIVE LOCKER THAT GAP COULD
BE CLOSED. AS I PROVIDERS WE
HOPE MANY HAVE WE BECOME NURSES
SHALL NAMED. TREVOR COUNSELORS
SOCIAL WORKERS AND EVEN FRIENDS
NOT TO MENTION THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO WORK IN THE MOST DANGEROUS
SITUATION AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
CAN HELP YOU- ISOLATED AND
VULNERABLE- IN ORDER FEEDBACK
MIGHT UNKNOWN BED AND NON HOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. I'M NOT CONNECT
COMMENT I NEXT COMIC COMES FROM
LINE. TO SEVEN NINE TWO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS A LEASE SEE
UNCLE SO AND I AM AND I HSS
PROVIDERS FROM KERN COUNTY. AND
I JUST WANTED TO GIVE MY
SUPPORT FOR GIVING A 10% FISCAL
PENALTY TO COUNTY LIKE KERN
COUNTY WHO FAILED TO BARGAIN
WITH US- IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
COST OF LIVING IN KERN COUNTY
WAS EIGHTEEN DOLLARS AND EIGHTY
FOUR CENTS AN HOUR. BUT I EACH
AT THIS WE ARE PROVIDERS HAVE
ONLY MADE AROUND MINIMUM WAGE
AROUND THIRTEEN DOLLARS TO WIN
KERN COUNTY HAVE BEEN MAKING
THE STATE'S MINIMUM WAGE FOR
THREE AND A HALF YEARS NOW. AND
THAT'S HOW LONG YOU HAVE BEEN
WITHOUT A CONTRACT ONCE AGAIN
UNTIL I AM IN SUPPORT OF GIVING
A 10% FISCAL PENALTY TO
COUNTIES LIKE KERN WHO FILLED
THE BARGAIN WITH. THANK. YOU
AND HAVE A GOOD EVENING THANK
YOU MA'AM. I NEXT. COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE. TWO SIX EIGHT
NINE TWO SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS AGREEMENT FOR
TAKEN THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AFFECTING
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLAR HEALTHY FUTURES AFTER
YOU PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE
INFANT SACRAMENTO. ALL THE
REASONS THAT SPREAD BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO EARLIER IN THE
HEARING WE ALSO WISH TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS RELATED TO. THE
FOSTER CARE OMBUDSPERSON IN ANY
OFFICE OF TRIBAL AFFAIRS TO
SUPPORT CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. OUR
NEXT COMIC COMES ONLINE. TWO
ONE SIX NINE TWO ONE SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS- CONNIE
BARKER ALL HOME CARE WORKER.
BOTH PAID AND AT TIMES UNPAID-
AND I'VE WORKED BOTH IN THE IHS
US SYSTEM AND PRIVATELY FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS I'M ALSO AN
ACTIVIST WITH AS HE ARE YOU
TWENTY FIFTEEN WHICH REPRESENTS
THE AYE CHáVEZ WORKERS IN MY
COUNTY- AND WITH LONG TERM
SERVICES FOR ALL GRASS ROOTS
NETWORK. MORE THANK YOU FOR
THIS MOST INFORMATIVE HEARING
AND TO SPEAK TO A SEVERAL
ISSUES UNDER ITEM FIVE RELATING
TO THINGS ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN
ON AGING OR THAT IT DEALT WITH-
ITEM NUMBER ONE THE 7%
RESTORATION PLEASE MAKE IT
PERMANENT. BUDGET FLEXIBILITY
SHOULD NOT BE HAD- STARTING
EVERY YEAR WITH THE MOST
VULNERABLE LET ALONE HAVE THAT
WRITTEN INTO LAWSUIT IT'S
MANDATED TO GO THAT WAY. I WAS
DOING IT THE WAY THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY DOING IT DOES NOT
PASS THE EQUITY TEST DOESN'T
PASS THE SMELL TEST EITHER
PLEASE GET RID OF THAT
PERMANENTLY. ITEM NUMBER TWO-
PLEASE MAINTAIN THE COVERT
RELATED PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY IS
THAT IT HAS BEEN REALLY
BENEFICIAL- TO MANY PEOPLE THAT
I KNOW INCLUDING ME AND MY
PARTNER WHO IS THE MAIN PERSON
THAT I CARE FOR- I'M
PARTICULARLY THINKING IN THIS
INSTANCE OF THE PROVIDER BACKUP
REGISTRY WHICH AS RESEARCH ALL
I SAID PREVIOUSLY IN THE
COMMENTS. SHOULD BE EXPANDED TO
INCLUDE PARAMEDICAL SERVICES I
AND ALSO THE ABILITY OF
PROGRAMS LIKE M. S. S. P. TO
PROVIDE SERVICES REMOTELY
INCLUDING. THINGS LIKE ADULT
DAY HEALTH- I NUMBER THREE. DO
TAKE THE ALL A- AND- WORK ON
GETTING THE COUNTIES TO GET
WAGES UP TO OF A LIVING WAGE
PLACE AND PROVIDE BENEFITS-
LIKE RETIREMENT AND SICKLY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS TO
HAPPEN IF WE'RE EVER GOING TO
HAVE A WORK FORCE FOR HOME CARE
THAT CAN KEEP UP WITH THE
DEMAND THAT THAT'S COMING OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS IT ISN'T
JUST THE AUDITOR WHO SAID THAT.
NUMEROUS REPORTS AS I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY HAVE SAID THE SAME
THING- USE CARROTS IN EVERY
CASE THAT YOU CAN BUT IF THE
CARROTS DON'T WORK WE MAY NEED
STEP. I AM I AM VERY MUCH IN
FAVOR OF DOING SOMETHING LIKE-
THE 10% PENALTY TO BRING THOSE
COUNTIES TO THE TABLE WHO HAVE.
REFUSED TO BE THERE AS FAR. AS
THE SIXTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE BUT
THIS CONCERNED THAT WOULD BE
ABSOLUTELY DISASTROUS PLEASE DO
NOT DO THAT- DO EXPAND THE MSSP
PROGRAM I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH
POSITIVE THINGS ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM- THE SOCIAL WORKERS
THERE. I HAVE DONE MORE FOR ME
AND MY PARTNER IN EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS WHERE WE REALLY
DESPERATELY NEEDED HELP WITH
SOMETHING AND IF THEY WERE
GOING TO BE DISASTROUS. RESULTS
IF WE DIDN'T GET IT- THOSE ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO AGAIN AND AGAIN
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS HAVE
MANAGED TO PUT US IN TOUCH WITH
PROGRAMS OR AGENCIES OR
RESOURCES THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW
WERE THERE. AND THAT PULLED US
THROUGH I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH
ABOUT IT. EXPANDED HOWEVER YOU
CAN TO GIVE MORE PEOPLE ACCESS
TO IT- THE IDEA OF AUTOMATIC
TERMINATIONS. I HSS. WHEN A
PERSON CAN'T GET IT TOGETHER TO
GET IN THE PAPERWORK. TO BE RE
UPPED FOR SS AS I. IS A
INCREDIBLY BAD I'D- PLEASE
DON'T THAT IF THINK YOU HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU'VE GOTTEN
EXTENDED GRACE PERIOD BECAUSE
YOU'LL END UP WITH PEOPLE-
EITHER DEAD OR IN NURSING HOMES
IF YOU DON'T. FINAL THING- THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING'S-
RECOMMENDATION TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF MAKING A LONG TERM-
SERVICES BENEFIT. AVAILABLE TO
EVERYONE SOMETHING THAT WILL
NOT BE MEANS TESTED IS. REALLY
WHERE WE HAVE TO GO ON THIS I
ACCESSING THESE KIND OF
SUPPORTS IT SHOULD NOT HAVE IS
A REQUIREMENT FOR IT SPENDING
YOURSELF DOWN INTO POVERTY AND
THEN KEEPING YOURSELF THERE
FOREVER. THAT'S JUST WRONG ON
ABOUT A MILLION DIFFERENT-
PARAMETERS AND ANYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO TO MOVE AWAY FROM THAT
MODEL AND TO A MODEL THAT HAS
LONG TERM SERVICES INCLUDED AS
BENEFITS THAT EVERYONE HAS
AFFECT ACCESS TO. IS WHERE WE
NEED TO GO PLEASE SUPPORT THAT
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
HEARING WHICH AGAIN I WANT TO
SAY HAS BEEN MOST INFORMATIVE.
THANK YOU MA'AM JUST FOR THE Q.
WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY FORTY
PEOPLE LEFT IN THE QUEUE WE ARE
READY FOR THE NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU AND I NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN NINE TWO SEVEN SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
RICHARD PRYOR AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF MISSION PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD IN SAN FRANCISCO
I'M HERE TO ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGET REQUEST
FOR THE CRADLE TO CAREER GRANT
PROGRAM. AS PROPOSED IN AB NINE
THREE Q. IT'LL FUND NEW PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS ACROSS THE STATE.
FROM NEIGHBORHOOD COORDINATE
PUBLIC BENEFITS AT THE
NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL AND
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES WHILE REDUCING
POVERTY. OUR PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
LATINO COMMUNITY. CONNECTED
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES TO
EMERGENCY KOPET INCOME RELIEF
EVICTION PROTECTIONS AND
MEDICAL HOMES. AND EQUITY
FOCUSED DATA DRIVEN COMMUNITY
LET INVESTMENT LIKE THE CRADLE
TO CAREER GRANT PROGRAM. IS A
REFLECTION OF GOOD GOVERNMENT
AND AN IDEA WHOSE TIME HAS
COME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU SIR.
OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM
LYING TO EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE TWO EIGHT EIGHT THE
LINE IS OPEN. X. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS PATRICIA OLD I'M THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR CHILD HELP
FOSTER FAMILY NEED OPTION
AGENCY. CHILD NOTHING'S BEEN IN
OPERATION SERVING CHILDREN OF
FOR OVER SIXTY YEARS WITH BOTH
IN S. R. G. P. EIGHT FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY AS WELL NATIONAL
HOTLINE. FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE MISTER CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STAFF AND
ESPECIALLY ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO
FOR CHAMPIONS THE FFA SOCIAL
WORKER PROPOSAL. SOCIAL WORKER
STABILITY IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO FOSTER YEARS ONE OF FOSTER
YOUTH THIS IS A SOCIAL WORKER
WITH HIM YEAR SHE HAS A
RELATIONSHIP WITH. THIS CAMP
DESTRUCTIVE PROMISED YOU PLAN
INCREASE FEELINGS OF PAST AND
PRESENT TRAUMA. MANY FACTORIES
HAVE NOT HAD AN ADULT MALE
LIFE. THEY COULD TRY TO LOOK TO
FOR GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT FOR
MANY FIVE THREE ITSELF DOWN THE
VERY IMPORTANT BOND IN THEIR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR ETHNIC
BASED POSTAL WORKER. BUT I
THOUGHT YOU'D HAVE THE SAME
CONSISTENT SOCIAL WORKER DURING
THEIR TIME IN FOSTER CARE THIS
CAN LEAD TO HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS AND INCREASE
THEIR CHANCE FOR PERMANENT
INDETERMINACY CATION
GUARDIANSHIP OR ADOPTION. BUT
MY OVER THIRTY PLUS YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN FOSTER
CARE AND ADOPTION AS A. THAT'S
THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR
EFFORT THINK BOSTON WORKER HAD
GIVEN THEM INCREASED CONFIDENCE
IMPROVED SELF ESTEEM AND A
FELINE THAT INTELLIGENT AND
LYFT TRULY MADE THEM FEEL
SPECIAL IN PORTLAND AND CARED
FOR. CURRENTLY ON MY STAFF I
HAVE. A SOCIAL WORKERS WHO WORK
ON ABOUT THREE YEARS AND ABOUT
THE. EXPRESS IN OF HAVING A CAN.
WAY JERRY THEIR TIME IN FACT
CARE ALONG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LINE UP WITH THE S. T. R. T. P.
A- FUNDING FOR THE- FAMILIES
SHOULD. THAT ENTIRE. INTENT
SUPPLEMENT INCREASES AND THE
CHILD CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM ON
BEHALF OF MY RESEARCH PARENTS
CHILDREN AND STAFF I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
HAVE A GOOD EVENING THANK YOU
MA'AM. I NEXT COMIC COMES FROM
LINE CUTE. ONE NINE NINE ONE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS CAMILLE SCHRADER I AM
THE FOUNDER. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF PUBLIC POLICY FOR REDWOOD
COMMUNITY SERVICES WE ARE A
MULTI AGENCY PROVIDER IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND- BUT I
WANT TO SAY. MY GOODNESS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND YOUR SERVICE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IF YOU SELL MANY VALIANT
AND AMAZING- PROGRAMS OUT THERE
AND THINGS THAT YOU FINDIN
SUPPORT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- I WANT TO SUPPORT
BE. SURPLUS WORKERS. IN AS WELL
AS THE IMPACT INCREASING AND
LOVE CHILD CARE BRIDGE HOW MY
MOST- SIGNIFICANT ITEM THAT I
REALLY HOPE YOU HEAR IS THAT
OUR MOST MARBLE ARE MOST
TRAUMATIZED- DYSREGULATED
CHILDREN END UP IN CONGREGATE
CARE OTHERWISE KNOWN AS NPR T.
P.'S IN CALIFORNIA. ARE IN NEED
OF THEM THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
CLINICAL AND THERAPEUTIC-
GETTING POSSIBLE THAT WE HAVE
AS YOU KNOW A HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN CHILDREN CAME FROM OUT
OF STATE AND IN THE TIME OF
CODED WE'VE BEEN HIT ESPECIALLY
HARD WE HAD TO. PROVIDE WORK
FOR CLASSES WE HAD HUGE ****
BUT HAVE TO PAY OVERTIME DOUBLE
TIME PEOPLE WHO ARE DEDICATED
TO STAYING WE HAD A LOT TO
VACANCY BECAUSE WE COULD NOT
TAKE ALL OF THE CHILDREN WHO
NEEDED THAT BECAUSE THE PUBLIC
RESTRICTIONS AND WE ARE
LITERALLY ALREADY PRE CALL
WHICH WERE STRUGGLING WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CPR AND AFTER
TEEPEES PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE
NOW. FOR US TO GET THROUGH THIS
NEXT THIRTY TIME AND TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE CARE OF THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN AS I WAS WE
MUST BE ABLE TO SUPPORT OUR
CURRENT IF YOUR TV PROGRAMS
WITH A ONE TIME ONE TIME YOU
HEAR ME ONE TIME COALBED RELIEF
ASKED TO KEEP US AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO TAKE GOOD CARE OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE MOST NEEDY
MOST AT RISK CHILDREN THAT WE
SERVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM. I NEXT COME IT
COMES MIND TWO ONE FIVE LINE
TWO ONE YEAR LINE IS NOW OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR JERRY
MEMBERS AND STAFFERS. MY NAME
IS JAY BE A FORM AND THEN THAT
SERVICES STATE COORDINATOR.
ORGANIZING OF BILLS SERVICES WE
NINETY METRIC WORKERS ASKED ME
LOCAL THIRTY AND THIRTY. THANKS
SO MUCH FOR HAVING HIS HEARING.
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED. 10% FISCAL PALLAVI.
I'M IN HOMES SIR. COUNTY TO
FAIL TO BARGAIN. WITH OUR UNION
COULD STAY. IN MY DUTIES I'VE
HAD THE PLEASURE TO TRAVEL UP
AND DOWN- THE STATE. IT'S GREAT
STATE TO MEET WITH OUR
WONDERFUL MEMBERS AND THEIR
CLIENTS. ONE OF MY MAIN DUTIES
IS TO HELP SECURE NEW CONTRACTS
WHERE MEMBERS COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. IN MOST OF OUR
COUNTIES WE HAVE PARTNERS TO
BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH. HOWEVER
THERE ARE SOME BAD APPLES. TO
PARTICULAR YOU IN TURN COUNTY.
WHERE MEMBERS HAVE NOT SECURED
ACCOUNT NEW CONTRACT UPWARDS
NEARLY EIGHT YEARS. THIS IS
UNCONSCIONABLE AND THAT THE
CHEMIST DISPARITY PASSED AND
NOW. UNTIL JANUARY FIRST OF
THIS YEAR THERE WAS AT LEAST A
RECOURSE OF A 1% PENALTY TO
LEVEL TO LEVY AGAINST THESE BAD
ACTORS. I THOUGHT I CHECKED I'M
A LITTLE TOO SMALL THERE WAS
SOMETHING. NOW THERE IS
NOTHING. ELSE THAT LEGISLATION
HAS EXPIRED. THAT IS WHY WE
NEED TO NOT ONLY RESURRECT NEW
POUNDS LEGISLATION AND MAKE
THAT LEGISLATION STRONGER SO
THAT SOME OF OUR- SOME OF OUR
STATE'S MOST ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
ARE HOME CARE WORKERS ARE ABLE
TO NOT ONLY LIVE. BUT RIDE
TODAY'S ECONOMY. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU. NEXT
TIME IT COMES TO MIND. TWO NINE
TWO NINE TWO NINE TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS MARK STUYVESANT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
CALLING ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ORGANIZATION
STATEWIDE. OR IN SUPPORT OF DR
REYNOLDS REQUEST TO RESTORE
FUNDING FOR THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM. THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT
HOPEFULLY THROUGH GIGI R. F.
FUNDS BUT WE ARE OPEN TO ANY
OTHER SOURCE. THE PROGRAM TO
BRING SOLAR POWER AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY TO AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOUSE. AND IT SOLVES THREE OF
THE STATE'S TOP PRIORITY GOALS
ONE REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THREE EQUITY AT THE
PROGRAM SERVES ADULTS IN AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. OUR NEXT COMIC COME TO
MIND. TWO NINE FIVE NINE TWO
NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I JUST
WANTED TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
STILL BEING HERE MY NAME IS
OVER THE LAWN WITH THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA. AS A MEMBER OF THE
TRUTH INJECTED IN TOPICAL
COALITION I STRONGLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT 1100%
OF ALL CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS.
GO DIRECTLY TO CHILDREN WE ARE
THE MANY GOVERNMENT- DEPT AND
THE 10% INTEREST ON THE DEBT.
ENDEAVOR LIKE THAT THE PENSIONS
BUT THE INABILITY TO PAY CHILD
SUPPORT. I AM HERE CALLED
ATTENTION TO THE
DISPROPORTIONATE RESOURCE
ECONOMIC DISPARITY PERPETUATED
BY THE CHILD HOW TO PROTECT
THEM THAT TAKE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION EACH YEAR IN TOP PUT
THEM LOW INCOME CHILDREN. A
THIRD OF THE TOP FOUR DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT CHILDREN THAT THE
STATE TAKE THAT MONEY FROM
FAMILY COURT LOW INCOME.
DECLARED CRITICAL TO PACK THE
1% ATOP THE QUIRKINESS. ANOTHER
NOTE I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION THAT WON HER TWENTY
EIGHT ORGANIZATION TO CUT THE
CORPORATE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND HOW THE
FUTURE POP THE TALK TO YOU
BECAUSE THEY'LL- TAKE THEM TO
AN- INFANT COUPLE THAT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND THANK YOU
FOR EVERYTHING I DO BY. EMAIL
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COME
CUSTOMER LINE ONE SIX FIVE.
NINE ONE. FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GO A. ONE SIX FIVE. OUR
NEXT QUESTION COMES TO MIND.
TWO NINE SIX NINE TWO NINE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING. MY NAME
IS ANNA AND I'M THE CEO AND
FOUNDER OF MARIN PROMISE
PARTNERSHIP IF THE CRADLE TO
CAREER PARTNERSHIPS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NONPROFITS.
GOVERNMENT DEPARTMENT FUNDERS
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS. WILL
COME TOGETHER TO CLOSE
EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT AND
OPPORTUNITY GAPS. WE ARE ALSO A
PROUD MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
CRADLE THE CREEK COALITION
WHICH INCLUDES BOTH TRIED TO
GATHER COMMUNITIES AND PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOODS. WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
THIRTY MILLION CLICK CRADLE TO
CAREER GRANT PROGRAM THAT WOULD
SUPPORT RESULT BASED DATA
DRIVEN APPROACHES. THAT
CHALLENGE POVERTY AND BRING
MEANINGFUL TRANSFORMATION TO
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU OUR NEXT WHEN
IT COMES TO MIND. THREE HUNDRED
NINE THREE ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD EVENING MY NAME IN
THERE ABOUT THE TACKLE AND THE
AND THE- STATE DIRECTOR AT THE
CAMPAIGN FISCAL SITE INSTITUTE
ON AGING. AND I'M CALLING
BECAUSE THE PART OF THE AND THE
THANK YOU BAKER NANCY. WITHOUT
ESTABLISHING OUR RATE AS A
PERMANENT RATE WE WOULD GO BACK
THE RATE STRUCTURE THAT IT'S
MORE THAN A DECADE OLD. AND I
FIGHT COULD NOT BE. ABLE TO GET
INTO THE WORK. WOULD YOU
STATEWIDE. INFORMAL BONTA
SENIOR STATE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
MA'AM. I NEXT TIME IT COMES ON
LINE. THREE ZERO ONE NINE THREE
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
OF THE STAFF MY NAME IS MELINDA
ELKINS POLICY STUDIES. DIRECTOR
FOR A SPONSOR FAMILY AGENCY AND
HAPPILY TAKEN MARK. OUR AGENCY
HAS BEEN FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE
SAME ADDRESS A SOCIAL WORKER
FOR SIXTEEN YEARS AND THE
IMPACT OF HER WORK HAS MADE ON
OUR AT THAT THEY USE HAS BEEN
EXCEPTIONAL. PROVIDING THEM
STUDENT THAT STABILITY PATH TO
PERMANENT THE INCREASE.
CONNECTIONS WITH BIOLOGICAL
PARENTS. AND RESEARCH PARENTS
AND ADOPTION. BAR AT THAT THEY
USE TO HAVE THE SAME SO WORKER.
THEM TO CREATE HEALTHY GOT
REALLY. MANAGEMENT THEIR
CHANCES FOR REUNIFICATION
GUARDIANSHIP AND ADOPTION.
ADDITIONALLY I'M AWARE OF. HOW
SOCIAL WORKERS THE ABILITY IS
SO IMPORTANT FOR YOU AND LIVING
A SOCIAL WORK INTERN.
PERMANENCY PLANS INCREASE
HEALING FROM TRAUMA. AGAIN
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
STAFF AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR FFA SOCIAL WORKERS
AND OTHER CRITICAL BUDGET
REQUEST SUCH AS HELPING
RESEARCH FAMILY DURING COLLEGE.
AND HELPING TO STABILIZE ASK
YOUR GP DURING CALL THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. OUR NEXT
COMIC CANCER LINE. TWO NINE
SEVEN NINE TWO NINE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAY I SAY I APPRECIATE THAT
CHAIRED OPENING- REMARKS
REGARDING INEQUITIES IN
COMMUNITIES REPRESENTING PEOPLE
OF COLOR- MY NAME IS DONNA THAT
CALL AND THAT HE WOULD PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD. AND I'M A TRUSTEE
FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. I AM ASKING FOR THE
BUDGET SUPPORT OF THE CRADLE TO
CAREER GRANT PROGRAM THE
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD MODEL HAS
BEEN TRANSFORMATIVE. AND UNDERS
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES. FUNDING
FOR THE CRADLE TO CAREER GRANT
WHICH IS DATA DRIVEN AND
TRANSPARENT WILL CONTINUE THE
PROVEN RESULTS THAT ARE CLEARLY
HELPING TO ALLEVIATE ALLEVIATE.
GENERATIONAL AND CHILD POVERTY
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
WITH BEAUTIFUL HARDWORKING
FAMILY ORIENTED PEOPLE SO
PLEASE BONTA CRADLE TO CAREER
GRANT. YOU WILL BE PROUD IS
LEGISLATORS OF THE IMPACT WILL
CHANGE THIS COLLABORATION A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION MAKE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE WHAT'S
YOUR BUDGET APPROVAL THANK. YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE THANK YOU
MA'AM. COMMENTED FOR MINE. TWO
NINE EIGHT NINE TWO NINE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU HELLO. MY NAME
IS RACHEL GREATEST MAN A MEMBER
OF THE TREE AND- IN CHILD
SUPPORT COALITION I STRONGLY
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO MODERNIZE
THE CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM IN
STAND 1100% OF ALL CHILD%
SUPPORT PAYMENTS DIRECTLY TO
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. EACH YEAR
THE STATE TAKES ALMOST FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION IN CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES TO REIMBURSE
CAL WORK HI. THIS COUNTRY HAVE
A POLICY CREAE DISTRACT WITH
THE CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM AMONG
PARENTS AND UNDERMINES THE GOAL
OF THE PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN. BOTH COLORADO AND
MINNESOTA SPENT FULL PAYMENT
THE FAMILY COLORADO FOUND
MONTHLY COLLECTIONS MADE IN
KERN ASSISTANT CASES. ROSE 76%
AFTER A POLICY CHANGE AND
MINNESOTA HAD AN INCREASE OF
42% BECAUSE PARENTS KNEW THEIR
MONEY. WAS GOING DIRECTLY TO
THEIR KIDS. LET'S WALK AWAY
FROM THE NOTION OF CHILD THAT
SUPPORT THE REVENUE GENERATING
PROGRAM FOR GOVERNMENT INSTEAD
BUT THE- THIRD TRAILBLAZING
STATE NATION THAT ONLY SUPPORTS
LOW INCOME PARENTS BY TAPPING
1100% OF PAYMENTS TO THEM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT TIME IT COMES ON LINE.
THREE ZERO TWO NINE THREE ZERO
TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIR AT
AMBER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME CHRISTINA POSITION DIEGO
AND I AM THE OBJECT THE POWER
TO WITH REYES AND ARE WE CAL.
THERE CALIBER COULD HAVE
CRITICAL COMING OUT THROUGH
OVER A HUNDRED AND YOU'RE GONNA.
CHAINS BUDGET YOU'RE OUT OF THE
NEED TO INVEST IN. MPS CARGO
THAT THE NOT YOU FOR FROM.
ATTENDED NINETY TWO WE WAS NOT-
THE AND PAPER CHEN TODAY. DON'T
YOU COMMUNITIES COME FROM
POVERTY BY BREAKING SILOS AND
ITEM. BURIED ROLE TO RESPOND.
OF LOCAL. TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
PROVIDE SERVICE ELIMINATE THE-
OF SERVICES AND I RESEARCH THAT
CHEN CALLED SAVINGS OVER THE
LONG. LONG BEFORE CALL THERE
ARE CRITICAL COMMUNITIES
FREDERICTON EQUITY GAPS AND SHE
MADE THE COLOR. DURING COLD
WORKING TO STREAM CONTENT EVERY
AND AVOID INTERRUPTION WITH
THAT THE- ORDERS. AND
ADDITIONALLY MET THE ELEVATED
INTO THEIR COMMUNITIES. HM
TRANSIT THEM BY IDENTIFYING AND
CHANGING POLICIES AND PRACTICES
FROM THE EQUITY LENS WITH
EXPLICIT INTENTION OF THE BATON
SYSTEMIC RACISM. EMBEDDED IN
PROBLEMS OF PRACTICE IF YOU
WANT TO TEACH OUR PARTY AND
THEN OUR LIFETIME UNION BETWEEN
THE CRADLE TO CAREER GRANT
PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK
SIX EXCUSE ME SIX. YOUR IS NOW
OPEN MIND. SIX ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HEY COULD YOU GREAT
HEALING YES. OKAY HEY MY NAME'S
ELECTED I'M FROM THE LOS
ANGELES REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
AGENCY EQUITY- PROGRAM AND I'M
JUST CALLING TO SUPPORT THE
HEALTHY FUTURES FOR FOSTER YOU.
THAT BY SENDING THE INFILL
REPRIMAND AND THAT IS ALL I
HAVE A GREAT DAY THE- THANK YOU.
CONNECT COMMENT PENSION LINE.
THREE ZERO FOUR NINE THREE ZERO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE THANK YOU MY NAME IS
AN ANAGRAM NINE AND I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF BEYOND
EMANCIPATION IN OAKLAND EACH
SHARE WITH THE POOR OVER SIX
HUNDRED PLUS YEARS FROM AGES
FOURTEEN AND TWENTY FOUR BY
OFFERING WRAPAROUND SERVICES
THAT EQUIP THEM TO
SUCCESSFULLY. TRANSITION INTO
ADULTHOOD. I AM ALSO A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO ENSURING POLICIES
HAVE ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL NEEDS
SUCH AS HOUSING. I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THAT-
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
PREVENTING. AND REDUCING.
HOMELESS COUPLE WHICH WILL
PROVIDE CRITICAL FUNDING DURING
CLOTHING AND BEYOND FOR HOUSING
SUPPORT. FOR CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
ALONE TWO HUNDRED YEARS. EXPECT
CARE ACT EXIT THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM EVERY YEAR UP TO HALF OF
THEM LIVE IN HOMELESSNESS YOU
HAVE THE POWER TO CHANGE THAT
STATISTIC BY INVESTING IN
HOUSING PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
THANK. YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU MA'AM. I NEXT COMIC
COMES FROM LINE. ONE NINE FIVE
NINE ONE NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT. HELLO
THANK YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE MY
NAME IS CLOSER THAN Y'ALL- MY
AGE OF THOSE PROVIDERS FROM
ORANGE COUNTY YOU THE W. ON THE
BOARD WITH YOU W. I'M AN ORANGE
COUNTY RENT. AND I KNOW IT'S
BEEN SAID BEFORE BUT I WANT TO.
SAY IT AGAIN SO WON'T BE
FORGOTTEN- ON THE REEF
RESTORATION OF THE 7% CUT WE
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING TO RESTORE
7% CUTS TO I H. OF THE HOURS.
YEAR AFTER YEAR AND- THE PUBLIC
NINETEEN HAS SHOWN THAT I HSS
IS NEEDED NOW MORE THAN EVER
WHICH IS WHY I SUPPORT
PERMANENTLY RESTORING 7% CUT
ONCE AND FOR ALL AND A 7% CUT
WAS PUT IN PLACE NEARLY A
DECADE AGO IT'S LONG OVERDUE.
FOUR RESTORATION I H. OF THE
SERVICES ARE NECESSARY TO KEEP
OUR OLDER ADULTS AND THOSE
LIVING WITH DISABILITIES THANKS
WE URGE YOU ALL TO SUPPORT.
RESTORING 7% CUTS PERMANENTLY.
EVEN WITH TEMPORARY RESTORATION
BY AGENTS OF PROVIDERS AND
RECIPIENTS HAHA THE 7% CUT TO
SERVICE HOURS HANGING OVER OUR
HEADS. FOR YEARS NOW I IT JUST
SAYS SO. IT IS BECOMING MORE
MORE IMPORTANT EACH AND EVERY
YEAR AND THAT IS WHY WE
SUPPORT. PERMANENTLY RESTORING
7% CUT WHICH IS. WE SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO TAKE HOURS FROM
DISABLED THIS IS WHAT. WE'RE
DOING YOU'RE DOING IF YOU CUT
THEIR HOURS THEY'VE THEY
REALLY. WHO NEED THE HELP AND
IF YOU CUT THEIR HOURS I DON'T
THINK IT'S GOING TO FIX THE
BUDGET WHEN YOU COULD GO TO
PEOPLE THAT ARE BILLING ERRORS
SOME PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE MONEY
TO HELP WITH WITH WHAT THE
BUDGET IS ABOUT. SO THIS IS MY
OPINION. AND. SO PLEASE
CONSIDER NOT TAKING FROM THE
DISABLED THAT REALLY NEED TO
USE OURS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. I NEXT TIME IT COMES
FROM LINE. THREE ZERO SEVEN
NINE THREE ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IS NOW OPEN. THREE HUNDRED
SEVEN. HELLO HELLO YES GO AHEAD.
ALL RIGHT I'M GOOD EVENING
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND STAFF THANK
YOU FOR HOLDING THE STATE'S
THEM FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON THE
ISSUE MY NAME IS SEAN YOUNG AND
I'M WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
FINANCIAL JUSTICE PROJECT I'M
IN THE OFFICE OF THE
TEMPERATURE TRIGGERING TAX
COLLECTOR I'M NOT A MEMBER OF
THE TRUTH AND JUSTICE IN CHILD
SUPPORT COALITION A COALITION
OF DOZENS OF COMMUNITY GROUPS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I STRONGLY
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO FIRST
ENSURE THAT A 100% OF ALL CHILD
SUPPORT IT IS THE CORRECTLY
CHILDRENJACKET A LIMIT
GOVERNMENT- CHILD SUPPORT THAT
IN THIRD I'M SORRY I LIMITED
AND 10% INTEREST PAYMENTS ON
THE DEBT AND THIRD AND DRIVER'S
LICENSE SUSPENSIONS FOR
INABILITY TO PAY CHILD SUPPORT
EACH YEAR THE STATE KICKED FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS FROM LOW
INCOME CHILDREN. THE PEOPLE WHO
MAKE THESE PAYMENTS ARE OF
CHILD ON CHILD SUPPORT ARE
PRIMARILY BLACK AND BROWN BOTH
BOTHERS LOCAL BERRIES TO WORK
AND HAVE A MEDIAN INCOME OF
LESS THAN FIFTEEN THOUSAND
ABOUT THE JUST BARELY ABOVE THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD NOT BE MAKING IT HARDER
FOR LOW INCOME PARENTS OF COLOR
TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES. SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY LAUNCHED A
PILOT PROGRAM TO RELIEVE LOW
INCOME FOLLOWS THE GOVERNMENT-
CHILD SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED
LARGER AND MORE CONSISTENT
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS BECAUSE
THEY KNEW MORE OF THEIR MONEY
WAS GOING TO OUR CHILDREN
CAN'T. LOW INCOME CHILDREN
FAMILIES ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
NEED RELIEF FROM GOVERNMENT-
CHILD SUPPORT DEBT NOW THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME REALLY
APPRECIATE IT BOB. GOOD NIGHT.
THANK YOU SIR. I TIME I CAN.
LINE V. FIVE. THREE THREE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS. OPEN GOING. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR THE KIDNEY
CALL ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
COST ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE BUDGET REQUIRED EXTENDING
THE INVISIBLE MAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. EX COMMUNISTS
FROM. NINE TO SIX THREE NINE
TWO SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
BACKGROUND ALIGNED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MATTHEW
MALDONADO AND WITH EIGHTY W.
AND PAN PROBABLY CONTRACTED BUT
NOT OKAY TO CALIFORNIA FOR MOST
TWO DECADES. PROSAPIO
VANPOOLING BE MAINTAINED THE
COST SHARING RATIOS FIFTY FIVE
STATE THIRTY FIVE COUNTY. OKAY
BUT ONLY PUT LIVES AT RISK.
WITH A FEW WAITED FALLING MANY
ARE NOW BACK TO THE
POSSIBILITIES OF BASIS. IT'S
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT NOW TO GET
SOME COUNTIES TO FIND A WAY TO
INCREASE. AT BASICALLY DO TO
CAP BECAUSE WOULD BE A DISASTER.
30% ARE WITHHOLDING NINETY ONE
A LOT OF FUN IT'S ONLY TO MAKE
SURE COUNTY BARGAIN IN GOOD
FAITH. THE HOBBIT SHOWS THERE
ARE MANY HOLES IN THE PROGRAM.
RIGHT THIS IS INTENDED TO
REQUIRE CHARGING BARGAIN IN
GOOD FAITH. THEY HAVE SHARED
KEVIN SHELLEY SPONSORED
BUILDING IMAGINE A COUNTY
SITTING AT A TABLE FOR OVER SIX
YEARS. AT SIX DIFFERENT ANNUAL
BUDGET CYCLE BUT WITHOUT A
CONSIDERATION TO WAITING.
CREATORS OF BENEFITS FOR
PROVIDERS. THIS WITH. THIRTY
EIGHT COUNTY TRITTICO MIGHT
THIS WE WILL NEVER COME TO
BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH. POINT TO
HAVE THEM COME TO THE TABLE IN
GOOD FAITH  THINK IT IS
DISINGENUOUS TO COME A SECOND
MENTAL AND ONLY CHEER FOR THE
COUNTY TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
TO DO WITH THIS PROGRAM I DO
APPLY THOSE CANONS WELL WILL BE
DOING A GESTURE IF WE DO NOT
COPY COUNTY TO CREATE HARMFUL
PARTIES. AND FAILED I SAID
PROGRAM THE STUDENTS AND
PROVIDERS. WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE IS PROTECTING NOT ONLY
THE- PROVIDERS AND CLIENTS WHO
ARE FORTUNATE TO LIVE IN COUNTY
THAT DO THE RIGHT THING TO THIS
PROGRAM. BY THE WAY THE PENALTY
COMES WITH THE PROCESS THAT
ALLOWS THE NEUTRAL PARTY HERE
EVERYONE SIDE. THE COMMITTEE
DOES NOT HAPPEN BY FLIPPING A
SWITCH WE STILL HAVE A PROCESS
YOU HAVE TO PROVE OR CASE TO.
A WIDE. COUNTY IS NOT
BARGAINING IN GOOD FAITH.
FINALLY WE HAVE TO STOP KICKING.
7% CUT DOWN THE- IT FROM BUT
TO. ADMINISTRATION THE- STAR UP
AS AN ATTENTIVE TWENTY. OF OUT.
CHINA NICOLE WOULD YOU DO TO A
PERCENT WILL ENDED AT FIVE.
WHICH IS NOT TO EACH YEAR OF
THE- FOR THE NIGHT BUDGET.
PEOPLE DEPEND ON THE PRO YOU TO
BE ASSURED THAT THEY ARE
GETTING THE QUALITY CARE THEY
NEED. POLICE FOUND ONE CRAWFORD
EASTERN 7% CUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THIS VERY LATE NIGHT
APPRECIATE. YOUR TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. OUR NEXT COMIC
PENSION LINE. THREE ONE TWO
NINE THREE ONE TWO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME REQUIRES A
BRETT I AM THE SUPERVISOR FOR
THE FOXY CARE DEPARTMENT AT THE
AT THE DEL MAR IN FAMILY
THERAPIST IN LOS ANGELES WITH
SEVENTEEN YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
IN THE FIELD. THANK YOU A
FAMILY MEMBER BACK AND ASSEMBLY
WOMAN RUBIO FOR CHAMPIONING THE
FFA SOCIAL WORKERS AND ALLOWING
US TO HEAR ABOUT AND ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THE REINVESTMENT
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS. AS YOU
MAY KNOW PERMANENTLY RATE
DROPPED FROM SEVENTY FOUR POINT
5% TO LESS THAN 3% WHEN THE
CHILD HAS HAD ONE SOCIAL WORKER
COMPARED TO MORE THAN THREE
SOCIAL WORKERS. SOME YEARS AGO
I WORKED WITH A TEAM FEMALE WHO
AT THAT TIME EXPERIENCE QUITE A
LOT OF LOSS IN HER LIFE HE WAS
UNFORTUNATELY REPLACE SEVERAL
TIMES WITHIN THE SAME AGENCY.
THAT CONTRIBUTES A LOT MORE
LOSS IN RELATIONSHIP AND HER
ACADEMIC I WAS ABLE TO REMAIN
HER SOCIAL WORKER TO HELP WITH
A SMOOTH TRANSITION IT WAS NOT
UNTIL SHE AGED OUT OF FOSTER
CARE THAT I REALIZED THE IMPACT
I HAD ON HER LIFE. BY BEING THE
ONE PERSON WHO REMAIN
CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT HER
SEVERAL REPLACEMENT HE AND I
HAD A CONVERSATION AS SHE
SHARED TAMI REMAINING HER
SOCIAL WORKER HELPED HER TO
COPE AND GET THROUGH EACH DAY.
SHE ALSO SHARED BECAUSE OF ME
SHE IS NOW ENROLLED IN SCHOOL
TO BECOME A SOCIAL WORKER TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE BACK TO YOU WHO
ARE IN NEED. PLEASE HELP US SET
THE STAGE TO REDUCE TURNOVER
AND INCREASED LONGEVITY OF OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS TO GIVE OUR
CHILDREN THEIR BEST CHANCE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT I AM ALSO IN
SUPPORT AT THE R. T. P.
INCREASE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
RESOURCE FAMILIES PUT YOUR CALL
THE IMPACT. IF IT AFFECTS UP
LIMIT INCREASE CHILD CARE
BRIDGE PROGRAM AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH AGAIN FOR HEARING ABOUT
THE DAY IN STAND WITH THAT
WHERE THE LONG HOURS. AT NIGHT
THANK. YOU MA'AM AND THANK YOU
FOR SHARING THAT STORY. OUR
NEXT COMES MIND ONE ONE. NINE
THREE ONE ONE YEAR LONG IS NOW
PLEASE GO AHED. GOOD EVENING
DOT GO OUT AND COME MEMBERS AND
JUNIOR THE TIPPING POINT
COMMUNITY AN ORGANIZATION THAT
BY POVERTY AND MEMBER OF THE
TRUTH AND JUSTICE AND CHILD
SUPPORT COALITION. PUBLIC CHILD
SUPPORT CONTEMPT INTERCEPT
INCOME AND ASSETS. TOTALING
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION EACH YEAR
IN CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
PARENTS PRIVATE PREDOMINANTLY
BLACK AND BROWN AND- SOLELY TO
PAY BACK THE COST THE PUBLIC
BENEFITS. CRUSHING 10% INTEREST
ON CHILD SUPPORT THAT
COLLECTIVELY THEIR DENTIST
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. I URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO ELIMINATE THAT
THAT ELIMINATE THE INTEREST
RATE ON THE STAT AT AND
DRIVER'S LICENSE SUSPENSIONS
BRAKING ABILITY TO PAY
GOVERNMENT OWED CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS. AND ENSURE THAT 1100%
A SHOPPER PAYMENTS GO DIRECTLY
CHILDREN NOT THE GOVERNMENT. BY
KEN BROWN FAMILIES ESPECIALLY
FALLING BEHIND BULLETIN JUSTICE
THEM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SIR. OUR NEXT TIME IT
COMES FROM LINE. THREE TWO FIVE
NINE THREE TWO FIVE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ALEXIS PERRY A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AN
ADVOCATE. I'M HERE TO ECHO IN
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE INVESTMENT OF THE 10%
SATISFIED ASK. AS WELL AS FOR
THE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND HEALTHY FUTURES FOR
FOSTERING A PROPOSAL TO EXTEND
THE IMPLANT. ABUTMENT WITH YOUR
SUPPORT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
FOCUS OUR EFFORTS ON PREVENTION
RATHER THAN REACTION. KEEPING
UP WITH THE PHILOSOPHY OF BEING
SOLUTION FOCUSED NOT ONLY DO I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT TO PARTNER
WITH THOSE OF US WHO ARE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED. I AM URGING
YOUR SUPPORT TO INVEST IN THE
PATHWAY TO A SOLUTION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR KIND. CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU MA'AM. OUR NEXT
COMMENT IS FROM LINE. TWO EIGHT
THREE NINE TWO EIGHT THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THANK YOU
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF MY NAME IS BRUCE WHAT'S
FROM SENIOR DIRECTOR
PRESIDENT'S YOUTH AND FAMILY
SERVICES. AN AGENCY THAT'S BEEN
SERVING YOU SINCE EIGHTEEN.
NINETY ONE. MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY SPOKE
QUITE ELOQUENTLY ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES IN S. C. R. T. P. IS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE LAST YEAR
THE QUOTE THAT. I WON'T GO OVER
THOSE DETAILS AGAIN. BUT I WILL
COMMENT THE PRIOR TO THIS CODED
WAYS. MANY OF US WERE ALREADY
SWIMMING UPSTREAM TRYING TO
KEEP OUR HEADS UP CLOSE TO THE
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES WITHOUT
SECURITY TEAMS. THANK YOU ITEMS
OF NOTE FIRST. IT'S BEEN WELL
ILLUSTRATED THE CRITICAL TRAUMA
INFORMED TREATMENT THAT WE
PROVIDE. HOWEVER WE ALSO
SERVICE SURROGATE PARENTS
TEACHERS COACHES EXPRESSIVE
ARTS INSTRUCTORS AND MANY MORE.
ALL OF WHICH ROLES ARE NOT
SPECIFICALLY FUNDED. THESE AS
IT HAS BEEN MENTIONED EARLIER
ARE OFTEN FUNDED BY DONOR
DEVELOPMENT. I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT WAS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR T. P.'S
WORK ABOUT. WHILE THEY WERE
DEVELOPED AT THE SAME TIME WE
ALL SAW SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
IN THE MINIMUM WAGE MANDATES.
THIS CREATES UPWARD PRESSURE
AND ADDED COST TO STAFF AND-
WHICH AGAIN IS THE ADDITIONAL
BURDEN ON TOP OF THOSE
CHALLENGES RELATED TO THIS PAST
YEAR CORRECTLY AFFECTED.
BACKING US BECAUSE THE PROGRAM.
IT SHOULD BE AT THE UNIT S. T.
R. T. T. SERVICE. BEING CALLED
ON QUOTE THE NEXT LEVEL OF CARE
UNDER A ACUTE PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITAL HAS BEEN INCREASING
EVERY YEAR. REQUIRING IT
SOMETIMES A STAFF PERSON FOR
EVERY CHILD OR TWO CHILDREN.
NOT THE RATIOS THAT WERE
INTENDED IN THE ORIGINAL
STRUCTURE OF S. U. R. T. P. AND
THE RESULTING BUDGET THAT GIVES.
LASTLY I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
TO AS IT HAS BEEN WITH THAT BUT
BASS SOCIAL WORKERS. THE TEN
YEAR AND COURTESY OF OUR STAFF
IS CRITICAL. TO THE SUPPORT
STABILITY AND SEALING UP THE
CHILDREN THAT WE SERVE. SO
AGAIN I SPEAK IN SUPPORT FOR
THE S. T. R. T. PAY IS ONE TIME.
SUPPORT AS WELL AS THE ONGOING
SUPPORT FOR- STABILITY OF FSA
WORKERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND THANK
YOU FOR EVERYTHING THAT YOU DO
FOR THE CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SIR. SHE I NEXT TIME
IT COMES FROM LINE. TWO ZERO
FOUR NINE TWO ZERO FIVE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN-
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR LETTING YOU
TESTIFY. I LISTEN TO THE
HEARING ALL DAY. MY NAME IS
CONNIE ARNOLD. I'M A DISABILITY
RIGHTS ADVOCATE FOR THIRTY PLUS
YEARS. PROBABLY MORE THAN THAT
ACTUALLY. I'M AND I HSS
RECIPIENT AND I'M ALSO ON. ON A
WAIVER WAIVER PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES. AND I'VE BEEN ON I
JUST THAT SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE WHEN IT WAS
HOMEMAKER CHORE. BACK IN THE
PROVIDERS WERE PAID THREE
DOLLARS AND THIRTY SIX CENTS
GROSS PER HOUR. AND IT WAS WHEN
RECIPIENTS HIRED PROVIDERS. I
DON'T REMEMBER ANY COUNTY
EMPLOYEES BEING PROVIDERS- I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT THE
STATE HAS EXEMPTED ITSELF FROM
LIABILITY FOR DEEMING
RECIPIENTS AN EMPLOYER AND
AFTERWARDS LIABILITY FOR THE
STATE INCLUDING ITS EXCLUSION
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA ELDER AND
DEPENDENT ADULT SILVA
PROTECTION ACT BECAUSE THE
STATE IS DIRECTLY CAUSING
NEGLECT ABUSE AND HARM ON
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES BECAUSE THEY'RE
CALLING IT. OUR CHOI. IN WHO WE
HIRE PERMANENT ABSENT WORKFORCE
BASED ON ONE RACK OF COMPETENT
AND READILY AVAILABLE
WORKFORCE. AND LACK OF
MEANINGFUL CHOICE OF ACCESS TO
PROGRAMS SERVICES AND
ACTIVITIES IN VIOLATION OF THE
ADA. AND OLMSTEAD FOR
RECIPIENTS EMPLOYERS TO LEAD A
NORMAL AND FULFILLING LIFE.
THERE'S A LACK OF RECIPIENT HAS
BEEN LTSS BUDGETS INCLUDING
TRAINING BUDGETS FOR EXISTING-
RECIPIENTS FOR. THE LADY TO
TRAIN PROVIDERS AND ALLOW- OUR
EXISTING PROVIDER TO HELP TRAIN
POTENTIAL NEW PROVIDERS ON OUR
ROUTINES. AND WE'RE NOT LOOKING
FOR SOME KIND OF ONE SIZE
TRAINING CONTRACT. THERE'S A
REAL LACK OF DIFFERENTIAL PAY
FOR PROVIDERS WILLING TO WORK
FOR HSS RECIPIENTS WITH SEVERE
DISABILITIES WHO HAVE MULTIPLE
CARE PROVIDERS WHERE AT LEAST
ONE IS A NON RELATIVE COMMUNITY
PROVIDER AND THAT IS AN
ESSENTIAL NEED IF YOU DON'T
HAVE DIFFERENTIATED PAY. FOR
PEOPLE WILLING TO WORK FOR
THOSE WITH SEVERE DISABILITIES
WILL NEVER GOING TO BE ABLE TO
FIND PROVIDERS THERE'S NO
RELIABLE- TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
BACKUP EMERGENCY SERVICE WITH
ACCESSIBLE REGIONAL ON CALL
SERVICE CENTERS. RECIPIENTS WHO
CAN DEPLOY A COMPETENT WORKERS.
WHO CAN PROVIDE CARE MEDICAL
SERVICES PROTECTIVE SUPERVISION
OR HANDLE COBIT POSITIVE
SITUATIONS. TO MEET RECIPIENTS
NEEDS- THERE'S AN ASSUMPTION
THAT THOSE OF US THAT ARE ON
THE WAIVER THAT THE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO HELP FIND IN SUPPLY
SUBSTITUTE CARE PROVIDERS WHICH
ISN'T THEIR JOB AND THEY DON'T
HAVE THE WORKERS. I THINK SOME
OF THE OTHERS SPEAKERS HAVE
SPOKEN ABOUT M. S. S. P. WHICH
IS A SEPARATE CHOICE AND FOR
SOME INDIVIDUALS THAT THE GOOD
THING. MANAGED CARE FOR MOVING
IN THE DIRECTION MANAGED CARE
THAT ISN'T GOING TO WORK
WITHOUT RAISING THE WAGES AND
DIFFERENTIATING WAGES- AS FAR
AS THE COUNTIES GO- AS FAR AS I
KNOW MOST OF THE COUNTY I JUST
AS WORKERS ARE MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS AND NOT
SOCIAL WORKERS AND THAT SHOULD
CHANGE. AND FOR THE COUNTIES
THERE'S NO PENALTY IF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES ARE SENIORS
GO INTO A NURSING HOME AT STATE
COST. AND I FIND IT REALLY
SHOCKING THAT WE WANT TO MOVE
MORE PEOPLE. AND I SUPPORT
MOVING MORE PEOPLE. LIKE THE
CCT PROGRAM FROM THE NURSING
HOMES TO THE COMMUNITY. BUT
WHAT WAS GOING TO WORK FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHAT ABSENT
EIGHT. WORKFORCE ALSO THERE'S
NO HOLIDAY PAY- FOR PROVIDERS
SO THAT ON HOLIDAYS PROVIDERS
ARE ABANDONED. I'M LOOKING AT
MY FACEBOOK PAGE RIGHT NOW AND
I KNOW SOMEONE WHO'S A
QUADRIPLEGIC AND SAN MATTEO.
RIGHT NOW THE INTERNET HAD HER
CARE GIVER CONTRACTORS SAY THEY
HAD A COP IN A BODY ACHE AND
NOW THAT THEY CAN'T COME TO
WORK. NOW SHE'S STUCK WITH NO
HELP AND STUCK IN BED FOR THREE
WEEKS SHE SAYS. BECAUSE THE WAY
THAT LIST THAT WE GET FROM THE
PUBLIC AUTHORITY A WORK LIST. I
HAVE ANOTHER PERSON WITH A
SPINAL MUSCULAR ATROPHY WHO'S
IN L. EIGHT. CAN'T DO ANYTHING
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT OF A
PROVIDER. AND SHE'S ABSENT A
PROVIDER IN THE PAST. WHICH IS
THE PUBLIC AUTHORITY IN LA
CAN'T FIND ANYBODY TO HELP HER
AND SHE'S BEEN HAVING
DIFFICULTY FOR TWO DAYS AND
CONTACTED HER WAIVER AGENCY AND
STILL THERE IS NO HELP-
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION
IS ONLY GOING TO MAKE THE
SITUATION WORSE. AND ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES FOR A
FRIEND OF MINE WHO IS IN A
WHEELCHAIR AND HE'S THREE
HUNDRED OVER THREE HUNDRED
POUNDS HE NEEDED THE CARE GIVER
AFTER HIS QUIT ON A FRIDAY
NIGHT AT. FOUR THIRTY IN THE
AFTERNOON WITH BOTH THE COME ON
THE WEEKEND. AND- I CALLED
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND I
WAS TOLD AT TWO MINUTES TO BUY
BY ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
STAFF IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY THAT
IF HE NEEDED HELP TO TELL HIM
TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL. AND THAT
THE PUBLIC AUTHORITY LISTS ARE
THE SAME LIST THAT THE- ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES USE AND
THERE IS A DEFICIENCY. THERE
BECAUSE THERE AREN'T ANY ANY
PROVIDERS OUT THERE IN THE LIST
THAT YOU GET FROM THE- PUBLIC
AUTHORITY OURSELVES THAT
STANDARD. AND THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH PEOPLE. OUT THERE TO
HELP THOSE WITH SEVERE
DISABILITIES. THEY'RE ALL OVER
INSTEAD PROMISE THE PROMISE
THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BUILD
LIVE. ON OUR OWN IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT IN THE COMMUNITY.
IS EIGHT IS NOTHING BUT A GREEN
AND MOST OF US WOULD LIKE TO
LIVE. NORMAL PRODUCTIVE
MEANINGFUL FULFILLING LIVES.
WITHOUT A MEDICAL MODEL LAND IN
APPROACH BUT WE'RE NOT BEING
GIVEN THAT BECAUSE THERE'S NO
WORK FORCE FOR AT THE HIGHER.
SO IN MY CASE I'M AN ELECTRIC
WHEELCHAIR BEEN IN A WHEELCHAIR
SINCE AGE SIX. I HAVE A SEVERE
DISABILITY I LIVE IN EL GROW
OLD AND IF I EVEN IF MY HOUSE
IS FULLY ACCEPTABLE. AND WHAT
GOOD IS THAT IF YOU CAN'T FIND
ANY PROVIDERS TO WORK FOR YOU.
SO IT'S CONSENSUAL THAT YOU
START INCENTIVIZING THESE JOBS
SO THAT THERE'S PROVIDERS- THAT
YOU'RE PAYING DECENT WAGES THEY
GOT DECENT HEALTH INSURANCE
VETERANS SICK LEAVE VACATION
AND AN UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
FOR THOSE INCLUDING FAMILY
MEMBERS WHEN A RECIPIENT DIES
ALL THE SUDDEN THEY'RE MONEY
DRIED UP AND THEY HAVE A
MORTGAGE TO PAY. IN SOME CASES.
THESE THINGS ARE WRONG. AND YET
I HEARD FROM AN ADVOCATE TODAY
I GOT AN EMAIL SAID IN A DAY OR
TWO THERE'S A BILL FOR MAKING
IT MORE EASY FOR PEOPLE TO GET
ASSISTED SUICIDE. SO WHAT
APPROACH ARE WE TAKING WE'RE
TAKING AN APPROACH THAT SAYS
IT'S OKAY DID NOT A WE DON'T
WANT TO SPEND THE MONEY. AND
IT'S RIDICULOUS IT IS
ABSOLUTELY WRONG AND- WHAT WE
NEED IS. YOU TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES RESTORED 27% I AGENTS
THAT. HI I SENT IN AN EMAIL
TODAY WITH FORTY SEVEN
SIGNATURES ON THE ON THE EMAIL-
ADDITIONALLY- I AGREE WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT WHAT IT
WHAT IT SAYS IS WHAT WE'VE BEEN
SAYING ALL ALONG. PLEASE FIX
THE PROBLEM. AND ALSO I SENT AN
ADDITIONAL LETTER WITH SOME OF
THESE COMMENTS IN THERE AND I
HOPE YOU'LL SERIOUSLY TAKE A
LOOK AT IT. BECAUSE THESE ARE
REAL ISSUES AND REAL LIFE. AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I APPRECIATE
IT THANK YOU MA'AM. COMING FROM
LINE. THREE TWO EIGHT NINE
THREE TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
MY NAME IS CENTER GENOVA AND
WITH THE SPIRIT THAT I
REPRESENT OUR FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM IN THE COUNTY OF
STANISLAUS MERCED AND LOWER ME.
THE MAN HERE TO SUPPORT THE FFA
SOCIAL WORKER INCREASED. AND MY
MESSAGE TONIGHT IS SIMPLE IN MY
YEARS OF DOING THIS WORK WITHIN
THE FOSTER CARE REALM I HAVE
LEARNED ONE THING ABOUT FOSTER
USE. THE SYSTEM TEACHES THEM
THAT RELATIONSHIPS DO NOT LAST
AND I HOPE THAT YOU CAN SUPPORT
THIS INCREASE SO THEY CAN HAVE
ONE PERSON IN THEIR LIFE THAT
MAY HELP THEM LEARN TO
RELATIONSHIPS ARE IMPORTANT.
AND THEIR LIFELONG ENDEAVORS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TONIGHT AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIO FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM. I
NEXT COMIC COME FROM LINE.
THREE THREE THREE NINE THREE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF YOU'RE A
FINE LINE THREE THREE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT
LINE. THE NEXT LINE IS LINE.
THREE ONE NINE NINE THREE ONE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO YES MA'AM HELLO
YEAH. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THREE ONE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. HELLO
YES MA'AM WE CAN HEAR YOU
SAYING HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM. WELL
I AM SORRY I AM SO SORRY MY
NAME IS LILLIAN KOENIG AND I
LIVE IN THE BAY AREA- I WAS
RECENTLY DURING THE COPA PUSHED
INTO EARLY RETIREMENT I'M ONE
OF THE BABY BOOMERS WANTED FOR-
IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN TO TEN
MILLION WHO HAVE BECOME-
SENIORS AND- I'M REFERRING TO
KIM MCCAULEY WEIGHED HER MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING. AND ESPECIALLY
THE RACIAL RACIAL JUSTICE PER
SENIORS I CAN HONESTLY TELL YOU
THAT DURING COLD IT- FAMILIES
ARE FEELING VERY VERY TRAINED
AND WHETHER THAT'S MENTALLY OR
PHYSICALLY WHEN THEY'RE DEALING
WITH THEIR ELDERLY PARENTS OR
THEIR SENIOR PARENTS WE WOULD
APPRECIATE THE- THE HOUSING
COMPONENT FOR SENIORS. TO BE
REALLY REALLY SCRUTINIZED MOST
OF US WOULD LIKE TO REMAIN IN
OUR HOME WHICH IS REALLY THE-
OF THE FORM OF WEALTH THAT WE
HAVE WHEN WE PUT EQUITY IN OUR
HOME BUT FOR THOSE OF THOSE
SPECS HAND. SENIOR HOUSING IS
SO IMPORTANT AND- SINCE ARE THE
BABY BOOMERS ARE AGING OUT- AND
WE BECOME WISER AND WE HAVE
GREATER BABY- EXCUSE ME BUYING
POWER AND MORE VOTING POWER. WE
REALLY NEED TO FOCUS IN ON OUR
SENIORS THE AREA OF THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING IS HAS COME DO
IT'S PROBABLY OVERDUE. SO YOU
KNOW COLBERT HAS IS SHOWING US
THE BURDEN OF- THE FINANCIAL
DRAIN THAT FAMILIES FEEL WHEN
THEY HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
ELDERLY MANY OF US ARE VERY
VERY FRIGHTENED OF BECOMING
OLDER. BECAUSE COLBERT ALSO
SHOWN THAT THE ELDERLY ARE THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION.
AND- I HOPE THE- THE MASTER
PLAN FOCUSES IN A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON OF THE BABY BOOMERS
BECAUSE WE AREN'T LOOKING
FORWARD TO VOTING PEOPLE INTO
OFFICE AND USING OUR BUYING
POWER. TO SECURE OUR RIGHTS AS
SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. NINE THREE
TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
COMMENT NOW PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE NINE EIGHT BTC
BANNING CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. HI MY NAME IS THE SAKE
OF ALLAH- I'M FROM YOUR
VERIFIED CALIFORNIA AND I'M A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH- I AM HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION-
ONE. AT ONE THREE ZERO
ORGANIZATION TO EXPRESS THE
COURTS FOR A HUNDRED AND SEVEN.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND HER FUTURES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE
INCIDENT SUPPLEMENT. THANK YOU
HAVE A GREAT DAY THANK YOU
MA'AM. OUR TIME IT COMES TO
LINE TO THREE EIGHT. NINE THREE
THREE EIGHT OR NINE IS NOW OPEN
GO AHEAD. THIRTY ARAMBULA
SENATOR THAT AND STATE YOU AT
THEM MEMBER. RUBIO THE AND THE
DAY. WORK RATE. MY IS KAREN
NEED I AM THE CHIEF PROGRAM. OF
THE LEAD WIFI FAMILIES. WORTH
STATEWIDE FAMILY AGENCY. I HAVE
WORKED IN THIS FIELD OF FOSTER
CARE WHICH I LOVE FOR TWENTY
SIX YEARS AND WAS ALSO A
KINSHIP CARE GIVER. I'M HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE EFFORT
STATE BUDGET REQUEST- I WANT TO
HEAR THAT IT HAS NEVER BEEN
MORE DIFFICULT TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN MASTER'S LEVEL SOCIAL
WORKERS IT'S GETTING HARDER AND
HARDER. AFTER FINDING IT STATIC
IN ACTUALLY DECREASING BECAUSE
WE DON'T REPEAT COLA ADJUSTMENT.
OUR MATHIS BUBBLE SOCIAL
WORKERS SUPPORT A THIRD OF THE
HIGHEST NEED CHILDREN AND YOUTH
AND FAMILY AND HOME BASED CARE
WE ARE THERE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN.
WE ARE TOLD WE PROVIDE COMMON
FORM CARE. THE COUNTIES HELP ON
A TO PARTNER WITH THEM WE ARE
CRITICAL IN THIS CONTINUE CARE
REFORM TO ENSURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN HAVE CONTINUITY AND
STABILITY AND PERMANENCY. I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE AND I KNOW
YOU'VE HEARD IT ALL OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THAT WHEN WE LOSE
OUR SOCIAL WORKER IT HAS SUCH A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON OUR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. AND
DOWNSTREAM COSTS TO THE
STATEMENT PERMANENTLY- IS
INTERRUPTED. I WANT TO SHOW. A
CALL COMMENT THAT SOME OF OUR
YOUTH HAVE SAID ABOUT THEIR
EFFORT A SOCIAL WORKER. AND
WHAT DATE THAT IT'S- AN
ADVOCATE SOCIAL WORKER IS LIKE
HAVING A MENTOR A POSITIVE ROLE
MODEL SOMEONE WHO TEACHES YOU
LETTERS PROVIDE YOU GUIDANCE.
AND SOMEONE YOU FEEL SAFE WITH
ACTON TRACK- SO PLEASE I
IMPLORE YOU TO TAKE THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY AND SUPPORT THE
EFFORT THEY RATE I ALSO WANT
TO- PROVIDE SUPPORT YES THEY
ARE HE- PARENTS DURING COLD
AND- WOMEN. AND CHILD CARE
BRIDGE PROGRAM AGAIN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CHAMPION THAT
EFFORT. HAVE A GOOD EVENING
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU MA'AM.
OUR NEXT COMIC COME FROM LINE.
THREE FOUR ZERO NINE THREE FOUR
ZERO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS ANNA JOHNSON FROM
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND HEALTHY FUTURES FOR
FOSTER USED TO EXTEND THE
INFANT SUPPLEMENT. WHICH IS A
HEALTH ECONOMIC AND RACIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES THAT CAN IMPROVE
THE FEATURES OF OUR FOSTER
YOUTH AND THEIR CHILDREN. THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION FOR
PREVENTING AND REDUCING POVERTY
HOMELESSNESS. THE GREEN
CALIFORNIA HOME BUDGET PROPOSAL
TO ESTABLISH A PERMANENT
ONGOING FUNDING SOURCE TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS WHICH
INCLUDES. A 10% YOU SATISFIED.
WE ALSO FOR THE EFFORT SOCIAL
WORKER FROM. THE FAMILIES
PREVENTION BACKSTEP COMMITTEE
REQUESTS AND THE FUNDING FOR
SERVICES REQUESTED BY C. TO
BEGIN CHILDREN NOW WE'RE ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE SPENDING
PROPOSAL FOR HOUSING FOR
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YOUTH.
THAT ACCOMPANIES SENATE BILL
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE CENTER
WIENER. I WANT TO NOTE SUPPORT
FOR THE STAFF POSITIONS NAMED
AN AGENDA TO FOR THE OFFICE OF
THE FOSTER CARE OMBUDSPERSON
AND THE OFFICE OF TRIBAL
AFFAIRS WITHIN CDSS. AND
FINALLY AND I'M EXPRESSING THE
SUPPORT. ON BEHALF OF YOUR
BASIC SLANT OF BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS WHO- HAD TO JOIN A
DIFFERENT MEETING AT THIS TIME.
A BOARD MEETING- IN SUPPORT OF
THE EXTENDING THE INFANT
SUPPLEMENT HEALTHY FUTURES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH ASK. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP TODAY
DR ARAMBULA. WE APPRECIATE YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. I NEXT COMIC
COMES FROM THE LINE. THREE FOUR
FOUR NINE THREE FOUR FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS LONG I
LIVE IN MERCED COUNTY AND I AM
A REGIONAL MANAGER WITH UT W.
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY. SOME OF
THE COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT
HAVE BEEN THE TOUGHEST ONES TO
NEGOTIATE CONTRACTS WITH OUR
MEMBERS HAVE GONE WITHOUT
CONTRACTS FOR UP TO SIX YEARS.
AND I HAVE SEEN FIRST CHILD
FIRST HAND HOW LONG AND DRAWN
OUT THIS PROCESS CAN BE. PART
OF IT IS DUE TO THE CONSULTANT
THE COUNTY HIRED. TO REPRESENT
THEM THESE CONSULTANTS TO HAVE
THE COUNTY ITS AND- THE BEST
AND AT HEART. OUR LONG OUT DOWN
CON IT SIXTY YEAR. AND ONE OF
THE- IT TOOK LONG IS DUE TO THE
END OF THE KIND. THE COUNTY
WEAPONS THEM BEING UNAVAILABLE
PERSONAL REASONS AND AT THE END
OF THE DAY THE TO PAY THE PRICE
ARE THE HOME CARE PROVIDER AND
THEIR- WITH THE CURRENT. AND
INCENTIVES IN PLACE WOLLEMI
COUNTY IS STILL SAYING NO TO
ANYTHING THAT WOULD CAUSE
WORKER WAGES AND BENEFITS.
WHICH THEY CURRENTLY DO NOT
HAVE ANY BECAUSE THE COUNTY
FILLED A MEDIC CAL IS A BENEFIT
TO THEM. COUNTY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CHANGE LIVES BY
UPLIFTING THEIR COMMUNITIES BUT
THEY ARE HURTING THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THEY SHOULD BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS. THIS IS WHY THE 10%
FISCAL PENALTY TO COUNTIES- NOT
BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH IS
NECESSARY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. COMMENT COMES FROM LINE.
ONE SIX FIVE NINE ONE SIX FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES SIR. GREAT-
ESTEEMED COMMITTEE CHAIR
ARAMBULA MEMBERS AND STAFFS.
I'M DR MARKEL BOTH CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORLD INDIAN HEALTH
BOARD. I'M A MEMBER OF THE
PEACE RIVER TRIBAL NATION
LOCATED IN NORTHEASTERN
CALIFORNIA. REALLY SINCE
ANCIENT TIMES I'M I'M I'M ALSO
A PROUD LIFELONG PATIENT OF
HAVE A HEALTH CLINICS IN OUR
STATE. AT THIS TIME I AM
PLEASED TO INFORM YOU THAT THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL INDIAN HEALTH
BOARD. AND THE FIFTY NINE FOR
THE RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND
NINETEEN TRIBAL HEALTH CLINICS
THAT WE WORK WITH. SUPPORT THE
REQUEST LISTED UNDER ISSUE FIVE
HE OTHER QUESTIONS REQUESTING
COMMENT SECTION MOM PAGE
FOURTEEN OF THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY. OUR THAT SECTION- SB
THIRTY SIX INDIAN HEALTH
CLINICS UNDER THE COW WORKS
PROGRAM. AUGUST CLINICS ARE
LOCATED IN RURAL FRONT HERE AND
URBAN INDIANS SETTINGS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. HOW DOES
CLINICS PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
FOR NATIVE AMERICANS AND THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS. SERVICES
INCLUDE INDIVIDUAL AND GROUP
COUNSELING AS WELL AS THE
INCLUSION OF WESTERN AND
TRADITIONAL MEDICINE TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUAL.
ARE THOSE INDIAN CLINICS ALSO
ASSIST IN SECURING AND
RETAINING EMPLOYMENT AND THEY
PROVIDE REFERRALS. FOR SKILLS
TRAINING PROGRAMS. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT NO NINE AS
PART OF THE GREAT RECESSION OF
THAT THIRTY SIX CLINICS
PROGRAM. UNDER CAL WORK STREET
RECEIVED A SUBSTANTIAL CUT. I
EVEN BACK THEN IT WAS ONLY
FUNDED ABOUT TWO POINT SEVEN OR
TWO POINT NINE MILLION. OUR AND
THE BE- CUT THAT WAS NOT
INTRODUCED HAS BEEN MAINTAINED
SINCE THEN AND- IT'S GREATLY
IMPACTED- THE ABILITY OF THOSE
CLINICS TO PROVIDE. THE
INTENDED SERVICES UNDER THE
CONTRACTS- NOW AS A RESULT OF
THE PANDEMIC OF THOSE THIRTY
SIX TRIBAL AND URBAN INDIAN
CLINICS ARE. STRUGGLING TO MEET
THE INCREASED DEMAND THAT HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT TO DEPEND- SO
WE'RE REALLY. ENCOURAGED
EMPLOYEES TO SEE THIS LISTED ON
THE AGENDA FOR DISCUSSION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT. HI THANK YOU
FOR- THE TIME AND LOOK FORWARD
TO FURTHER DIALOGUE ON THE
TOPIC THANK YOU HAVE A GOOD
EVENING THANK YOU SIR. OUR NEXT
COMIC COME FROM LINE. THREE
FIVE ZERO NINE THREE FIVE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
GINNY THRASHER AND THE
COMMUNICATION ACCORDING FOR THE
BRIGHT FUTURE EDUCATION
PARTNERSHIP IN MONTEREY COUNTY
AND PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
CRADLE TO CAREER COALITION.
WHICH INCLUDES PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN STRIDE
TOGETHER COMMUNITIES. I AM
EXPRESSING SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING OF THE CRADLE TO CAREER
GRANT PROGRAM THAT WILL ENABLE
THE COST EFFECTIVE DELIVERY OF
RESOURCES AND SERVICES. TO
THOSE MOST IN NEED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. CRADLE TO CAREER
COMMUNITIES WORK COLLECTIVELY
WITHIN A PARTNERSHIP OF BOTH
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO REDUCE DISPARITY.
THROUGH A WHOLE CHILD WHOLE
FAMILY COMMUNITY CENTERED
APPROACH WITH THE ULTIMATE GOAL
OF LIFTING CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY AND
ENSURING CHILDREN HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO SUCCEED
IN LIFE. THIS COORDINATED
EFFORTOF COMMUNITY PARTNERS IS
A COST EFFECTIVE STRATEGY TO
PROVIDE NEEDED SERVICES TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILY. AND REDUCE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AMONG
CHILDREN. I URGE YOU TO TAKE
THIS IMPORTANT STEP IN
ADDRESSING CHILD POVERTY BY
INVESTING IN THE CRADLE TO
CAREER GRANT PROGRAM. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU MA'AM. I NEXT COMIC COMES
FROM LINE. THREE FOUR NINE NINE
THREE FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
O'MALLEY WITH A CALIFORNIA
LABORFEDERATION. AND
SPECIFICALLY WANTED TO ATTRACT
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE AND- AND I.
HFS IN HOW THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING- HOW WE CAN MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE GROWING NUMBER OF
OLDER ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES. FIRST WE
BELIEVE THAT- AT 10% FISCAL
PENALTY ON COUNTIES AND DO NOT
BARGAINING IN GOOD FAITH. IS AN
IMPORTANT WAY TO GUARANTEE THAT
ARE AT I. HSS PROVIDERS. ARE
PAID THE WAGES THEY DESERVE-
SECOND MAINTAINING THE CURRENT
6535% SHARE COP IN PLACE. AND
FINALLY FOR AND SUPPORT OF THE
PERMANENT RESTORATION OF THE 7%
CUT. TO ENSURE THIS RECESSION
ERA BASED CUTS WOULD NOT COME
BACK AGAIN NEGATIVELY IMPACTING
HFS PROVIDERS. AND CONSUMERS
ALIKE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. OUR NEXT QUESTION OR
COMMENT COMES FROM. ONE THREE
FIVE FOUR NINE THREE FIVE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH. I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. AND IT'S NOT TOO LONG
AGO I WAS A TEEN PARENT. I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND. HEALTHY FUTURES FOR
COST YOU PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE
INFANT SUPPLEMENT. AS WELL AS
THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
PREVENTING AND REDUCING COST
YOU'D HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL
WHICH WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
FUNDING DURING COVERT. AND
BEYOND FOR HOUSING SUPPORT.
SERVING CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM. THE LAST ONE I SHOW
IN QUEUE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME IF LINE.
THREE FIVE SEVEN NINE THREE
FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK YES MA'AM.
EXCELLENT OKAY THANK YOU- THANK
YOU MEMBERS I KNOW IT'S REALLY
LATE CALL TRY TO BE AS QUICK AS
POSSIBLE MANY METHODOLOGY CAN
BE ON BEHALF OF THE ADVANCEMENT
PROJECT. AND WE DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE THAT- ONGOING
CONVERSATION ADDRESSING EQUITY
IN CALIFORNIA TRYING TO MAKE IT
MORE ACCESSIBLE CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL. AND NOT GOOD FOR YOU AND-
INSTEAD OF THAT WE WANT TO TAKE
A CAN YOU. TALK ABOUT OUR
PROPOSAL FOR HOLD OUT ATHLETE
WHICH WAS PUT TOGETHER BY THE
WHOLE CHILD EQUITY PARTNERSHIP.
CAME TOGETHER TWENTY TWO CAME
TOGETHER ABOUT A YEAR AND A
HALF AGO THE BILL THE
COLLECTIVE RACIAL EQUITY
AGENDA. AND BERMAN OF
CALIFORNIA YOUNG CHILDREN. IT'S
A GROUP OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH FAMILIES EARLY LEARNING
CARE ADVOCATES EDUCATORS HEALTH
AND WELLNESS EXPERTS. AND
OTHERS WHO ARE WORKING TOGETHER
TO IDENTIFY THE INSTANCE THE
MATIC. BARRIERS TO OPPORTUNITY.
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AND ARE THEY DON'T LIKE
THEM HOLD TWELVE EQUITY OF IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE OFFICIALLY
NOW TOO WITH THE PANDEMIC AND
THREE BILL THE AND- SO INCREASE.
CHAU FOR FAMILY CARDS HIT BY
THE PANDEMIC- SO A QUICK
INTRODUCTION TO THE OVERALL ASK
IT'S A ONE TIME INVESTMENT OF
TWO HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. OVER THREE YEARS TO
ESTABLISH THE HOLDS HOW EQUITY
FUND TO PRIORITIZE THE MOST
UNDERSERVED CHILDREN- AND THEN
ALSO THERE'S THE EQUITY FUND TO
BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OTHER AGENCIES THAT SUPPORT
CHILD WELL BEING- THAT IS MADE
UP OF THREE PARTS WHICH
INCLUDES AN EQUITY INDEX TO
ALLOCATE THE EQUITY FUND. A
FUNDING FOR THE WHOLE FAMILY
WELLNESS HUBS AND PROGRAM IN
TRAINING. FOR TARGET POPULATION-
AND- WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP LATE- BUT DEFINITELY
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THE EQUITY
INDEX THE WELLNESS HUB I WOULD
BE THE PROPOSAL- POLL OF TWENTY
FOUR PROBABLY THE WHOLE FAMILY
WELLNESS HUB IN THE HIGH SPEED
AREAS- DEFINED BY THE EQUITY
INDEX- AND THEN AGAIN THE-
PROGRAMMING TRADE THE TARGET
POPULATION WHICH WOULD BE-
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT PROGRAMS DAM EMBRACE
THE CULTURAL RACIAL AND
LINGUISTIC TERMS OF BLACK
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES AND PRIORITIZE
PROGRAMS AND ACCESS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW INCOME
CHILDREN OF COLOR- YEAH AT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL YOUR
HARD WORK ILLEGALLY HOURS. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU IN THE FUTURE ON THE
EFFORTS THERE AGAIN MAKE AN
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
THANK YOU. AND GOOD NIGHT THANK
YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU MISTER
SURE THAT DOES. INCLUDE THE
NUMBER OF OUR COLLEAGUES THAT I
HAD IN QUEUE FOR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. OPERATOR CAN I ASK
YOU TO DO ONE MORE SWEEP JUST
TO BE SURE. BE GLAD TO THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO QUEUE UP AT THIS
TIME FOR QUESTION AND ANSWER OR
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCHTONE
KEYPAD. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO NOW IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE
INCLUDED THANK YOU. I DO HAVE A
FEW MORE THAT HAVE QUEUED UP
ONE MOMENT. OUR NEXT COMIC
COMES FROM A LINE OF. ONE FIVE
NINE NINE ONE FIVE NINE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI YES GOOD EVENING THIS
IS MARJORIE DELGADILLO AND I AM
THE MANAGER OF YOUTH FAMILY.
AND COMMUNITY COLLABORATIONS
FOR MARIN PROMISE PARTNERSHIP.
IN COAST MIWOK TERRITORY IN
MARIN COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA. I
AM CALLING TODAY AND TOEXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT AND FUNDING THE
CRADLE TO CAREER GRANT PROGRAM.
AND THIS IS A VITAL PROGRAMS
THAT STREAMLINE SERVICES AND
MAKES- COMMITTED INVESTMENT.
INTO OUR COMMUNITY ACTUALLY I
BLANKS AND RESTRAINS AND
EMPOWERS COMMUNITY TO LEAD
THEIR OWN TRANSFORMATION. IT IS
ALIGNED WITH A COMMON VISION
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS WELL
AS LEADERS WORK TOGETHER TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CHILDREN HAVE
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES THAT
WILL GUIDE THEM INTO ADULTHOOD.
FREE OF OBSTACLES THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY IMPACTED THEIR
COMMUNITY IF WE WANT TO BE
CHILD POVERTY AND IN OUR
LIFETIME WE NEED TO INVEST IN
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THREE TO THE
CRADLE TO CAREER GRANT PROGRAMS
AND- AS A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
MYSELF- HAVE BUSTER USE HAS
WORKED IN THAT. THAT YOU ASKED
HOW THE RATS WITH CONGRESS
MEMBER KAREN BALANCE- I AM
PULLING INTO PORT AND GET THAT
HEALTHY FUTURES- WHICH WAS
INTRODUCED BY RUBIO AND ALSO IN
REGARDS TO THE EIGHTEEN MILLION
THAT WILL ACCESS. IN PREVENTING
HOMELESS FOSTER YEARS AND IT IS
ONLY BECAUSE I HAD A COMMITTED-
SOCIAL WORKER WHO BELIEVED IN
ME THAT I WAS ABLE TO DO THIS
WORK AND I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
WORK FOR ALMOST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS SH AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
DO AFTER ANOTHER SEVENTY FIVE
IF I HAVE TO. WE WILL NOT
STASHED IN A THAT TO ASK.
BECAUSE WE TAKE CARE BYE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND HAVE A GOOD
NIGHT YOU TOO. I NEXT COMIC
FROM THE LINE. THREE FIVE EIGHT
NINE THREE FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
ANGIE KEITH AND I AM THE
ADMISSION OF PLACEMENT
COORDINATOR FOR HI JOE
ENTERPRISES. AND AFTER TWO PM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA THANK YOU ALL
I KNOW IT'S BEEN A VERY LONG
DAY FOR APPRECIATE YOU GUYS ARE
LISTENING TO US AND ALSO FOR
YOU GIVING ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
TO. GET THERE ANY OTHER CALLERS
IN THE QUEUE- I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADDITIONAL
COVERT NINETEEN FUNDING FOR R.
F. SHARE T. P.'S- I'M SURE M.
P. BACKING UP A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT. AS AN ACTOR TP
WE ARE DEFINITELY IMPACTED-
FROM STAFF YOU KNOW NOT HAVING
ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE PP TO OUR-
THAT. AND DEFINITELY AS WE ARE
HOPEFULLY NEARING AN END OF THE
PANDEMIC BUT STILL ENSURING
THAT OUR STAFF AS WELL AS
RESIDENTS. HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO FILL SPACE- FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO STAFF APPROPRIATELY-
OBVIOUSLY WITH CUTTING NINETEEN
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF YOU KNOW
HITS WITH US NOT BEING ABLE TO.
BE AT FULL CAPACITY DUE TO YOU
KNOW CERTAIN LIMITATIONS SO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON THE PLATFORM AND I
HOPE YOU ALL HAVE A GREAT.
NIGHT AND A GOOD EVENING. THANK
YOU MA'AM. OUR COMIC COUNTRY
MIND. FIVE EIGHT. NINE TWO FIVE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS JANELLE IN MARYLAND MY SON
AND I ARE RESIDENTS OF ORANGE
COUNTY AND I GREW UP IN LOS
ANGELES. I ENTERED INTO FOSTER
CARE WITH MY ONE MONTH OLD SON
IN MY ARMS AT THE AGE OF
FIFTEEN. I AM AN ADVOCATE FOR
PREGNANT AND PARENTING YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS HEALTHY.
NUTRITION FOR FOSTER YOUTH
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THAT THE
INFANT SUPPLEMENT. I UNDERSTAND
FIRSTHAND THE DESPERATE NEED TO
SUPPORT TEAM PARENTS AND FOSTER
CARE WHO OFTEN LACK SUPPORT
SYSTEM. GUIDANCE AND RESOURCES.
THE LONELINESS AND ISOLATION
ARE ALREADY CHALLENGING ENOUGH.
WHEN I WAS IN THE SYSTEM ARE
CONSTANTLY STRIVE TO LEARNING
HOW TO CARE FOR MY CHILD ON MY
OWN. I BENEFIT FROM INSTANT
SUPPLEMENT AND IT MADE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE. HOW DID NOT RECEIVE
THE AND SOME SUPPLEMENT I WOULD
HAVE STRUCK BOB FIGURING OUT
HOW TO OBTAIN. THE NECESSARY
ITEMS SUCH AS DIAPERS CLOTHING.
FORMULA AND MUCH MORE. PARENTS
AND FOSTER TO THIRD COURT BE
MARKED PRESENT WHAT THIRD
CHILDREN BUT THE CONSTANT.
STRESS OF WORRYING. HOW THEY
WILL MEET THEIR CHILDREN MEANS.
HAPPINESS THAT WOULD HELP EQUIP
PREGNANT AND PARENTING YOUTH
COULD BE THE BEST PARENT
POSSIBLE AS THEY NAVIGATE THE
SYSTEM DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
BEYOND. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU MA'AM. OUR NEXT COMIC
COMES FROM LINE. THREE THREE
THREE NINE THREE THREE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS JOE EVERITT WHAT THE
SENATE COMPLEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. AS A MEMBER OF
THE TRUTH AND JUSTICE AND CHILD
SUPPORT COALITION A COALITION
OF DOZENS OF COMMUNITY GROUPS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO DO THE
FOLLOWING ENSURE THAT 1100% OF
ALL CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS GO
DIRECTLY TO CHILDREN. ELIMINATE
GOVERNMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
DEBT AND THE 10% INTEREST RATE
PAYMENTS ON THE DEBT AND ANY
DRIVER'S LICENSE SUSPENSIONS
FOR INABILITY TO PAY CHILD
SUPPORT. OUR COALITION APPLAUDS
THE CSS THE TOPICS MENTIONED A
DRIVER'S LICENSE FOR INABILITY
TO PAY GOVERNMENT- CHILD
SUPPORT DEBT SINCE MARCH
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY. BUT
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE
THESE CHANGES PERMANENT PARENTS
NEED THIS NOW MORE THAN EVER A
CALIFORNIA BEGINS TO BE OPEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
OPERATOR WE'RE READY FOR THE
NEXT CALLER. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO NOW. THERE ARE NO COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR I WILL TAKE THAT AS
THE CLOSE OF PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
TODAY AS WE CLOSE DOWN TODAY'S
MEETING I JUST WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO. THANK ALL THE STAFF
THAT MADE TODAY'S HEARING
POSSIBLE FROM GENERAL SERVICES
WHO HELPED TO CLEAN THIS ROUND
TO THE TECH WHO HELPED TO PUT
ON THE PRESENTATION TO THE
SERGEANTS WHO KEPT US SAFE FROM
THE STAFF WHO PRESENTED THE
AGENDA. I ALSO WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ALL OF THE
PANELISTS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
TODAY'S HEARING AND WITH THAT
WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED. GOOD
NIGHT.